hey this is Andrew Brown over here at
free Camp bringing you another free
Cloud certification study course and
this time it's the Azure Solutions
architect expert also known as the a305
and the way we're going to achieve uh
Azure certification is through lectur
content Hands-On labs and as always I
provide you a free practice exam that
way you can go get that certification to
put it on your resume or LinkedIn to go
get that Solutions architecture role if
you like these kind of free Cloud study
courses the best way to support more of
these materials is by purchasing the
optional paid materials over on the
exampro platform exampro doco uh if you
don't know me I'm Andrew Brown and I've
taught a lot of different Cloud
certification study courses here Azure
adabs gcp kubernetes terraform uh you
name it I've taught it so you're in
great hands and I will see you in class
uh in a moment
[Music]
ciaoo hey everyone it's Andrew Brown and
we're at the start of our journey asking
the most important question first which
is what is the a305 so the a305 um is a
certification or an exam uh to get the
certification Microsoft Azure solution
architect expert I use a funny wording
there because um previously you had to
take two separate exams the 303 and the
304 and then that would get you the
certification but uh Microsoft has seen
the light and now we just have one exam
for a certification it looks like it's
mostly like that now but just understand
the future they might change that but
yeah the a305 more or less means
Microsoft Azure Solutions architect
expert going to get off screen here now
but uh yeah it is an expert level
certification and it's focusing on
comprehensive strategies for Designing
Solutions on Azure it has a deeper dive
into advanced networking configurations
you don't see me doing this but I'm
doing quotations air quotations here
sorry air
quotations for the word advance because
it's not as in-depth as something like
the um uh the A700 Advanced networking
but yes you do need to know your
networking your Cloud net working very
well for the certification it has a
broad examination of data and Security
Solutions in Azure uh the sc900 is a
great recommendation for that but we'll
talk about that when we look at the road
map here and this has extensive Hands-On
knowledge you should know how to do
things in the Azure portal arm templates
and other uh uh resilient architectural
tools all Azure exams are very code and
script driven so having great developer
experience is a must make sure you do
things in the um the portal um now this
one the 305 is not as um technically
heavy like the 104 in terms of Hands-On
but it still is a great challenge
because of how broad uh the information
is being covered in the 305 who's the
certification for well consider the
certification if you're uh looking to
get an Azure Solutions architect expert
role uh you're designing Solutions using
Microsoft Azure you're implementing and
monitoring Azure infrastructure you're
creating configuring resources for Azure
applications uh enjoy crafting resilient
and scalable Cloud architectures I want
to warn you this is a hard exam um it is
very common to fail this exam even if
you practice a lot and you do your best
job uh it may just come down to the type
of questions you get so you know we do
the best to give you practice exams and
all the information here just understand
when you get to expert level or
professional level certifications it's
not you it's just the questions and you
might have to try multiple times so
don't get discouraged if you uh if you
take an exam and you're just like one
point shy away that is what it's like
doing these professional or expert
certifications let's take a look at our
Azure road map um and I'm right away I'm
already noticing that this is a bit
buggy this is supposed to just say 305
but just you know ignore that one one
little bug there that says 305 but
anyway uh we have a bunch of uh Azure
certifications Microsoft certifications
this isn't the full list um in fact
there are some that I probably would
even recommend on Route there but
definitely before you go for expert you
should have your A9 a900 gives you a
good broad view of all services uh the a
104 is generally what is uh or
absolutely recommended uh on path to the
305 I would also pick up the 204 on the
way um in fact in this course a lot of
the content not a lot of the content but
a good chunk of the content came from
our 104 and our 204 and then we had to
round it out with other things so
understand that these two are are part
of the course if you've done the 104 204
you're going to be in really good shape
or well aligned for the 305 and then you
can spend time trying to figure out case
studies and things like that I would
probably also add the sc9 00 on here uh
that is a fundamental certification the
dp900 would be also a good one um I'm
just kind of running out of space for
all these things that's why I don't have
them all listed like here you can see I
have the networking one shoved down in
here um but Azure just has a lot a lot
of certifications okay um but anyway how
long would it take to uh pass uh for
studying well if you're beginner don't
do this exam it is not a beginner
certification it would take you uh well
over a month if you're a beginner start
in the fundamentals do the associates um
and work your way up to it if you're
experienced you already have that 204
that that or and the 104 and you already
have multiple uh years working
experience it might not take you that
long to study but you know on average I
think 50 hours is for somebody in the
mid-tier area we're looking at 50%
lecture 50% uh practice or sorry 50%
lecture in Labs 50% practice exams I
actually probably would even bump this
up a bit more more try to get your hands
on as many practice exams as you can the
huge challenge with um uh Microsoft
certifications is they have a rich uh
type of exam questions and not everyone
can emulate those questions so a lot of
times you are uh needing to overstudy uh
with simpler exam type questions in
order to try to be able to tackle the
harder exam so just understand that that
is something you have to consider um 30
days absolutely you need a whole month
for this exam uh for for uh for studying
a recommended study one to two hours
really Max your time out and so that you
are in the best shape possible um what
other things should we consider well
make sure you watch the video lecture
content do the Hands-On Labs absolutely
do all of them and do the best that you
can in fact there are Labs that we
wanted to record but they were so hard
to do and this course was already so
long that we didn't even record them and
put them in here but we actually do have
um I believe additional Labs with the
instructions on our platform so you know
max out as many Labs as you can to make
sure or or Hands-On work make sure
you're in good shape absolutely do paid
online practice exams we have our own
sets here um just ignore these numbers
here I just did not feel like taking a
new screenshot um but uh yeah just the
the times are a little bit different
here because you actually get 120
minutes and it's more around 60
Questions so 57 makes sense um but
anyway yeah you definitely want to look
into that in terms of the actual exam
guide outline there are four domains and
each domain has its own waiting this
determines how many questions in a
domain that will show up uh Microsoft
exams they like to do arrange of
questions which it's not great for the
test taker but I guess it makes the exam
harder I you know I don't personally
like this I don't like that they do
ranges like this but uh you know I guess
they think that makes it if it's more
more confusing then therefore the exam
must be more worth it for the end result
I don't know so the first domain um or
section whatever you want to call it
it's between 25 and 30% of the exams so
this design design identity governance
Monitoring Solutions the next one is 20
to 25% for design data storage solutions
the next one is 12 to 20% so design
business continuity Solutions and then
30 to 35% to design infrastructure
Solutions where are you going to take
this exam it's going to be with Pearson
view um previously Microsoft I think
they offered it I think it had PSI
online before um even adab us is doing
the same thing they're just doing
Pearson so Pearson and Pearson view um
so you can do it at inperson test center
or online for the convenience your home
uh from your own home so what we're
talking about is Pearson view online
this is the online product exam system
and then you have the Pearson view uh
network of test centers this is where
you do it in person the word Proctor
means a supervisor visor so someone is
going to monitor you during this exam um
sometimes when you uh go for your exam
they're uh uh like online they will go
and actually call and talk to you and
ask you to show the room and it can be
very involved so just understand that uh
there is somebody watching while you
take these exams uh the grading for this
one is um 700 out of a th000 points so
basically it's around 70% I say around
70% because aure uses scaled scoring so
um technically it's not exactly 70% it's
700 out of a th000 I know that's
confusing but generally uh what you want
to do is aim to go get 80 80% I always
think if you have a margin of 10% above
that you're passing for practice exams
then you're giving yourself a buffer you
might even want to go higher and try to
Target
85% um and in the result you will
actually probably get
70% um in terms of the the amount of
questions there's between 40 and 60 so
you should be able to get 12 and 18
questions wrong though the thing is is
that when we save 12 18 that's not
exactly true because you have to
understand the format of the questions
for Microsoft Azure exams and they have
a lot of different kinds of formatted
questions you got multiple choice you
got multiple answer you got drag and
drop you got build list reorder you have
active screen you got hot areas you have
case studies you'll absolutely see case
studies in this exam and then questions
can have exhibits so it can get really
complex um in terms of what you will see
will be different from other folks you
definitely will see multiple choice
multiple answer you'll definitely see
case studies and some of these other
ones might show up some questions are
worth more than one points there is no
penalty for wrong questions so do not uh
do not leave any questions blank some
questions cannot be skipped and you have
to fill them in um so yeah there's a lot
going on there the duration is two hours
um I could have swore that the 204 was
three hours but I looked it up and maybe
they changed the time but I really
thought they would give you more time
for this exam but yeah it's just two
hours so it is still a stressor um you
get two minutes per question basically
so we're looking at an exam time of 120
minutes but your seat time is 150
minutes all we do is we add 30 minutes
to to make the seat time the seat time
refers to the amount uh uh that you
should allocate for the exam um so this
includes time to review instructions
Show online Proctor your workspace read
and accept the NDA complete the exam
provide feedback at the end of the exam
the reason I I include this here is just
to remind you that um when you're when
you are planning this you have to plan
for all of the time not just the exam
but also the time around the exam this
exam is only valid for 12 months uh this
is something different so Azure used to
have two years and then you'd have to
pay every time now they're doing every
12 months so every year you
recertify um however the recertification
process supposedly isn't as hard because
renewals are free um and I think you can
even check in like six months into it if
you want to do uh uh if you want to do
it sooner but we'll take a look at that
because again those are new things to me
and I want to uh share those with you
yeah hopefully that gives you an idea of
the exam guide itself but we'll see you
in the next one okay
ciao
hey this is Andrew Brown and welcome to
the marketing site on Microsoft for the
a305 and you'll notice the name of this
is actually called designing Microsoft
Azure infrastructure Solutions and it
gets you that badge the uh Solutions
expert but the uh strange thing is that
Microsoft does not name the badge the
same thing as the exam uh it's not that
strange if you understand the history of
their certifications they like to
sometimes have more than one exam that
you have to pass in order to get a badge
and so they don't name them the same as
the badge so that's just what's there
and the old exam used to have two the
304 and the 303 but we'll go down here
below because the reason I'm on this
page is I want to show you the sandbox
if you go here to the sandbox and we'll
open this up we can see the formatting
of the questions now it's not example
questions um we have example ones on our
platform and we have we should have a
free set but what we'll do we'll go
ahead and click next and this is just
like if you were to take it online or a
test center and we'll click through and
we'll go here and there's just 10
questions and the purpose of the sandbox
is to show you the formatting of the
questions I'm going to get out of the
way there we go and so the first one we
have is a multiple choice pretty
straightforward says what is your
favorite sound we'll say a bell we'll
click next this one is multiple choice
so here we can checkbox two things we'll
do that the next one here is drag and
drop so you have these things you drag
and then you drop them into the area on
the right here notice that um I can
actually fill in multiple so uh you know
just it can vary based on the type of
question so it might not just be one to
one these things might still remain in
here then we have um build order build
list reorder so which five tasks should
you do in the correct order so you say
making a sandwich We'll add the pickles
the Mayo the ketchup this that this
uh whoops this and that okay and then
you can move them around notice that
this actually has more than five
questions these are draggable here
you'll notice these everywhere we'll go
ahead and hit
next um this question is an active
screen so which option should you ACH uh
choose to achieve this goal so we'll
scroll on down
here um to answer select the appropriate
setting in the applications example
properties window in the answer area so
notice here if we hover over might be
hard to see see but there is a blue line
so it's showing like where do you click
right so here that's the only one we
drop it down then we choose an option
here so it's kind of like
simulating um a components without
actually having the
environment we'll go to the next one
here so this one is an active screen so
you need to implement self- serving
provisions of virtual machines this
actually kind of sounds like a proper
question the solution must ensure that
the user caner the virtual machines Etc
what do you choose so we'll go here and
we'll choose option one and then op
option to notice that these are relaying
to this table here but this is just you
know another way that we could be
working with stuff here we have a hot
area so here it says which Services
should you configure so we'll go take a
look here and notice that we can select
something from the hot area so it's very
similar to that other one um active
screen again you're just like clicking
on stuff we'll go to the next one here
and so this is a case study so uh case
studies are uh pretty complex the idea
is you can click around here and read
all of this stuff okay so you read
through all of this stuff and then what
you're going to do is go back to your
question at the top I know it's
confusing but that's where it is and
then you can go ahead and answer uh the
question we'll go back and hit next then
you have exhibits so exhibits are
basically just tabs the idea is that you
read the question and then you can go
look at exhibit there can also be
multiple exhibits so I think in this one
here's an example where you have
multiples and then you go back to your
question and then you answer it okay so
you know hopefully that uh makes things
really clear um but you can see that
they really do have a lot of different
formatted questions and uh that can make
this uh quite challenging if we want to
read about the specifics of the exam we
can go to the uh study guide now I
remember there being at least in
previous exams um or um in other exams
you used to have a PDF you can download
I can't seem to find that anymore all
there is is the marketing site here
maybe that's what they want to do but
you can go through here and read about
like the certification renewals the
scoring all the stuff here we were
mentioning about certification renewal
so if you want to read a bit more about
that where they talk about how renewals
are free and you have a six-month
renewal window and things like that you
can read all about it um but yeah there
you go and uh we'll see you in the next
one
hey this is Andrew Brown and before we
get into Azure ad I need to point
something out it's not called Azure ad
anymore it's called Microsoft entra ID
Microsoft decided to change the name of
azure ad why nobody knows but I can tell
you no customer likes this particular
change um somebody just had a lot of
time on their hands over at Microsoft
but we do need to address this and I
need to point out that I'm not refiling
all of the content that I made just to
change the name because that's crazy I
will at some point when this when the
content is stale but the content is not
stale they just changed the name on us
um but I wanted to just go over that
quickly here so uh the names here we
have Azure ad is now Microsoft entra ID
then the Azure ad tiers is from P1 P2
still P1 P2 the Azure ad external
identities is now called Microsoft entra
external identities and if we scroll on
down we have a logo change so instead of
this which by the way I really like the
old
logo they didn't need a muck with it but
anyway we have uh the older ones here
and so this is the new one
here and so there are some name changes
here Azure ad single sign on now
Microsoft entra entra uh single sign on
we'll go down below here and you can see
well more name changes okay so um anyway
yeah they renamed it and you know
customers are just going to take a while
to get used to it I still like calling
azuread I know a lot of other people
that like still calling it azuread but
it's at some point we'll get moved over
to it and we're just going to use both
names okay now coming over to uh uh the
portal I need to show you that if you
type in Azure ad it's still going to
pull up Microsoft Entre ID okay now you
don't want Azure ad B to see which is
interesting they didn't rename that U
which is a it is part of azure kind of
in a sense but it's more for um if
you're building applications and you
want to um have authentication into it
so just understand that there's not
consistency all over the place
especially even their documentation the
marketplace still says Azure ad all over
the place um even down below uh you know
Azure ad notification so you know
there's just going to be that Legacy of
azure ad but anyway yeah what you want
to do is go go over to Microsoft Entre
ID it all looks the same it's just some
name changes okay but but yeah there you
go see you in the next
[Music]
one hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Azure active
directory and this is a cloud-based
identity and access management service
to manage users sign-ins and access to
ad related resources so Azure active
directory is Microsoft's cloud-based
identity and access management service
which helps you your employees sign in
and access resources so that could be
external resources like Microsoft Office
365 Azure portal SAS applications or
internal resources so applications
within your internal networking or
access to workstations on premise and
you can use Azure ad to implement single
sign on so you can see that Azure ad is
basically like the the the one solution
to log everything and uh we actually use
it at exam Pro we use it with Microsoft
teams or uh you know for the exam pro
pro platform our mid panel is tied to it
so when we want to log into the mid
panel with credentials we have it there
uh we use it with AWS to log into there
and we use it to log into Azure so it
has a lot of flexibility and if you're
building out applications for
Enterprises they're likely using ad and
so this is the reason why everybody
adopts it or needs to understand it so
it's a service I really really do want
you to understand and know as your
active directory comes in for additions
we have the free tier and by the way
each uh uh uh tier that goes up has the
features before it but uh free has MFA
SSO basic security usage reports and
user management then you have the Office
365 apps which is uh revolves around if
you're using that Suite so you have
company branding SLA two sync between on
premise and cloud and then the premium
tiers which really comes into Enterprise
or or or on premise hybrid architecture
so hybrid architectures Advanced group
access conditional access premium 2
identity protection and identity
governance only thing I don't like about
Azure ad is that uh you can't really
create your uh custom access controls
unless you have premium one or premium
two but that's just how they do it so
there you go
[Music]
go so let's take a look at the use case
for Azure ad and we basically covered it
in the introduction but I just want to
reiterate it in a different way with a
bit of a visual uh so that it really
helps uh it sync into your uh brain
there so Azure ad can authorize and
authenticate to multiple sources so it
can authenticate to your on- premise ad
to your web application allow users to
log in with uh ipds uh so identity
providers could be like use Facebook or
Google login uh you can use it with
Office 365 or a Azure Microsoft and so
just a visual here uh notice that uh we
have Azure ad and using Azure ad connect
we can connect to on premise through uh
app registrations we're able to uh
connect our web application to Azure ad
with external identities we can um use
Facebook or Google uh uh uh login and
then for cloud applications we can
connect to Office 365 or Microsoft
[Music]
Azure so active directory existed way
before Azure and so let's just do a
quick uh uh rundown of the history so we
have an idea of what we're looking at so
um Microsoft introduced active directory
domain services in Windows 2000 to give
organizations the ability to manage
multiple on-premise infrastructure
components and systems using a single
identity per user so it's been around
for 20 years and Azure ad takes this
approach to the next level by providing
organizations with identity as a service
so idas solution for their apps across
uh cloud and on premise and both
versions are still used today because
they just have different utility and so
we have active directory which is for on
premise and then you have Azure ad which
is just the cloud hosted version and in
many regards these can also be connected
together um but there you
go so remember that the domain
controller is the server that users are
going to be using to authenticate to the
directory Service uh and so when you
create an active directory Azure sets
one up for you but there's some cases
where you might want to set one up
yourself and the reason why is that you
could be like an on like an Enterprise
where you already have your own active
directory on premise but you've decided
that you want to move it over to Azure
ad uh because you just want a fully
managed active directory and uh you want
to tap into the cloud but uh the thing
is that some domain Services those are
features on your domain controller just
might not be available and that's where
you're going to need to set up your own
domain controller and that's where Azure
active director domain Services come
into play because these provide managed
domain services and so they have managed
domain services such as domain joins uh
group policies uh
ldaps uh uh curb Ross Never Can Say That
properly ntlm authentication and so the
great thing is here is you can have
these domain services but you're not
going to have to deploy them manage them
attach them they're just going to work
so there you
go so let's talk about um uh the term
tenant and a tenant represents an
organization in an active directory and
a tenant is dedicated to the Azure ad
service instance a tenant is
automatically created when you sign up
for either Microsoft Azure or Microsoft
InTune or Microsoft 365 and each a or
Azure ad tenant is distinct and separate
from other azure ad tenants and so if
you uh if you were in um uh Azure ad and
you clicked on your tenant information
that's that's basically what that is
right so that's my exam Pro one and it
has its own special tenant ID and we can
see that it's licensed for Office 365
and so that tells you that I'm using the
Office 365 uh tier of azure
[Music]
ad so now let's take a look at some of
the ad objects starting with users so
users represent an identity for a person
or employee in your domain and a user
has login credentials and can use them
to log into the Azure portal so here I
am a user and you can see it shows how
many times I've logged in and I'm part
of different uh ad groups uh and so you
can assign roles and administrative
roles uh to users you can add users to
groups you can enforce authentication by
uh like with MFA you can track user
sign-ins as you can see on the right
hand side you can track device uh
devices users login and uh and allow or
deny devices
uh you can assign Microsoft licenses
Azure ad has two kinds of users we have
users that's a user that belongs to an
organization and guest users this is a
guest uh is a user that belongs from
another organization and we'll cover uh
Azure ad roles uh in the r section here
uh because that is what's that you're
going to be using to apply to these
users so groups in Azure ID lets
resource owners assign a set of access
permissions to all members of the group
instead of having to provide the rights
one by one and so on the right hand side
here you can see I have a bunch of
groups in exam Pro and groups can
contain owners and owners have
permissions to add or remove members and
then the members have rights to do
things okay and so for assignment you
can assign roles directly to a group you
can assign applications directly to a
group and to request join groups so uh
the group owner can let users find their
own groups to join instead of assigning
them to them and the owner can set up
the group to automatically accept all
users that join or require approval this
is really great when uh you just want
people to do the work themselves as
opposed to having to do all that manual
labor of adding them to
groups let's talk about how we're going
to uh give users rights to access uh
resources and there are four different
ways to do that the first is direct
assignment and this is where the
resource owner is going to directly
assign the user to the resource then you
have group assignment this is where the
resource owner assigns an a a group to
the resource which automatically gives
all group members access to the resource
then you have rulebase assignment this
is resource owner uh this is where the
resource owner creates a group and uses
a rule to Define which users are
assigned to a specific resource and then
you have external uh Authority
assignment this is this access comes
from an external Source such as an on-
premise directory or SAS application and
I just want you to know that there's
four different ways to do it so uh to
get access to
resources all right let's take a look at
managed identities for Microsoft enter
ID or Azure ad managed identities is a
concept in Microsoft enter ID that
Associates identities with internal
resources where these identities have
their own roles and tokens managed
identities increases security by
allowing you to link directly resources
to other resources without having to
share any security information over the
network those resources will be
authenticated against enter ID to see if
they have the necessary permissions to
manipulate other resources for example
we can allow our applications to access
Azure key vault in order to retrieve a
secret without exposing any
passwords managed identities is
available in two types system aside
identities are created and managed by
enter ID when you create a managed
identity in a service instance only that
Azure resource can use this identity to
request tokens from enter ID user
assigned identities are created and
managed manually the identity is managed
separately from the resources that use
it the table provides a comparison
between system assigned and user
assigned features in the context of
azure creation for system assigned the
identity is created as part of an Azure
resource whereas user assign the
identity is created as a standalone
Azure resource life cycle for system
assigned the identity shares its life
cycle with the Azure resource It's
associated with while user assigned the
identity has an independent life cycle
deletion for system assigned when the
associated Azure resource is deleted the
identity is also deleted whereas user
assigned the identity must be deleted
explicitly sharing across Azure
resources for system assigned the
identity cannot be shared and is
associated with only a single Azure
resource whereas user assign the
identity can be shared and can be
associated with more than one Azure
resource managed identity is under the
identity blade for an Azure resource you
assign roles to provide permissions to a
managed identity in summary managed
identities enhance security through
seamless resource integration
eliminating exposed credentials with
system assigned and user assigned
options Azure bolsters efficient
flexible Resource
[Music]
Management let's talk about external
identities so external identities in aad
allows people outside your organization
to access your apps and resources while
letting them sign in uh and use whatever
identity they prefer so your partners
Distributors suppliers vendors or other
guests can bring their own identities
such as uh Google or Facebook uh you can
share apps with external users that's
for B2B stuff uh if you develop apps and
tender for Azure ad tenants uh for
single tenant or multi-tenant you can do
that as well uh you can develop white
label apps for consumers and customers
so this would be like Azure ad uh
b2c so there you
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and the next topic will be exploring
or access reviews in Microsoft enter ID
or azuread access reviews in Microsoft
enter ID allow you to regularly review
and manage access to resources in your
organization with access reviews you can
review who has access to resources and
determine whether their access is still
necessary access reviews are useful in
maintaining security and compliance by
ensuring that only authorized
individuals have access to sensitive
resources access reviews can be
conducted for various types of resources
such as applications groups and
SharePoint online sites you can
configure access reviews to occur on a
regular schedule and select reviewers to
conduct the reviews reviewers can be
internal or external to your
organization during an access review the
reviewer will be presented with a list
of people who have access to the
resource being reviewed they can choose
to approve or revoke access for each
individual access can be revoked
immediately or scheduled for a later
date reviewers can also provide a reason
for their decision which can be useful
for auditing purposes access reviews are
crucial in large organizations to
regularly identify and resolve access
issues they ensure resources are
accessed only by necessary users and
that access is revoked when no longer
needed overall access reviews maintain
security by assessing user access
ensuring compliance preventing breaches
and safeguarding data promoting a
security aware culture make sure to know
access reviews because it did show up a
few times on the
exam the next topic will be covering his
single side on on an enter ID single
sign on an enter ID is a feature that
allows users to authenticate once with
enter ID and then access multiple
applications and services without having
to authenticate again when a user signs
into enter ID with their credentials
enter ID creates a security token that
can be used to access other resources
within the same organization this token
can be used to authenticate the user to
other cloud based or on premises
applications that have been integrated
with enter ID SSO supports a wide range
of applications including cloud-based
applications such as Microsoft 365
Salesforce and Dropbox as well as on
premises applications such as SharePoint
and sap SSO can also be used with
custombuilt applications using industry
standard protocols such as saml open ID
connect and
oo there are several ways you can
configure an application for SSO
choosing an SSO method depends on how
the application is configured for
authentication Cloud applications can
use open ID connect ooth saml
password-based or or linked for SSO
single sideon can also be disabled on
premises applications can use
password-based integrated Windows
authentication header based or linked
for SSO Deon premises choices work when
applications are configured for
application proxy this flowchart can
help you decide which SSO method is best
for your
situation the main SSO protocol
supported in Azure include open ID
connect in ooth open ID connect is an
identity layer built on top of ooth 2.0
it allows for authentication and
authorization of users in a secure and
standardized manner it is saml saml is
an XML based protocol used for
exchanging authentication and
authorization data between an identity
provider and a service provider it is
commonly used for Federated
authentication
scenarios password based authentication
this refers to the traditional username
password authentication method where
users provide their credentials directly
to authenticate linked authentication
Azure provides the ability to l link
multiple accounts from different
identity providers to a single user
identity this allows users to
authenticate using any of their linked
accounts integrated Windows
authentication it will let users access
applications using their Windows domain
credentials utilizing their current
Windows session for
authentication header based
authentication in this method the
application accepts an authentication
token in the form of a header in each
request the token is validated by the
application to authenticate the user
you'll need to be familiar with these
assets o protocols is there will be
questions asking you which SSO protocol
is best suited for a specific
application what is multiactor
authentication a security control where
after you fill in your username email
and password you have to use a second
device such as a phone to confirm that
it's you logging in MFA protects against
people who have stolen your password MFA
is an option in most Cloud providers and
even social media websites such as
Facebook so that's an overview of single
sign on an ENT
ID the next topic we'll be going over is
conditional access conditional access
provides an extra layer of security
before allowing authenticated users to
access data or other assets conditional
access is implemented via conditional
access policies which are a set of rules
that specify the conditions under which
sign-ins are evaluated and allowed for
example you can create a conditional
access policy that states if the user
account name is member of a group for
users that are assigned The Exchange
user password security SharePoint or
Global administrator roles require MFA
before allowing access this policy
enables MFA enforcement based on group
membership simplifying the process
compared to configuring MFA for
individual users when roles
change conditional access policy
analyzes signals including user and
location device application and
real-time risk and verifies every access
attempt via access controls this
requires MFA block access and allow
access signals or metadata associated
with an identity attempting to gain
access user or group membership policies
Target specific users and groups giving
admins find grain control over access
named location information IP location
information IP address ranges are used
to permit or deny access based on
geographical locations device policies
can be applied based on the platform or
status of a user's device application
users attempting to access specific
applications can trigger different
conditional access policies real time
sign and risk detection signals and
Azure ad identity protection detect
risky sign-ins if risks emerge policies
can prompt actions such as password
resets multifactor authentication or
block access pending admin
intervention Cloud apps or actions can
include or exclude Cloud applications or
user actions that will be subject to the
policy user risk for customers with
identity protection user risk risk can
be evaluated as part of a conditional
access policy user risk represents the
probability that a given Identity or
account is
compromised common decisions Define the
access controls that decide what level
of access based on Signal
information block access most
restrictive decision Grant access least
restrictive decision still require one
or more of the following options require
multiactor authentication require device
to be marked as compliant require hybrid
enter ID join device require approved
Client app and require app protection
policy conditional access policies are
available and can be utilized with the
following licensing plans Microsoft 365
business premium Microsoft 365 E3 and E5
enter ID premium P1 and enter ID premium
P2
licenses overall conditional access acts
as a robust security measure in Azure
ensuring that authenticated users can
only Access Data under specific
conditions
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this section we'll be going over
the types of azure roles roles can be a
bit confusing this is because Azure has
three types of roles that can serve the
same purpose the first type of role are
classic subscription administrator roles
this is the original RO system next we
have Azure roles this is an
authorization system that's also known
as role-based access controls and is
built on top of azure resource manager
then we have Azure active directory
roles Azure ad roles are used to manage
Azure a resources in a
directory Azure active directory roles
are used to manage Azure a resources in
a directory such as creating or editing
users assigning administrative roles to
others resetting user passwords managing
user licenses and managing domains among
other tasks the rules follow a similar
rbac model and include several built-in
roles like Global admin application
admin application developer and billing
admin but also allow the creation of
custom roles for more specific control
Azure rules specifically Azure rule
based access control is a system that
provides fine grained access management
for Azure resources allowing
administrators to Grant users specific
rights to resources there are several
predefined roles in Azure like owner
contributor reader and user access
administrator each providing specific
levels of access to Azure resources and
custom roles can be defined as well
classic subscription administrator roles
refer to the older model of azure access
control and include three types account
administrator service ad administrator
and co-administrator Azure roles and
classic subscription administrator roles
can have overlapping responsibilities
for example the service administrator in
the classic Model has a similar role to
the owner role in the Azure rbac where
both can manage resources in the
subscription however Azure rbac roles
provide a more granular level of control
compared to Classic roles offering more
specific access management they allow
administrators to delegate specific
tasks and Grant specific permissions
reducing the need to give full
administrative privileges and therefore
for enhancing
[Music]
security the next topic will be covering
are the access controls so identity
access management essentially allows you
to create and assign roles to users for
the Azure rules or the rbac system rules
restrict access to Resource actions
which are also known as operations there
are two types of rules the first type
are built-in roles these roles refer to
the set of predefined roles offered by
Microsoft and azure the rules are read
only and cannot be altered cover a wide
array of standard scenarios to
facilitate efficient and secure access
management for Azure resources the
second type of rule are custom rules
these rules represent user defined roles
in Azure tailored to incorporate unique
permissions and logic based on specific
requirements that are satisfied by the
available built-in roles a role
assignment is when you apply a role to a
service principle which could be a user
group service principle or managed
identity deny assignments lock users
from performing specific actions even if
a role assignment grants them access the
only way to apply deny assignments is
through Azure blueprints so that's the
access controls for
[Music]
Azure hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering classic administrators classic
administrators refer to the original
role system in Azure despite the Legacy
status of classic administrators
understanding these roles can still be
beneficial like when work with older
Azure setups however it's recommended to
use the new rbac system for managing
access to resources given its enhanced
granularity and flexibility classic
administrators have three types of roles
the first type is a account
administrator this role is essentially
the billing owner of the Azure
subscription it's responsible for
managing subscriptions making payments
and changing the billing details the
account admin has no access to the Azure
portal meaning they can't manage
resources directly the second type is
service administrator this Ro shares the
same level of access as a user assigned
the owner role at the subscription scope
in the rbac model they have full access
to the Azure portal meaning they can
manage all resources within the
subscription the third type is
co-administrator this has the same
access level of a user who is assigned
the owner role at the subscription scope
it's similar to a service admin but the
main difference is that there can be
multiple co- administrators offering
shared management capabilities you
shouldn't have to worry much about the
classic admin roles because I don't
think I encountered any exam questions
on it it'll mostly be focused on the
rbac and Azure ad roles also note that
classic resources and classic
administrators will be retired on August
31st
[Music]
2024 the next topic we'll be covering is
the Azure Ro based access control so
Azure Ro based Access Control helps you
manage who has access to Azure resources
what actions they can perform on
resources and in what scope which are
the areas they have access to ro
assignments are the way you control
access to Resources by assigning a role
to a security principle like a user
group service principle or managed
identity at a particular scope you
define who can perform what actions on
which resources our role assignment
consists of these three elements scope
and role definition and security
principle there are four fundamental
Azure roles which include owner
contributor reader and user access
administrator Azure rbac includes over
70 built-in roles these roles are
designed to serve many common use case
and range from brought to very specific
permissions such as virtual machine
contributor or network
contributor scope is the set of
resources that access for the role
assignment applies to scope access
controls at the management subscription
Resource Group and resource level
assigning a role at the Management Group
level inherits it across all Associated
subscriptions and resources at the
subscription level it applies to all
resource groups and resources within the
specific subscription a role assigned at
the resource Group level affects all
resource within that group at the
resource level a role assignment applies
only to that specific resource a role
definition is a set of permissions that
determines what actions can be performed
such as read write or delete on various
resources roles range from broad such as
owner with extensive management
permissions to specific such as virtual
machine reader with more targeted
permissions Azure has built-in roles and
you can Define custom roles this table
shows the four fundamental built-in
roles the owner role has full access to
all resources including the right to
delegate access to others the
contributor role can manage all types of
azure resources including the ability to
create update and delete but can't Grant
access to others the reader role has the
ability to view existing Azure resources
but can't make changes or Grant access
to others the user access administrator
role has the ability to manage user
access to Azure resources including
granting and revoking access but can't
create update or delete
resources a security principle
represents the identities requesting
access to an Azure resource such as a
user which is an individual who has a
profile in Azure active directory a
group which is a set of users created in
Azure active directory a service
principle which is a security identity
used by applications or services to
access specific Azure resources or a
managed identity which is an identity
and Azure active directory that is
automatically managed by Azure so that's
an overview of azure role-based Access
Control
the last type of role we'll be covering
are azuread roles azuread roles are used
to manage azuread resources in a
directory such as create or edit users
asside administrative roles to others
reset user passwords manage user
licenses and manage domains we'll go
over a few important built-in azuread
roles so here are some that you should
know the first one is global
administrator this grants you full
access to everything all the features in
Azure a
another important role is user
administrator this grants you full
access to create and manage users for
the billing administrator role this role
can make purchases manage subscriptions
and support tickets including monitor
service Health not all organizations
needs can be satisfied by these
predefined roles therefore you can
create custom roles which are very
flexible and can Define the exact set of
permissions that you need keep in mind
that you'll need to purchase either
Azure a d premium P1 or P2 to create
custom roles so that's a short overview
of azurea D
[Music]
rolles hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering the anatomy of an Azure role so
it's important to know that the property
names in an Azure Ro definition can vary
depending on whether you're using Azure
Powershell or Azure CLI the two
different interfaces use different
syntax and terminology we have an
example here on the right and we'll go
through the properties together a ro
definition and Azure consists of these
properties name this is the display name
of the custom role also note that the
ones highlighted in blue is the Syntax
for Azure power shell and bold black is
for Azure CLI so it's name for Azure
power shell and rle name is for Azure
CLI the next property is ID this is the
unique ID of the custom Ro and it is
autogenerated for you is custom this
indicates whether this is a custom role
it can be either true or false
description this property describes the
role actions this is an AR of strings
that specify the management operations
that the role is allowed to perform not
actions an array of strings that specify
the management operations that are
excluded from the allowed actions data
actions this is an array of strings that
specify data operations the role is
allowed to perform to your data within
that object not data actions this is an
array of strings that specify the data
operations that are excluded from the
allowed data actions assignable Scopes
this is an array of strings that specify
the Scopes that the custom Ro is
available for assignment you can only
Define why Management Group and
assignable scopes of a custom
role so in this example we see that
there is an asterisk symbol that's used
in the specific actions and the actions
property like storage Network compute
Etc this is called the Wild Card
permission symbol represented as an
asterisk this is used in the actions not
actions data actions and not data
actions properties to represent all or
any operations and wild card allows you
to apply to match
everything in the examp example of
actions microsoft. storage asterisk slre
in a rle definition this means that the
role is granted the permission to
perform read operations on all resource
types under the Microsoft storage
resource provider so the Wild Card
essentially allows you to either Grant
or deny a wide range of permissions with
a single statement however it should be
used with caution because it can grant
or deny more permissions than intended
if not properly
managed
it can be a bit confusing to distinguish
between Azure policies and Azure rules
so we'll do a little comparison to help
you understand the key differences for
the Azure policies they are used to
ensure compliance of resources they
evaluate the state by examining
properties on resources that are
represented in resource manager and
properties of some resource provider it
doesn't restrict actions which are also
called operations they ensure that
resource state is compliant to your
business rules without concern for who
made the change or who has permission to
make a change even if an individual has
access to perform an action if the
result is a non-compliant resource Azure
policy still blocks the create or update
as for the Azure roles they are used to
control access to Azure resources they
focus on managing user actions at
different levels of Scopes and Azure
roles do restriction on Azure
resources another thing people tend to
get confused between our Azure ad roles
versus Azure roles for Azure ad roles
they are used for managing Azure ad
resources for Azure roles they are used
for fine grained Access Control to Azure
resources active directory resources
include users groups billing licensing
application registration Etc Azure
resources included virtual machines
databases cloud storage Cloud networking
Etc by default Azure roles and Azure a
roles are separate and do not span Azure
and Azure a by default the global
administrator doesn't have permissions
to manage Azure resources Global
administrator can gain access to Azure
resource if granted the user access
administrator role so azuread roles are
specifically for managing Azure a
resources while Azure roles focus on
access control to Azure
[Music]
resources hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure policies Azure policies
enforce organizational standards and
assess compliance at scale policies do
not restrict access they only observe
for compliance here is an image with a
list of built-in policies that you can
use right away from Azure let's go over
a few key aspects of azure policies the
first one are policy definitions which
is a Json file used to describe business
rules to control access to resources
then we have policy assignment this is
the scope of a policy's effect it can be
assigned to a user a resource Group or
Management Group next we have policy
parameters the these are the values you
can pass into your policy definition
which makes your policies more flexible
for reuse and we have initiative
definitions this is a collection of
policy definitions that you can assign
for example a group of policies to
enforce pcss
compliance next we'll look at viewing
non-compliant resources once a policy is
assigned it will periodically evaluate
the compliance State you can see how
compliant we are on the compliance tab
according to the example in the image it
shows that we we are non-compliant it
can occur due to many factors but it's
most likely because virtual machines
should have Disaster Recovery
enabled so let's look at some of the
main use cases for Azure policy
organizational compliance Azure policy
enforces standards and assesses
compliance at scale such as enforcing
compliance labels on all resources cost
control policies can prevent over
provisioning to save costs like limiting
the creation of high class VNS security
enhancements policies can improve
security by enforcing configurations for
example requiring secure transfer for
All Storage accounts resource
consistency policies can enforce
consistent configurations like a
specific naming convention or tag
structure Regulatory Compliance policies
can ensure specific configurations for
Regulatory Compliance such as data
hosting in specific regions for data
sovereignty so that's in brief overview
of azure
[Music]
policies the scope of an Azure policy is
the set of resources that the policy is
applied to when you assign a policy you
define the scope at which the policy is
enforced this could be as broad as a
management group or as specific as a
single resource the hierarchy of Scopes
and Azure are like other Scopes like
asure resource manager or rbac it moves
from brought to specific in the
following order Management Group greater
than subscription greater than Resource
Group greater than resource at each
level you can apply different policies
as per your requirements policies apply
higher levels of the hierarchy are
inherited by all the lower levels this
structure provides a powerful mechanism
for applying broad organizational
policies while still allowing for
flexibility and customization at lower
levels it's a key part of how Azure
enables you to manage and control your
resources effectively and in a way that
suits your organizational
[Music]
needs hey this is Andrew Brown from
exampro and we'll go over the anatomy of
an Azure policy definition file display
name this serves as an identifier for
the policy and has a 128 character limit
type this field which is red only
indicates the source of the policy it
could be guiltin maintained by Microsoft
custom created by you or static
Microsoft owned and typically pertains
to Regulatory Compliance description
this provides the context of the policy
metadata this optional field is used to
store key value information on the
policy though this determines which res
resource types are evaluated and changes
whether resource provider or Azure
resource manager is used resource
manager modes include all this includes
resource groups subscriptions and all
resource types and indexed this only
includes resource types that support
tags and location resource provider
modes were used in deprecated services
like Microsoft container service data
and are now primarily utilized in
services like Microsoft kubernetes data
and Microsoft key Vault data moving on
to parameters parameters are values
passed into the policy to improve its
flexibility a parameter has the
following properties name the identifier
for the parameter type could be a string
array object Boolean integer float or
datetime metadata utilized by Azure to
display userfriendly information such as
description display name strong type
assign permissions default value an
optional field to set a default
parameter value allowed values an
optional field for setting accepted
parameter values you reference
parameters by using field and in next
let's go over the policy rule so this
consists of if and then blocks in the if
block you define one or more conditions
that specify when the policy is enforced
you can apply logical operators to these
conditions to precisely Define the
scenario for a
policy the next concept we'll look into
is the policy Rule and policy effect
which is important in determining the
impact of the policy so we'll go over a
list of common policy effects deny if a
resource is created creation or update
doesn't adhere to the policy it fails
audit this creates a warning event in
the activity log when evaluating a
non-compliant resource but it doesn't
stop the request upend this effect adds
extra parameters or FS to the resource
during its creation or update for
example it could append tags on
resources like cost center or specify
allowed IP addresses for a storage
resource audit if not exists similarly
to the audit effect this creates a
warning event in the activity log when a
resource doesn't comply with the policy
but it doesn't stop the request audit is
used to audit the properties of a
resource while audit if not exists is
used to audit the existence of a related
resource deploy if not exists this
effect executes a template deployment
when a specific condition is met for
example if SQL encryption is enabled on
a database a template can be executed
after the database creation to configure
it in a specific way and the last one is
disabled this effect turns off the
policy rule often used for testing
purposes these policy effects provide a
range of resp responses to
non-compliance enabling you to manage
your resources according to your
organization specific
[Music]
requirements hey this is angrew Brown
from exam Pro and we're going to take a
look at how to keep things compliant
within our Azure account with Azure
policy so let's make our way over to the
Azure policy portal by typing policy at
the top here and right away you can see
already that I have a policy assigned I
didn't sign this Azure did this for me
by default and it's a great way to start
understanding how this is useful so I'm
going to go ahead and just click into
that one there and this is an initiative
uh policy meaning that it's made up of a
bunch of policies we'll go over that
over in a moment but you can see here
that's saying hey you should turn on all
these things they're not turned on by
default so you should turn them on and
these are ones that you have not turned
on you might not want to consider
turning some of these on uh if you have
to consider costs but I think most of
these are free um but that's something
that you'll have to decide on your own
uh but that gives you a general idea
there so let's go back to policy at the
top on left hand side here we can see
our assignments and here I have that
initiative type there if I click into it
allows me to edit it there uh and what's
really nice is if I want to disable it I
could just disable it uh but I think
this is a default one so oh no I can
disable it okay great and you can see it
was assigned by who uh and then you can
also uh take remediation actions uh here
so by default this assignment will only
take effect on newly created uh
resources existing resources can be
updated via a remediation task after the
policy is assigned so if you need this
apply to ones that are created or or
prior or updated that's something you
might want to do but anyway we'll get
out of there and we'll go take a look at
all the big list of predefined uh
definitions uh that Azure gives us so
this is a great way for us to get
started um you'll notice on the right
hand side we have initiative and we have
policy again initiative is a collection
of policies down below and these are
individual ones let's just go take a
look at some uh policies and maybe we we
can go apply one to like a virtual
machine um so what I'm going to do is
just drop down um this here and we can
just unselect here and let's just go
take a look do we have one called
virtual machines not really um but we we
go for compute here and we can just take
a look here so uh audit virtual machine
without Disaster Recovery let's take a
look at that
one and I just want to see the full
description here audit virtual machine
without Disaster Recovery configured I
think that sounds really good to me so
I'm going to go ahead and assign that
and we can choose a
scope and so I'm going to choose my
subscription here and then we can choose
a resource Group and you're going to
notice that I don't actually have any
resources so uh to scope that within so
what we'll go do is launch ourself a
virtual machine so make our way over to
the virtual machine um portal here we'll
add a virtual
machine and I want something really
cheap and so here it's set to a more
expensive one because I was launching a
Windows Server uh previously but I want
the cheapest server I can get actually
before I do that I'm just going to go
back and oh yeah it's on Ubuntu just
making sure and the one I had that was
really cheap is the B1
LS and so I'm just going to go up here
to the top we'll name this
beour and uh we'll put in the beour
group
there um this size does not support
Azure spot that's totally fine I don't
need spot did I turn that on by accident
oh I
did and this all looks fine to me I'm
not going to be logging into this
machine we just want to launch it up as
an example I'm going to move to standard
SSD CU I don't need premium here and
this looks fine to me we'll go ahead and
hit review and create so uh we'll go
ahead and create
that and I guess we have to download
that private key probably a good idea
we're not going to use it for anything
but that's
okay
and now it's deploying let's see if we
can select the scope as it's creating
I'm not sure if it'll let us do that I'm
just going to hit cancel here and reopen
here and let's see if it shows up now it
doesn't so uh we'll just wait a moment
here uh I'll go back to my policy
here and I'm just going to wait for this
server to create and once that is
created um what we'll do is we'll just
come back here and see if we can now
scope that all right so after a short
little wait um our server is ready here
so let's make our way back to our policy
here and uh I guess I lost it so I have
to go back to
definitions and we'll drop down
categories deselect we'll go to
compute and we'll go ahead and uh click
on Disaster Recovery again here you can
see the policy and its entirety so
that's kind of nice uh we'll go ahead
and assign that and we'll choose our
scope so we'll go back here choose
subscription one now we should have
beour and I'll go ahead and hit select
uh we can assign it exclusions not
something I'm going to do today um there
is the name of it that's totally fine
then we can hit enabled and I'm the one
who's enabling it so that sounds like a
good idea we'll go next uh we're going
to leave REM remediation off we don't
need to do that today we'll hit create
uh and so now this policy is assigned it
says here please note that the
assignment takes around 30 minutes to
take effect so if we work our way back
here and look at
assignments um I don't see it here yet
so there it
is and um it's probably not going to
show us on this there so we'll go back
to our
overview and so I want to see it hasn't
started yet so we'll just wait for a
while here might take 30 minutes might
take 10 not sure and we'll just see what
happens this should show up as
non-compliant but let's see that
actually happen all right so after
waiting a little while here I think it
was about 15 20 minutes we can now see
that it's saying that it's non-compliant
so we'll go ahead and click into
there and we can see what exactly it is
complaining about
let me click over to that
resource so there you go it's not too uh
complicated there uh we'll go ahead and
just uh delete that
assignment and uh if you're wondering
where blueprints are they're all the way
over here we talked about blueprints in
the actual course not something we
actually have to do because it is
probably a better way of uh doing things
I just wanted to point that out uh to
you um but yeah there you go so it's as
simple as
that
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this section we'll be covering
Azure resource manager Azure resource
manager is a service that allows you to
manage Azure resources Azure resource
manager is a collection of services in
the Azure portal so you can't simply
type in Azure resource manager in the
search tab it is a management layer that
allows you to create update or delete
resources apply management features such
as access controls locks or tags and
right infrastructure is code using Json
templat
we will be examining the following key
components that form the Azure resource
manager layer we have subscriptions
management groups resource groups
resource providers resource locks Azure
blueprints as well as resource tags
Access Control role-based access
controls Azure policies and arm
templates you can think of azure
resource manager as a gatekeeper all of
the requests flow through arm and it
decides whether that request can be
performed on a resource such as the
creation updating and deletion of a
virtual machine and its arm's
responsibility to authenticate and
authorize these requests arm uses
azure's role-based Access Control to
determine whether a user has the
necessary permissions to carry out a
request when a request is made arm
checks the users assigned roles and the
permissions associated with those roles
if the user has the necessary
permissions the request is allowed
otherwise it is
denied the next concept we'll go over is
the scope for Azure resource manager
we've briefly covered scope in Azure
policy and Azure rbac but we'll go into
more detail with them in the following
sections for
arm so scope is a boundary of control
for Azure resources it is a way to
govern your resource by placing
resources within a logical grouping and
applying logical restrictions in the
form of rules management groups are a
logical grouping of multiple
subscriptions subscriptions Grant you
access to Azure Services based on a
billing and support agreement resource
groups are a logical grouping of
multiple resources and resources can be
a specific Azure service such as Azure
VM
so that's an overview of azure resource
[Music]
manager Azure management groups provide
a way to manage multiple subscriptions
by organizing them into a hierarchical
structure every directory is assigned a
single top level management group known
as The Root Management Group this root
group forms the base of the hierarchy
and can have multiple management groups
or subscriptions nested under it one of
the key benefits of using management
groups is that all subscriptions within
a Management Group automatically inherit
the conditions apply to the Management
Group some important facts about
management groups you should know are a
single directory can support up to
10,000 management groups the hierarchy
of a Management Group tree can be up to
six levels deep not including the root
level or the subscription level each
Management Group and subscription could
have only one parent each Management
Group could have multiple children all
subscriptions and management groups
exist within a single hierarchy in each
directory so that's a short overview of
azure management
[Music]
groups before you can do anything in
your Azure account you'll need to have a
subscription an Azure account can have
multiple subscriptions and the most
commonly used ones are free trial pay as
you go and Azure for students for
example if you wanted developer support
you would add a developer support
subscription to your account once a
subscription is set up it provides you
with the ability to configure various
settings and features features such as
resource tags these allow you to
categorize your resources according to
your organizational needs access
controls helps manage access and
permissions for your Azure resources
resources groups are logical containers
in which Azure resources are deployed
and managed cost management and billing
provides tools to track and manage your
Cloud spending and more these features
provide you with a high degree of
flexibility and control over your Azure
resources allowing you to manage your
resources effectively and
securely
the next topic will be covering a
resource groups so a resource Group is a
container that holds related resources
for an Azure solution for example you
might have a resource Group that
contains multiple virtual machines for a
specific project or application as for
resources these are manageable items
available through Azure a resource could
be an individual entity like a virtual
machine next we have resource providers
these are services that Supply Azure
resources an example of a resource
provider is Microsoft compute which
provides compute resources like VMS in
order to use Azure resources you have to
register resource providers many
resource providers are registered by
default for you with your subscription
however for certain resources you may
need to manually register the resource
provider this image shows a list of
resource providers available in Azure
and in the status you can see if they
are either registered or not registered
you can register resource providers
under your subscription in the Azure
portal through Azure Powershell or Azure
CLI this ensures you have access to the
latest resources and features provided
by that
[Music]
service the next topic we'll explore our
resource tags so a tag is a pair
consisting of a key and a value that you
can assign to Azure resources these tags
can be used to categorize resources
based on different criteria relevant to
your organization here are some examples
of tags Department equals Finance status
equals approved approved team equals
compliance environment equals production
project equals Enterprise location
equals West us tags allow you to
organize your resources in the following
ways Resource Management tags can help
you sort and manage resources based on
specific workloads or environments such
as developer environments cost
management and optimization tags can be
used for cost tracking setting budgets
and creating alerts operations
management tags can be used to manage
business commitments and service level
agreement operations such as Mission
critical Services security tags can be
used for classifying data and assessing
security impact helping you manage your
security posture other helpful ways
include governance and Regulatory
Compliance Automation and workload
optimization all in all tags provide a
flexible customizable method for
managing your Azure resources according
to your specific
[Music]
needs the next topic will be covering a
res resource locks resource locks are a
critical feature in Azure that helps
Safeguard important resources from
accidental modifications or deletions as
an admin you may need to lock a
subscription Resource Group or resource
to prevent other users from accidentally
deleting or modifying critical resources
especially in environments with multiple
administrators or automated processes in
the Azure portal you can set the
following lock levels him not delete
this lock ensures authorized users can
still read and modify a resource but
they can't delete the resource
read only this lock ensures authorized
users can read a resource but they can
delete or update the resource there are
a number of ways to manage locks here
are some of them Azure portal you can
easily create View and delete locks
through the Azure portal Azure poers
shell UCM dlet like new as resource lock
to manage locks Azure CLI commands like
as lock create help manage locks Azure
resource manage your templates you can
also Define locks in your arm
templates
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this section we'll be covering
Azure blueprints Azure blueprints enable
quick creation of govern subscriptions
the key term here is governed while one
can easily create a subscription in
their account a govern subscription
indicates there's a process and set
expectations for how the subscription
should be configured Azure blueprints
allow you to compose artifacts based on
common patterns or those specific to an
organization into reusable blueprints
the service is designed to help with
environment set
environment setup blueprints are a
declarative way to orchestrate the
deployment of various resource templates
and other artifacts such as Ro
assignments policy assignments Azure
resource manager templates resource
groups Azure blueprint Services powered
by the globally distributed Azure Cosmos
DB ensuring blueprint objects are
replicated across multiple regions
providing redundancy and
resilience a common query is the
difference between an arm template and
an Azure blueprint
nearly everything that you want to
include for deployment in Azure
blueprints can be accomplished with an
arm template with arm templates you can
store them either locally or in Source
control there isn't an active connection
or relationship to the arm template post
deployment on the other hand Azure
blueprints maintain a connection between
the blueprint definition what should be
deployed and the blueprint assignment
what has been deployed Azure blueprints
can upgrade multiple subscriptions
simultaneously if they're governed by
the same blueprint this means Azure
blueprint supports Improv tracking and
auditing of deployments so that's an
overview of azure
[Music]
blueprints hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and what we're going to be
doing is moving resources from one
Resource Group to another and
understanding the limitations around
that uh so I just have this page pulled
up here because I just want to emphasize
that I've seen exam questions on this
stuff and there's a lot of little
nitty-gritty things that could show up
as a solution so the idea is that when
you're talking about about moving
resources um you know you're moving them
uh into different regions or to
different subscriptions or different
resource groups and generally they're
pretty straightforward but there are
some edge cases where uh things will not
work as expected and that's based on um
some particular services so when we're
looking at app Services devop Services
classic deployment Network movement
guidance Recovery Services virtual
machines so I definitely know that for
app Services you're going to run into
issues uh like if you're moving from uh
one subscription to another and you
already have a web app uh service in the
one that you're moving it into it won't
allow you to do it and so there's a lot
of little things like that
okay um and also if you are migrating
them you can go ahead and use the
diagnostic tool to uh debug it and it
will tell you some additional
information so you will have to read
through all of these I just can't show
you all that in a follow along um but
what we'll do is we'll just go through
the basics here of moving things between
between resource groups and so what
we'll need is a few resource groups so
I'm going to add a new one and we're
going to call this one the USS fed or
the Federation of
planets and we'll put that uh East
us and then we will make another
Resource Group and we'll call this the
Klingon
Empire and for fun we will place it in
uh West
so we'll go ahead and create that so now
we just need something we can move
around back and forth so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to make my way over
to diss because that's a great example
of something we can move around and
change and so I'm going to add a new
dis and uh I'm going to place this in
the
Federation and I'm just going to say um
dilithium I can never spell that right
right let's see if I can get the proper
spelling for this thing that is not real
di lithium
here and so it's going to be over here I
don't care about availability zones and
stuff like that Source type this is
fine and so we have the initial size I
do not need a drive that big let's go
super
small uh we could even do an hcd because
those are even cheaper and we'll just
choose the small size down
here um and so we'll pick
32 and so this should be alal encryption
networking we don't really care we're
not doing anything other than moving
this around so we'll go ahead and review
and
create right and so then we'll go create
that
resource and we'll just wait a little
while here it shouldn't take too
long all right so the dis is ready so
we'll go to this resource and here it is
so now let's say we want to move that to
our other resource Group which is in
another region what we're going to do is
we're going to go back to our resource
groups
here and if we go into the Federation of
planets what we can do is uh go to
overview select the dis go over here and
say move to another Resource Group and
I'll just click these other ones to show
you I don't have any other subscriptions
to move this to um so I'll just go back
there I thought maybe could show you
some stuff but I just realized I don't
have much in this account or with other
subscriptions so we'll just go back to
overview here and just move it to
another Resource Group and technically
we're moving it to another region so
we'll see how that
goes um and so we will
select um the klling on Empire I
understand that the tools and scripts
associated with the will not work uh etc
etc so we'll hit
okay
and that's going to take a little bit of
time to move so while that is going I'm
going to make a new tab so we don't lose
that history there I just want to talk
about some settings you can put on your
resource groups so if we go into the
Kling on Empire and we go down below
here we should have the ability to apply
locks and there are a few different
types of locks we have readon and delete
so readon means it's a readon resource
and delete means we cannot delete the
resource which makes sense right so read
only should mean we shouldn't be able to
modify this so I'm going to say uh don't
touch do not
touch and I say okay here and so what
that means is that I should not be able
to
modify the resource uh whether I can
delete it or not is another story we'll
find that out and another question is
can I move that resource outside of this
if it's set to those modes and that's
what we're going to find out so moving
back over here um has this finished
moving it's still validating so we're
going to have to wait a little bit here
and I'll see you back in a moment all
right so after waiting a little while
here I believe that it's done moving so
I'm still in my old Resource Group here
what we'll do is click back into here go
to overview and we see that it's no
longer there but if we go over to the
cing on Empire we go back over just
clicking to overview there it is so we
had no problems moving the dis to
another region and another Resource
Group now we did apply this lock over
here so what is going to happen when we
try to
modify this dis I think you know the
answer but let's give it a go just to
see what happens so over here we're
going to want to uh re resize it here
I'm going to pick 64 I'm going to go hit
resize and it says fail to update the
dis because of that reason so um there
you cannot perform a right operation
because of the lock so there you go um
now let's go back and we are going to go
apply uh another lock here this time I'm
going to make it so you can't delete it
and so we say don't do not delete
me all right and so what we'll do is
we'll go back uh and we'll try to delete
it so we'll hit the delete button we'll
say Yes again it says you cannot do it
now here's the next question can you
move that resource out or in to Resource
Group if it has lock or read only on uh
and that's what I want you to guess
whether you can or not CU you are in
read only so would you be able to move
something that's readon so we'll go
ahead and move it we're going to move
this to another Resource Group and I'm
going to send it back to the Federation
of planets I say I understand hit okay
and it failed the check we'll see why
cannot perform the right operation
because there are locks please remove
some of the locks so which is it is it
delete is it the read only do I have to
remove both that's what we need to go
find out so back in our Resource Group
I'm going to go ahead and first remove
parent resource locks can't be edited
here okay that's fine so we'll go back
to here and we will go into the locks
and we'll first delete the
readon and then what we'll do is we will
attempt
to uh delete this
again see what happens it looks like
it's moving so it's not that you can't
move it uh out if it's in readon or
sorry in delete but you but you can't if
it's read only because it's readon right
now when we're talking about moving
resources into a group that's set to
read only I'm almost certain that you
can absolutely do that um so uh we could
stage that I guess just to make sure so
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to set up another Resource Group just to
make sure that we we know this for
certain just in case I Wrong the star
the Romulan star
Empire Romulan star
Empire and I'm going to just leave in
the same region and so for this one in
particular what I'm going to do is apply
a readon I might as well just put both
on here but I'll just I'm just going to
do read only and we'll say do not delete
me and then what I'll do is I'll go back
to the Federation
planets and I'm just going to actually
I'll just go to discs and we'll create a
new dis here
um and we will place it in the
Federation
here and we will just say um dark
matter or
antimatter and we will just change this
to hhd as small as we can go we'll
review and create that and we'll go
ahead and create
that and this will not take long we do
not have to wait that long for
this and notice here that
um we could not uh this is interesting
so there was an error moving the
resource moving resources failed because
resource grou Federation has active
deployment so if you are moving stuff uh
and then you do deploy it's going to
cancel that deploy so that's interesting
to know um so I believe that this new
one is deployed I cannot remember I
think we set this one to have read only
here on the um what do you call it the
uh rulin star Empire which isn't showing
up there it is just double check there
so the question is can I move a resource
into a
readon we'll go
here and uh I guess we need to actually
go to the Federation of
planets we'll go to overview view we
have antimatter and I want to move
that into
Romulan star Empire say I
understand it'll either say we can or we
can't and we absolutely can otherwise it
would aired out at this point so
hopefully you can keep that straight so
you can move a resource into a group
that has readon you cannot move it out
if it's set you can absolutely move it
out if it's set to delete delete just
protects against delete if you are
moving your resource from one Resource
Group to another uh and then you deploy
something it's going to cause that
movement to fail and then there's those
edge cases for uh moving Resources with
Azure and that's something you should
spend some time reading up on those use
cases or maybe I'll just uh pick out the
most important ones and put it into a
cheat sheet all right uh and so what I'm
going to do is just go ahead and clean
this stuff up um so what I'm need to do
here is go and and remove the delete I
think it's only on here so if I go to my
locks I'm going to go back to Resource
groups
here and we will delete the locks
here and so now I can go ahead and
delete
these groups I guess I have to do them
one by one which is kind of annoying but
that's just how it
goes
[Music]
it says it's locked it's not locked
anymore oh it's still there look at
that
okay could have swore I definitely uh
did something there there we
go
and we will go ahead and delete the last
one there we are so yeah hopefully you
know a bit more about moving resources
[Music]
around hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this segment we'll be
diving into arm templates so what
exactly is infrastructure is code
infrastructure is code is the process of
managing and provisioning computer data
centers such as those in Azure using
machine readable definition files like
JSO n files rather than depending on
physical Hardware configuration or
interactive configuration tools you
write a script that will set up cloud
services for you there are two main
approaches to IAC declarative here you
describe your desired outcome and the
system figures out how to achieve it
imperative here you provide Specific
Instructions detailing exactly how to
reach the desired State arm templates or
JSO n files that Define Azure resources
you want to provision and Azure Services
you want to configure with arm templates
you can ensure a declarative approach
meaning you merely Define your intended
setup and the system handles the rest
build remove or share entire
architectures in minutes reduce
configuration mistakes and know exactly
what you have defined for a stack to
establish an architecture Baseline for
compliance or over arm templates Empower
you to establish an architecture
Baseline for compliance achieve
modularity break up your architecture in
multiple files and reuse them Ensure
sensibility add Powershell and Bash
scripts to your templates test using the
arm template toolkit preview changes
before you create infrastructure via
template see what it will create
built-in validation will only deploy
your template if it passes track
deployments keep track of changes to
architecture over time policy is code
apply Azure policies to ensure you
remain compliant use Microsoft
blueprints which Forge a connection
between a resource and its template
integrate with CI CD Pipelines utilize
exportable code letting you capture the
current state of resource groups and
individual resources and benefit from
Advanced authoring tools for instance
Visual Studio code offers sophisticated
features tailored for crafting arm
templates so as you can see arm
templates has quite a lot of
[Music]
uses all right moving forward let's
delve into the structure or the skeleton
of arm templates skeleton is a term used
to describe the basic framework
structure of an arm template think of it
as the blueprint that guides how an arm
template should be organized and what
elements it should contain schema this
describes the properties that are
available within a template content
version this denotes the version of your
template you can provide any value for
this element API profile use this value
to avoid having to specify API versions
for each resource in the template
parameters these are the dynamic values
you feed into your template when you're
deploying or updating resources it
offers flexibility and enabling you to
use the same template in different
scenarios or environments just by
changing the parameter values variables
this is where you can process or
transform the parameters or resource
Properties by using function Expressions
you can manipulate input values making
your template more Dynamic and adaptable
functions within the arm template you
can Define user specific functions this
allows for reusable custom logic
reducing redundancy and simplifying the
template resources here you list out all
the Azure resources you intend to deploy
update it defines what your
infrastructure looks like and how each
component is configured outputs after a
successful deployment you might want to
retrieve specific values or results the
output section is where you define these
values be at the IP address of a newly
created VM or the URL of a web app
overall an arm template skeleton
provides a structured and consistent
approach to Define deploy and manage
Azure
[Music]
resources moving forward let's just
discuss one of the pivotal components of
the arm template the resources resource
this represents any Azure component or
service you wish to provision it could
be a virtual machine a database or a
network interface Etc type this defines
the kind of resource you're provisioning
this typically follows the format of
resource provider /resource type for
instance if you're looking to create a
storage account you'd use the type
microsoft. storage SL storage accounts
API version each resource type
corresponds to an API version which is
essentially the version of the rest API
used for that particular resource it's
important to note that each resource
provider published has its own API
versions so you need to ensure you're
using the correct one for your chosen
resource name this attribute specifies
the unique name of the resource for
example if you're setting up a virtual
machine this could be my virtual machine
location this is a common attribute for
most resources it determines the Azure
region where your resource will be
deployed such as East us or west Europe
other property beyond the basic
attributes each resource type has its
own set of properties that allow for
deeper configuration these properties
can very widely depending on the
resource for a virtual machine it could
be the size or the operating system for
a database it might be the capacity or
replication
[Music]
settings in this segment we'll delve
into a fundamental component of arm
templates the parameters parameters play
a critical role in arm templates they
allow you to pass specific values into
your template thus allowing you to
create more flexible and dynamic
infrastructure
configurations defining a parameter as
shown in the example to define a
parameter named storage name it's a
tight string with a minimum length of
five characters and a maximum length of
20 characters once you've defined a
parameter you can then reference it in
various parts of your template such as
type API version name and so forth type
dictates the expected data type for the
input value common types include string
secur string in bu object secure object
and array default value if no value is
provided it will be set to default value
allowed values this is an array of
allowed values Min value the minimal
possible value max value the maximum
possible value Min length the maximum
length of characters or array max length
the maximum length of characters or
array description the description that
will be displayed to the in the Azure
portal in summary parameters are the The
Gatekeepers of customization and arm
templates the next topic we'll be
covering are the arm template functions
functions and arm templates are powerful
tools that allow you to transform and
manipulate your arm variables think of
them as the building blocks that enable
you to create more Dynamic and flexible
configurations template functions these
are built-in functions provided by Azure
for a wide range of common tasks user
defined functions these are custom
functions you can create to cater to
specific needs that aren't addressed by
the built-in template functions
functions are called using parentheses e
such as the example shown here
categories of template functions array
functions tools for handling arrays some
of these include array concat contains
create array empty first Etc comparison
functions for equating or contrasting
values coess equals less lesser equals
greater and greater or equals date
functions to manipulate and time date
time ad UTC now deployment functions
pertaining to the deployment itself
deployment environment parameters and
variables logical functions for logical
operations and or if not numeric
functions mathematical and numeric
operations add copy index div float int
min max Etc object functions for object
manipulation contains empty intersection
Json length and Union resource functions
related to Azure resources extension
resource ID list account SAS list Keys
list Secrets Etc string functions for
string manipulation and evaluation base
64 Bas 64 to Json base 64 to string
concat contains Etc we won't go over all
of them but this is just to show you
that there are a lot of functions
available to
[Music]
you the next topic we'll cover are the
arm template variables template
variables are used to simplify your arm
templates you transform parameters and
resource properties using functions and
then assign them into a reusable
variable in this example the storage
name variable is computed by combining a
parameter named storage name prefix with
a unique string derived from the
resource groups ID to call a variable
you use the variable function as shown
in this
example sometimes your templates might
become more intricate and you may need a
hierarchical structure to your variables
that's where nested variable come in you
can use JSO and object to have nested
variables to scope your variables for
multiple use cases scoping nesting
variables based on environment consider
scenarios where you have configurations
That Vary based on the environment like
test or prod you might want to neatly
encapsulate variables specific to each
environment within a JSO n object as
shown in the example you can use
parameters to choose the environment and
then reference nested variables as
followed in the example variables
parentheses square brackets
dotproperty overall variables and R
templates are powerful tools that can
simplify your template make it more
adaptable and improve its
maintainability the arm templates are
just about defining and provisioning
resources they also offer a way to fetch
information about the deploy resources
this is where the output section of your
arm templates comes into play outputs
returns values from deployed resources
so you can use them programmatically
for example you might want to know the
static IP of a created VM or the
connection string of a deployed database
you specify the type and value under
outputs here the output name resourc it
is capturing the ID of a public IP
address resource it's noteworthy that
the type is explicitly mentioned
ensuring type safety once your resources
are deployed these outputs can be
fetched using Azure CLI po shell or the
Azure sdks for instance with Azure CLI
this command retrieves the resourced
output value from a specific deployment
in a resource Group so that's a quick
overview of outputs and arm
[Music]
templates hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at Azure
resource manager templates also known as
arm templates and this helps you uh
deliver infrastructure as code meaning
that when you have a resource such as a
virtual machine or a storage account
instead of manually configuring it every
single time through um uh the portal
what you can do is provide a
configuration file that defines finds
all the properties that you want it to
be configured with and the idea is that
you can uh keep this file and share with
other uh other people so they can easily
uh create the same resources as you and
then you know exactly how your stuff is
is configured so what we're going to do
is uh launch a new template now you
can't go up here and just type in arm
because these arm templates are managed
uh at different levels so at one level
is subscription or the resource groups
so when you have a resource Group you
have deployments within them and that's
where uh these templates are deployed uh
but just to deploy one from here what
we're going to do is type in deploy why
they didn't make it so you can type an
arm I do not know but if you go down
here we have deploy a custom template
and so from here we have some common
templates so if I click into web app and
I go edit a template we already have
some stuff pre-filled in I'm just going
to go back and discard that go back to
select a template and we're going to
build our own and by default we'll have
that schema that content version which
is 1.0.0 point0 our parameters and our
resources so today I want to launch a
virtual machine and uh what you normally
would have to do is go here uh and look
up what is that you want to create so if
it's this uh Microsoft compute virtual
machine you'd go through here and you'd
have to make sure you have all these uh
properties so you define the resource
here right the type um and then you
define the properties that you want and
down below you can go through here and
see them all that's a lot of work I
don't want to do that so I'll go to add
resource here drop this down and click
uh where is it virtual machine where are
you there you are and I'm going to call
this one Warf and Warf and Warf because
it's not just going to create a virtual
machine it's going to create other
things uh that I need with it as well
such as the storage account the network
interface and the virtual Network so you
can see that we have a bunch of
parameters here so the name the type the
name the admin username the password and
the OS version oh you know what I think
I chose a window Windows one I do not
want a Windows one I want a Linux one
because that is easier for me to work
with here so we choose ubun 2 so I'll
just fill this in
again all right and so um back up here
you know we have the Ubuntu version
between some versions here and then
there's the type so that's for uh
replication then we have variables here
so if we go to VM size this is the VM it
will it will set here uh variables are
either you can have string values or you
can use function to transform other
parameters into other stuff that you'll
reference throughout your template then
down below we have those resources here
so what we'll do is um actually I'm
going to copy this because it's it's
very highly likely we're going to want
to make some kind of change and so I
have vs code over here on the on the
left right hand side I'm just going to
paste that on in there um and what we
will do this is a Json file make things
a little bit easier here great and what
I'll do is just move that off screen and
we'll go ahead and we will save this and
we'll see if we can deploy
this so I'm going to type in Warf here
and we'll launch in Canada east I'll
name this Warf we will name the username
Warf but lowercase and then we'll do
testing 1 2 3 4 5 6 capital on the T
notice that it is uh hidden there and
then we will choose 14 which is
defaulted here and lrs we'll go ahead
and do review and
create and we'll hit create here
so this is going to fail I already know
because it has a misconfiguration it'll
tell us how but while that's going we'll
take a look at our input so this is the
values that were inputed these are the
outputs if we had defined any which we
have not um and if we go back to our
template I just wanted to show you that
we have that secure string so when we
were typing our password that's why we
didn't see it um so just things like
that so I'll go back up here and our
deploy failed why what happened so we
open it up here the requested VM size
standard D1 is not available in the
current region so the template we have
is not that great um it it needs some
configuration because we can't use D1 I
think that doesn't exist anymore and so
what we really want to use is the
standard B1 LS all right standard B1 LS
so I'm going to cut that and for the
time being I'm going to go back to our
original
template and this is one big template
I'm going to look for those variables oh
they're all the way at the bottom here
nice and so I'm going to just go ahead
and paste that in B1 LS just double
check making sure I spelled that right
standard uh standard B1 LS looks good to
me so I'm going to move that off screen
and the question is what do we do what
do we do when a deploy fails so let's go
take a look at what has happened here so
this all got deployed into a resource
Group and under here this is where our
deployments are
so when we look at this
template it we can see that it failed we
can click into here get the same
information um and if we click into here
it just brings us back to where we just
were but if we go look at what was
actually deployed uh under our Resource
Group under the overview we'll notice
that it created the virtual Network the
storage account and the network
interface so when it fails it creates
what it can but it doesn't roll back
okay so the question is is then how do
you do cleanup so you might think I'll
go to deployments and what I'll do is go
ahead and delete that template and we
can go ahead and do that which by the
way you can't edit this template all you
can do is um all we can do here see I
just want to show you that you cannot
edit it we can download it and stuff
like that but uh so you might think well
if I go ahead and delete that
template just making sure we're in the
right place
here you might think that might roll
back those resources but it doesn't it
just deletes the template so if you
really want to get rid of this stuff
what you got to do is go ahead and
delete all these resources
manually so um I wish it kind of had a
roll back feature but that's just how it
is but there are some nice things that
uh Azure does here which we'll talk
about in a moment so I think we have
adjusted it to the correct value now so
hopefully this is going to be all we
need to make it work so what we'll
do is go to our deployments here
uh and we can't do it here but so we'll
go back to the top here and type in
deploy and we'll go to custom
template and what we'll do is build our
own template in our editor and I'm just
going to copy the contents
here okay we'll go
copy and I will go paste and we'll make
sure that this is all good looks fine to
me we'll go ahead and hit save and we
will choose Warf so we don't have to
make a new one and we will fill in uh
the name as Warf username is Warf I'll
call Warf 2 just in case helps us keep
track of what we're doing here testing 1
2 3 4 5 6 with a capital on the
T 14 L RLS lrs and we'll go ahead oh we
have one issue here cannot deploy
Resource Group worth
deleting uh we'll go back
and we will hit create here I don't
think I deleted the resource Group let
me just go double
check I almost I'm almost certain I
deleted all the contents of it
right oh so there's already one here so
we're just waiting for that to
delete just going to go delete for us
please thank
you it failed to delete we'll go take a
look as to
why resources not
found
mhm uh we'll go back to our resource
groups give this a refresh
here okay so you know what I must have
deleted the resource Group which is
totally fine I I could have SW I only
delete the contents of it but we'll just
call this war regular then we'll go
ahead and hit uh great here and so this
time I have better feeling about
this and so we will just have to wait a
little bit it won't take too
long I'll see you back in a moment okay
so after waiting a little bit here our
uh our thing seems to be deployed so if
we go to Resource groups we can see that
our virtual machine is deployed so uh
that's pretty much all there is to it
one other thing I'd like to show you is
that whatever you have whatever is in
your resource Group you can actually
export the template so uh if you did
configure something manually all you'd
have to do is find the resource go up
here to well um it is export template
and there's your template and it just
has that single resource in there I
can't remember if if I go into here if I
select multiples um I go X or where is
it
export
template look it's going to include all
that stuff so if you already have
existing resources that you provisioned
and you want to have them that's what
you can do notice that some things won't
be included in the template when you do
that but you can just go ahead and
download them and then you have them for
later so yeah that's all there really is
to um arm other than learning the uh the
nitty gritties of the actual language
that's just how you work with it there
so what I'm going to do is make my way
over to my Resource Group group here and
I'm just going to go ahead and delete
this
here and we're all good to
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure monitor so Azure monitor
is a comprehensive solution for
collecting analyzing and acting on
Telemetry from your cloud and on
premises environments it serves as is
the backbone for gaining insight into
the performance and health of your
applications infrastructure and even the
network he features visual dashboards A
visual representation of your data smart
alerts intelligent notifications based
on specific conditions automated actions
set automation based on certain triggers
log monitoring track and analyze event
logs many Azure Services by default are
already sending Telemetry data to Azure
monitor what is observability it's the
ability to to measure and understand how
internal systems work in order to answer
questions regarding performance
tolerance security and faults with a
system or application to obtain
observability you need to use metrics
logs and traces you have to use them
together using them in isolation does
not gain you observability metrics a
number that is measured over a period of
time for example if we measured the CPU
usage and aggregated it over a period of
time we could have an average CPU metric
plugs a text file where each line
contains event data about what happened
at a certain time traces a history of
request that travels through multiple
apps or services so we can pinpoint
performance or failure looks like they
should have called it the Triforce of
observability the sources of common
monitoring data to populate data stores
order by highest to lowest application
operating system Azure resources Azure
subscription Azure tenant custom sources
the two fundamental data stores are
metrics and logs Azure monitor monor
functionalities insights this can be for
applications containers VMS or other
Monitoring Solutions visualize using
dashboards views powerbi and workbooks
you can create Rich visual presentations
of your data Analyze This involves
delving deep into metrics analytics and
log analytics respond Based on data
Azure monitor can alert you or even
autoscale resources integrate extend the
capabilities by using logic apps or
export APS for more flexibility overall
as your monitor is a comprehensive
solution vital for ensuring that your
applications and services run optimally
and any issues are detected and dealt
with
[Music]
properly the next topic we'll be
covering are the various sources from
which azzure monitor collects data
application code Azure monitor
application insights offers robust
metrics about the performance and
functionality of your applications and
code you'll get performance traces
application logs and even user Telemetry
you'll need to install instrumentation
package in your application to collect
data for application insights
availability tests measure your
application's responsiveness from
different locations on the public
internet this helps in assessing the
reliability and uptime of your services
nrixs descriptive data regarding your
application's performance operation and
custom metrics log store operational
data about your application including
page views application requests
exceptions and traces you can send
application data to azure storage for
archiving view the details of
availability tests stored and debug
snapshot data that is captured for a
subset of exceptions is stored in Azure
storage log analytics agent is installed
for comprehensive monitoring dependency
agent collects discovered data about
processes running on the virtual machine
and external process dependencies agents
can be installed on the OS for VMS
running in Azure on premises or other
Cloud providers Diagnostics extension
collect performance counters and store
them in metrics
application insights logs collect logs
and performance counters from the
compute resources supporting your
application allowing them to be analyzed
alongside other application data the
Azure Diagnostics extension always
writes to an Azure storage account while
Azure monitor for VMS uses the log
analytics agent to store Health State
information in a custom location the
Diagnostics extension can also stream
data to other locations using a vet hubs
resource logs provide insights into the
internal operation of an Azure resource
and are autom automatically created
however you must create a diagnostic
setting to specify a destination for
each resource platform metrics will
write to the Azure monitor metrics
database with no configuration you can
access platform metrics from metrics
Explorer for trending and other analyzes
use log analytics copy platform metrics
to logs send resource logs to Azure
storage for archiving stream metrics to
other locations using event
hubs Azure subscription this includes
Telemetry related to to the health and
operation of your Azure subscription
Azure service Health provides
information about the health of the
Azure services in your subscription that
your application and resources rely on
Telemetry related to your Azure tenant
is collected from tenant wide services
such as Azure active directory Azure
active directory reporting contains the
history of sign and activity and audit
trail of changes made within a
particular tenant for resources that
cannot be monitored using the other data
sources write this data to either
metrics or logs using an azure monitor
API this will allow you to collect log
data from any rest client and store it
in log analytics in the Azure monitor
metrics
[Music]
database Azure monitor is integral to
maintaining the health and performance
of your applications and resources
collecting two fundamental types of data
logs and metrics Azure monitor logs
collects and organizes log in
performance data from a variety of
monitored resources data consolidation
logs can be pulled from diverse sources
such as platform logs from Azure
services log and performance data from
Agents on Virtual machines and usage and
performance data from applications
workspaces all these logs are organized
into workspaces providing a centralized
repository for in-depth analysis query
language Azure monitor logs offers a
sophisticated query language which can
quickly analyze millions of Records
making it an ideal choice for complex
data analytics log analytics you can
interactively work with log queries and
their results using Azure log Analytics
tool in contrast Azure monitor metrics
collects numeric data and organizes it
into a Time series database here's why
that's important numeric data metrics
are numerical values captured at regular
intervals they are a snapshot that
describes a particular aspect of a
system at a specific Moment In Time
lightweight metrics are designed to be
lightweight allowing for near realtime
data analysis this makes them
particularly useful for alerting and the
rapid detection of issues metrics
Explorer the metrics Explorer tool
allows for interactive analysis of
metric data providing a more immediate
understanding of your system's
performance and
[Music]
health the next topic we'll cover are
the data retention and archive policies
of azure monitor logs this is an
important aspect of your monitoring
strategy as it allows you to control how
long your data remains stored and
accessible by default in the Azure
portal you can set this retention time
anywhere from 30 to 730 days for the
whole workspace if you want you can also
specify different storage durations for
certain tables within your workspace
letting you manage different types of
data as needed this gives you the
flexibility to meet any business or
regulatory rules about data storage
however note that to tweak these
retention settings you have to be on the
paage tier of azure monitor logs to set
retention and archive policy by table
why navigate to the Azure portal and go
to the log analytics workspace where the
data is stored to under the setting
section select usage and estimated cost
three then select data retention four in
the data retention blade you can modify
the retention period for each table by
default it is set to 31 days but you can
extend it up to 730 days five for
archiving data you can use Azure data
Explorer which lets you retain data
beyond the 2-year limit and gives you a
highly scalable analytic service so
that's an overview of the data retention
and archive policies of azure monitor
logs you'll most likely encounter a
question related to this on the exam so
be sure to know
[Music]
this hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure log analytics so log
analytics is a tool in the Azure portal
used to edit and run log queries with
data in Azure monitor logs log analytics
processes data from various sources and
transforms it into actionable insights
it ingests data from Azure monitor
windows and Linux agents Azure services
and other sources once the data is
collected you can use log analytics
query language to retrieve consolidate
and analyze the data log analytics uses
a query language called
kql now we'll go over some of the
benefits of log analytics centralized
log management collect and analyze data
from multiple sources both on premises
and in the cloud in a centralized
location powerful analytics utilize the
custo query language to run Advanced
analytics on large amounts of fast
streaming data in real time custom
dashboards create custom dashboards and
visualizations to display real-time data
and Trends integration seamless
integration with other Azure services
and Microsoft Solutions such as powerbi
and Azure Automation and alerting set up
alerts based on specific criteria to
proactively identify and respond to
potential issues before they affect your
users log analytics workspace is a
unique environment for Azure monitor log
data each workspace has its own data
repository and configuration and data
source and solutions are configured to
store their data in a particular
workspace so that's an overview of azure
log
[Music]
analytics the log analytics agent is a
lightweight agent that can be installed
on Windows and Linux machines to collect
and send log data to Azure monitor it
provides a way to centralize logs from
various sources and enables the analysis
of the data using tools like Azure
monitor logs Azure dashboards and Azure
monitor workbooks the agent can collect
logs from various sources including
Windows event logs custom logs
performance counters and CIS log it
supports both agent-based and agentless
data collection and can be configured to
collect data from on premises and
cloud-based
environments the log analytics agent is
set up to monitor certain Windows event
logs like security system or application
logs the data from these logs is then
gathered and sent to log analytics for
analysis using queries and
visualizations the log analytics agent
is set up to monitor CIS log servers or
network devices it collects data from
these sources and sends it to log
analytics allowing for detailed analysis
and troubleshooting both methods for
collecting log data allow for
centralized management and Analysis of
log data from multiple sources which can
help to improve visibility and
streamline troubleshooting and issue
resolution you can expect to see a
question related to log analytics agents
and choosing either Windows event logs
for a Windows agent or CIS log for Linux
agent on the
exam
[Music]
the next topic will be covering our
application insights application
insights is an application Performance
Management Service and it's a subservice
of azure monitor APM is all about the
monitoring and management of performance
and availability of software apps it
strives to detect and diagnose complex
application performance problems to
maintain an expected level of service so
yuse application insights automatic
detection of performance anomalies
application insights automatically
identifies performance anomalies in your
system powerful analytics tools it comes
with robust analytics tools to help you
diagnose issues and understand what
users do with your app continuous
Improvement it is designed to help you
continuously improve performance and
usability of your applications platform
agnostic it works for apps on net
node.js Java and python hosted on
premises hybrid or any public Cloud
devops integration it can be integrated
into your devops process and mobile app
monitoring it can monitor and analyze
Telemetry from mobile apps by
integrating with visual studio app
center to use application insights you
need to instrument your application this
involves installing the instrument
package or enabling application insights
using the application insights agents
were supported there are many ways to
view your Telemetry data apps can be
instrumented from anywhere when you set
up application insights monitoring for
your web app you create an application
insights resource in Microsoft azure you
open this resource in the azzure portal
in order to see and analyze the
Telemetry collected from your app the
resource is identified by an
instrumentation
key what does application insights
monitor request rates response times and
failure rates dependency rates response
times and failure rates exceptions page
views and low performance ax calls user
and session counts performance counters
post Diagnostics diagnostic Trace logs
and custom events and metrics
where do I see my Telemetry smart
detection and manual alerts application
map profiler usage analysis diagnostic
search for instance data metrics
Explorer for aurad data dashboards live
stream metrics analytics Visual Studio
ET overall application insights is a
comprehensive APM service that offers
automatic detection of performance
anomalies powerful analytics tools and
is designed to help you continuously
improve performance and usability
[Music]
in this segment we'll delve into the
topic of application insites
instrumentation so what is
instrumentation in simple terms it's a
way to make your application smarter by
adding a few lines of code or in some
cases none at all you can monitor how
your app performs and where it might be
running into issues you instrument your
application by adding the Azure
application insights SDK and
implementing traces in the case of a
node.js application you can install the
Azure application insights SDK using npm
with the following command npm install
application insights hyphen save
application insights this is the name of
the package you are installing which is
azure SDK for application insights
hyphen save this flag saves the package
as a dependency in your package.json n
file here this piece of code lets you
configure what you want to
collect Azure supports the following
languages net Java python node.js
JavaScript
Auto instrumentation allows you to
enable application monitoring with
application insights without changing
your code this table shows which Azure
Services support application insights
and in what programming languages the
services range from Azure app service on
Windows and Linux to Azure functions
Azure spring Cloud Azure kubernetes
service and more GA General availability
meaning it's fully supported and ready
to use public preview still being tested
but you can use it not supported you
can't use application sites here through
agent you need to install a special
piece of software to use this service o
NBD on by default meaning the feature is
automatically enabled through extension
available but needs an extension to work
we won't go through the entire table but
we'll give a few examples for
applications written in.net and hosted
on Azure app service on Windows
application insights is generally
available and enabled by default for
applications written in Python and
hosted on Azure functions application
insights is available and enabled by
default but for dependencies monitoring
you will need to use an extension so
that's an overview of application
insights
[Music]
instrumentation hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam proo and in this section we'll
be covering Microsoft Sentinel formerly
known as Azure Sentinel Microsoft
Sentinel is a scalable Cloud native
solution that encompasses two key
functionalities security information
event management this is all about
collecting and analyzing security
related data to provide real-time
analysis of security alerts generated by
applications and network Hardware
security orchestration automated
response this refers to the collection
of tools that enable an organization to
Define standardize measure and automate
responses to security events Microsoft
Sentinel delivers intelligent security
analytics and threat intelligence across
the Enterprise providing a single
solution for alert detection threat
visibility proactive hunting and threat
response with Microsoft Sentinel you can
collect data at Cloud scale across all
users devices applications and
infrastructure both on premises and in
multiple clouds detect previously
undetected threats and minimize false
positives using Microsoft's analytics
and unparalleled threat
intelligence investigate threats with
artificial intelligence and hunt for
suspicious activities at scale tapping
into years of cyber security work at
Microsoft respond to incidents rapidly
with built-in orchestration and
automation of common
tasks Microsoft Sentinel comes with a
number of connectors for Microsoft
Solutions such as Microsoft 365 Defender
Office
365 Azure a or Microsoft enter ID
Microsoft Defender for identity and
Microsoft Defender for cloud apps you
can use common event formats CIS logit
rest API Windows event logs common event
format and trusted automated the
exchange of indicator information
one notable feature of Microsoft
Sentinel is the ability to create Azure
monitor workbooks workbooks provide a
flexible canvas for data analysis and
the creation of Rich visual reports
within the Azure portal they allow you
to tap into multiple data sources from
across Azure and combine them into
unified interactive
experiences it tells a story about the
performance and availability about your
applications and services workbooks are
temporary workspaces to define a
document like format with visualization
intertwined to help investig and discuss
performance Microsoft Sentinel uses
analytics to correlate alerts into
incidents incidents are groups of
related alerts that together create an
actionable possible threat that you can
investigate and
resolve Microsoft Sentinels Automation
and orchestration solution provides a
highly extensible architecture that
enables scalable automation as new
technologies and threats emerge built on
the foundation of azure logic apps
includes 200 plus connectors for
services my Microsoft Sentinel also
offers deep investigation tools that
help you to understand the scope and
find the root cause of a potential
security threat you can choose an entity
on the interactive graph to ask
interesting questions for a specific
entity and drill down into that entity
and its connections to get to the root
cause of the
threat additionally Microsoft Sentinels
powerful hunting search and query tools
based on the miter framework enable you
to proactively hunt for security threats
across your organization's data sources
before an alert is triggered after you
discover which hunting query provides
high value insights into possible
attacks you can also create custom
detection rules based on your query and
surface those insights as alerts to your
security incident
responders while hunting you can create
bookmarks for interesting events
enabling you to return to them later
share them with others and group them
with other correlating events to create
a compelling incident for
investigation lastly let's talk about
pricing Microsoft Sentinel has two
different pricing models capacity
reservations this involves being build a
fix fee base on the selected tier
enabling a predictable total cost for
Microsoft Sentinel pay as you go with
this option Bill per gigabyte for the
volume of data ingested for analysis in
Microsoft Sentinel and stored in the
Azure monitor log analytics
workspace and there you have it a
comprehensive look at Microsoft Sentinel
a robust seam and Source solution that
can help protect your organization's
infrastructure applications and
[Music]
data hey this this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering the identity management best
practices we'll start things off by
discussing the principle of lease
privilege a term you may have come
across before so the principle of lease
privilege is a security principle that
states that users applications and
services should be granted only the
minimum access necessary to perform
their assigned tasks and no more in
Microsoft Azure the principle of lease
privilege is a critical aspect of
security that helps prevent unauthorized
access data breaches and other security
incidents
the principle of lease privilege in
Azure involves limiting access to Azure
resources such as virtual machines
storage accounts and databases as well
as Azure services such as Azure active
directory and Azure key Vault Azure
ro-based Access Control permits
administrators to Grant roles to users
groups and apps based on their access
levels following the principle of lease
privilege helps minimize unauthorized
access risks and potential harm from
compromised credentials thus reducing
the Azure environment's attack
surface following the principle of lease
privilege can help organizations comply
with regulatory requirements and best
practices for security to implement the
principle of lease privilege in Azure
administrators should follow these best
practices assign roles based on the
leaste amount of privilege needed to
perform the task monitor role
assignments and permissions regularly to
ensure they align with business
requirements limit the use of shared
accounts and use individual user
accounts where possible Implement
multiactor authentication to prevent
unauthorized access access to user
accounts use Azure policy to enforce
compliance with organizational policies
and Industry regulations Implement
network security groups and firewalls to
control traffic to in from aure
resources and regularly review Access
Control policies and adjust as necessary
to ensure that they remain effective so
that's an overview of the principle of
lease
privilege the next topic will cover our
privileged identity management or Pim
for short within Azure D now why should
you care about Pim because it's like a
VIP lounge for your most sensitive
resources controlling who gets in when
and what they can do once they're inside
so privileged identity management is an
Azure aervice enabling you to manage
control and monitor access to important
resources in your organization you can
manage resources from Azure ad Azure
Microsoft 365 Microsoft and two and more
so what are the key features of P Im
Just in Time access this feature allows
you to Grant privileged access to Azure
ad and Azure resources only when needed
assign time bound access to resources
using start and end dates required
approval to activate privileged roles
enforce multiactor authentication to
activate any role use justification to
understand why users activate get
notifications when privileged roles are
activated conduct access reviews to
ensure users still need roles and
download audit history for internal or
external audit it's important to note
that Pim is part of azurea D premium 2o
so you'll need that subscription to
access these features by taking
advantage of Pim and its features you
can ensure a more secure and controlled
environment for your
[Music]
organization next we'll be diving into
another critical topic Azure ad identity
protection so what does it do identity
protection is a feature of azuread that
enables you to detect investigate
remediate and Export identity based
risks for future analysis Microsoft
analyzes a staggering 6.5 trillion
signals per day to identify and protect
customers from threats identity
protection can notice risky users risky
sign-ins and risk
detections let's take a closer look at
the types of risks that identity
protection can identify Anonymous IP
address this is a sign in from an
anonymous IP address like those used by
the tour browser or anonymizer vpns a
typical travel this refers to a sign in
from a location that is atypical based
on the users's recent sign-ins malware
linked IP address a sign in from an IP
address linked to malware unfamiliar
signin properties a sign in with
properties that haven't been seen
recently for the given user leak
credentials indicates that the user's
valid credentials have been leaked
password spray this involves multiple
usernames being attacked using common
passwords in a unified Brute Force
manner Azure a de threat intelligence
this is when Microsoft's internal and
external threat threat intelligence
sources have identified a known attack
pattern and there are others detected by
Microsoft Defender for cloud apps such
as new country activity activity from
Anonymous IP addresses and suspicious
inbox
forwarding the risk signals can trigger
remediation efforts such as requiring
users to use azuread multifactor
authentication reset their password
using self-service password reset or
even blocking until an administrator
takes
action identity protection categorizes
risk into three tiers low me medium and
high and administrators can use key
reports for investigations such as risky
users risky sign-ins and risk detections
reports in the risky users report you'll
find comprehensive details about
detected risks a complete history of all
risky sign-ins as well as the users
overall risk history to give you a full
picture of security
concerns in the risky signin report
you'll see signin categorized as at risk
confirmed compromised confirmed safe
dismissed or remediate this report
provides both real time and aggregate
risk levels associated with each sign
and attempt it also includes the types
of risk detections triggered the
conditional access policies applied
multiactor authentication details and
information about the device application
and location involved in the
signin risk detections offers filterable
data covering up to the past 90 days it
provides detailed information about each
type of risk detected as well as other
risks that were triggered simultaneously
in the locations of the sign and
attempts had been follow-up actions
admins can take various actions like
resetting the user password confirming a
user compromise dismissing user risk
blocking user side ends and investigate
further using Azure app so with Azure ad
identity protection you're not just
identifying risks but you're also given
powerful tools to act on
[Music]
them hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro in this segment we'll delve deep
into Azure key vault pivotal tool to
ensure the security of your Cloud
applications and services Azure keyal
helps you Safeguard cryptographic keys
and other Secrets used by Cloud apps and
services Azure key Vault focuses on
three things certificate management this
feature allows for easy provision
management and deployment of both public
and private SSL certificates these
certificates can be used with Azure and
internally connected resources Key
Management this enables the creation and
control of encryption Keys used to
encrypt your data secrets manag
here you have a secure space to store
and tightly control access to tokens
passwords certificates API keys and
other Secrets note that certificates
contain a key pair which is a
combination of a key and a secret this
should not be confused with key
management and secrets management which
are distinct
functionalities moving forward let's
talk about hsms or Hardware security
modules these are dedicated Hardware
devices specifically designed to
securely store encryption Keys when it
comes to adhering to standard standards
we reference the federal information
processing standard or fips this is a
guideline recognized by the US and
Canadian governments that specifies the
security requirements for cryptographic
modules that protect sensitive
information in line with fips we have
two levels of compliance for hsms fips
104 diminus 2 level two compliant this
compliance level is for multi-tenant
hsms where multiple customers are
virtually isolated on a single HSM fips
104 diminus 2 level three compliant this
level on the other hand pertains to
single tenant hsms where One customer
utilizes a dedicated HSM in essence
Azure key vault is an indispensable tool
for ensuring that your cloud data
remains both accessible and secure
whether you're working with certificates
encryption keys or various Secrets Azure
key Vault has you
[Music]
covered all right let's dive into the
core of azure key Vault the Vault itself
a vault is where your secrets and keys
reside safeguarded either by software or
by hsms validated to the standards of
fips 1004 diminus 2 level two Azure key
vaults provides two types of containers
vaults these containers support both
software and HSM back Keys HSM pools
these are specialized containers solely
for HSM back keys to activate your HSM
you will need to provide a minimum of
three RSA key pairs up to a maximum of
10 and specify the minimum number of
keys required to decrypt the security
domain called a quorum you do not choose
the container on creation you just
choose between standard and premium when
you choose premium and create enough RSA
key pairs you will begin to use HSM
pools diving a bit into technicalities
Azure key Vault rest API is used for
programmatically managing Azure key
Vault resources allowing you to perform
operations such as create a key or
secret import a key or secret revoke a
key or secret delete a key or secret
authorize user or apps to access its
keys or secrets and monitor and manage
key usage Azure key Vault rest API
supports three different types of
authentication managed identities and
identity managed by Azure ad recommended
is best practice service principle and
certificate this method uses a
certificate for authentication Service
principle and secret a combination of a
user identity and a secret key one
feature to note is the soft delete
functionality soft delete allows you to
recover or permanently delete a key
vault in secrets for the duration of the
retention period this feature is enabled
by default on cre
mandatory retention period prevents the
permanent deletion of key vaults or
Secrets prior to the retention period
elapsing furthermore enabling Purge
protection safeguards your secrets from
being prematurely purged either by users
or by Microsoft bolstering the security
of your
Vault next up on our agenda is breaking
down the pricing of azure key Vault
knowing how your bill for this service
can help you make informed decisions and
optimize your costs Azure key Vault
offers two pricing tiers standard and
premium the notable distinction between
the two is that while both tiers support
software protected Keys only the premium
tier allows for HSM protected Keys
here's a closer look at the pricing
tiers first 250 Keys regardless of
whether you're on the standard or
premium tier you'll be buillt $5 per key
every month
25115 Keys the price drops to $2.50 per
key monthly again consistent across both
tiers 1501 to 4,000 Keys the cost
further reduces to 90 cents for each key
every month 4,1 plus keys for larger key
volumes Beyond this point you'll be
charged at a rate of 40 cents per key
per month Secrets operations both tiers
are priced at 3 cents for every 10,000
transactions involving Secrets
certificate operations exclusive to the
premium tier each certificate renewal
request is buil at $3 managed Azure
storage account key rotation this
service only available in the premium
tier is priced at $1 per renewal HSM
protected Keys specifically for HSM
protected Keys the pricing is further
broken down based on the key types for
RSA 2048 bit Keys the cost is $1 per key
per month along with an additional
charge of 3 cents per 10,000
transactions for RSA 3072 bit and
4096-bit keys as well as ECC Keys the
first 250 keys are priced at $5 per key
per month so that's an overview of the
pricing model for Azure key vault
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering is
double encryption for Azure key Vault
before we dive in let's quickly recap
infrastructure encryption for storage
accounts by default Azure ensures that
your storage account data is encrypted
when it's at rest infrastructure
encryption adds a second layer of
encryption to your storage accounts data
now let's jump into Azure diss double
encryption double encryption is
precisely what it sounds like it's where
two or more independent layers of En
encryption are enable to protect against
compromises of any one layer of
encryption this strategy ensures that
even if one encryption layer is
compromised the data remains protected
by the other Microsoft has a two-layered
approach both for data at rest and data
in transit for data at rest disk
encryption this is achieved using
customer managed keys and infrastructure
encryption this uses platform managed
Keys strengthening the base layer and
for data in Transit Transit encryption
using transport layer Security 1 2 the
Safeguard data as it travels through
networks and an additional layer of
encryption provided at the
infrastructure layer so that's a quick
overview of double encryption for Azure
key
vault in this section we'll go into
detail on the keys in Azure key Vault
when it comes to creating a key in Azure
you have three primary choices generate
Azure will generate the key for you
import import an existing RSA key that
you already possess and restore backup
restore a key from backup for Keys
generated by Azure you can use either
RSA or EC RSA or rivest shamier or
Adelman this supports key sizes of 2048
3072 and 4096 bits EC or elliptic curve
cryptography here you can select from
p256 P 384 p521 or p256 k for Keys
generated by azer you can set an
activation and expiration date
additionally you're not bound to a
static version of a key you can create
new versions of keys you can also
download backups of keys but remember
that backups can only be restored within
the same Azure subscription and within
Azure key Vault when you have a premium
Vault you'll key options for HSM you can
generate either an RSA or EC
specifically for HSM or import an RSA
key for HSM as shown in the
example now let's talk about Key
Management types Microsoft managed key
or Keys managed by Microsoft they do not
appear in your Vault and in most cases
are used by default for many Azure
services customer managed key are Keys
you create in Azure key Vault you need
to select a key from EV Vault for
various Services sometimes customer
managed means that the customer has
imported cryptographic material and any
generated or imported keys are
considered cmk and Azure in order to use
a key an Azure service needs an identity
established with an Azure adid for
permission to access the key from The
Vault Additionally you have the option
to implement infrastructure encryption
while while Azure already encrypt
storage account data at Rest by default
opting for infrastructure encryption
adds a second layer of security
fortifying your storage accounts data
even
further the next topic will be covering
our secrets in Azure key Vault Azure key
Vault Secrets provide Secure Storage of
generic Secrets such as passwords and
database connection strings key Vault AP
as accept and return secret values as
strains internally key Vault stores and
man of Secrets as sequences of octets
with each secret having a maximum size
of 25k bytes the key Vault service
doesn't provide semantics for Secrets it
accepts the data encrypts it stores it
and returns a secret identifier for
highly sensitive data clients should
consider additional layers of protection
for data for example encrypting your
data using a separate protection key
before storing it in the key Vault keyal
also supports a content type field for
Secrets allowing clients to specify the
content type of a secret to a assist in
interpreting the secret data when it's
retrieved note that the maximum length
of this field is 255
characters every secret stored in your
key vault is encrypted key vault encrypt
Secrets at rest with a hierarchy of
encryption Keys all keys in that
hierarchy are protected by modules that
are fips 14 minutes 2 compliant the
encryption Leaf key is unique to each
key Vault while the root key is unique
to the entire security world the
protection level may vary between
regions for example chid uses fips 1004
dimin 2 level one and all other regions
use level two or higher diving into
secret attributes we have exp this is
the expiration time after which the
secret data should not be retrieved NBF
not before default value is now this
defines the time before which the secret
data should not be retrieved enable this
tells us whether the secret data can be
retrieved or not with its default set to
True additionally there are readon
attributes for created an update in
order to access Secrets within your
applic a code you can would use the
Azure SDK for example we have a net
example in this image here another
option is to use tools like Azure CLI so
that about covers the important details
of secrets in Azure key
Vault the next topic will be covering
our x59 certificates first let's unravel
what public key infrastructure is pki is
a set of rules policies Hardware
software and procedures needed to to
create manage distribute use store and
revoke digital certificates and manage
public key encryption so what exactly is
an x59 certificate it is a standard
defined by the international
telecommunication Union for public key
certifications X 59 certificates are
used in many internet protocols
including SSL TLS and https signed and
encrypted email and code signing and
document signing a certificate contains
an identity which could be a host name
an organization or an individual along
with a public key built on platforms
like RSA DSA or
ecda but who issues these certificates
here comes the role of the certificate
Authority a trusted entity that issues
digital certificates a c acts is a
trusted third part trusted both by the
subject of the certificate and by the
party relying upon the
certificate a certificate Authority can
issue multiple certificates in the form
of tree structure known as a chain of
trust root certificate Authority this is
a self-signed certificate the private
key associated with it signs other
certificates it's important that the
private key of root or protected
intermediate certificate Authority these
certificates are signed by the roots
private key they protect the root
certificate because the root certificate
does not have to sign every issued
certificate and entity certificate a
certificate issued by the ICA used by
the end entity the entity in the case is
an SSL certificate for a
website a certificate contains of
metadata about version number the
version of the x59 standard serial
number a unique serial number assigned
to the certificate by the certificate
Authority signature algorithm ID the
algorithm used to sign the certificate
such as RSA or DSA issuer the name of
the certificate Authority that issued
this certificate validity period the
start and end dates during which the
certificate is valid subject the
identifier for the individual or
organization to whom the certificate was
issued subject public key the public key
that is authenticated by this
certificate this field also names the
algorithm used for public key generation
ation ISS your unique identifier allows
multiple Cas to operate as a single
logical CL subject unique identifier
allows multiple certificate holders to
act as a single logical entity
extensions allows a c to associate
additional private information with a
certificate all the metadata is publicly
readable anyone can view it so that's an
overview of x59
[Music]
certificates hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam Pro and in this fall along
we're going to be learning all about
Azure Vault so let's get to it so what I
want you to do is go on the top here and
type in key Vault and here we'll have to
go ahead and create ourselves a new
Vault and so from there we're going to
create a new Resource Group I'm going to
call this Resource Group my example
Vault and then we will make a vault key
here so I'll say My Vault example which
is kind of funny because this one's
slightly different so you've seen I've
done this before so I'm I'm going to do
my example vault as the name here and
for the region Us East is fine for
pricing we'll keep it at standard soft
delete is enabled um and then there's
the option for Purge protection so we
are going to enable Purge
protection and uh this is going to play
into other follows we'll explain that as
it goes but Purge protection does not
allow you to uh Purge things uh easily
once it's enabled so what we'll do is go
ahead and and review and
create and we'll go ahead and go review
create and we'll give it a moment
here and we'll just wait till it's done
deploying okay all right so after a
short little wait our vault is created
and so what I want you to do is go to
the resource and we're going to be using
this Vault a little bit in some of the
Fall alongs and in some cases is not so
much
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and this
fall along we're going to be doing some
things with uh keys with an Azure key
Vault so what I want you to do is make
your way to the Keys blade on the left
hand side here we're going to generate
or slimport a new key we're going to
choose the generate option in terms of
naming we're going to call this my disk
key and we are going to choose RSA 2048
that seems totally fine to me everything
else seems okay so we'll go ahead and
create that key so we'll give it a
moment to create doesn't take too long
and then what we're going to do is go on
the left hand side to I am access
controls and what we're want we're going
to want to do is add a new Ro assignment
so we can go ahead and start using this
uh key so what I want you to do is go
and look for key Vault administrator
which is here we'll go ahead and hit
next and then for our uh user we will
choose ourselves so under user I'm going
to select the members I'm looking for
the account I'm using there I am and
your brown go ahead and select that
there and so that is all we need to to
assign it so that we can actually uh
work with that key so I think a good
idea is to use a key uh to encrypt a
disk so what we'll do is make our way
over to dis encryption sets because
before you can encrypt a dis you need to
have an encryption set so we'll go ahead
and create ourselves a new encryption
set we'll call we'll use the uh sorry
the same um resource ccrypt so it's very
easy clean up afterwards we'll call this
my disk encrypt set here and in terms of
the encryption type we're going to use
double encryption because that's much
better you have two keys that encrypt it
so that's a lot better we are going to
choose our vault so we have my example
Vault there's only one option here and
in terms of the key we'll select my dis
key terms of the version uh we'll select
the current version we'll go ahead and
hit review
create and then we will go and create
that and we'll give give it a moment to
create that encryption set shouldn't
take too long here and after a short
little wait uh our resource should be
deployed it took about a minute for me
and if we go here it's going to have
this message up here it's very small but
it says to associate disk image snapshot
this dis encryption set you must Grant
permissions to key Vault so all we have
to do is click that uh alert and will
grant permissions and so now we are able
uh to use that key um or like to to
we're going to have the permissions
issues is solved so what we'll do is go
to type and create a new disk and so we
can apply
this key to that encryption so we go
ahead and create we're going to choose
the same Resource Group here I'm going
to call this my example Vault and um or
sorry my
example uh dis so that's a little bit
more clear than that and for the
availability Zone doesn't matter for the
source type um it doesn't matter as well
in terms of the size we want this to be
cheap we're not really using this for
real so we'll use standard HDD and we'll
say okay in terms of encryption this is
where things get fun we go to double
encryption we choose our key here we'll
go ahead review and
create and we'll just give it a moment
for that to well we'll hit create and
we'll have to wait a little while here
for that create that resource so we'll
just wait until that is created okay and
after a very short while the dis is
ready so we'll go to that resource we'll
go to the encryption tab to see that
encryption is applied so that's all it
takes to use a key to encrypt a dis so
we are going to still use some of these
accounts there's no clean up yet I'll go
back here and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one hey this is Andrew Brown and this
follow along we're going to learn about
backup and restore key so what I want
you to do is go back into the uh
Resource Group that we just recently
created and we're going to make our way
over to keys so I'm just or sorry we got
to get into the Vault first then we'll
go over to keys and the idea is that we
have this key here and so um you can see
that we have this current version so you
can add additional versions but what's
going to happen if we try to back this
up so when you back this up you're going
to get this file here and if you open up
this file it's going to look like a
bunch of gobbly goop so I'm just going
to try to open it here um I have it up
off screen here so I'm just trying to
open it up within uh Visual Studio code
so I'm just going to open up visual
studio code again doing this off screen
here just give me a moment all right and
so this is the file um that we encrypted
uh and you take a look here and it's
it's doesn't look like anything but the
idea is that it is our backup of our key
so that we can rein ort
that and just taking a look at the key
name this is what it looks like so it
says my example Vault my dis key then
there's this um uh date and that's key
backup so just recognize that's the
format and the date is very useful to
indicate when you backed it up so let's
go ahead and delete this key because the
idea is we want to uh restore that
backup and so we have deleted that key
there and uh what we're going to do is
we're going to attempt a restore so I'm
going to go ahead and
go occurred while restoring the key the
key you're trying to restore already
exists why would it throw that error
we've clearly deleted it and the reason
why is that we have Purge protection on
we did that in the um first first part
when we set up this actual Vault here
I'm going to just see if we can find the
settings wherever that Purge protection
is I'm trying to remember where it is
Purge protection is enabled so we can go
here and once you enable it you cannot
turn it off it's going to retain it for
a certain amount of days um and so all
you can do is soft delete keys so this
key is not actually deleted yet if you
go to manage deleted Keys you can see
the key is over here and if you try to
click on Purge it is disabled because we
cannot remove the key because we have
Purge protection on but we can recover
the key so we'll go ahead and
recover uh and so that will allow us to
recover the
key and if we refresh here it's going to
take a little bit time for that key to
restore so we'll just have to uh wait a
little bit and then it will show
up here's one other thing I wanted to
show you was under policy because you
know um if you go under where's policies
here um or access policies if you look
under our user here and we look at the
key permissions um there is an option to
purge and we don't actually have that uh
turned on right now but if we were to
save this and we were to still go to
that Purge option it would still say the
same thing so even if you have Purge
permissions it does not matter if Purge
protections turned on it still will not
let you purge but you would need a
combination of those in order to uh you
know be able to do things there so to
really show you how to do that recovery
I think what we should do I'm just going
to delete our old key here because we
don't care about it but we are going to
well I guess we could try to import it
into the other one so I'm just going to
undo that for a second but we are going
to go ahead and create ourselves another
Vault so I'm going to go and type in
Vault at the top here and we're going to
be a little bit more careful when we
create this Vault so we'll go here and
we will choose um
my example Vault I'm going to say My
Vault no
protect and the pricing tier will be
standard one day we're going to leave it
or well seven is the lowest and we'll
say disable Purge protection because we
don't want to have that
enabled and we'll see if we can import
the key into another Vault I'm not sure
if we can do that worst case we'll make
a new key download the key re-upload it
but I'm just curious what would happen
if we tried to upload the same key as
it's still in another Vault I'm not
exactly
sure all right so this deployment is
successful I'm going to go to this
resource I'm going to go ahead to go to
create and we're going to restore from
backup and we're going to take this key
and see if we can actually import it
here so it looks like we can take a key
and it can exist in multiple vaults I'm
going to go ahead and delete this key
and we're going to say are you sure you
want to delete this key I'm going to say
yes and if we go to manage
keys and we refresh it takes a a little
bit of time here so we'll just wait a
moment for this to uh
persist and after a short little wait
like about 2 minutes I refresh and the
key is here so if I go here you'll
notice the purges option is still not
available we can obviously recover um
but we don't have Purge um protection on
so if we go to access policies over here
and we'll go ahead and scroll down and
select Purge and save our changes we can
then go back to Keys we'll give it a
moment to save we go back to Keys we'll
refresh it we'll manage our keys
and we'll go ahead and Purge it and that
will permanently Purge it there so
that's all it takes uh to do that so
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exampro
and in this section we'll be going over
the integration with on premises
Solutions with Azure starting with Azure
adconnect Azure adconnect is a tool
provided by Microsoft that enables
organizations to synchronize on premises
active directory with Azure active
directory C this synchronization enables
organizations to extend their on
premises identities and security
policies to the cloud and enable
seamless access to cloud-based
applications Azure a DEC connect allows
for seamless single side on from your on
premises workstation to Microsoft Azure
Azure adconnect has the following
features password hash synchronization
this feature syncs user password hashes
from on premises active directory to
Azure ID enabling the same signing
method for both pass through
authentication this allows you users to
maintain the same password across on
premises and Cloud platforms without
needing a separate Federated environment
setup Federation integration an optional
feature it facilitates a hybrid setup
using on premises a DFS infrastructure
and provides management tools like
certificate renewal and server
deployment synchronization this is
responsible for creating and aligning
users groups and other objects between
on premises and Cloud ensuring identity
information matches across both Health
monitoring Azure adconnect Health offers
robust activity monitoring with a
dedicated azzure portal section to
review this data here are the steps for
installing configuring and synchronizing
on premises active directory with
azuread using Azure adconnect Why
install Azure adconnect install Azure
adconnect on a server connected to both
on premises a and Azure a to configure
Azure ad connect use the wizard to set
up synchronization settings Source
Target directories and sync frequency
three synchronized directories aure a
DEC connect syn on premises a with
azzure a d replicating changes from
source to Target for Monitor and manage
continuously Monitor and manage the
synchronization process to ensure
accuracy and meet business needs overall
Azure a DEC connect is your bridge
between the on premises world and Azure
it ensures a synchronized coherent and
seamless
experience the next topic we'll be
covering is azure a application proxy
Azure a application proxy is a service
provided by Microsoft Azure that allows
organizations to provide remote access
to their on premises web applications it
allows users to access the applications
securely from anywhere using any device
without the need for complex network
configuration or exposing the
applications directly to the internet
organizations can publish their on
premises applications to the cloud
providing secure remote access for their
users the service allows organizations
to use their existing on premises
infrastructure and application
architecture leveraging the benefits of
the cloud it provides Advanced security
features such as multiactor
authentication and conditional access
policies ensuring that only authorized
users can access the
applications the azuread application
proxy service consists of two main
components while an Azure a d
application proxy connector a
lightweight agent that is installed on a
server within the organizations's on
premises environment the connector
establishes a secure outbound connection
to the azuread application proxy service
which which enables communication
between the on premises application and
the azuread service to Azure ad
application proxy service a cloud-based
service that manages the authentication
and authorization of users who access
the on premises web applications through
the application proxy connector it also
routes traffic to the appropriate pen
servers and enforces policies set by the
organization next let's look at the
azuread application proxy architecture
here's an image of the process and we'll
go through each step why an user access
the user accesses the application and
gets redirected to azuread for sign in
any set conditional access policies are
checked two token issuance after
successful signin azuread sends a token
to the user's device three token
interpretation the client sends this
token to application proxy which
extracts the user principal name and
security principal name for request
forwarding application proxy forwards
the request to the connector installed
on premises five additional
authentication optionally the connector
May perform additional authentication
and then sends the request to the on-
premises application six server response
the application's response is sent back
through the connector to the application
proxy service seven response delivery
finally the application proxy service
delivers the response to the user's
device next we'll go over some of the
use cases for Azure a application proxy
remote access Azure ad application proxy
is commonly used to provide secure
remote access to on premise applications
employees working from home or other
remote locations can securely access
their internal applications just as if
they were in the office single signon
application proxy can integrate with
azuread to provide single signon
capabilities this allows users to
authenticate once and then access
multiple applications without needing to
sign in again conditional access with
application proxy you can leverage Azure
ad's conditional access policies for
your on premise applications this
provides granular control over over
access based on user location device
status and other factors Legacy
application modernization application
proxy can help organizations expose
Legacy on premise applications to the
internet in a secure manner without
changing the application code this can
be a key part of a strategy to modernize
Legacy
applications scalability and performance
Azure a d application proxy scales
automatically to meet your
organization's usage patterns and
provides a global reach without needing
to open additional firewall ports this
can help help improve the performance
and availability of your
applications in conclusion Azure a
application proxy is like a security
guard in a bridge ensuring that your on
premises applications are both
accessible and protected be sure to know
this as it'll definitely appear on the
[Music]
exam hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be going
over storage accounts in Azure Azure
storage offers several types of storage
accounts each with different features
and their own pricing models these
storage account types include standard
general purpose V1 which is now
considered Legacy standard general
purpose V2 blob storage block blob
storage and file storage storage
accounts vary with the following
features supported Services essentially
this answers the question what can I put
in this storage account your options
include blob file Q table disk and data
Lake Gen 2 performance tears this
focuses on the speed of your read and
write operations Azure offers to tiers
standard and premium access tiers how
often do I need quick access to files
the tiers are hot cool archive
replication how many redundant copies
should be made and where Azure provides
various replication options including
lrs GRS R GS zrs gzrs R gzrs deployment
model Azure has two models resource
manager and
classic the table details different
types of azure storage accounts their
capabilities performance tiers access
tiers replication methods and deployment
models type this column describes the
different types of storage accounts
general purpose V2 this is the latest
version of azure storage accounts and
supports various services like blob file
Q table disk and data Lake Gen 2 general
purpose V1 this is the older version and
supports blob file Q table and disk
block blob storage designed for storing
block blobs and aen blobs file storage
specifically tailored for Azure file
shares blob storage meant for storing
block and the pen blobs service these
are the storage Services each account
type can provide performance tiers Azure
offers two performance tiers standard
back by hard disk drives and suitable
for general purpose storage premium uses
solid state drives and is optimized for
high performance and low latency
workloads access tiers these Define the
data access frequency hot for frequently
accessed data tool optimize for storing
and frequently accessed data for a
minimum of 30 days archive for rarely
Access Data with a minimum of 180 days
storage duration replication Azure
provides multiple replication options
for ensuring data durability and
availability lrs locally redundant
storage stores multiple copies of your
data in a single data center GRS Geo
redundant storage replicates your data
to a secondary region raw GRS read
access Geo redundant storage offers
readon access to the data in the
secondary location in addition to Geo
replication zrs Zone redundant storage
spreads data across multiple
availability zones gzrs geozone
redundant storage combines both zrs and
GRS by spreading data across
availability zones and replicating to a
secondary region raw gzrs like gzrs but
with read access to the secondary region
deployment models resource manager this
is azure's modern deployment model it
allows you to group related resources
together for easier management classic
the older deployment model that existed
before the the introduction of the Azure
resource
manager lastly let's explore the five
core Services Azure provides in the
storage domain Azure blob a massively
scalable Object Store for text and
binary data also includes support for
big data analytics through data like
storage Gen 2 Azure files manage file
shares for cloud or on premises
deployments Azure cues a messaging store
for Reliable messaging between
application components Azure tables a
nsql store for schema Less storage of
structured data Azure diss Block Level
storage volumes for Azure VNS so that's
an introduction to storage accounts in
Azure the next topic we'll be exploring
is azure blob storage in more detail
blob storage is an object store that is
optimized for storing massive amounts of
unstructured data unstructured data is
data that doesn't adhere to a particular
data model or definition such as text or
binary data Azure blobs are composed of
the following core components storage
account this is essentially your unique
space or Nam space in Azure and it looks
something like this HTTP colon doubleist
account. blob. core. windows.net
container this component functions
similarly to a folder in a file system
blobs here is where the actual data is
stored Azure storage supports three
types of blobs why block blobs these are
ideal for storing text in binary data
it's made up of blocks of data that can
be maned individually and they can store
up to about 4.75 tip of data two append
blobs specially optimized for append
operations these are ideal for scenarios
such as logging data from virtual
machine three page blobs capable of
storing random access files up to 8
terabytes in size and they are suited
for store virtual hard drive files and
serve as discs for Azure virtual
machines when it comes to transferring
data into Azure blob storage there are
multiple Methods at your disposal
including as copy and easy easy to use
command line tool for Windows and ltic
Azure storage data movement Library a
net library that uses as copy in the
background Azure data Factory an ETL
service by Azure blop pews this virtual
file system driver allows for direct
data access through the Linux file
system Azure data box a robust physical
device designed to transport data to
Azure securely Azure import export
service a service where you ship your
physical discs for data transfer onto
Azure so that's an overview of azure
blob
storage the next topic we'll be covering
are the performance tiers in Blob
storage in a bit more detail there are
two types of performance tiers for
storage accounts standard and premium
before we delve into the details it's
essential to understand the term iops
iops stands for input output operations
per second the higher the iops the
faster a drive can read and write
premium performance tier in this tier
data is stored on solid state drives
these drives are optimized for low
latency operations ensuring higher
throughput and speed data access some of
the ideal use cases include interactive
workloads analytics AI or machine
learning processes and data
transformation tasks and SSD has no
moving parts and data is distributed
randomly this is why it can read and
write so fast on the other hand standard
performance the standard tier stores
data on hard disk drives these drives
offer VAR Performance Based on the
access tier such as hot cool or archive
the standard tier shines in the
following use cases backup and Disaster
Recovery operations storing media
content and bulk data processing an HDD
as moving Parts an arm that needs to
read and write data sequential to a disk
it is very good at writing or reading
large amounts of data that is close
together overall your choice between
premium and standard largely depends on
your specific requirements whether you
prioritize Lightning Fast data access or
more budget friendly voluminous data
storage
moving on to the next topic we'll be
covering access tiers for blob storage
in more detail so there are three types
of access tiers for standard storage
cool hot and archive hot tier ideal for
data that's access frequently it has the
highest storage cost but you get the
lowest access cost use cases data that's
in active use or expected to be access
frequently and data that staged for
processing an eventual migration to the
cool access tier cool here best for data
that's in frequently accessed and stored
for at least 30 days it has lower
storage cost but higher access cost use
case great for short-term backup in
Disaster Recovery data sets older media
content not viewed frequently anymore
but is expected to be available
immediately when accessed and large data
sets that need to be stored cost-
effectively while more data is being
gathered for future processing archive
tier best for data that's rarely
accessed and stored for at least 180
days it has the lowest storage cost but
the highest access cost use case best
suited for long-term backup secondary
backup and archival data sets original
data that must be preserved even after
it has been processed into final usable
form and compliance and archival data
that needs to be stored for a long time
and is hardly ever
accessed before we move on let's touch
upon some essential technical aspects
account level tiering any blob that
doesn't have an explicitly assigned tier
infers the tier from the storage account
access tier setting blob level tiering
you can upload a blob to the tier of
your choice changing tiers happens
instantly with the exception from moving
out of archive rehydrating a blob when
moving a blob out of archive into
another tier it can take several hours
this is known as rehydrating blob life
cycle management here you can create
rule-based policies to transition data
to different tiers such as after 30 days
move to Cool
Storage when a blob is uploaded or moved
to another tier it's charged at the new
tier rate immediately upon tier change
when moving from a cooler tier the
operation is building is a right
operation to the destination tier where
the right operation and data right
charges of the destination tier apply
when moving from a hotter tier the
operation is built as a read from the
source tier where the read operation and
data retrieval charges of the source
tier apply early deletion charges for
any blot moved out of the cool or
archive tier May apply as well cool and
archive early deletion any blob that is
moved into the cool tier is subject to a
cool early deletion period of 30 days
any blob that is moved into the archive
tier is subject to an archive early
deletion per period of 180 days this
charge is prated so that's a more
in-depth look into the access tiers for
blob
storage the next topic we'll be covering
is the replication and data redundancy
for storage accounts so when you create
a storage account you need to choose a
replication type replication stores
multiple copies of your data so that it
is protected from planned events
transient Hardware failures Network or
power outages or even massive of natural
disasters primary region redundancy
these include locally redundant storage
and Zone redundant storage secondary
region redundancy this includes Geo
redundant storage and geozone redundant
storage secondary region redundancy with
re access re access Geo redundant
storage and reais geozone redundant
storage as you can expect the greater
level of redundancy the more expensive
the cost of
replication for redundancy in the
primary region data is replicated three
times in the primary region there are
two options for storing in the primary
region locally redundant storage copies
data synchronously in primary region
99.999999999% that's 11 9's durability
this is the cheapest option so redundant
storage copies data synchronously across
3 A's in primary region
99.9% 12 9's
durability for redundancy in the
secondary region data is replicated to a
secondary region in case of primary
Regional disaster the secondary region
is determined based on your primary's
pair region secondary region isn't
available for read or right access Geo
redundant storage copies data
synchronously in primary region copies
data asynchronously to another region
99.9% that's 16 NES of durability gozone
redundant storage similar to GRS but
adds synchronous replication across
three availability zones in the primary
region before a synchronously
replicating to another region
maintaining the same
99.9% that 1699 durability level
redundancy in the secondary region with
read access data is replicated
synchronously to primary region your
data will be in sync with your primary
and you'll have red access read access
Geo redundant storage ensures
synchronous data replication within the
primary region into another region
offering a high durability of
99.9% with
169 read AIS geozone redundant storage
this goes a step further by replicating
data synchronously across three
availability zones in the primary region
before synchronous L replicating to
another region maintaining the same high
durability level so choosing the right
replication strategy depends on your
business needs weighing costs against
data durability and accessibility and
that about covers main points for the
replication and data redundancy for
storage
accounts the next topic we'll be
exploring is a z copy so what is a z
copy a z copy is a versatile command
line tool designed specifically for
copying blobs or files to or from Azure
storage accounts it's a goto utility for
many when they think of data transfer
with Azure while download first things
first to get started with a z copy
you'll need to download the executable
file compatible with your operating
system be it windows litx or Macos to
before you begin transferring data
ensure you have the necessary level of
authorization you will need to have the
level of authorization via attached
roles for downloading you'll require the
storage blob data reader Ro for
uploading the rules necessary are
storage blob data contributor and
storage blob data owner three you gain
access either via a z copy login options
for authentication include using Azure
active directory or a shared access
signature known commonly as SAS this
prompts you deci side in you'll then be
guided to use a web browser open a
specific page and enter a given code to
authenticate for copying data to move
data use the straightforward copy
command a z copy copy whether you're
uploading or downloading this command is
your way to data transfer so that's a
quick summary of how to utilize a z
copy the next topic we'll be covering is
the life cycle Management in Azure
storage Azure storage life cycle
management offers a rule-based policy
that you can use to transition blob data
to the appropriate access tiers or to
expire data at the end of the data life
cycle with the life cycle management
policy you can transition blobs from
cool to hot immediately when they are
accessed to optimize for performance
transition blobs blob versions and blob
snapshots to a cooler storage tier if
the objects have not been accessed or
modified for a period of time to
optimize for cost delete blobs blob
versions and blob snapshots at the end
of their life cycles Define rules to be
run once per day at the storage account
level and apply rules to Containers or
to a subset of blobs using name prefixes
or blob index tags as
filters so to manage the life cycle of
our blobs inside containers a life cycle
management rule must be created navigate
to your Azure storage account go to life
cycle management find and select blob
service and click on add a rule from
here decide whether to May apply this
rule to all blobs inside the storage
account or filter the blobs to have this
rule applied in this storage account for
example if Bas blobs were last modified
for more than one day ago then delete
the blob for example if bass blobs were
last modified from than one day ago then
delete the blob if base blobs were last
modified more than 2 days ago then then
move to Cool Storage overall Azure
storage life cycle management gives you
automated tools to handle data
efficiently as it progresses through its
life cycle balancing between performance
needs and cost
[Music]
considerations hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam Pro and in this section we'll
be covering the Azure SQL offerings
let's break them down SQL server on
Azure VMS provides SQL server and Os
level access supports various SQL n OS
versions this is an ideal choice for
migrations and applications that need
direct interaction with the operating
system managed instances single instance
gives SQL server and Os access for
robust needs supports various SQL and Os
versions best for isolated SQL workloads
needing dedicated resources instance
pool enables pre-provisioning of
resources for efficient migration host
smaller cost-effective instances this is
a perfect fit if you're looking to
migrate several smaller databases in b
es suitable for batch migration of
smaller databases databases single
database offers hyperscale storage up to
100 terabytes features demand-based
serverless compute best for cloud
applications needing a fully managed
service elastic pool enables resource
sharing among databases simplifies
Performance Management with multiple
databases best for managing and scaling
databases with variable usage patterns
so that's an overview of the Azure SQL
offerings whether you're migrating
scaling or starting fresh Azure has a
SQL solution tailored for your
needs let's talk about Azure SQL
databases in more detail Azure SQL
database is a fully managed relational
database service provided by Microsoft
Azure it's a cloud-based database
service that offers a high level of
scalability availability and security
Azure SQL database is based on the
latest version of Microsoft SQL server
and it's designed to handle various
workloads ranging from small web
applications to large Enterprise
workloads hazure SQL database supports
popular relational database engines such
as SQL Server MySQL and postgressql and
offers a variety of deployment options
including single database and elastic
pool Azure SQL database offers several
benefits that make it a popular choice
for businesses looking to migrate their
on premises databases to the
cloud some of the key benefits include
fully managed service Azure handles
administrative tasks like patching and
backups freeing businesses to focus on
core tasks High availability built-in
automatic failover and Disaster Recovery
capabilities ensure data access even
during outages scalability Azure SQL
database easily scales resources
according to workload optimizing costs
security Advanced features like threat
protection and data encryption ensure
secure data storage integration Azure
SQL database integrates seamlessly with
other Azure Services supporting the
development of modern datadriven
applications the Azure SQL database
service offers various tiers to cater to
a range of requirements and workloads
here's a breakdown basic tier this is
the most economical tier optimized for
lighter database workloads its best for
tasks like testing and development as
well as for other non-critical workloads
you can store data up to 2 gb and it
provides 5 dtus which stands for
database transaction units that offer a
combined measure of compute storage and
EO resources
standard tier this tier is designed to
handle the majority of database
workloads it's ideal for business
critical production workloads the
storage capacity is up to 1 tbte and it
offers a range of 10 to 4,000
dtus premium tier build for Mission
critical databases this tier emphasizes
High transactional rates it's
particularly suitable for workloads with
high volume transactions allows data
storage up to 4 terabytes and it
provides 125 to 20,000 dtus
general purpose tier this tier is
designed for customers with demanding
database workloads fits best for
moderate to heavy transactional
workloads offers storage up to 4
terabytes equipped with 5 to 80v cores
providing robust computational capacity
hyperscale tier optimized for extremely
large data volumes High transaction
rates and great concurrency this tier is
the best fit for large volume of ltp
workloads provides a massive storage
capacity of up to 100 terabytes provides
a compute range of 4 to 160 V cores in
summary Azure SQL database offers a
comprehensive set of tiers that cater to
everything from lightweight development
tasks to high demand Mission critical
applications ensuring that organizations
can pick the perfect blend of cost
performance and capacity for their
needs the next topic will be covering
our Azure SQL database elastic pools
Azure SQL database elastic pools are a
simple cost-effective solution for
managing and scaling multiple databases
that have varying and unpredictable
usage demands the databases in an
elastic pool are on a single server and
share a set number of resources at a set
price the concept of elastic pools
refers to a shared pool of resources
such as CPU memory and storage allocated
to a group of databases this shared set
of resources can be automatically
adjusted and distributed among the
databases based on their varying demand
Azure SQL database elastic pools is
ideal for businesses with many databases
experiencing varying workloads instead
of allocating dedicated resources per
database an elastic pool shares
resources across databases for efficient
use and cost
reduction benefits of azure SQL database
elastic pools coste effective share
resources across databases pay only for
what you use Performance Management
resources are autom managed across a
pool no manual adjustment required
flexibility and scalability auto scales
to meet demand handling traffic spikes
smoothly simplified Administration
easier management with shared resources
across databases use cases for Azure SQL
database elastic pools SAS providers
manage varying customer database
activity costs effectively development
and test environments efficient less
expensive process for regular database
setup and teardown businesses with
multiple apps optimize resource usage
and cost by sharing resources among
databases with varying activity so
that's an overview of aure SQL database
elastic
[Music]
pools next we'll be exploring Azure SQL
managed instance in more detail Azure
SQL managed instance is a fully managed
database service offered by Microsoft
Azure designed to provide an easy
migration path for SQL Server workloads
to Azure it provides a managed instance
of SQL server in the cloud allowing you
to run your existing applications with
minimal changes it's built on top of the
latest SQL server engine and supports
all its features including complex
queries and userdefined functions it
offers various deployment options
including Standalone automatic failover
configurations and cross region
replication for Disaster Recovery aure
SQL managed instan is ideal for
modernizing SQL Server workloads
consolidating multiple SQL Server
instances and building new Cloud native
applications some of the main benefits
of azure SQL managed instance include
easy migration provides a Swift simple
migration path for SQL Server workloads
to Azure with minimal application
changes fully managed Microsoft handles
maintenance backups and updates allowing
focus on applications High availability
built-in capabilities for automatic
failover and Disaster Recovery ensure
constant application availability
Security offers features like data
encryption and threat detection for data
protection performance supports large
databases High transaction rates and low
latency queries integration seamlessly
integrates with other Azure services for
easy Cloud native application deployment
Azure SQL managed instance has two
service tiers general purpose this tier
is for light to medium IO applications
using local storage and providing an
economical and scalable option suitable
for small and medium-sized businesses
needing an affordable Cloud option
business critical this tier is for high
IO applications offering High
availability automatic failover and
premium storage ideal for critical
applications in large Enterprises
ensuring high performance availability
and durability so that's a brief
overview of azure SQL managed
instances the next topic we'll be
covering is database scalability both
Azure SQL database and Azure SQL managed
instance enable you to scale database
Resources with minimal downtime
adjusting quickly to workload or traffic
changes to dynamically scale database
resources you can use the the following
options horizontal scaling this involves
adding or removing replicas to adjust
the capacity of your database both Azure
SQL database and Azure SQL managed
instance support horizontal scaling
vertical scaling this involves adjusting
the resources allocated to your database
such as CPU or memory again both Azure
SQL database and Azure SQL managed
instance support vertical scaling the
exact process for scaling your database
resources may vary depending on which
service you are using but in general the
steps are as follows determine the
resource needs of your database such as
the required CPU and memory and the
expected workload or traffic decide on
the scaling option that best meets your
needs whether that be horizontal or
vertical scaling use the Azure portal po
shell or the Azure CLI to configure the
scaling settings for your database
monitor the performance of your database
to ensure that the scaling changes are
providing the expected
improvements the difference between
Azure SQL database and Azure SQL managed
instance when a when it comes to
dynamically scaling database resources
Azure SQL database offers a wide range
of service tiers each with varying
levels of performance and capabilities
these service tiers allow you to choose
the level of resources that best meets
your needs and to easily scale up or
down as needed as your SQL managed
instance offers two service tiers
general purpose and business critical
these service tiers are designed to meet
different needs with general purpose
offering a balance of price and
performance and business critical
offering higher performance and
availability for Miss critical workloads
so that's a quick overview of database
scalability focusing mainly on the
commonly used Azure SQL database and
Azure managed SQL
instance the next topic we'll be
covering is dynamic data masking Dynamic
data masking or DDM an Azure is a
feature that helps prevent unauthorized
access to sensitive data it is a
security feature of azure SQL database
Azure synapse analytics and SQL Server
that automatically conceal sensitive
data in the result set of a query for
example if you have a credit card number
stored is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9101 11121 a
dynamic data masking rule might conceal
the numbers with all X's except for the
ending four numbers in the query results
ensuring most of the data stays
protected and away from prying eyes
Dynamic data masking is useful for
scenarios where you want to provide a
level of data security without needing
to modify database operations it's often
used in scenarios like reducing the
exposure of sensitive data in your
database when users are running reports
or analytics and preventing accidental
exposure of sensitive data especially
when data is being used for development
or testing
purposes key features realtime masking
data is masked in real time and does not
affect the underlying data stored in the
database the actual data remains intact
and is not physically changed
customizable masking patterns you can
Define different types of masks
depending on the nature of the data from
partially hiding email addresses to
fully masking credit card numbers except
the last four digits the choices are
vast and flexible role-based access
control a masking permissions can be
granted to users who need to access the
actual data ease of use Dynamic data
masking is simple to set up and doesn't
require changes to the database or
applications common use cases for
dynamic data masking include protecting
personally identifiable information
financial data and other sensitive data
types in non-production environments or
in applications with user roles that
require access access to a database but
not all of its sensitive data so that's
an overview of dynamic data
masking Azure storage provides several
security and encryption features to
ensure the confidentiality integrity and
availability of your data here are some
of the key features encryption at rest
Azure storage automatically encrypts all
data at rest using Azure storage service
encryption or customer managed Keys
using Azure key Vault encryption and
Transit all data transferred to INF aure
storage is encrypted using secure SSL
TLS protocols keeping your data secure
during Transmissions rule-based Access
Control Azure storage provides rbac
which enables you to Grant permissions
to users groups and applications at A
fine grain level access keys and shared
access signatures Azure storage provides
two types of authentication mechanisms
for accessing storage accounts access
keys and shared access signatures access
keys are account keys that allow full
access to a storage account while
provides granular Access Control to
specific resources within a storage
account Azure private link enables you
to access Azure storage resources over a
private end point in your virtual
Network this ensures that traffic
between your virtual Network and Azure
storage remains on the Microsoft Azure
backbone
Network Azure virtual network service
and points Azure virtual network service
and points enable you to extend your
virtual Network to Azure storage
similarly to Azure private link this
ensures traffic remains within the
confines of the Microsoft azure Azure
Network Azure firewall this is a managed
cloud-based network security service
that protects your Azure virtual network
resources you can use Azure firewall to
secure traffic between your virtual
Network and Azure storage Azure Monitor
and Azure security Center Azure Monitor
and Azure security Center provide
monitoring and security features for
Azure storage Azure monitor allows you
to monitor storage account metrics and
logs Azure security Center provides
security recommendations and threat
detection for Azure storage overall
Azure storage isn't just a storage
solution it's a fortress designed to
protect your data at all levels from
encryption mechanisms and access
controls to private networking and
threat detection it's equipped to tackle
diverse security
[Music]
challenges hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure synapse analytics so
Azure synaps analytics is a data
warehouse and unified analytics platform
it offers a code free visual environment
that streamlines and simplifies the
building of ETL elt processes it allows
for easy ingestion of data via more than
95 native connectors ensuring
comprehensive access to a wide variety
of data sources the integration of
Apache spark into Azure synapse
analytics allows for the use of tsql
queries across both the data warehouse
and Spark engines tsql short for
transact SQL is Microsoft's
implementation of SQL it's used to
interact with relational databases in
Microsoft SQL Server in addition it
supports a variety of languages
including tsql python Scala spark SQL
and net broadening its accessibility to
different developers Azure synapse
analytics is not limited to data
warehousing it's also seamlessly
integrated with both artificial
intelligence and business intelligence
tools for instance it works in harmony
with Azure machine learning for AI
purposes and leverages Azure cognitive
services for identity and access
management moreover it integrates
effectively with Microsoft powerbi for
efficient data visualiz Iz ation and
business intelligence
operations taking a look at this image
it shows a simple process of azure
synapse analytics you can ingest data
from many data sources such as on
premises data cloud data SAS data or
streaming data the data is stored in
object storage via data Lake storage Gen
2 you can manage Azure synapse analytics
via the synapse studio interface you can
output the data to various Azure
services such as Azure purview Azure ml
or
powerbi let let's talk a bit about
synaps SQL a vital component of this
platform snaps SQL is a distributed
version of tsql designed for data
warehouse workloads it extends tsql to
address streaming and machine learning
scenarios you can use built-in streaming
capabilities to land data from cloud
data sources into SQL tables it
integrates AI with SQL by using ml
models to score data using the tsql
predict function it offers both
serverless and dedicated resource models
for unpredictable workloads that are
unplanned or bursty you can use the
always available serverless SQL in point
for predictable workloads create
dedicated SQL pools to reserve
processing power for data stored in SQL
tables and there you have it a concise
introduction to Azure synaps
analytics the next topic we'll be
covering is the dedicated SQL pool and
serverless SQL pool both are crucial
components in the Azure synapse
analytics Suite but they serve distinct
purposes let's break them down dedicated
SQL pool is essentially a query service
over the data in your data warehouse the
unit of scale is an abstraction of
compute power that is known as a data
warehouse unit think of dwu as a measure
of computational power ensuring your
database operations run efficiently once
your dedicated SQL pool is created you
can import Big Data with simple poly
based tsql queries and then use the
power of the distributed query engine to
run high performance analytics ensuring
you derive meaningful insights from your
data on the other hand serverless SQL
pool is a query service over the data in
your data Lake one of the beauties of
the serverless Paradigm is its
adaptability scaling is done
automatically to accommodate each query
resource requirements in the world of
data change is the only constant whether
you're adding nodes removing them or
managing failovers the serverless SQL
pool is resilient it constantly adapts
to ensure every query receives the
resources it needs guaranteeing
successful execution a in essence if you
want Power go with dedicated SQL pool if
you value adaptability choose serverless
SQL pool either way asure simplifies
your data operations making it easy to
manage complex
tasks all right let's dive into Apache
spark integration within Azure synapse
Azure synapse can deeply and seamlessly
integrate with Apache spark which is one
of the most popular open-source Big Data
engine used for data preparation data
engineering ETL and even machine
learning tasks it offers machine
learning models with sparkml algorithms
and azl integration for Apache spark 3.1
with built-in support for Linux
Foundation Delta Lake provides a
simplified resource model that frees you
from having to worry about managing
clusters it has a rapid startup process
along with aggressive autoscaling
capabilities ensuring your system adapts
swiftly to workload demands offers
built-in support foret allowing you to
easily incorporate your expertise and
existing net code with in a spark
application maximizing efficiency and
resource
utilization now let's talk about spark
in conjunction with data Lake and Azure
synapse Azure synapse removes the
traditional technology barriers between
using SQL and Spark together you can
seamlessly mix and match based on your
needs and expertise tables defined on
files in the data Lake are seamlessly
consumed by either spark or Hive SQL and
Spark can directly explore and analyze
paret CSV tsv and JSO n files stored in
the data Lake
and you benefit from fast and scalable
data loading capabilities between SQL
and Spark
databases overall Azure setups coupled
with Apache spark offers a Powerhouse of
tools and capabilities making your data
operation smoother and more
efficient Azure synapse link is a
feature in Azure synapse analytics that
provides seamless integration and
real-time analytics capabilities between
Azure synapse analytics and operational
data stored in Azure Cosmos DB
it creates a tight integration between
Azure Cosmos DB and Azure synapse
analytics allowing users to explore and
analyze their data with no extraction
transformation and loading process
required no data duplication and no
impact on the performance of
transactional workloads aszure synapse
link forms a connection between Azure
Cosmos DB's transactional database and
Azure synapse analytics analytical
capabilities it accomplishes this by
creating a real-time updated columnar
based analytical store within Cosmos DB
benefits of azure synaps link for Azure
Cosmos DB realtime analytics Azure
synaps link enables realtime analytics
by allowing direct querying of live
operational data in Azure Cosmos DB
without impacting its performance
operational and analytical data cohesion
it eliminates the need for complex ETL
processes this simplifies the data
architecture as it provides immediate
and seamless access to analyze
operational data cost efficiency Azure
synaps link reduces costs by avoiding
the need for additional storage and
resources that are typically required
for ETL processes increase productivity
by removing the need for manual data
extraction or synchronization processes
Azure synaps link saves time and
increases productivity for data
scientists and
developers improve data freshness with
Azure synaps link the most upto-date
data from Azure Cosmos DB can be
accessed for analytics and Reporting in
real time this ensures data freshness
and
accuracy so when should you use Azure
synaps link for Azure Cosmos DB you
should consider using Azure synaps link
for Azure Cosmos DB when you are an
Azure Cosmos DB user wanting to conduct
analytics business intelligence and
machine learning on your operational
data you are currently running analytics
or bi on your Azure Cosmos DB
operational data using separate
connectors or you are executing ETL
processes to transfer operational data
into a distinct analytic system in such
cases AZ your synaps link offers a
seamless analytics experience without
impacting the performance of your
transactional store however it's not
ideal if you require traditional data
warehouse capabilities like high
concurrency workload management and
persisting Aggregates across multiple
data
[Music]
sources hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure data Factory Azure data
Factory is essentially a cloud-based
managed service that plays a pivotal
role in ETL elt and data integration
process is it acts like a Powerhouse
orchestrating data movement and and
transforming data seamlessly on a large
scale here's a breakdown you can create
pipelines to schedule data driven
workflows making data transformation and
integration hassle-free build complex
ETL processes that transform data
visually with data flows this means you
can transform data in a more intuitive
and Visually appealing way use compute
services such as Azure HD Insight Hado
Azure data bricks and Azure SQL database
thus offering flexibility and Power in
how you handle your data once your data
has undergone transformation you can
publish your transform data to data
stores such as Azure synapse analytics
which can store and derive meaningful
insights Azure data Factory has the
ability to turn raw data into organized
meaningful data stores and data likes
ready for further analysis and Reporting
so that's a quick introduction to Azure
data
Factory the next topic we'll be covering
are the core components let's dive into
each one and understand their
significance Pipelines think of these as
the assembly lines of your data Factory
at pipeline is a logical grouping of
activities that performs a unit of work
it orchestrates and automates the flow
of data activities these are the
specific tasks within a pipeline an
activity is essentially a processing
step in a pipeline the action items or
the work stages in your pipeline data
sets these represent the data structures
or the blueprints within the data store
Link services they Define the connection
information necessary for data Factory
to access external resources like your
data sources data flows data flows
Define how data moves through a pipeline
or under goes transformation offering a
visual representation of data's journey
and
manipulations integration run times this
is the engine under the hood the
integration runtimes are the compute
infrastructure used by Azure data
Factory to facilitate the data movements
and compute processes control flow the
control flow orchestrates the sequence
of activities in a pipeline it
determines how activities are chained
ordered or branched ensuring the
systematic flow and process processing
of data in a nutshell these seven
components are the backbone of azure
data Factory they work harmoniously
ensuring your data is efficiently moved
transformed and
processed the next topic will cover in
Azure data Factory is the data
orchestration process data ingestion
data is ingested from a variety of data
sources this could be on premises SQL
Server databases external data or any
other supported data sources a DF
supports a wide range of connectors that
can be used to pull data from these
sources data can be ingested in batch or
realtime modes depending on the
requirements data storage and
transformation after data ingestion it's
often stored in an intermediate storage
for processing this could be Azure blob
storage which is a scalable object
storage for unstructured data for more
structured analytics ready data Azure
synapse analytics which is an analytics
service can be used at this stage ADF
pipelines can transform data by cleaning
shaping and enriching using mapping data
flows analysis once the data is ready
it's then loaded into a data model for
analysis this is where Azure analysis
Services come in it allows you to build
semantic models on your data which
provide a Consolidated view of your
business data and support high
performance reporting and analytics
visualization the data model can then be
used by reporting tools like powerbi to
create visualizations dashboards and
reports that provide actionable business
insights security and authentication
throughout this process asure active
directory is used for authenticating and
authorizing users it provides identity
and access Management Services ensuring
that only authorized users have access
to your resources and data and there you
have it that's an overview of the data
orchestration process in Azure data
Factory from raw data to insightful
visualizations all while being securely
guarded the next topic we'll be covering
is Microsoft SQL Server integration
Services commonly known as ssis
Microsoft SQL Server integration
Services is a platform for building
Enterprise level data integration and
data transformation Solutions as sis can
be used to automate SQL Server databases
additionally it can be used as an
integration runtime within Azure data
Factory you can perform the following
tasks with ssis copy or download files
load data into Data warehouses cleansing
data for better accuracy dive into Data
Mining and managing SQL Server objects
and data s sis can perform elt with
variety of sources such as XML flat
files and relational data sources s sis
is built-in tasks and Transformations
graphical tools for building packages
and integration Services catalog
database where you store run and manage
packages you can use the graphical
integration Services tools to integrate
and transform data without having to
write code s sis designer is a graphical
tool that you can use to create and
maintain integration Services packages
picture a canvas where you lay out your
data operations all with simple drag and
drop
functionalities here is an image that
outlines the ssis designer in action
with a data task flow example ssis
allows you to drag out data
Transformations with a variety of common
tasks such as aggregate merge lookup and
many more and here you can design
different kinds of control or data flows
so that sums up our overview on
Microsoft SQL Server integration
services
next we'll quickly go through the
pricing tiers of azure data bricks so
you can get a better understanding of
which one is best for your workload
Azure data bricks offers two pricing
tiers premium and standard here's what
each tier brings to the table premium
SKU the premium tier offers a full set
of Advanced Data bricks features such as
role-based Access Control integration
with Azure active directory for identity
management and datab Bricks Delta engine
which is a high performance engine for
large scale data Lakes it is the most
appropriate for Big Data analytics
workloads and organizations requiring
Advanced security and team-based
workflows standard SKU the standard tier
offers a subset of the data bricks
platform features and is more
costeffective for smaller workloads or
development in test environments it
includes the basic data bricks runtime
in the collaborative workspace but does
not include role-based access control or
Azure ad integration so that's an
overview of the pricing tiers of azure
data
bricks hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we're
delving into to Azure datab bricks a
game changer in the world of big data
and artificial intelligence Solutions
Azure datab bricks is an Apache
spark-based analytics platform optimized
for the Microsoft Azure cloud services
platform it's designed to simplify the
process of building big data and
artificial intelligence solutions by
providing a unified analytics platform
that accelerates the preparation of data
for analytics and machine learning key
features collaborative environment Azure
data bricks provides a shared workspace
for collaboration among data Prof
professionals it facilitates dashboard
creation and project sharing across
various languages Azure integration as a
native service it integrates smoothly
with Azure services like data Factory
synapse analytics machine learning and
powerbi simplifying analytics pipeline
creation Apache spark integration it
incorporates an optimized runtime for
Superior performance offering a
serverless Apache spark experience with
Auto configurability and integrated
Azure Security Auto scaling and
performance it offers Auto scaling and
speed optimization for faster processing
of Big Data workloads scaling to
thousands of nodes and handling diverse
workloads robust security it delivers
Enterprise grade security with data
encryption active directory integration
role base Access Control private network
connectivity and Industry standard
compliance use cases D data analytics
Azure data bricks can process large
volumes of data in parallel making it
suitable for big data processing and
analytics machine learning it provides
provides a platform for preparing data
and developing training and deploying
machine learning models realtime
analytics Azure data brick supports
streaming analytics allowing for
real-time insights from data ETL
processes Azure data bricks can be used
for building robust ETL pipelines data
exploration and visualization the
collaborative workspace in Azure data
bricks allows for data exploration and
visualization enabling data scientists
and analysts to derive insights from
data just to recap the key differences
as your data focuses on analytics big
data and machine learning while Azure
data Factory primarily handles data
integration and pipeline orchestration
in the
[Music]
cloud hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this but before we delve into
the specifics of azure data Lake let's
clarify what a data Lake actually is in
simple terms a data lake is a
centralized and scalable repository
capable of storing a vast range of data
including raw unstructured and
semi-structured data it's designed to
accommodate a massive volume of data
commonly utilizing objects referred to
as blobs or files as its primary mediums
for storage here is a visual of a lake
with ones and zeros representing the
vast amount of data that it can
accommodate the processing of this data
can be simplified and broken down into a
few pivotal steps collect this step
involves Gathering data from various
sources transform here data under goes
Transformations or modifications through
the usage of elt or ETL this process
converts the raw data into a more
organized semi-structured format ready
for further analysis distribution this
phase makes the transform data
accessible to various programs or apis
publish finally data sets are published
to metadata cataloges making it easier
for analysts to locate and tap into
valuable data resources so that sums up
a quick introduction to data lakes and
the foundational process
involved
now that we have a solid grasp on what a
data lake is let's delve into the
specifics of azure data Lake Azure data
lake is a highly scalable and secure
data Lake that allows you to store and
analyze large amounts of data it is
composed of two main components Azure
data Lake storage and Azure data Lake
analytics Azure data Lake storage this
is a massively scalable and secure data
Lake that allows you to store all types
of data there are two generations of
azure data Lake storage Azure data Lake
storage gen one it provides a single
repository where you can capture data of
any size type and Speed without forcing
changes to your application as the data
scales Azure data Lake storage Gen 2
this is a set of capabilities dedicated
to big data analytics built on Azure
blob storage it combines the scalability
and cost benefits of object storage with
the reliability and performance of The
Big Data file system capabilities to
Azure data Lake analytics this is an on
demand analytics job service that
simplifies big data instead of deploying
configuring and tuning Hardware you
write queries to transform your data and
extract valuable insights it includes
usql a language that unifies the
benefits of SQL with the expressive
power of your own code it also allows
you to dynamically scale the resources
you need for your jobs making it coste
effective as your data Lake storage gen
one the first version of data Lake
storage and will be retired in 2024 new
users should use Gen 2 Azure data Lake
storage Gen 2 Data Lake storage is azure
blog storage which is has been extended
to support big data analytics work loads
designed to handle pedabytes of data and
hundreds of gigabits of throughput in
order to efficiently Access Data data
Lake storage adds a hierarchical main
space to Azure blob storage and there
you have it a comprehensive overview of
azure data
[Music]
like next we'll be exploring Azure data
Lake storage Gen 2 in more detail given
that the exam will feature questions
asking you to identify the most suitable
type of storage for specific scenarios
it's essential to have a firm Gra grasp
on which option is best suited for
different tasks Azure data Lake storage
Gen 2 plays a vital role in Azure data
Lake by providing a secure scalable
platform to store large data volumes it
is tailored to support high performance
analytics and machine learning
operations here are some of its core
features hierarchical mainspace enables
organizing and managing data in a
hierarchical file and folder structur
similar to traditional file systems
simplifying data organization and
Transformations scalability designed to
handle enormous amounts of data from
pedabytes to exabytes with high
throughput and low latency it can also
manage High volumes of small rights
common in Big Data scenarios security
incorporates Azure active directory for
identity and access management
role-based Access Control firewall rules
and virtual network service in points
along with encryption at rest and and
Transit it also supports Azure private
link ensuring data travels over a
private Network cost Effectiveness
offers lowcost storage with life cycle
management policies that a automatically
move data to cheaper storage tiers or
deleted after a specified period
lowering costs performance provides the
high performance Computing needed for
big data analytics and allows choosing
the best performance characteristics for
specific workloads through its
performance tiers overall Azure data
Lake storage Gen 2 is an extended
version of azure blob storage designed
for big data analytics providing
additional capabilities like
hierarchical file systems and fine
grained Access
Control
the next topic we'll be covering is the
second core component to Azure data Lake
which is azure data Lake analytics Azure
data Lake analytics is an on demand
analytics job service streamlining the
complexities of Big Data operations
instead of going through the cumbersome
processes deploying configuring and
tuning Hardware all you write queries
using usql to transform your data and
extract valuable insights effortlessly
to illustrate its efficiency exporting
approximately 2.8 billion rows of TP CDs
store sales data which is around 500 GB
into a CSV format file took less than 7
minutes and importing a full 1 terab set
of source data into Azure analysis
Services by using the Azure data Lake
connector took less than 6 hours now
let's talk a bit about usql usql is a
structured query language included
within data Lake analytics to perform
queries on your data Lake it's versatile
allowing you to query and combine data
from a variety of data sources including
Azure data Lake storage Azure blob
storage Azure sqldb Azure SQL data
warehouse and even SQL Server instances
running in Azure VMS for those who like
Hands-On experiences you can install
Azure data Lake tools for visual studio
to perform usql jobs on your Azure data
lake so that's an overview of azure data
Lake
[Music]
analytics hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering is Cosmos DB but before we talk
about Cosmos DB it's important to
understand the key types of nosql
databases first up let's talk about key
value stores key value stores are simple
and fast but they generally lack
features like relationships indexes and
aggregation in a key Value Store data is
stored in pairs where a unique key is
stored alongside a corresponding value a
simple key Value Store will interpret
this data resembling a dictionary also
known as associative arrays or hash
although this kind of data storage can
resemble tabular data it doesn't require
consistent columns per row making it
schema less due to their simple design
they can scale well beyond a relational
database next let's explore what a
document store is a document store is a
nosql database that stores documents as
its primary data structure these
documents can be structured as XML but
are more commonly found in JSO or
similar formats essentially document
stores are a subclass of key value
stores but have a more intricate
structure allowing for complex queries
and operations here's a visual that
displays the components of a document
store compared to a relational
database now let's move on to
understanding graph databases a graph
database is a database composed of a
data structure that uses vertices also
known as nodes or dots which form
relationship to other vertices through
edges arcs or lines this type of
database is particularly powerful for
mapping relationships and identifying
patterns use cases for graph database
fraud detection real-time recommendation
engines Master data management Network
and and operations identity and access
management traceability and
Manufacturing contact tracing data
lineage for gdpr customer 360° analysis
product recommendations social media
graphing and feature engineering the
nodes can contain data properties while
the edges can hold relational data
including directional information and
other data properties so that's an
overview of three key types of nosql
databases
now that we have a better understanding
of the key types of nosql databases it's
time to delve into the main topic Cosmos
DB Azure Cosmos DB is a service for
fully managed nosql databases that are
designed to scale and have high
performance attributes Cosmos TB
facilitates interaction with different
types of nosql database engines through
distinct apis namely core SQL a document
data store as your Cosmos dbapi for
mongodb another document data store
Azure table a key value data store
Gremlin a graph data store based on
aache Tinker pop these no SQL engines
offer two specific capacities provision
throughput where you pay for a
guaranteed capacity and serverless where
you pay only for what you use Cosmos DB
shines with its incredibly quick
response times and solid support for
scalability it's a fully managed service
meaning Azure takes charge of all
automatic management updates and patches
main advantages of azure Cosmos TB into
integrates with many Azure services
including Azure functions Azure
kubernetes services and Azure app
services integrates with many databases
apis like the native core SQL mongodb
Cassandra and Gremlin support for
multiple development sdks spanning
Donnet Java Python and
nodejs offers a schema less service with
automatic indexing of data ensuring
rapid queries guaranteed uptime SLA of
99.999% availability data replication
between Azure regions is automatic data
protected with encryption at rest and
ro-based access and autoscale is
provided to handle a variety of workload
sizes next let's talk about Cosmos DB
apis different types of AIS are
available in Azure Cosmos DB to support
a wider range of applications these apis
allow data to be delivered via documents
key value pairs y columns or graph data
for new projects the core SQL apis are
strongly recommended whereas for
existing databases is the specific
database API is recommended the apis are
as follows for SQL API the default API
for utilizing Azure Cosmos DB and
enables data querying with a language
akin to SQL mongod DB API facilitates
communication with mongod DB databases
and document storage Cassandra API
allows interaction with Cassandra using
the Cassandra query language and
supports data storage as a partition row
store Azure table API a communication
tool for Azure table storage it supports
it indexing in the partition and row
Keys Gremlin API helps in creating a
graph-based data view that can be quered
using graph traversal language so that's
an introduction to Cosmos
DB next up on our agenda is the cosmos
DB Explorer Cosmos DB Explorer provides
a userfriendly web interface that allows
users to delve into an engage with their
Cosmos DB accounts you can readily
access this interface by heading to
cosmos. azure.com
here is a cosmos DB core SQL within
Cosmos DB Explorer adding a document to
the database which is very
straightforward it's worth noting that
when you journey through Azure to access
a cosmos DB account under the data
Explorer section you're essentially
interacting with the same interface as
cosmos DB Explorer furthermore the
versatility of Cosmos DB Explorer shines
through with its compatibility with
other database types for example it's
seamless integration with a graph
database using Gremlin so that's a quick
overview of Cosmos DB
Explorer the next topic we'll be
covering is partitioning schemas in
Cosmos DB partitioning in Azure Cosmos
DB plays a pivotal role in optimizing
performance data in Cosmos DB indexes is
strategically grouped by partition Keys
ensuring quick and efficient data access
main concepts of partitioning schemas in
Azure Cosmos DB partition Keys think of
these as the backbone of partitioning
they are the keys used to group items
together and can be like lik to primary
keys in relational databases essentially
they dictate how data is divided and
organized within the system a logical
partition is a group of items that all
have the same partition key value
physical partitions consists of a set of
logical partitions Azure Cosmos DB
manages logical partitions which can
have one to many replica sets are made
up of a group of physical partitions
that are materialized as a self-managed
dynamically load balanced group of
replicas that span across multiple fault
domains each physical partition is not
alone it has a set of clones or replicas
this set of replicas is what we refer to
as a replica set replicas ensure data
durability availability and
consistency logical partitions are
mapped to physical partitions and these
physical entities are then spread
globally ensuring data availability and
low latency access across regions to
clarify the term in the image a
partition set refers to a collection of
physical partitions these partitions
collectively manage the same logical
partition keys and they Ensure this
consistent management across multiple
regions in essence Cosmos DB's
partitioning architecture is
meticulously designed for scalability
fault tolerance and Optimal Performance
whether you're considering logical or
physical partitions replica sets or
partition Keys each plays a crucial role
in ensuring that Cosmos DB remains one
of the most efficient nosql databases on
the
market the next topic we'll be covering
is choosing a partition key at partition
key has two components partition key
path and the partition key value for
example you can consider an item user ID
Andrew works for Microsoft if you choose
user ID as the partition key the
following are the two partition key
components while in Partition key path
this would be user ID this path
essentially points to the property and
your data item that holds the partition
key value alpha numeric characters and
underscores are accepted and you can
navigate through nested objects using
the standard path notation to partition
key key value for our example this is
Andrew it's the specific value found at
the partition key path this value can be
either a string or a number your
partition key for all containers should
be a property that has a value which
does not change you can't change the
value of a property if it's your
partition key the partition key should
have a wide range of possible values to
distribute data and workload uniformly
across various logical partitions spread
request unit consumption and data
storage evenly across all logical
partitions this ensures even rot
consumption and Storage distribution
across your physical
partitions let's talk about unique keys
so unique Keys provide developers with
the ability to add a layer of data
Integrity to their database by creating
a unique key policy when a container is
created you ensure the uniqueness of one
or more values per partition key a
unique key is scoped to a logical
partition if you partition the container
based on the zip code you end up with
duplicated items in each logical
partition it's important to know that
you can't update an existing container
to use a different unique key
a unique key policy can have a maximum
of 16 path values each unique key policy
can have a maximum of 10 unique key
constraints or combination when a
container has a unique key policy
request unit charges to create update
and delete an item are slightly higher
in addition unique key names are case
sensitive the next topic we'll be
covering our containers in Cosmos DB
Azure Cosmos containers are useful for
scalability in Azure Cosmos DB both in
terms of storage and throughput they are
beneficial when you need a different set
of configurations for each of your Azure
Cosmos DBS because they allow you to
customize each container individually
some applications may require robust WR
capabilities for logging While others
prioritize reading due to data access
needs with Cosmos DB containers each
application can have a customized
container that meets its demands
balancing performance and cost asure
Cosmos container has some container
specific properties and those properties
which can be system generated or user
configurable vary according on the used
API and Azure Cosmos container has a set
of system defined properties depending
on which API you use some properties
might not be directly exposed the table
lists various system defined properties
in Cosmos DB and indicates which ones
are system generated versus user
configurable additionally it also
denotes which properties are used by
different apis for nosql Cassandra manga
B Gremlin and table rid type system
generated purpose acts as a unique
identifier for a container supported by
only the API for no SQL eag type system
generated purpose utilized for
optimistic concurrency control it
ensures that only one client can change
an item in the database at a time
supported by only the API for no SQL TS
type system generated purpose represents
the timestamp when the container was
last updated supported by only the API
for nosql self type system generated
purpose provides an addressable Yuri of
the the container it's essentially a
unique reference or link to the
container supported by only the API for
nosql ID type user configurable purpose
denotes the name of the container
supported by all the apis listed there
are many more properties but we won't be
able to list them all
here the next topic we'll be covering
are the capacity of Cosmos DB containers
so what is capacity capacity defines the
amount of underlying resources are
available to support consumption of
resources such as compute and storage as
we've briefly touched upon before Cosmos
dbs2 capacity modes provision throughput
and serverless provision throughput in
this mode you allocate a specific amount
of throughput for your containers this
throughput is Quantified in terms of
request units per second this mode is
suitable for workloads where traffic can
be predicted it offers a high degree of
flexibility letting you match your
provision capacity to the expected
demand serverless this mode is the
opposite in its approach instead of
provisioning in advance you simply run
database operations without setting any
predetermined capacity this mode is
beneficial for smaller workloads or
those that might experience
unpredictable traffic spikes while it
offers the advantage of Simplicity and
configuration there are some inherent
limitations to be aware of when it comes
to geod distribution the provision
throughput option in Cosmos DB offers
unlimited multi- region support in
contrast the serverless option is
restricted to a single region in terms
of storage capacity while provision
throughput allows for unlimited storage
per container serverless is Cap at 50 GB
performance- wise both options deliver
less than 10 ms latency for Point reads
however while provision throughput
guarantees less than 10 ms latency for
rights under its SLA serverless offers
less than 30 MS for rights as covered by
its SLO regarding billing provision
throughput charges per hour based on the
set Ru s irrespective of actual R
consumption on the other hand serverless
charges are based on the actual Ru as
consumed by your operations build on an
hourly
[Music]
basis next we'll delve into the
consistency levels in Cosmos DB these
levels play a pivotal role shaping the
availability latency and accuracy of
database operations aure Cosmos DB
provides five different consistency
levels to maintain data availability and
quering performance depending on your
requirements the consistency levels in
Cosmos DB can be visualized as the
Spectrum this ranges from strong to
eventual on the strong side it has
higher latency lower availability but
has worse read scalability but as you
move towards eventual you gain lower
legancy higher availability and better
read scalability strong linearizability
reads are guarantee to return the most
recent version of an item bowed
staleness consistent prefix reads lag
behind writes by at most K prefixes or t
interval session consistent prefix
medonic reads medonic rights read your
rights WR follows read reads consistent
prefix updates returned or some prefix
of all the updates with no gaps eventual
outof order reads you set default
consistently at the cosmo B account
Level under default consistency
blade strong consistency this level
guarantees that read operations return
the most recent data while it's Rec cost
align with bounded tailess they are
higher than those of session and
eventual consistencies furthermore data
written can only be read once the
majority of replicas have successfully
replicated it now it stailness causes re
operations to lack behind rights due to
time or version disparities despite
having the same re cost as strong
consistency it's pricier than session
and eventual consistencies it stands out
as the most consistent when compared to
session consistent prefix and eventual
this level is ideal for globally
distributed applications that prioritize
High availability and minimal
latency session session consistency
ensures that data read within a session
matches the most recent write in that
session however other sessions might see
outdated or dirty data from recent wrs
in different sessions it's the default
consistency for new databases its Rec
cost fall between those of bounded stal
less strong and eventual
consistencies with consistent prefix
read operations fetch the latest data
replicated among replicas although it
may not be the absolute latest
situations can arise where dirty data
appears due to changes in one replica
that haven't propagated to others its
consistency is superior to eventual but
Trails behind other levels eventual
consistency offers the least Assurance
with no guarantees on immediate data
accuracy however it boasts the lowest
latency Optimal Performance and the most
cost-effective read operations among all
levels so that's an overview of the
consistency levels in Cosmos
[Music]
DB hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure rid's cach but before we
talk about Azure ridy cache we'll need
to know what ridy is so ridy is an open
source and memory database store Ries
accs as caching layer or a very fast
database since all data is stored in
memory it's highly volatile meaning data
loss is possible under certain
conditions rides is very fast that it
can deliver content from its store with
single to double digit milliseconds such
as 10ms despite its imemory nature
ridies provides options for data
persistence allowing you to balance
performance with durability it can
periodically save data snapshots to dis
or append each command to AOG red is a
key value store and it supports the
following data structures sets and
sorted sets collections of strings in
which every item is unique lists a
collection of strings sorted according
to the order they were inserted hashes
perfect for story objects these are maps
between string fields and string values
bit maps and bit Fields allow for
operations at the bit level providing
extremely efficient storage hyper log
log a sophisticated algorithm to count
unique values geospatial indexes Grant
the ability to manage spatial items in
query by position streams new in rides
it offers a way to log in realtime
stream data so that's an introduction of
rid's the next topic we'll be covering
is azure cash for rides Azure rid cash
is based on the popular op Source rid's
cache it gives you access to a secure
dedicated rid's cache that Microsoft
manages and that you can access from any
Azure application Azure R's caches an in
memory database that caches data in key
value pairs it helps your application
become more responsive even as the
customer load increases it takes
advantage of the redu engines low
latency High througha capabilities this
distributed cash layer allows your data
tier to scale independently allowing for
more efficient use of your application
layers compute
resources Azure red cash perfectly
complements Azure database services such
as cosmos DB and Azure SQL it provides a
cost-effective solution to scale read
and write throughput of your data tier
using the caches side pattern you can
store and share database query results
session States static content and more
Azure cash for stores session State and
other data that needs low latency access
diagram of cash aside pattern on Azure
storage first we'll need to check the
rid's cach to see if your item is
available if the item is found we'll
retrieve it if the item is not found
we'll pull the item from the table
storage recash it in redas and then
return the results on the right we have
an image that should clearly explain the
workflow overview check if cash exists
if true go to step two and obtain the
data if cash could not be found go to
step three and recash the item and
return the results so that's a summary
of azure cash redes and how it
works the next topic will be covering
our caching expiration policies for
Azure rid's cach Azure rid's caches
expiration policies are configured per
each request so we could have an
expiration policy different for each
cach key for rid's distributed cach
those expiration policies are as follows
absolute expiration relative to now this
policy sets the duration for the cash to
live counting from the moment the item
is added to the cash for example if you
set this to 10 minutes the cash item
will expire 10 minutes after it has been
added absolute expiration this policy
sets a specific date and time when the
cash item will expire once that date and
time are reached the cash item is
evicted regardless of when it was added
sliding expiration this policy defines
an expiration time relative to the last
access time of the particular cach item
If an item has a slighty expiration of
10 minutes it will expire if it hasn't
been accessed in those 10 minutes every
time the item is accessed its expiration
timer is reset so that's a brief summary
of the Azure rid's caches expiration
[Music]
policies hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering non-relational data storage
Solutions in Azure starting with Azure
table storage Azure table storage isn't
your regular relational database instead
it's a nosql data store for
semi-structured data needly housed
within Azure storage accounts what makes
it particularly appealing especially in
today's fast-paced Tech world is its
ability to handle vast amounts of
unstructured or semi-structured data
without being tied down by a fixed
schema there are two ways to interact
with Azure tables the first is azure
table storage API a robust tool for
developers to seamlessly integrate query
and manage their data it provides you
the flexibility to interact
programmatically and customize according
to your application's needs on the other
hand we have Microsoft Azure storage
Explorer it offers a userfriendly
interface to browse manipulate and
manage your data without writing a
single line of code think of it as your
visual window into the world of azure
tables here is a visual of azure storage
Explorer a standalone app that makes it
easy to work with Azure storage data on
Windows Mac OS and Linux you can create
blob containers upload files create
snapshots of disk and more so when
should you use Azure table storage large
amounts of semi-structured data if you
have massive volumes of semi-structured
or unstructured data but don't need the
complexities of a relational database
costeffective storage Azure table
storage is a budget friendly solution
especially when compared to full-fledged
databases it's suitable for projects
where lowcost storage is a priority
scheme of flexibility if your
application has evolving data structures
where the schema can change over time
the schema less design of azure table
storage offers flexibility scalability
requirements for applications that need
to scale out by adding more data
entities but don't require complex joins
stored procedures or secondary indexes
and fast access and high throughput if
you need a storage solution with low
latency and high availability
characteristics for quick access to data
so that's an overview of azure table
storage the next topic we'll be covering
is adding entries in Azure table storage
when you enter data you must provide a
partition key this is a unique
identifier for each partition within a
table this key enables Azure to
distribute table data across multiple
nodes for improved data access and load
balancing for instance you might use the
date and time as a partition key for log
data ensuring entries are evenly
distributed and easily sorted row key
this key is a unique identifier within a
partition allowing you to pinpoint a
specific entity it's like the address of
your data within the partition for
instance in a list of customers a
customer ID could serve as a r key Azure
table supports a diverse set of data
types string textual data such as names
or addresses Boolean true or false
values binary data such as file or image
date time specific date and time
information double floating Point
numbers get Global unique identifiers in
32 and in 64 whole numbers both small
and large when you need to retrieve data
you can perform queries using both
partition and row keys this dual Key
System allows for Rob in flexible data
retrieval operations for example if
you're looking for a specific
transaction in a financial database you
can use the partition key to narrow down
the date and the row key to find the
exact transaction Azure table storage
allows you to apply additional filters
to your queries if you need to find all
entries from a specific location or all
entries falling under a particular
category you can easily set up filters
to refine your search so that's a quick
overview of adding entries in Azure
table
storage
the next topic we'll be covering is
azure Q storage Azure Q storage is a
robust and straightforward messaging
broker that facilitates smooth and
secure message exchange between various
applications and services within the
Azure environment key features simple
message broker Azure Q storage allows
Services running on cloud infrastructure
to communicate with each other
asynchronously it can handle large
numbers of messages simultaneously
ensuring your services remain highly
responsive security Azure Q storage uses
authenticated HTTP as protocols ensuring
that data transmission is secure and
reliable message size it can hold
messages up to 64 kilobytes in size
accommodating a wide range of data types
and
sizes for storage and access storage
account Q storage is stored within an
Azure storage account ensuring a secure
and unified setting for All Storage
needs access keys and connection strings
utilize the same axis keys and
connection strings for Q storage as with
other resources in the storage account
ensuring streamlined and consistent
access management Azure Q storage offers
three ways of handling messages on the
que Peak this option allows you to
preview a message in the queue without
deleting or locking it it's useful for
determining the next message to process
delete after successfully processing a
message an application will typically
delete the message to ensure it isn't
processed again receive and lock by
locking a message it ensures that other
parts of the system can process the
message simultaneously after process ing
the lock is either renewed or the
message is
deleted Azure portal easily create a
Quee and send messages through the
userfriendly interface of the Azure
portal Azure SDK or CLI for more
programmatic control most interactions
with the queue including sending peing
and deleting messages can be performed
using the Azure SDK or command line
interface here is a python example to
help you understand what this looks like
developers can create cues add messages
and process them with just a few lines
of code so that's an overview of azure Q
storage the next topic will be covering
are the key Concepts in Azure Q storage
cues can be accessed by using the
following URL format https storage
account. q.c. windows.net Q the
following URL addresses a Que in the
diagram https by account. q.c cor.
windows.net images to download here's a
breakdown of the components store
storage account a storage account is
required for all Azure storage access
think of it as your gateway to Azure
storage Services q a q contains a set of
messages keep in mind the Q name must be
all lowercase message you can store any
format of data in a message but it must
not exceeds 64 Koby if for version 2017
0729 the maximum time to live allow is 7
days for version 2017 0729 or later the
maximum time to live can be any positive
number or minus one indic that the
message doesn't expire in addition the
default time to live is 7 days if this
parameter is not
specified you can interact with the
queue via the Azure CLI subcommand a Z
Storage message action clear deletes all
messages from the specified que delete
deletes the specified message get
retrieves one or more messages from the
front of the queue peik retrieves one or
more messages from the front of the
queue but does not alter the visibility
of the message put adds a new message to
the back of the message queue update
updates the visibility timeout of a
message so that's an overview of the key
Concepts in Azure Q
[Music]
storage hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this segment we'll be
covering Azure files Azure files is a
fully managed file share in the cloud a
file share is a centralized server for
storage that allows multiple connections
it's like having one big share drive
that everyone or in this example
multiple virtual machines can work on at
the same time to connect to the file
share you can use Network protocols like
the server message block or network file
system when a connection is established
the file shares file system will be
accessible in the specific directory
within your own directory tree this
process is known as
mounting backups you shared snapshots to
backup your file share these snapshots
are readed only and incremental meaning
they only contain data that has changed
since the last snapshot you could have a
maximum of 200 snapshots per file share
and these can be retained for a whopping
10 years remember backups are stored
within your file share if you delete the
share you say goodbye to the backups as
well soft delete you can prevent
accidental deletion by turning on soft
delete with soft delete your data isn't
immediately removed instead it's marked
for deletion and held for a certain
period before it's permanently erased
Advanced threat protection an additional
layer of security intelligence that
provides alerts when it detects
suspicious activity on your storage
account store tiers premium store on to
SSD with singled digigit milliseconds
for most EO operations transaction
optimized store on HDD with transaction
heavy workloads that don't need the
latency offered by premium file shares
hot optimized for general purpose file
sharing scenarios such as team shares
and Azure file sync cool stored on HDD
for cost efficient storage optimized for
online archade storage
scenarios types of storage general
purpose version 2 deployed onto HDD file
storage deployed on the SSD identity on
premises Azure storage can integrate
with an on- premises active directory
domain service managed Azure storage can
be joined to Microsoft managed active
directory domain service store account
key use a combination of storage account
name as the username and the account key
as the password for mounting networking
a aure files can be access from anywhere
both inside and outside your Azure
account through the storage accounts
public in point remember SMB uses Port
445 if you face connection issues check
if this port is open in your
organization to mount your file share
encryption Azure files is encrypted at
rest using Azure storage service
encryption Azure files is encrypted and
Transit with SMB 3.0 plus with
encryption or
https and there we have it a
comprehensive look into Azure files and
its noteworthy
features continuing from our discussion
on Azure files let's now explore its
main use cases use cases for Azure files
completely replace or supplement on
premises file servers Network network
attached storage devices lift and shift
your on premises storage to the cloud
via classic lift or hybrid lift lift and
shift means when you move workloads
without rear tting for example you can
directly import your local VMS to the
clab classic lift both the application
and its data are moved to Azure hybrid
lift here only the application data gets
moved to Azure files while the
application remains operational on
premises simplify Cloud development
shared application settings multiple VMS
and developer workstations need to
access the same configuration files
diagnostic share all VMS log to the file
share developers can M and debug all
logs in a centralized Place Dev test
debug developers can quickly share
essential tools needed for local
environments containerization you can
use Azure files to persist volumes for
stateful containers while use Azure
files instead of setting up your own
file share server shared access Azure
files is preconfigured to function with
standard networking protocols like SMB
and NFS fully managed Azure manages
maintenance and security patches to
ensure your file storage is secure and
updated scripting and tooling you can
automate the management and creation of
files shared with Azure API and
Powershell resiliency Azure files is
built for durability ensuring that your
data is always safe and accessible so
these are the main reasons and scenarios
for incorporating Azure files into your
infrastructure the next topic we'll be
covering is azure file sync Azure file
sync is a service that it allows you to
Cache azzure file shares on an on
premises Windows server or Cloud VM how
does it work caching Azure file sync
transforms your Windows Server into a
quick cach of your Azure file share this
means that you can access the data you
need faster than ever without having to
rely on the cloud multiple protocols
regardless of the protocol you're
comfortable with be it SMB NFS or ftps
aure file sync lets you access your data
locally granting greater flexibility
Global caches for businesses operating
globally as your file s Sy allows
setting up caches in multiple locations
for faster data access key benefits
centralized storage with Azure file sync
you get centralized file services in
Azure allowing multiple locations to use
cloud tiering and direct Cloud access to
store and access data integrated with
Azure backup Azure file sync integrates
seamlessly with Azure backup offering
unified and streamlined backup Services
Cloud tearing as your storage needs
change older or rarely used files can be
moved to Azure saving space on your
local servers easy integration it's
designed to integrate smoothly with your
existing infrastructure meaning less
learning curve and disruption so that's
a brief overview of azure file
[Music]
sync hey this is Andie Brown from exam
Pro and in this follow I'm going to show
you how to set up a file share uh and
mount it to a virtual machine so let's
get to it so the first thing we're going
to do is go all the way to the top and
we're going to type in storage accounts
because if you type in files or um Azure
files you're just not going to get
anything because it is a subservice uh
within a storage account so we'll go
ahead and hit add and I think I will
name uh I'll make a new Resource Group
as I always do I'm going to name this
one as
keos okay and then we'll name the
account as such now I want to show you
something here so under the account kind
uh if you remember from our lecture
content you can create a uh a file share
under general purpose 2 um but if you go
to premium 2 you'll have just a file
storage type that means only your this
storage account is only for creating a
file storage and that's if you want to
use the premium tier 4 uh um axis and we
don't today um but I will show you uh
when we get to that in a moment here uh
just to point that out to you so what
we'll do is go ahead and hit review
create actually before we do that let's
just double check if there's anything
interesting here sometimes there is so
under Azure files for large file shares
um provides file share support up to 100
terabytes so right now it's it's
disabled but if you wanted larger files
you could go ahead and enable that but
we're just going to leave it off I'm
going to go ahead and hit review and
create now as this is creating and this
goes pretty darn quick uh what I'm going
to do is launch a new virtual machine
because we need something uh to mount
the file share too so make your way over
to Virtual
machines and what we're going to do is
launch a Linux one just because that's a
lot easier for me to do here and they're
generally more inexpensive so we'll
choose
Kos I'm also going to name the virtual
machiney evos and we'll choose Ubuntu as
our image so just go down here make sure
you choose 18 LTS generation 2 and under
the sizes we'll expand it make sure you
choose B1 LS because that costs around
$6 a month under your password we will
choose Azure user as the name and then
for the password itself testing 1 two 3
capital on that t so capital T testing 1
23 4 5 6 sorry it's always uh 1 2 3 4 5
6 we should probably open up Port 44
five um but uh we'll get to that when um
we get to the uh actually after we
create it here so I'll hit review and
create and we will go ahead and just
give it a
moment just takes a little bit of time
and we'll just go and create that
there so as that is creating we'll go
back to our storage account we'll go
into it and uh as as you notice these
are the services the the things that we
can launch in our storage account what
we want is a file share that's Azure
files um and notice here that the
capacity is set to 5 terabytes and it
has a soft delete for 7 days it's not
configured with Azure Azure active
directory as of yet if we wanted to use
that to authenticate but what we'll do
is click on file share on the right hand
side I'm going to name our file share as
keyos I'm going to set the total to uh 3
gigabytes because we don't need a lot of
data and remember that tier I talked
about well here it is it's disabled but
if we had created it a a a premium
storage account and a file file storage
we could could have chosen that all
right so we'll go ahead and hit create
and this doesn't take too long as that's
going let's make our way back to our
virtual machine it looks like it's
deployed so we'll go to that resource
and then on the left hand side we'll go
to networking because I want to open up
that Port Port Port 445 that's what ssnb
SMB communicates on and so uh down below
all this is fine but if we were to go
here there isn't one for SMB so what
we'll do is just put in 445 and we'll
say TCP and I'll just write down your
SMB and we'll go ahead and hit add and
that only takes a moment there we'll
make our way back to our storage account
we'll click in or sorry into our files
yeah Serge account in our files notice
we have connect and upload and so what
we're going to do is Click uh connect
and it's going to give us some
instructions here that we can run and
this is going to be the mount point so
I'm going to go make my way back to here
and I see that that record has been
created and I'm going to open up our uh
Cloud
shell and so if you've never opened up
cloud Cloud shell before It'll ask you
to make a storage account that is
specific just for it just say yes make
sure you're in bash mode we cannot do
this in Powershell and uh within your
virtual machine if you're on the right
tab here you'll go to overview and we're
going to grab that public IP address
type SSH Azure user at sign paste in the
IP address we'll hit enter type in yes
to accept the fingerprint and then type
your password capital T testing 1 23 4 5
6 okay and it'll let us in and what
we're going to need to do is do a pseudo
apt update and I'm going to do Ampersand
Ampersand just so we can run this in one
line we're going to type in pseudo apt
install cifs utils this is the utility
that we're going to use to do um that's
part of the mounting so we need to make
sure that is installed and so we'll let
that go um up apt update can take a lot
of time or a very little amount of time
it just depends on how many updates
there are but it shouldn't take too long
um and so what we're going to do is
prepare this because this is not the
easiest to work with and so what we'll
do I already have it open here because I
was given this a go earlier this is the
exact same thing but I'm going to delete
it out so it's one: one because I think
it might have changed a little bit here
whoops and so I will copy this
here and paste it in and we'll just give
it a quick read so what it's going to do
um I don't know if it would color this
if I went to bash here shell script
there we go it's a bit easier so it's
going to uh create a Dory called Mount
keos um and then it's going to create
another directory for the SMB
credentials it's going to store the
username and then the password in these
credentials we're going to chamod it so
we have our permissions uh and then we
have this bass script here um which is a
little bit hard to read but it is using
cifs so it's doing some something there
and setting that stuff up and then it's
using CFS it's actually mounting this
case so that's what we're going to do so
um just go going back over here and back
to this other
tab um what I'm going to do here
is um oh sorry now this is ready we're
going to just type in clear and I'm
going to run each of these commands so
I'm going to grab the make directory
here and I'm going to paste that in if
you paste all this in half the time it
messes up when you have multi-line like
that so it's not even worth trying uh so
we'll do copy we'll make that other
directory
here and then uh we have this pseudo
bash line here so we'll copy that
okay hit enter and then we'll grab this
next line here we'll copy that paste
that in hit
enter did not like the space in front of
it I think it's just a really long line
so what I'll do is I'll just grab that
line and move to the wall make my life a
little bit easier and we'll paste that
in like
that um it's saying the credentials does
not
exist hold on
here so we'll just write clear it's okay
if it happens so this directory should
exist right so if I do um um
PWD Etc or we should just be able to
autocomplete it so CD Etc I'm hitting
tab to autocomplete and then we want
SMB and this says
credential so it's missing the S so
there's my mistake okay so I'm going to
go ahead and remove that because if we
don't have it named right it's just not
going to work right so we'll go ahead
here and make sure we copy the entire
line that was my mistake and we'll paste
that in there we'll go to the next line
copy that paste that
in copy the next
line here paste that
in and uh we will what we'll do is we'll
chamod the
file okay so if we want to check to make
sure it's the correct permissions what
we can do is is um do an LS paste in the
or just write in the path uh which is
SMB credentials here and here we can see
the file if we do a hyphen La it will
show us that it has the correct
permission so see it's really locked
down there that's what the Chabad did if
we want to see the contents of that file
to make sure that those things are in
there uh what we can do is type in um
cat and just grab that whole link here
we might have to give it pseudo it might
complain for that it does so we'll put
pseudo in front of that and so we just
want to make sure there's one username
and one password um and everything looks
okay there we'll type clear we'll make
our way back here and so now we'll run
these commands so that's the first
one and then this say is the second
one we'll make sure that that n matches
up i o yep I O hit enter and so now it
should work so if we were to upload a
file uh that should be in good shape but
if we want to get to that directory
we'll just type in Mount if we keep on
hitting tab it will show us there's
keyos okay and so you know this is where
we're going to create some files so I
actually don't have a file prepared so
give me a moment I'll be back in a
moment with a file all right I'm back
and I've uh prepared an image for our
self load so going back to our uh file
share in here we have the upload button
just go ahead and click that and on the
right hand side it's going to give you a
popup and uh within that popup there um
just go find your image I'm just
offscreen grabbing it so this is uh my
image what I'm uploading which is keas
uh keas fagio it's who we named it after
he's the collector in Star Trek Con
generation and so what I'll do is go
ahead and hit
upload right and so that file is
supposedly there if we go back here and
do uh LS there's the file right um and
so probably it should be reflective so
if we were to go and uh delete this file
so we'd say remove or maybe if we made a
new directory let's see what happens if
we say um you know uh the episode's
called the most toys in Star
Trek just see if it actually reflects
back and forth so we do a refresh there
it is can I drag no I can't drag but I
could probably move this file over there
so we'll say move uh keos fio into the
most toys episode and if we go back here
and
refresh you get the idea right so yeah u
i mean that's as simple it is uh with
the file share there okay so now that
we're all done here with Azure file
share we can't or we can't use this to
make a file sync because we would have
to use Windows for that so this is all
pretty much done so what I want you to
do is go to your resource groups we'll
find keyos and we'll go ahead and delete
this and we'll call this uh part of our
follow along 100% done here okay so see
you in the next
[Music]
one hey this is angre Brown from exam
Pro and we are going to take a look at
using Azure file sync so uh previously
we set up a file share with just Linux
but we're going to take it a bit further
and set up a sync so what we're going to
do is we're going to do two things we're
going need to set up a new storage
account and we'll also have to launch a
virtual machine since virtual machines
take longer to launch than a storage
account what I want you to do I still
have the old tab here from the last uh
follow along but what I want you to do
is make your way over to Virtual
machines open that a new tab and we'll
go ahead and launch ourself a Windows
Server so up in the top left corner hit
uh ad virtual machine we'll give it a
moment I'm going to call this new one uh
well we we can use keos again so I'm
going to go ahead and do that we'll say
this is keyos and I'm going to choose
this time Windows 2019 server so we have
a Windows server and I want uh
2019 um it doesn't necessarily have to
be let me just double check
here um yeah we'll just do 2019
generation 2 here and we'll scroll on
down here and I'm going to put an Azure
user and then we'll do um uh capital T
testing 1 2 3 4 5 6 capital T testing 1
2 3 4 5 6 scroll on down we are
definitely going to want Port 3389 open
um we'll open up these two ports as well
I think that's okay and we'll go ahead
hit review and create well actually
before we do that I don't think I choose
the right size so um we'll just wait a
moment here as it's complaining and
we'll change this because you can't have
a B1 LS we're going to have to go with
um uh
dsv uh SV uh DS V3 okay because it has
two V vcpus at the minimum actually we
can go with this one here because it
just has to be two and four so I think
we can get away with a B2 which is 50 50
bucks a month which we're not going to
keep that around for very long we'll go
ahead and hit
create um we might need actually before
that I'm just going to add another disc
just in case because I really don't want
to have to do this if I have to make
another one and so we're just going to
say an empty disc here I
suppose yeah that seems fine to me and
I'm going to go ahead
and hit uh yeah we should enable dis now
we'll do nothing there and we'll say
okay and go ahead and hit review
create and we'll just give it a moment
takes a little bit of time and go ahead
and hit create there and while that's
creating now we'll go over and make
ourselves a storage account so I'll make
a new one here and we'll call it uh
we'll put it in our keos and we'll call
it keos we'll stick with Standard
General 2 that's totally fine for our
use case we'll go ahead and hit create
and this will not take
long it's very fast to making storage
accounts virtual Windows Virtual
machines not as
fast so we'll just give it a moment
here
and it looks like it's created so we'll
go to the resource and then under file
shares we'll click on that we'll create
a new file share and this will be called
keos and we'll set 5 gigabytes because
we really don't need a large one we'll
create it and so this can be used for
Windows or Linux uh in this case we're
going to be using it for um uh windows
so what we can do uh we'll just have to
wait for that to finish deploy but we're
going to have to set up as your file so
if we go files I think we type it in
here will it show up no so if the thing
is we need to get file sync and it's in
a kind of a weird spot so if we go to
all services and then we type in
files whoops it a little bit too quick
there uh I'm just looking for it
here uh what if we type in
sync there we go so what I'm looking for
is storage sync
Services can we type it up here
sync yeah so that would have been the
way I would have gone gone gone and
found it there but we need to find uh as
your files I'm just trying to
remember how to get to
there so I could have swore we could
type in file
sync yeah here it is a your file
sync and so this is how we get to it I
know it's quite a let me just double
check to make sure if that's somewhat if
we can actually type that up here file
sync no okay so what we would want to do
is go ahead and uh create this if we
want to take a look we can check the
plans this seems okay so we'll go ahead
and hit create and under here we're
going to put it into keyos and then for
the provider name it will be the storage
sync service name will just be keyos as
well um and I guess we'll stick with
Central us I guess it just really
depends on where our virtual machine
storage account is I hope everything's
launching in the same place I don't
think it matters but I'm just going to
double check here so this one is in
Canada east and then our storage account
let's just go take a look where it is it
is in um Canada east so maybe we could
launch this in Canada east if it doesn't
give us any grief it doesn't so that's
great we'll go ahead and hit
create and we'll give that a little bit
of time there and if our instance is
ready we should go ahead and connect to
it because there's going to be a couple
things we need to install okay so I'm
going to go over to RDP here and we're
going to uh download the TP file and
that's going to open up that so we'll
just double click it we'll say connect
if you're on a Mac you got to download
the client if you're on Windows it's
already it should be pre-installed if
you if you're on a Chromebook you'll
have to use a Bastian but I'm going to
type in Azure
user and that password capital T testing
1 2 3 4 5 6 we'll hit okay I'll say yes
I'll
connect and we'll just give it a moment
there to
load we are going to need uh two things
we need to install but just give me a
moment here I'll go fetch
them all right so now that we uh I have
our Windows machine we're uh inside of
it here what I want you to do is open up
um Powershell so if you type in
Powershell we do need to run this in
administrator mode so just type it in
it's a little bit slow when you're rping
which is totally fine and what I want
you to do is right click and run as an
administrator uh and what we're going to
do is install Azure RM because we need
it in order to use um the Azure file
sync agent okay so type in install
hyphen module and then uh type in name
Azure RM and then we'll say allow
clobber don't ask me what clobber does I
have no idea but that's what Microsoft
or Azure tells us that we should uh
whoops uh did I spell that right no it's
all correct okay that we should do this
thing is pretty darn slow so uh we'll
just have to wait here a little while um
and once that's done we'll we'll
continue on to the next part
okay okay so after waiting a little bit
it asks us the question so we're just
going to hit why to everything all right
and uh as that's going here um it can
take a little bit of time so what I'm
going to do if I can even minimize this
here um and I did not mean to minimize
Azure uh or this here oh the other one
already prompted that was pretty fast
actually it's going really fast as of
today um but as that's
going um
what we'll do is we'll make our way back
over uh to sync storage here because or
storage sync we were waiting for this to
get set up uh because we're going to
have to go uh set up a sync group so I'm
going to just call this uh keyos make
everything easy we'll stick with that
Azure subscription we'll drop this down
and we'll choose keyos in here uh and
then for the Azure file share we'll
choose
keyos and once that's created we'll
click into that and what we are trying
to do is we're adding a cloud uh
endpoint here so we would choose our
storage account and we would choose uh
this here and hit
create okay and so now we have a cloud
endpoint but we still have to uh
continue on with our uh our virtual
machine here so just wait until this is
done this will take a little bit of time
okay all right so now that uh we um uh
we have that installed the the power
shell for uh resource manager what we're
going to need to install is the Azure
file sync agent in order to do that
we're going to have to go to the
internet but before we do that we really
want to uh uh turn off a particular
feature um so turn back on protective
mode I was fiddling with it earlier but
if we were to go and it doesn't matter
where we go we say Azure file uh sync
agent
okay and if we were to go see we started
getting this pop up and drives us crazy
so what we can do because this isn't a
big deal it's just for uh testing here
we're going to turn that off so um go to
your local server where it says I I IE
enhanced security configuration click on
that and just turn it off you know
because it'll drive you crazy and then
we'll go back to inter Explorer
completely close it reopen it and now uh
what we can do is look for that aure
file sync so we'll type in aure file
sync uh agent
download and that's is azure
microsoft.com maybe later for that
experience it's easier if you go to the
Microsoft site and uh if you go here
just give it a moment scroll on down
click on the download button and we want
uh 2019 because that's the server we
launched right and that and we're trying
to uh sync with storage sync so we'll go
ahead and hit next this is 50 megabytes
so it shouldn't take too
long
um and we're going to wait for it to
download if it doesn't uh well we'll say
allow once for the site here so maybe it
was trying to download yeah there it
goes and we will save
it
and we will always allow for Microsoft
here it's totally fine and it's already
finished downloading so we'll go ahead
and run
that and just give it a moment here
we'll hit next we'll accept the terms uh
we'll install it there that's totally
fine we'll use the existing proxy uh
configuration Uh custom configure proxy
well we don't have any custom so we
leave it alone we'll leave Microsoft
updates on uh it' probably be good to
checkbox that on but I'm just going to
go install next
here all right and so we'll let the
agent
install usually doesn't take too
long any I'll see you back here in a
moment all right so now that we have our
St agent set up we'll just hit finish
here uh and I don't know why it opened a
bunch of windows but that's just what it
does and so we're just going to wait for
for it to pop back up here and then
we'll say
okay and then what it'll want to do is
connect so it says Azure environment uh
so it is azure Cloud right and I'm just
going to sign into my account and I'm
going to try and log in here so let me
just go grab my
credentials all right so I entered my
credentials in here so we'll go ahead
ahead and hit sign in and we'll give it
a moment there we're going to choose our
subscription we will choose our Resource
Group which is keyos and our storage
sync there hit register
and I'll see you back here in a
moment all right so it looks like our
registration was successful so that
means that we should be able to create a
server endpoint uh and go from there
okay so I'm going to just go ahead and
hit close and uh I'll come back here to
you in a moment all right so now what
we're going to do is set up a folder for
uh that that we're going to want to uh
uh be synced okay because the idea is to
back up or sync that directory there so
uh what's going to happen here is we're
going to make our way down to a file
explorer and from this PC I'm just going
to go to the C drive I made that other
drive because I assumed we were just
going to throw it on there but honestly
I'm just going to put it in the window
or the C drive here we'll make a new
folder called keos we'll make it all
lowercase and inside of here I'm just
going to make a new file here called
hello.txt nothing super exciting um and
so uh probably we need to turn on
sharing so that's just a habit of mine
so we'll go to properties here sharing
share and we'll just make sure that
Azure Azure user has both that and it'll
ask us to turn network discovery on
we'll say okay keos keos okay I can't
remember if we have to turn that on or
not but uh you know as long as we get
this working that's the most important
part here so now that we have that going
what we want to do is make our way back
to um Azure here and so we had our uh
what was the sync sync
storages and what we'll need to do is go
into our sync storage once it ever lets
us uh get there we'll click on keyos and
we'll go into sync groups we'll click
into our keyos sync group we have a
cloud endpoint we'll need to create an
add server endpoint drop down here we
have a registered server so you know how
we typed in our we typed we typed in our
we logged into the Azure file sync agent
that's how this registered server is
showing up we're going to give it a path
so this is going to be C back SL keyos
right um so this all looks
okay and what we'll do is we will say
let's just check this here this is all
okay and we'll go ahead and hit uh
connect all right and so this takes a
little bit of time to provision it's
going to show up here in a moment if I
hit refresh it's provisioning so I'll
see you back here in a
bit you know I just remembered is that
uh we do actually have to turn on cloud
tering or it's going to stay pending
forever so so I'm going to go to enable
here and uh always preserve specific
percentage of free space on the volume
uh sure we can do 20% here we don't need
a date policy here and this all looks
okay so we'll go ahead and hit save uh
because if we don't do that it's not
going to actually it's not going to move
it to the cloud right so we'll give that
a go oh the health is good um and but
we'll just give it a moment here
okay so we give it a little bit of time
here it says the Point failed which I
really don't believe it because I just
checked and it was working totally fine
but what I want to do is show you if I
go over to Microsoft Azure here and we
go over to uh storage accounts and we go
to keyos and we go into file shares and
we click into this one we can actually
see the files here so it clearly is
syncing uh I'm not sure why we got that
error I've never seen that error before
um cloud is not supported for the
specified path well that's fine okay so
if the server path didn't work maybe
it's the cloud cloud endpoint but but
generally that is the workflow to uh get
uh syncing working so you pretty much
have all the working knowledge you need
um but uh what we'll do is go ahead and
tear all this stuff down because we are
100% done so I'm going to go to our
resource groups
here and uh what we'll do is go into
keyos and we'll just make sure that
everything is there even the storage
sync service I just wanted to make sure
it was all there and what we'll do is go
ahead and write in keyos and go ahead
and delete and that should take
everything down no problem all right so
there you
go all right so just one more thing uh I
was doing that cleanup and then today I
woke up the next morning and when I
checked my resource groups the keyos was
still here so I went in here and we
still had uh the storage sync service so
what you're going to want to do is go in
here and I think what it wants you to do
actually tell us the message here if we
go delete Resource Group we type in
keyos and uh it will complain that uh
it's it still need you have to get rid
of the um the resources within it so I
already know that's going to fail um but
what I want you to do is delete the sync
group a so if you select the sync group
here and go ahead and delete
that we might also have to delete the
end points
first usually uh usually a is really
great about tearing everything down but
in this case uh it's not giving us a lot
of help here so we'll just say um yeah
we want to delete this end point too
let's delete all the server so you got
to first delete the server endpoints to
delete the cloud endpoint to delete the
group then to delete the actual uh
service so it's a little bit um
convoluted but uh you know I guess for
whatever reason this one is not
automated like the other one so just go
through those process make sure that you
get everything deleted out okay um and
then you should be in good shape
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering the core backup and Disaster
Recovery Solutions in Azure starting
with Azure site recovery Azure site
recovery is a hybrid backup solution
that facilitates sight to sight recovery
from on premises to the cloud ASR is a
critical component for your business
continuity and Disaster Recovery
strategy site recovery replicates
workloads from a primary site to a
secondary site in the event the primary
site encounters a failure site recovery
will fail over to the secondary site to
ensure continuity of services Azure site
recovery can replicate Azure VMS between
different regions also known as cross
region replication various OS such as
Windows and Linux on premises to Azure
seamlessly transition from your local
servers to the cloud between other cloud
service providers such as AZ to Azure
different machines including VMware
hyperv or physical machines recovery
time objectives this is the amount of
time your business business can afford
to have its systems unavailable or
offline before it significantly impacts
your business recovery Point objectives
this is the maximum amount of data loss
your business can tolerate measured in
time before a disaster occurs this
overview highlights Azure site recovery
a key tool for protecting business
operations against unexpected
disruptions the next topic we'll be
covering is Recovery Solution for Azure
site recovery a Recovery Solution for
Azure hybrid and on premises workloads
should be designed to meet specific
recovery objectives including recovery
time objective recovery Point objective
and Recovery level objective recovery
time objective RTO is the maximum amount
of time that an application can be down
before it starts causing significant
business disruption a Recovery Solution
should be able to restore the system and
data within the specified RTO time frame
for example if the RTO is 1 hour then
the Recovery Solution should be able to
restore the system and data within 1
hour of an outage
recovery Point objective RPO is the
amount of data loss that is acceptable
after an outage The Recovery Solution
should be able to restore the system and
data to the required RPO level for
example if the RPO is 1 hour then the
Recovery Solution should be able to
restore the data to the most recent
point in time within 1 hour of the
outage recovery level objective R is the
level of recovery that is required after
an outage the rlo can vary depending on
the type of data or application being
recovered a Recovery Solution should be
able to restore the data or application
to the required rlo level for example if
the rlo requires a point in time restore
The Recovery Solution should be able to
restore the data to the specific point
in time when recommending a Recovery
Solution for Azure hybrid and on
premises workloads the following factors
should be considered business
requirements The Recovery Solution
should align with the business
requirements including the RTO rlo and
RPO objectives these objectives should
be identified during the planning phase
workload types different types of
workloads may have different RTO rlo and
RPO requirements The Recovery Solution
should be able to accommodate the
requirements of each workload type
hybrid or on premises The Recovery
Solution should be able to handle hybrid
or on premises workloads depending on
the specific requirements of the
organization data protection The
Recovery Solution should provide data
protection including backups and
replication to ensure that the data can
be recovered in case of an outage
testing the Recovery Solution should be
tested regularly to ensure that it meets
the RTO rlo and RPO objectives testing
should be conducted in a controlled
environment to avoid any negative impact
on production systems by considering
these factors you can enhance your Azure
site Recovery Solutions ensuring Swift
and efficient data recovery to maintain
business
continuity in this section we're going
to explore an example of azure site
recovery architecture This Disaster
Recovery Solution utilizes Azure site
recovery alongside other managed
services like traffic manager and
virtual Network this combination
provides a costeffective and high
availability environment suitable for
small to medium businesses this allows
companies to focus more on their core
Solutions benefiting various Industries
including Health Care travel and
hospitality and Manufacturing for
example it can be used in portable
healthcare clinics restaurant chains and
local Logistics and Supply chains here
is a breakdown of the architecture
traffic manager this Azure service
wrotes DNS traffic enabling easy
redirection from one site to another
based on policies set by your
organization Azure site recovery this
service handles the orchestration of
machine replication and manages the
setup of failback procedures virtual
Network this is the location where the
failover site is established when a
disaster happens blot storage this is
where the replica images of all machines
protected by site recovery are stored so
that's an overview of the example Azure
site recovery architecture
shown
the next topic we'll be covering is the
Azure Backup Service another crucial
tool for backup and Disaster Recovery
Solutions Azure backup service is a
Cloud solution from Microsoft that
offers secure scalable and simple data
backup in recovery across various Azure
Services you won't find it by searching
based on the service name however Azure
backup is seamlessly integrated within
numerous Azure Services making its
operation quite intuitive the five core
components of azure backup Mars agent
helps in backing up files folders and
System state data from on premises
machines and Azure VMS to a backup
Recovery Services Vault and Azure
Recovery Services Vault manages and
organizes your backups in a cost
effective secure and scalable manner
Azure backup server MBS used to backup
on premises data to Azure for hybrid
protection VM extension allows the
backup of azure VMS without the need to
deploy any additional agents backup
policy defines when and how your data is
backed up
what can be backed up on premises Azure
VMS Azure manage discs Azure file shares
SQL Server sap handed databases Azure
database for postgressql servers and
Azure blobs why use Azure backup offload
on premises backups saf card your data
by moving backups to Azure backup Azure
iOS VMS ensure your Azure VM data is
protected scale easily adjust your
backup storage size based on your needs
get unlimited data transfer no limits or
charges for data trans transfer keep
data secure ensure your data is secure
both at rest in and Transit centralized
monitoring and management have a unified
View and manage your backups easily app
consistent backups restore applications
back to a precise State automatic
storage management no need to manage
Backup storage explicitly multiple
storage options choose between different
storage options based on your needs so
that's an overview of azure backup
service
the next topic we'll be covering is
azure Recovery Services Vault Azure
Recovery Services vault is a storage
entity in Azure that stores backup
copies of data and configuration
information over time this data can be
related to various Azure resources like
virtual machines workloads servers or
workstations backup for Azure Services
RS Vault protects data from various
Azure services including iOS VMS Azure
SQL databases Azure blob storage Azure
file shares and Azure functions recovery
Services Vault supports various
platforms including system center data
protection manager Windows server
integrates with Azure backup server for
application protection and other
platforms Recovery Services vaults has
the following features enhanced security
Azure Recovery Services Vault encrypts
data in transit and at rest for secure
backup and restore processes Central
monitoring the Azure portal allows
centralized monitoring of all backup and
restore tasks across hybrid environments
azure role-based Access Control Azure
rbac enables granular access control and
management of Recovery Services vaults
soft Elite this feature retains backup
data for an additional 14 days after
deletion protecting against accidental
or malicious data loss cross region
restore crr enables data restoration in
a secondary region during a disaster in
the primary region ensuring business
continuity so that's an overview of
azure Recovery Services
vault
next let's explore the Microsoft Azure
Recovery Services agent the Mars agent
plays an important role in backing up
files folders and the system state from
Windows based on premises machines and
Azure VMS all backups facilitated by the
Mars agent are securely stored in a
Recovery Services vault in Azure Mars
agent is also known as the Azure backup
agent note that the Mars agent does not
support Linux operating systems to get
started with utilizing the Mars agent
for backup purposes follow these steps
create an Azure Recovery Services Vault
this Vault will store all the backups
create a backup policy within the Vault
set the terms and conditions for backups
ensuring they align with your
requirements configure secure rub for
backup depending on your security and
performance needs you might opt for
Pathways like Express routes or private
end points download the Mars agent
download the agent from Azure install
and register the agent to your Windows
machine once installed register it for
Activation and functionality overall the
Mars agent streamlines the backup
process for windows-based systems
ensuring that data is both safely stored
in Azure and swiftly recoverable when
[Music]
needed next let's explore the Azure
backup policy Azure backup policy allows
users to Define and configure how data
backups are managed on the Azure
platform it lets you set the frequency
retention duration and type of backups
to ensure data protection and meet
organizational requirements creating a
backup policy and azure inv involves a
few essential steps select a data source
type choose the type of data you want to
back up such as Azure virtual machines
or posters ql data base determine the
frequency decide how often you want the
backups to occur this could be daily
weekly or any other frequency that suits
your needs set the retention details
determine how many snapshots or backup
copies you wish to retain and for how
long choose the time range for retention
specify the time range during which you
want to retain the backups this setting
helps in managing the life cycle of the
back up data efficiently in summary
Azure backup policy allows you to set
customized backup in retention settings
for Reliable and consistent data
protection the next topic we'll be
covering is azure VM backup Azure VM
backup is a solution for backing up and
restoring virtual machines running on
Azure it allows organizations to protect
their virtual machines and their data
against various issues such as
accidental deletion Hardware failure
ransomware and other for forms of data
loss how it works Azure VM backup
utilizes Azure backup to offer a
centralized backup solution manageable
through the Azure portal Powershell or
rest apis it supports both windows and
Linux virtual machines allowing for
backup and restore operations at both
the dis and VM levels multiple backup
options are available including full
backups incremental backups and
differential backups backup retention
policies enable organizations to retain
backups for specified durations
enhancing data man management and
compliance ke features the solution
employs the robust infrastructure of
azure backup ensuring encryption at rest
and support for backing up VMS across
different regions and availability zones
the integration with Recovery Services
vaults further strengthens the
protection and management of backup data
Disaster Recovery Beyond backup Azure VM
backup bolsters Disaster Recovery
strategies by enabling the replication
of virtual machines to a secondary
region this redundancy is vital in
mitigating the impact of outages or
disasters organizations can seamlessly
fail over in fail back virtual machines
ensuring minimal downtime and enhanced
business continuity in conclusion Azure
VM backup stands out as a resilient and
dependable backup in recovery solution
for Azure hosted virtual
[Music]
machines hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this follow along we're
going to be looking at backup solutions
for Azure so let's make our way all the
way to the top here and launch ourselves
a virtual machine
that we are going to be using uh as a
means to back up so what I'll do is
create a new group here um and we will
call it
peard uh and we'll call this virtual
machine peard and scrolling on down here
yeah I want to stick with a Windows
Server 2019 Gen 2 so go over here select
it uh as generation 2 there and for the
machine you want to make sure it's a b2s
cuz you need at least two vpcu and 4 GB
Ram to launch a Windows uh server there
for the the user is going to be Azure
user for the password capital T testing
1 2 3 4 5 6 capital T testing 1 2 3 456
uh we'll have RDP uh I'm not sure if
we'll end up using it uh but if we do we
have that open we'll go ahead and go to
the review page we'll wait for it to
allow us to hit create give it a
moment great we'll hit
create and then we'll give it a moment
to see that it is deploying and if it's
deploying I'll see you back here in a
moment great so it looks like our
virtual machine is ready to go here so
what we'll do is go all the way to the
top here and type in backups we can go
to vaults directly but let's take a look
here at the backup center uh where we
can kind of have a bit of an overview of
stuff so the idea is we have vaults
where we're going to store our backups
we can create backup jobs backup
policies so let's get to it and and
first create ourselves a vault so we'll
go ahead here and create ourselves a new
Vault and we have two options we have
Recovery Services Vault or a backup
Vault so uh the difference here is that
one is just for backing up things like
databases discs and Etc where Recovery
Services is more like a like a sitewide
recovery so you're going to notice it
includes virtual machines and all these
other stuff uh generally you'll probably
want to go with Recovery Services Vault
because it is just basically a new
version of the backup Vault so let's go
ahead and do
that and uh we'll place this in our Bard
um a resource Group there and we'll just
say peard backup or vault Vault there we
go and we'll go ahead and hit review and
create and we'll go and hit create
there and we'll just give it a moment
there to deploy all right so our
Recovery Services vault is ready and
we'll go ahead and click back up and
down below ask us what kind we are
running so we have Azure stack and on
premise it's just Azure and we have a
virtual machine so we'll go ahead and
hit backup and notice that we'll have to
set up a backup policy and here we have
a default one but let's actually go and
make a new one so we can kind of learn
some of the settings that we can set so
we can say the frequency the time Etc
probably want to set this to my time
zone so I'm in Toronto if I can find it
here which I believe is
-5 uh I was trying to type to see if I
could do that but I wasn't uh getting uh
getting there too well um we'll just say
central Canada there that's okay it's
off by an hour but that's close enough
um and you can have weekly monthly and
yearly backups but we're going to stick
with the daily backup for 30
days um and this is okay we don't have
to enter that in we'll hit all right
okay and now we can add our virtual
machine so we'll go here and select the
card hit okay enable
backups please select at least one that
has backups enabled so what we'll do is
open up our Azure tab here make our way
over to our virtual machine and just
make sure that that stuff is
enabled so we'll go over
here um and we'll go to
backups and here we can actually even
set set it from here so I guess we'll
select our existing Vault here it'll say
enable
backups but that set it up with a
default one right so I'm a bit surprised
we couldn't do it that way
but we'll make our way back
here as long as it works that's the
thing with Azure it's just you know
you'll do something and then you'll find
that uh you have to do it slightly
different uh but we we'll just wait
until that's done there so after waiting
a very short while uh it looks like
backups are turned on so if we were to
go to our overview and go to backups you
can see we have one backp item if we go
over to our backup items we'll see under
virtual machines we have Bard um we did
set the default policy so I guess if we
wanted to switch that out we probably
could if we just go back and let's just
go create a policy of our own just so
that we are familiar with that there um
and we'll say an Azure virtual machine
one so my special
policy
okay and um this is for 180 days we go
ahead and hit
create and once that policy is deployed
we'll be able to associate I can't
remember if this will be super fast but
we'll give it a moment here yep it is
super fast and then once uh we have that
poliy we can go into it and then start
assigning things to it actually I think
when I made the lecture content I don't
even remember there being a backup
center so to me this is all a little bit
new um so maybe I'll go back and up to
the slides cuz I I usually say there is
no centralized service but they have one
now so um that's uh pretty darn good um
so for Associated items we don't fetch
any data for services completed um so
I'm just trying to figure out how we can
change that policy there if we go to
backups we just change it over
here uh I'm not sure how to switch out
the policy but I know at least if we
want to do backup now we just press that
there it's really not that important to
know how to swap out a policy just more
so the fact that you know what a backup
policy is and you can apply to machines
and things like
that yeah so there we go we just had our
own backup
there and uh yeah there's not much else
here to look at but uh yeah there you go
set backup policies so I guess what
we'll do is go ahead and tear all this
down and so that was our book card there
we'll go ahead and delete this Resource
Group
and there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro in this section we're diving into an
introduction to Azure kubernetes service
or a KS Azure kubernetes service
simplifies the process of deploying a
managed kubernetes cluster in Azure one
of the main benefits of using a KS is
that Azure will take over the management
of the kubernetes master notes for you
including Health monitoring and routine
maintenance your resp responsibility
lies only in maintaining the agent nodes
an additional benefit is the cost
effectiveness of a KS the service itself
is free you only incur charges for the
agent nodes within the cluster not the
Masters when you deploy in a KS cluster
both the kubernetes master and all nodes
are deployed and configured for you
during the deployment process you can
also configure additional features such
as advanced networking Azure active
directory integration to use kubernetes
Ro based Access Control monitoring
capabilities and Windows Server
containers are supported in a KS so when
should one opt for a KS well a KS is
ideal in scenarios where you need full
container orchestration this includes
situations demanding seamless service
Discovery across multiple containers
automatic scalability to handle varying
loads and coordinated and smooth
application upgrades in summary a KS
offers a streamline managed solution for
container orchestration in Azure
simplifying the setup and maintenance of
a kubernetes
cluster
the next topic we'll be covering is
called bridge to kubernetes bridge to
kubernetes is an extension available for
both visual studio and visual studio
code that allows developers to write
test and debug microservice code
directly on their local development
workstations with bridge to kubernetes
you can integrate a service running
locally with yours cluster this bypasses
the need to create Docker and kubernetes
configurations for the lifetime of this
connection a proxy is added to your
cluster in place of your kubernetes
deployment that redirects requests to
the service to your development computer
when you disconnect the application
deployment will revert to using the
original version of the deployment
running on the cluster it's important to
note that Azure Dev spaces will be
retired on October 31st 2023 existing
users are encouraged to transition to
using bridge to kubernetes as their
client development tool ensuring a
streamlined and integrated development
experience on their local machines while
interacting with the ks clusters so
that's a brief overview bridge to
kubernetes a very useful tool to
streamline development and debugging for
developers the next topic we'll be
covering are the Recovery Solutions for
Azure kubernetes service that's
practices for business continuity and
Disaster Recovery in Azure kubernetes
service use multiple availability zones
Azure AKs supports multiple availability
zones which distribute your application
across different data centers this
ensures High availability and resiliency
in the event of a data center failure
when you create a new KS cluster you can
choose to create it across multiple
availability zones Implement backup and
restore backing up your KS cluster
ensures that you have a copy of your
application and data in case of data
loss or corruption Azure AAS supports
backing up your application data and
kubernetes resources such as deployments
and services using the Valero backup and
restore tool use Azure site recovery
Azure site recovery is a disaster
recovery solution that replicates your
KS cluster to a secondary location this
can be used useful in the event of a
disaster or outage as you can fail over
to the secondary location and resume
operations for monitor your a KS cluster
it is important to monitor your KS
cluster for any potential issues or
failures Azure provides a range of
monitoring and alerting solutions such
as Azure Monitor and Azure service
Health which can help you proactively
detect and respond to issues five test
your Disaster Recovery plan to ensure
that your Disaster Recovery plan is
effective it is important to test it
regularly you can use tools like azure
site recovery to perform failover tests
and ensure that your KS cluster can be
recovered in the event of a disaster six
use Azure kubernetes service with Azure
Arc Azure Arc enables you to manage your
KS cluster and other kubernetes clusters
across multiple clouds and on premises
environments from a single control plane
this provides greater flexibility and
resilience in the event of a disaster or
outage by following these best practices
you can ensure that your Azure
kubernetes service cluster is resilient
highly available and recoverable in the
event of a disaster
[Music]
routage hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure regions and availability
zones starting with Azure regions Azure
regions are physical locations around
the world where Microsoft as data
centers to provide cloud services each
region is composed of multiple data
centers that are geographically
dispersed to provide redundancy
resilience and high availability to
customers P facts about Azure regions
multiple data centers each region is
made up of at least one data center but
many regions have multiple data centers
for added redundancy and availability
Global presence Azure regions are
distributed around the world covering
almost every major continent and country
unique identifiers each Azure region is
designated by a distinct name such as
East us or west Europe which indicates
its geographical location resource
deployment when creating resources in
Azure you can choose which region to
deploy them to based on factors such as
proximity to users data sovereignty
require requirements and service
availability data residency data in a
region stays within that region unless
explicitly copied or replicated to
another region for redundancy or
Disaster Recovery purposes continuous
expansion Microsoft continually expands
its Azure footprint adding new regions
to cater to emerging markets and
customer needs in essence Azure regions
are the Cornerstone of azure's global
infrastructure guaranteeing High
availability redundancy and adherence to
Regional data
norms
the next topic we'll be covering our
Azure availability zones Azure
availability zones are physical data
center locations within an Azure region
that are typically located in separate
buildings or regions but still close
enough to provide low latency network
connectivity these zones help protect
applications and data from data center
level failures by providing redundant
Power Cooling and networking and Azure
region is a geographic location that
contains one or more data centers an
availability zone is a unique physical
location within an Azure region key
points of azure availability zones each
availability zone is composed of one or
more data centers with independent Power
Cooling and networking each data center
within an availability zone is connected
through a high-speed low latency Network
availability zones are designed to
provide High availability for critical
applications by Distributing them across
different zones by deploying
applications across multiple zones it is
possible to achieve a higher level of
redundancy and fault tolerance virtual
machines storage accounts and other
Azure resources can be deployed to
specific availability zones within a
region to ensure High availability Azure
traffic manager can be used to Route
traffic between different zones based on
various criteria such as geographic
location latency and performance so
that's an overview of azure availability
zones the next topic we'll be covering
are the availability options for Azure
virtual machines while we've briefly
mentioned these terms in the past we'll
now explore them in detail specifically
in the context of VMS Azure virtual
machines provide several options for
achieving High availability and ensuring
business continuity here are the primary
strategies availability sets an
availability set is a logical grouping
that informs Azure about application
redundancy and availability requirements
ideally to ensure High availability and
meet azure's
99.95% SLA place at least 2 VMS within
an availability set there are no es for
the availability set itself costs arise
only for the individual VM instances
created within virtual machine scale
sets these sets enable the automatic
deployment and scalability of identical
VMS VMS can auto adjust their capacity
as per demand facilitating autoscaling
for applications VM scale sets are built
to integrate with Azure load balancer
and application Gateway ensuring traffic
is evenly distributed across VM
instances VM distribution across fault
domains and update domains further
fortifies High availability ility Azure
site recovery this service delivers
Disaster Recovery capabilities for VMS
it facilitates VM replication to a
secondary location which could be
another Azure region a different data
center or an on premises site both
physical servers and virtual ones
including those on hyperv and VMware can
be replicated using site recovery Azure
backup Azure backup offers backup
solutions for VMS their applications and
data you can back up to the cloud
ensuring backups are application
consistent meaning they're usable and
can be restored as needed these backups
can either be retained in the
originating region or transferred to
another for Disaster Recovery
additionally Azure backup provides
extensive retention periods in backup
archiving aligning with Regulatory
Compliance needs overall these are the
main options for availability options
for Azure virtual
[Music]
machines hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
going over Azure virtual machines Azure
virtual machines offer a highly
configurable server experience through
virtualization you can run a server
without the hassles and expenses of
maintaining physical Hardware however
it's important to note that VMS are not
entirely maintenance-free they still
require OS patch applications and
package installations and configurations
key points about Azure VMS configuration
and size the size of the VM is
determined by its image this image
defines the combination of vcpus memory
and Storage capacity subscription limits
as of now there's a limit of 20 VMS per
region on a per subscription basis
billing Azure VMS are buil at an hourly
rate availability a single instance VM
offers 99.9% availability when all its
storage discs are of Premium quality to
achieve a
99.95% availability deploy two instances
in an availability set storage you can
attach multiple manage discs to your
Azure
VMS networking components when you
launch an Azure virtual machine other
networking components will be either
created or Associated to your virtual
machine including Network Security Group
a virtual firewall with rules concerning
ports and protocols this is attached to
the Nick network interface a device that
handles IP protocols and network
communication virtual machine instance
the actual server that's running public
IP address the address that you will use
publicly access your VM virtual Network
the network in which your VM is located
overall as your virtual machines offer a
versatile and strong cloud computing
space allowing easy and seamless
deployment of robust applications and
systems the next topic will be covering
our operation systems in Azure VMS so
what is an operation system well I'm
sure you already know this but the OS is
the program that manages all other
programs in a computer who most commonly
know operation systems or Windows Mac OS
and liux when you launch a virtual
machine you need to choose an image
which has a specific operation system
Microsoft Works closely with Partners to
ensure the images available are updated
and optimized for an Azure runtime you
can find most of these images in the
Azure Marketplace including Sue liex
Enterprise server Red Hat Enterprise
liex auntu server Debian free bestd
Azure Marketplace flat car container
Linux Rancher OS thei library for Azure
mesosphere DC OS on Azure Docker images
Cloud B Jenkins platform if the
available options do not meet your
requirements you can bring your own
Linux by creating a Linux virtual hard
disk note that in Azure only the fixed
vhd format is supported not the hyperv
virtual hard disk format so that's an
overview of the operating systems in
Azure
VMS the next topic we'll be covering are
the sizes of azure VMS Azure VMS come in
a variety of sizes that are also
optimized for specific use cases is
azure VMS are grouped into types such as
general purposes and compute optimized
and sizes such as B and dsv 3 also
called series or SKU family general
purpose balanced CPU to memory ratio
testing and development small to medium
databases and low to medium traffic web
servers skus B dsv 3 DV3 D4 D4 dsv 2 and
so on compute optimized High CPU to
memory ratio good for medium traffic web
servers work appliances batch processes
and app servers skus ffs fsv 2 memory
optimized High memory to CPU ratio best
for relational database servers medium
to large caches and in memory analytics
has K's S3 F3 east4 E4 F4 S4 and so on
storage optimized offers High disk
throughput and IO ideal for Big Data SQL
and osql databases data warehousing and
large transactional databases skus lsv2
GPU specialize VMS for heavy graphic
rendering and video editing model
training and inferencing with deep
learning available with single or
multiple gpus skus NC NC V2 ncv3 and
cast T4 V3 ND and so on high performance
compute features the fastest and most
powerful CPU virtual machines with
optional High throughput network
interfaces skus HB hbv2 HC H there are
previous series of virtual machines
sizes not shown here like basic a the
type of image May limit you to specific
VM sizes use Azure sorting and filtering
options to explore sizes based on
various parameters such as
cost Azure compute unit provides a way
of comparing compute performance across
Azure skus ACU is standardized on a
small VM aside the value of 100 all
other skus then represent approximately
how much faster that SK you can run a
standard Benchmark let's break down the
provided information information A1 a4u
family a CU vcpu 100 ACU stands for
Azure compute unit which is a measure of
the relative computational performance
of different Azure skus and this family
each virtual CPU is rated at 100 acus
vcpu core 1:1 this means for every
virtual CPU you allocate it corresponds
to one physical core D1 D14 SKU family
SCU vcpu ranges between 160 to 200 50
this indicates that VMS in this family
have a higher computational performance
per vcpu compared to the Asser vcpu core
1:1 similar to the ass series each
virtual CPU corresponds to one physical
core in summary knowing Azure VM sizes
helps pick the best option for your
needs ensuring efficiency and cost
Effectiveness the upcoming topic
explores hyperv focusing on the
distinctions between Generation 1 and
generation 2 hyperv is a hardware
virtualization product from Microsoft
enabling the creation and management of
virtual machines each VM functions as a
separate computer equipped with its own
operating system and software
applications in many ways hyperv mirrors
the functionalities of virtual box there
are two generations of hyper vvms
Generation 1 supports a wide range of
guest operating systems generation 2
primarily support 64-bit versions of
Windows alongside more recent versions
of litx and free bestd operating systems
Azure offers both Generation 1 and
generation 2 VMS aligning with hyperv
and structure but bearing distinct
characteristics key differences between
Azure gen 1 and Gen 2 gen one based on
bios architecture Gen 2 utilizes ufi
based boot architecture enhancing Boot
and installation times only Gen 2 VMS
employ secure boot ensuring the boot
loader is authenticated by a trustworthy
Source gen 2vm support a substantially
larger boot volume of up to 64 terab
hyper vvms are packaged as either vhd or
vhdx files consolidating their
structural components for efficient
management and deployment in conclusion
understanding hyperv Generations AIDS in
optimizing virtualization and ensuring
OS
compatibility the next topic we'll be
covering is SSH RDP and Bastion Azure
virtual machines offer multiple methods
to connect including SSH RDP and Bastion
let's dive into each secure shell is a
protocol to establish a secure
connection between a client and server
this is used to remotely connect to your
Azure VM via the terminal S sh operates
on Port 22 via TCP RSA key pairs are
commonly used to authorized access
remote desktop protocol is a proprietary
protocol developed by Microsoft which
provides a user with a graphical
interface to connect to another computer
over a network connection this is how
you can remotely connect to Windows
Server via virtual virtual desktop RDP
operates on Port 3389 utilizing both TCP
and UDP Bastion Azure Bastion is a
service you deploy that lets you connect
to a virtual machine using your browser
and the Azure portal it provides secure
and seamless RDP SSH connectivity to
your virtual machines directly from the
Azure portal over TLS a Bastion is a
hardened instance that is monitored
users connect to this VM which then
establishes a connection to the Target
instance sometimes known as jump so to
ensure op optimiz security and
connectivity it's important to
understand these methods we'll delve
deeper into each and subsequent
sections let's go into a bit more detail
with SSH secure shell or SSH is a
cryptographic network protocol commonly
employed to securely access and manage
servers remotely it is very common to
use SSH key pairs as a means to
authenticate to your VMS SSH key pairs
is when you generate out two keys a
private key this is the key that remains
confidential and should never be shared
or exposed it is stored securely on your
local system and is used to initiate a
connection to the VM a public key as the
name suggests this key can be shared
publicly it is added to the servers or
vm's authorized Keys list how does SSH
key authentication work when you attempt
to SSH into a server your system uses
the private key to send a cryptographic
proof the server which has the
corresponding public key verifies the
authenticity of the cryptographic proof
a if the proof is verified meaning the
keys have matched your authenticated and
granted access advantages of using SSH
key pairs security SSH Keys provide a
more secure method of authentication
than traditional passwords without the
correct private key unauthorized access
attempts are effectively thwarted
convenience once set up users can
connect without needing to remember and
input a password each time automation
automated scripts and services can use
key pairs to establish connections
without human intervention so that's a
more in-depth look into
SSH let's dive into the remote desktop
protocol commonly known as RDP RDP is a
protocol developed by Microsoft that
allows users to remotely connect to
Windows systems when you want to use RDP
to access your Windows Server you'll
first need to download the RDP file for
Windows 10 users the remote desktop
client is pre-installed so there's no
additional software to download however
if you're using Mac OS you can easily
get the Microsoft Remote Desktop app
from the Apple Store once you've got the
necessary tools simply open the
downloaded RDP file during this process
you'll be prompted to enter the username
and password that you set up during the
creation of your VM on the Azure portal
RDP uses encryption to secure
Communications ensuring confidentiality
it also supports features like audio
redirection clipboard sharing and
printer redirection for a seamless
remote experience in conclusion RDP
provides an efficient way to remotely
access Windows those
systems the next topic we'll be covering
is azure Bastion Azure Bastion serves as
a secure Bridge enabling you to connect
to your server via SSH or RDP without
exposing it to the public it will
provision a web-based interface for both
RDP and SSH eliminating the need for
external clients this can be especially
useful for devices like Google
Chromebooks which might not support
traditional RDP clients when setting up
azure you'll need to add a dedicated
submit to your virtual Network named
Azure basan submit this submit should
have at least a 27 size equating to 32
addresses if you have a Windows Server
which requires RDP and have a Bastion in
the same v-net you simply enter in your
user name and password as you normally
would if you have a Linux server you can
SSH with the Bastion you can use SSH
private key or password that you set
when you created your VM key benefits
single click access Rd p and SSH
sessions available directly through the
Azure portal secure session Azure
Bastion offers RDP SSH over TLS with
support for TLS 1.2 plus no public IP
needed RDP SSH connects via the vm's
private IP simplified NSG management no
need for nsgs on the Azure Bastion
subnet allows RDP SSH solely from Azure
Bastion managed service Azure Bastion is
a fully managed secure platform for RDP
SSH protection from scans VMS aren't
exposed to the internet preventing Port
scanning centralized hardening Bastion
at the vnet perimeter eliminates
individual VM hardening so that's an
overview of azure
Bastion let's take a look at a
comparison between Windows versus liux
servers Azure VMS offer the flexibility
to run both windows and liux based
servers Windows licensing to run Windows
you'll need a valid license if you don't
act activate it certain features may be
restricted Azure does offer a way to
leverage existing licenses through its
hybrid benefit program authentication
typically you set up a username and
password during the VM creation instance
size to smoothly operate Windows you
typically need a larger VM size starting
at least with a B2 due to its
comprehensive desktop environment
environment Windows provides a full
desktop environment complete with a
graphical user interface making it more
intuitive for those familiar with the
windows ecosystem l
licensing most Linux distributions are
open source and don't require any
licensing fees authentication Linux
offers flexible authentication you can
set up a username and password or more
commonly use SSH key pairs for a more
secure connection instance size Linux
servers especially those without a
graphical user interface have minimal
system requirements this means you can
run them on smaller VM sizes conserving
resources and cost environment
traditionally Linux systems operate with
a terminal Bas and environment although
there are distributions with graphical
interfaces overall your choice between
Windows and Linux will largely depend on
the specific needs of your project
familiarity with the operating system
licensing costs and desired system
resources the next topic will be
covering is update Management in Azure
update management allows you to manage
and install operating system updates and
patches for both windows and Linux
virtual machines that are deployed in
azure on premises or with other Cloud
providers when you launch an Azure VM
you can go to operations and turn on
guest plus host Updates this will
install the Microsoft monitoring agent
that will be used to monitor your
instances Azure automations is the
underlying service that is installed the
agent update management will perform a
scan for update compliance by default a
compliance scan is performed every 12
hours on Windows and every 3 hours on
Linux it can take between 30 minutes and
6 hours for the dashboard to display
updated dat data from managed computers
in Azure automation you can enable the
update management change tracking and
inventory and start or stop VMS during
off hours features for your servers and
virtual machines these features have a
dependency on a log analytics workspace
and therefore require linking the
workspace with an automation account so
Azure update management offers a
comprehensive solution for ensuring your
virtual machines are always up to date
with the latest patches and
updates oh right let's take a look at
Azure virtual desktop formerly known as
Windows Virtual desktop Azure virtual
desktop on Microsoft Azure is a desktop
and app virtualization service that runs
on the cloud Azure virtual desktop works
across devices like Windows Mac iOS
Android and LX with apps that you can
use to access remote desktops and apps
you can use most modern browsers to
access Azure virtual desktop hosted
experiences use Azure virtual desktop
for specific needs like when security is
a concern because all day data is saved
on the server and cannot be left on the
device of a user key features and
benefits enable secure and productive
remote work on any device Azure virtual
desktop provides full Windows 10 and
Windows Server desktop and application
virtualization on any personal device
seamless integration with Microsoft 365
apps for Enterprise and Microsoft teams
reduce cost of Licensing and
infrastructure use eligible windows or
Microsoft 365 licenses to access Windows
Virtual desk top and pay only for what
you use protect against outages to stay
productive help keep your team running
during outages by leveraging built-in
Azure site recovery and Azure backup
Technologies simplify it Management
Windows Virtual desktop manages the
virtual desktop infrastructure for you
so you can focus on users apps and Os
images instead of hardware and
maintenance Keep application and user
data secure easily apply the right
access controls to users and devices
with Azure active directory conditional
access ACC so that's an overview of
azure virtual
[Music]
desktop hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we're going to be launching
our own Bastion using Azure Bastion
services so there's two ways to set this
up we can go to bastions over here and
create a Bastion this way or we can
create one uh after we've created a
virtual machine I prefer the ladder so
let's go ahead and do that and launch
ourselves a new virtual machine and so
we can either use launch a Windows
server or a Linux server today I'm going
to be launching a Windows
server and uh what we'll do is go down
here I'll make a new group we'll call it
the
Enterprise and uh as we do that we'll
just name this uh
Enterprise D and we'll launch that in
Canada C or us or Central us that's fine
with me uh 2019 data center Gen 2 is
totally fine if you go here you're
trying to find it you go hit select and
we'll choose Gen 2 Data Center it is
expensive but uh we're not going to be
using this for very long uh for the
username I'm going to put uh data and
for the I'll just make it Azure user to
make our lives a bit easier and then
we'll put testing capital T 1 2 3 4 5 6
testing 1 2 3 4 5 6 and we will go down
below we're fine with the settings here
we're going to go next to dis we're
going to leave the dis to premium that's
fine we'll let it create a new network
that's totally
fine management is okay and we'll just
actually go hit review and
create and now we'll just hit create so
that it will go ahead and do that it'll
tell us that it's in
progress and we'll just wait a little
bit here I'll see you back in a
moment all right so our instance is
ready so let's go ahead and go to this
resource here and then on the left hand
side you'll have connect and so I'm
going to going to show you and you don't
it's not necessary for you to do uh this
step because you're going to I'm going
to show you how to connect VI the Bas in
but I'm going to go ahead and download
this file the RDP file and this will
only work if you're on windows by the
way well I guess it will work on Mac but
you'd have to install the um uh the uh
RDP uh service for that users with
Windows there and so here this is azure
user we're going to type in testing with
a capital T just double check that there
I'm going to log in make sure that this
works uh do we'll do that one more time
oh you know it's testing 1 2 3 4 5
six there we go we'll say
yes and we'll just make sure that we can
uh remote desktop into this just before
anything else and there we go so that's
all good to me I don't need to see
anymore we'll go over to Bastion we'll
say use Bastion and this is going to set
up a Bastion service in order to use
Bastion you need to have another um uh
address space uh defined for it it makes
it really easy to uh make it here so I'm
just going to go
10.0.1
do0
24 and we'll go ahead and hit
okay and so down below it's going to
choose an address
space um we have a security group um I'm
just going to put it for none I don't
think I want one on
that
and if we scroll on down here we have
the resource Group so we're going to put
it in the same Resource Group and we'll
go ahead and create
that so now before this they didn't have
this really nice wizard you used to have
to go and and create all those things
individually in your virtual network but
this is really nice it does take a bit
of time for this to provision so I'll
see you back here in a bit that took a
bit of time for that to create that
Bastion but it is ready to go and so now
that we have it we can go ahead and
utilize uh this connection here and so
right away it I think it's setting up
for RDP here so what we'll do is type in
Azure user uh and then capital T testing
1 2 3 4 5 6 we'll go ahead and hit
connect and so notice that I didn't have
to use an external application I could
just uh run it in right here it's all in
the web browser so that's pretty much
how uh the Bastion works I can't
remember the pricing on Bastion I think
it's a little bit of money so I don't
want to keep this uh laying around here
but this is great if you let's say
you're on a Chromebook which are
becoming really popular where you can't
install native applications uh or you're
just having issues because you're on
like Linux or something like that so
there you go that's all there is to it
we'll go ahead and clean this up and so
I'm just going to go here find the
resource Group and we'll go ahead and
delete I'm just making sure that
bastion's within there so it is
good and there we go
[Music]
so we just launched a virtual machine
for Linux now let's go ahead and launch
one for Windows so I'm going to go to
the top here and type in Virtual
machines we'll go to the first link I'm
going to hit add add virtual
machine and uh what we'll do is we'll
create a new group the last one I had
was called beor I'm going to call this
one
kardashia
and I'm going to name this uh machine
also named
kardashia and this time what we want to
do is is we want to move over to a
Windows Server I find the easiest one to
learn with is the Windows 10 Pro server
uh just because I find these ones a
little bit daunting so I'm going to go
Windows 10 Pro uh and then what we're
going to do is go choose a larger size
this is not going to work we cannot run
a Windows server on a B1 LS so we're
going to have to go a little bit larger
and uh we don't have to go too much
larger here but the idea here is that
there's going to be a a more expensive
spend here so we're not going to be
wanting to keep this running for long
but here we have the b2s that is the
appropriate size to run this anything
smaller I don't think is going to
work and we are going to put in a
password here so I'm just going to put
in
kardashia and we'll do
kardashia uh one
two3 put a capital on it I guess we'll
just do this
here and I'm just going to go back and
lowercase this
one and uh we're going to allow the
inbound Port of 3389 because that is
what RDP needs are going to confirm that
I have a Windows license I actually
don't but the thing is you can still
launch one for uh your test purposes
it'll it'll just complain saying you're
not activated uh so there are some
limitations but it's good enough for us
to uh learn okay and so now that that is
all great we'll go next to diss we're
going to go with pre or standard SSD
this time uh we are going to go ahead
and hit uh next and go to networking
it's going to create us a new v-net
which is a great idea we're going to let
it create a uh a network security group
on the Nick just like before we'll go
ahead and hit
next uh we'll leave all these options
alone this all seems fine to me uh and
we'll hit next review and
create
and we'll go ahead and create This
Server all right and so that's going to
go ahead and create it so I'll just see
you back here in a moment when that's uh
done deploying all right and so after a
short little while here it looks like
our Windows server is now deployed so
what we can do is go to that resource
and if you want to to see what it's
deployed it's the same stuff as always
you have your network interface card
your virtual Network NSG the IP address
but let's actually go to that resource
now and so let's see how we can gain
access to this virtual machine and so
what we can do is use RDP luckily I am
on a Windows machine and so um I already
have the rdb client uh that I can use so
all I got to do is download the rdb file
and then once we have that file I can
just double click it and I can open this
up if you're on a Mac uh you can
download uh the app in the app store and
so I'll go ahead and type in my password
so my username was
kardashia and then my password was
capital c a r d a SS I A1 23 we'll hit
okay and then it'll give us another
warning we'll say yes and now we are in
our virtual machine so there you go how
cool is that I'll give it a moment to
load up but this is a full uh Windows 10
Pro uh and as I said before you know we
don't actually have a license so if
you're afraid of spining up because you
think you're going to get charged a
license fee uh for Windows you do not
have to worry that's not going to happen
you have to do some manual intervention
uh for that to happen so we'll just wait
a little while here for this to load um
it is not we're not using the most
powerful machine so it does take a
little bit of time and so we just hit
accept
here and here we are so we are on uh we
have our nice Windows machine here
whoops I don't know if it has any games
let's go take a
look maybe we play M
sweeper
um no maybe maybe you have to download
in the store I'm not that familiar with
Windows machines but um so there you go
so we'll go ahead and close that and you
know if we were using the Bastion it's
the same process you saw how we used it
with SSH but if we had the Bastion and
it's so much work to set one up we
already did that before uh but all you
do is enter your credentials in on the
page just as we did and it and it's just
a lot easier that way uh so let's go
ahead and just tear down this machine
we're all done with it so I'm just going
to hit um uh
Delete and uh if we find that Resource
Group we should be able to easily delete
them all I find the easiest way is to go
up here go to all resources and then
there's the resource Group there and
then hit delete Resource Group and then
I'll type in the name of it which is
kardashia and I'll delete all those
resources but after that's done always
just take a double check uh on your all
resources Tab and just make sure that
those resources are gone because
sometimes they stick around but there
you go that's as simple as it was to
launch a Windows
[Music]
machine hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and let's take a look here at
virtual machines which I consider the
backbone of most cloud service providers
and Azure keeps it really simple by
calling it um virtual machine so we can
go up here and type in virtual machine
and make our way over here but right now
I don't have any options because I'm
using a tenant uh that doesn't have a
subscription applied to it so what I'm
going to do is go switch back to my
original tenant and this one has a sub
subscription applied to
it and so what I'll do is just click
back up here and now we'll just type in
Virtual
machines and I can now see uh I have
options of creating virtual machines so
let's go ahead and go create a Linux one
first and then we'll go ahead and create
a Windows one and then we'll see how we
can connect to it all right so first
we'll go to the top here and hit add
we'll click on virtual
machine and we're going to be presented
with a lot of options so we'll have to
choose a subscription and so there is
mine I want to probably create a new
Resource Group here I'm going to call
this one
beour and we'll name this uh vour again
and I'm going to launch this in Us East
I'll just set it to one availability
zone for the time being uh then here we
have what we can choose as an image I
can click on see all
images and choose from a variety of them
so if I didn't want to use Ubuntu I
could launch something else like Debian
or something like that uh but really I
just want to uh stick with uh Ubuntu cuz
I'm fine with that version with 18 uh
then here's what what really matters is
the size cuz that's going to affect our
cost so if we click on see all sizes we
have this uh Nifty um table where we can
sort the cost it's just loading in the
cost here it's Dynamic this is going to
be based on uh what your base
subscription is so if you're in Canada
you're going to see Canadian prices
you're in the US you're going to see us
prices etc etc and I care a lot about
cost here so I'm just going to sort this
by cost and here we have the B1 LS which
is very cost effective we have a ram of5
GB and some other options there so we'll
go ahead and select that there and we
have a couple options we can use SSH
public key or we can uh utilize a
password and so I think what we'll do is
use an SSH public key because that's uh
pretty much the standard there we're
going to name the username beig or if it
lets
us probably won't probably want some
additional options there oh it's okay oh
great and uh we'll go ahead and generate
a new key pair and I'm just going to
name that one
beour and uh we have some options here
for inbound rules uh so you could set to
none this is just setting up the uh NSG
for you uh but we're probably going to
want to have that Port open uh for SSH
because that's how we're going to make
our way back in here if we're running a
um like an apachi server we'd want to
have Port 80 open so we can go ahead and
do that
we'll take a look at now
diss so here we have an options between
premium um standard and standard hhd um
I just want this to be cost effective so
I'm just going to go with standard HDD
uh but generally you you want to have um
at least uh standard or premium SSD when
you're running uh real web development
workloads uh then there's encryption
here and so it's always turned on by
default which is great they also have
this option of double encryption with
the platform manage and customer manage
key uh we're just going to leave that
that as default enable alteris
compatibility that's not something we
need to do here CU we are not using
alter disk and here you can see that you
can attach multiple uh diss here um so I
can go and do that but that's not
something I need to do today and some
other Advanced options which we do not
care about we'll go over to networking
and so it's going to end up creating us
a new v-net for us and we'll create a
new subnet for us and assign it a IP
address uh it will also set up a NYX uh
network security group so the network
Security Group is not going to be
applied at the subnet level it's going
to be applied at the Nick which is
attached to the um dc2 there and so
we'll just leave it to basic we're going
to allow in inbound ports for Port 80 um
and 22 that was carried over uh from
earlier we can put this behind a load
balancer but I don't think we're going
to do that right now we'll go over to
management uh we have some additional
options here for monitoring uh this is
all okay here we can set it to auto
shutdown actually I'll leave that alone
loone you can also enable backups here
we'll go Advanced and now we have this
option here for custom data uh I covered
a section on cloud and nit and uh they
don't call this user data but most other
providers will call this user data so we
could provide a bash script or
additional information here if we wanted
to then down below uh there's some host
group options we're not going to worry
about that and proximity placement group
this is really important if you need to
have um instances nearby uh I think this
is pretty common with um what's it
called high capacity workloads H hfc I
can't remember the initialism right now
but we covered in the core content then
we can tag our resource here uh we'll
just leave that alone I don't care about
tagging too much but generally it's good
to tag in practice and then we will get
to review and create our server here
we'll go ahead and hit
create and then we'll have to download
our private key so we can utilize it
later and so that's downloaded there and
now we're just waiting for it to deploy
this and I'll see you back here in a
moment so we had to wait a little bit
there and finally um our deployment is
complete and we can go ahead and just
review all the things that it created so
notice that it created the virtual
machine it created a network interface a
Nick for us the NSG the network security
group the um virtual Network and also a
public IP address um when I do cleanup a
lot of things I always miss are these IP
addresses and I know that um azzure gave
me a warning that said hey you're about
to spend uh $700 yearly on IP addresses
because you weren't releasing them so
when we do the cleanup step I'll
definitely uh emphasize about deleting
those IP addresses and how to go about
that let's go take a look at the actual
resource
now so here we are and uh you can see we
have a lot of options the left hand side
such as the disk um so we can see the
disk options there and there's
additional Security Options let's go go
take a look at how we can go ahead and
connect to the server and so uh there's
different options here so we have RDP
SSH and Bastion since we are using a
Linux machine we're not going to be
using RDP that's really for
Windows um but the trick here is that um
I would need to have a client on my
computer to connect like um I think it's
called putty if you're on a Linux based
machine it's a lot easier uh and
certainly I have the uh Linux subsystem
installed so I could probably um connect
that
way but I figured let's just go ahead
and connect via Bastion because I think
this is a pretty darn cool feature so
let's go ahead and create ourselves a
Bastion and this will take a little bit
of time here but we'll go ahead here and
just set up subnet so to associate a
virtual Network to a Bastion it must
contain a subnet with the Azure Bastion
subnet so they actually have a special
subnet for it so what we'll do is we'll
just go back to our um our server here
uh which we called beour
and I think we can find the subnet
through here so on the left hand side if
we go to networking we probably could
find it that way um so I'm just looking
for that Security Group um in
there it should be um maybe it's not
there if it's not
there um well you know we could just go
over make our way over to subnets it's
not a big
deal cuz it's called beour it's pretty
darn easy to find to begin with and so
under subnet here what we need to do is
add a a special one here and just got to
remember how this works um so you need
to create a a subnet called Azure
Bastion subnet with a prefix of at least
27 so we'll go ahead and add a new
subnet and we'll call it
that uh we'll take out the space
there and the range is 10 0 1 0 Etc so
we'll just do it on two 0 do um
2.0
sl27 uh 102 is not
contained yeah it overlaps so we'll do
two do not contain the virtual Network
address space oh right so we have to add
the address space
first oops we'll just hit cancel
here that's okay we'll discard that
we'll make our way over to address space
and we'll go ahead and add
10.0 uh
2.04 that'll give was a pretty darn uh
large range
there and so now what we'll do is go
back to our
subnet and we'll go ahead and create
that
there and it said only needed 27 so
we'll just give it only 27 we don't need
to go bigger than we need and that
should be okay we'll go ahead and hit
save and it shouldn't take too long so
now that we have that we can go back
here and we'll give give this another go
here
here uh it's there so it shouldn't be
complaining maybe what we'll do is just
start from the uh the start here
again yeah there you go that the Azure
portal is like that a lot where you'll
have something set up and it has the Old
State of it and so you just have to
trust yourself that you know what you're
doing and you have to go back but if you
don't have a lot of confidence a lot of
times you'll get stuck and you'll think
okay I don't have it right but always
just try again and hit refresh um
because the Azure portal is very
inconsistent so we're just going to have
to wait for this to create this does
take uh a little while to create so I'll
see you back in a moment so after
waiting five minutes our Bastion is now
created and so what we can do is without
even using a putty client or having to
use Linux directly uh we can just uh
connect through via the Bastion uh so
here uh we'll see we have some options
here so we want to do SS H uh private
key from local
file okay and what we can do is go ahead
and select our beor key and then I'll
just scroll down here and hit
connect oh um and I think we made the
username
beour and we'll go ahead and connect
now and it's complaining about a popup
here so we'll go up here and
say always
allow and we'll try that
again
and then we'll say allow
again and so now that we're into our
server here let's go ahead and try to
install aachi and see if we can get at
least the default page running um so
this is using Ubuntu if my memory serves
me correctly should be app get install
Apachi
2 and we'll just hit Y for
continue and we'll just wait for this to
install doesn't take too darn
long
and after a short little wait there uh
it finally did install also if you
notice this little icon here we have a a
little clipboard here um I don't seem to
ever use that there so that's fine um
now when you install a Pochi we might
have to go ahead and start it up um so
let's just take a look to see if it
actually is in the running directory
here so we'll go to cdar www and so
that's where the default directory is
right um but we can just check to see if
uh it's running by doing a PS Ox I think
it's
httpd or we can say Apache here and so
it looks like it's already running so
that's pretty great for us and since
it's running on Port 80 and we've opened
up Port 80 we should probably be able to
access that um here so let's go back to
our actual virtual machine so we'll go
to Virtual
machines and uh we have that virtual
machine running I'm just going to click
into it because I just want to find out
it's public IP
address so here it is there and for
lucky this will just work just a copy to
clipboard button right
there and look at that we have the
default page Isn't that cool um so
that's all there really is to it and I
could even update this page you don't
have to do it but I'm just going to
update it for fun actually I probably
have to restart the server so maybe I
won't do that um but yeah so we
connected through the basion so that was
pretty darn easy we probably could have
also used um the cloud shell to connect
um
but maybe we should we could give that a
go as
well since we're all done here let's go
ahead and do some cleanup the first
thing I want to do is uh the easiest way
is actually to go to all resources here
at the left hand side and this really
gives you an idea of everything that's
running in your account so I actually
have other stuff in here uh that's not
relevant um but the idea is that all of
our stuff is running within a resource
Group um and so I'm just taking a look
there I'm not seeing this is all
resources here um see if we see Resource
Group here yeah they're all there right
there so I can go ahead and click that
and so everything more or less should be
self-contained within here see all that
stuff um you can even see the v-net is
part of it as well and so if I go ahead
and delete this Resource Group it should
delete all this stuff so I'm just going
to type beour to
confirm and we'll go ahead and
delete and that should do a good job of
cleaning up all those
files I'm not sure if it will delete the
IP it should right there but if it
doesn't what I recommend is after
everything is deleted just go back here
to all resources and just double check
to make sure they all vanish because
when this is done they're all going to
uh start to vanish from this list and if
there's anything remaining you'll know
because it's still here right so just be
careful about that that's all I want you
to know um and so that's the Linux part
and so let's go ahead and actually now
set up a Windows
Server hey hey this is Andrew Brown from
exampro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure app service Azure app
service is an HTTP based platform for
web apps re estf apis and mobile bin
Services you can choose your programming
language in Python Java or any other
language and run it in either a Windows
or Linux environment it is a platform as
service so it's the Heroku equivalent
for Azure Azure app service takes care
of the following underlying
infrastructure OS and language security
patches load balancing Auto scaling and
infrastructure management azzure app
service makes it easy to implement
common Integrations and features such as
Azure Dev Ops for deployments GitHub and
dockerhub package Management Systems
easy to set up staging environments
custom domains and attaching TLS or SSL
certificates you pay based on an Azure
app service plan shared tier includes
free and shared options litex isn't
supported here dedicated tier includes
basic standard premium premium 2 Premium
3 and there's isolated tier as your app
service is versatile you can deploy
single or multi-container Docker
applications when you create your app
you have to choose a unique name since
it becomes a fully qualified domain
overall Azure app service simplifies
your web hosting needs ensuring you can
focus on coding and let Azure do the
heavy
lifting let's delve into runtimes in
Azure app service so what is a runtime
environment a runtime environment refers
to the softt sof Ware and settings
needed for a program to run in a defined
way at runtime a runtime generally means
what programming language and libraries
and framework you are using a runtime
for Azure app services will be a
predefined container that has your
programming language and commonly used
library for that language installed with
Azure app Services you're presented with
a range of runtimes to choose from
including net. netcore javar Ruby
node.js PHP and python moreover Azure
app Services generally supports multiple
versions of each prr programming
language for example for Ruby you might
find versions 2.6 and
2.7 it's worth noting that cloud
providers including Azure May phase out
support for older versions over time
this not only ensures that they're
offering the latest and most efficient
tools but also promotes better security
practices among users pushing them to
keep up with the latest patches so
that's an overview of runtimes and Azure
app
service the next thing we'll be covering
are custom containers in Azure app
service Azure app service gives you the
flexibility to use custom containers for
both windows and Linux the primary
reason you might opt for a custom
container is to use a distinct runtime
that isn't natively supported or to
incorporate specific packages and
software here's a straightforward
process to get started with custom
containers and Azure app service design
your container Begin by creating a
Docker container tailored to your needs
on your local Machine push to Azure once
your container is ready push it to the
Azure container registry this
centralized repository ensures that your
container is easily accessible within
Azure deploy and go live finally deploy
your container image directly to the
Azure app service once deployed Azure
takes care of scaling maintenance and
updates another advantage of custom
containers in Azure app services that
they offer more granular control over
your environment you can fine-tune
performance security and other aspects
of your application environment to suit
your
needs the next topic will be covering
our deployment slots in Azure app
service deployment slots allow you to
create different environments of your
web application Associated to a
different host name this is useful when
you require a testing staging or QA
environment alongside your production
setup deployment slots let you swiftly
replicate your production setting for
various purposes ensuring consistent
testing environments you could also swap
environments this is useful for
executing blue green deployments by
using swap you can promote your stage in
environment to production with thesee
you can promote our staging to
production by swapping if something goes
wrong you could swap them back this
capability ensures minimal downtime and
enhances the user experience since you
can introduce changes in a controlled
manner rolling them back if necessary in
addition Azure ensures that when
swapping the instances are warmed up
before traffic is routed resulting in
zero downtime so that's a quick overview
of deployment
slots the next topic we'll be covering
is the app service environment in Azure
app Service app service environment is
an Azure app service feature that
provides a fully isolated and dedicated
environment for securely running app
service apps at high scale this allow
you to host windows and liux web apps
Docker containers mobile apps and
functions app service environments are
appropriate for application workloads
that require very high-scale isolation
and secure network access and high
memory utilization customers can create
multiple ases within a a single Azure
region or across multiple Azure regions
making ases ideal for horizontally
scaling stateless application tiers in
support of high requests per second
workloads ases comes with its own
pricing tier called the isolated tier
ases can be used to configure security
architecture apps running on ases can
have their access gated by Upstream
devices such as web application
firewalls app service environments can
be deployed into availability zones
using Zone pinning there are two
deployment types for an app service
environment external ass and
ilbs external ass exposes the ass hosted
apps on an internet accessible IP
address if the v-net is connected to
your on premises Network apps and your
ass also have access to resources there
without additional configuration because
the ass is within the v-net it can also
access resources within the v-net
without any additional
configuration ilbs exposes the ass
hosted apps on an IP address inside your
v-net the internal in point is an
internal load balancer so that's an
overview of app service environment and
Azure app
service the next thing we'll be going
over is deployment in Azure app service
so what is deployment well it's the
action of pushing changes or updates
from a local environment or repository
into a remote environment Azure app
Services provides many ways to deploy
your applications including run from
package deploy zip or War deploy via FTP
deploy via Cloud sync such as Dropbox or
one drive deploy continuously with
GitHub bitbucket and Azure repos which
using kudu and Azure pipelines deploy
using a custom container CI CD pipeline
deploy from local git deploy using
GitHub actions deploy using GitHub
actions containers and deploy with
template run from a package is when the
files in the package are not copied to
the WW root directory instead the zip
package itself gets mounted directly as
the re only ww rout directory all other
deployment methods in app service have
deployed to the following directory for
Windows Deon we use back slashes home
site ww root for Linux we use forward
sles home site ww rout since the same
directory is used by your app at runtime
it's possible for deployment to fail
because of file lock conflicts and for
the app to behave unpredictably because
some of the files are not yet
updated zip and War file deployment uses
the same kuduo service that powers
continuous integration based deployments
kudu is the engine behind get
deployments in Azure app service it's an
open source project that can also R
outside of azure kudu supports the
following functionality for zip file
deployment deletion of files left over
from a previous deployment option to
turn on the default build process which
includes package restore deployment
customization including running
deployment scripts deployment logs and a
file size limit of 248 megabytes you can
deploy using Azure CLI Azure API via
rest and Azure
portal you can use file transfer
protocol to upload files you will need
your own FTP client you just drag and
upload your files go to the deployment
Center get the FTP credentials for your
FTP client you can use dropbox or one
drive to deploy using a Cloud sync
Dropbox is a third-party cloud storage
service one drive is Microsoft's cloud
storage service you go to deployment
Center configure for Dropbox or one
drive when you turn on sync it will
create a folder in your Dropbox Cloud
Drive one drive apps as your web apps
drop box apps Azure this will sync with
your home site ww root so you just
update files in that folder in summary
Azure app service offers a range of
deployment methods ensuring flexibility
and ease for
developers the next topic we'll be
covering is autoscale and Azure app
service autoscaling is the process of
adjusting a server infrastructure
capability to fulfill incoming requests
from your web application it usually
takes seconds for the changes to take
effect and can be done automatically
according to preconfigured metrics it
does not need any new deployment or
coding changes scaling options in Azure
app service horizontal scaling this
involves adding or removing servers from
your infrastructure for example during
hight traffic periods you might scale up
from 1 to three virtual machines when
demand decreases you can reduce the C to
minimize cost vertical scaling this
suggest the resources of an existing
server such as CPU memory or storage for
example if you find that your app
application is processing a large amount
of data and needs more storage for logs
you might opt to increase the storage
capacity of your existing server overall
Azure app service autoscaling
dynamically adjusts resources to meet
real time application
demands the next thing we'll be covering
is the Azure app service plan Azure app
service plan determines the region of
the physical server where your web
application will be hosted and defines
the amount of storage RAM and CPU your
application will will use it offers
several pricing tiers shareed tiers
there are two shared tiers free and
shared free tier provides this tier
offers 1 GB of disk space supports up to
10 apps on a single shared instance
provides no availability SLA and allows
each app a compute quoto 60 minutes per
day shared tier provides hosting
multiple apps up to 100 on a single
shared instance no availability s SLA is
offered and each app gets a compute
quote of 240 minutes per day it's worth
noting that litx based instances are
supported in this
tier dedicated tiers basic standard
premium premium 2 Premium 3 Bic offers
more disk space unlimited apps three
levels in this tier that offer varying
amounts of compute power memory and disk
storage standard allows scaling out to
three dedicated instances guarantees
99.95% availability and also has three
levels with varying resources premium
provides the ability to scale up to 10
dedicated instances and ensures
99.95% availability and it includes
multiple Hardware level
options isolated tier dedicated Azure
virtual Network full Network and compute
isolation scale out to 100 instances and
availability SLA of
99.95% so the Azure app service plan
lets you tailor your hosting environment
and budget to fit your application
needs the next topic will be going over
is enabling diagnostic logging in azzure
app service Azure provides built-in
Diagnostics to assist with debugging an
app Service app Diagnostics logging is
an important part of any web
application's operation it allows you to
troubleshoot exceptions not exception
errors alerts and warnings as well as
track and improve the user experience
with Azure Diagnostics logging you may
log application events generated by your
application web server logging with a
raw version of requests made to your app
only available for for the windows
platform detailed error Pages saving
copies of the error Pages presented to
your user only available for the windows
platform failed request tracing with
detailed information regarding failed
requests deployment logging logging
detailed information about the
deployment process in order to
troubleshoot when a deployment fails to
enable application logging for Windows
apps in the Azure portal navigate to
your app and select app service logs
select on for either application logging
or application logging or both the file
system option is for temporary debugging
purposes and turns itself off in 12
hours The Blob option is for long-term
logging and needs a blob storage
container to write logs to you can also
set the level of details included in the
log as shown in the table below disabled
this level doesn't capture any logs
error at this level only error and
critical logs are captured warning this
level captures logs that are warning
error and critical information this
level encompasses a broader range of
logs capturing info warning error and
critical categories verbose this is the
most detailed level capturing all
categories Trace debug info warning
error and critical in essence As you
move from disabled to verbose the range
of logs captured increases with verbose
capturing the most comprehensive set of
logs enable application logging for
Linux container in app service log set
the application logging option to file
system in Quota specify the dis quota
for the application logs in retention
period set the number of days the log
should be retained when finished select
save it so asure app Services diagnostic
logging is essential for optimizing
troubleshooting and monitoring your
application let's take a look at
configuring Azure web app settings Azure
web app settings can be configured
through the Azure portal or the Azure
CLI the Azure portal also offers a bulk
editing option the main settings that
may be configured for your Azure web app
are the following t SL SL SSL settings
to have a secure and encrypted
Communication channel API settings such
as technology stacker platform Settings
app settings you can override your
configuration stored on the web config
connection strings in order to do not
have it written on the web config
default documents displays default web
pages when accessing the root of your
website URL path mappings configure
settings according to the user OS
overall Azure web app settings offer a
simplified way to optimize and here your
Azure web
[Music]
application hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam Pro and we are going to be
learning about Azure app services in
this follow along uh and it's a service
that's supposed to make it easy for you
to deploy web applications I say
supposed to because it really depends on
your stack Azure has more synergies with
other stacks and others so like if
you're like me and you like Ruby on
Rails you're going to find a lot of
friction with rails and Linux but if
you're using something like Windows
servers or python orn net you're going
to have a much easier time still really
great service just wish they'd make it a
bit more broad there but let's hop into
it so before we can go use that service
let's make sure that it's activated and
so we'll go over here and we'll go to as
your subscription and then down below
we're going to go to Resource provider
now you think what you could do is just
type in app Services uh and you'd be
wrong because the the service is under a
particular provider so if you want to
figure out what provider it is we can go
um Azure resource
providers and they have a page on
documentation here that lists them all
so if I search for Azure app
Services it's under web and domain
registration so we're going to make sure
this is registered if we're using a
custom domain which we are not today we
need this one activated so going back
here I will type in web and you can see
it's registered so if yours is not
registered go ahead and hit that I
believe this by default is generally
registered with new Azure accounts so I
don't think that is an issue for you but
we'll go back up here close these
additional tabs and we will type in
Azure app
services and we will look for that
service so there it is and we'll go
ahead and hit
add um and so I'm going to give it a new
name I just made it a moment ago but I'm
going to try again and try to use the
same name so we're going to call this
Voyager Great and then I'm going to go
ahead and name this Voyager and I
already know that that is taken so I'm
going to type in Delta
Flyer and these are fully qualified
domain so they are unique with Azure app
Services you can run a Docker container
we're doing code this time around and
what I like to use is Ruby um but again
you know if I want to use the cicd I'm
not going to be able to use the
deployment center with Ruby so that is
not possible um and so we're going to go
with python and run either a flask or a
Django app I haven't decided yet I am in
Canada so let's go to Canada east and uh
down below here we have the plans
generally the plans will tell you the
cost underneath look you'll notice that
it's loading but I just want to show you
that there are some discrepancies in
terms of pricing so if I was to go to
Azure app Services
pricing and we were to pull this up here
we can kind of see the pricing
here okay and if we scroll on down right
now we're looking at a premium V2 uh and
oh no I don't need help I'm okay you'll
notice that it's 20 cents per hour so if
I go here and do that times 730 because
there's 730 hours in the year that's
$146 I believe this is showing me in USD
dollars yeah and in here it's showing
me03 Canadian which is lower um so it
could be that because I'm running in a
Canada east region it's the price is
different but you could imagine that if
I had this at this cost at uh what did
we say here um at 146
USD to CAD I'd actually be paying
$182 so you got to watch out for that
kind of stuff but I'm pretty sure this
is what the cost is so just be aware
that if you look stuff up in here it's
not necessarily reflective so you got to
do a little bit more work to figure that
out uh if we wanted to go here uh we
cannot choose the free tier when we're
using Linux if we're using Windows I
believe we can use it we're working with
Linux today so that's just how it's
going to be um for the B1 this is
totally fine but we want to utilize
deployment slots deployment slots is an
advanced feature of uh the production
version and that's the only way we're
going to be able to use it here this is
20 cents per hour again so I don't want
to be doing this for too long but I
think what we'll do is before we do that
we can just do an upgrade to devb to
prod so we can experience that I'm going
to go and just choose B1 okay so we go
next um we do not need any application
insights for the time being and it will
not let us so it's okay we'll go next
review and
create and we'll go ahead and create
this resource here and I will see you
back when this is done so um our
resources Now set up we'll go to
Resource and now that we're in here
you'll notice if we hit browse we're not
going to see anything because we do not
have anything deployed which makes sense
right uh so we're going to actually have
to go ahead and deploy something so we
are going to make our way over to the
deployment
Center and uh it's just going to tell us
that we have yet to configure anything
and that's totally fine we're going to
go to
settings it'll give it a moment and so
the thing is is that we're going to need
something to deploy um I did not create
an app but the great thing uh is in the
Azure documentation they have a bunch of
quick starts here all right and
apparently they have one for Ruby as
well but today we are looking at python
uh and so they actually have an example
repository for us here which is
github.com asure samples python docs
hello world and I mean I could go make a
repo for you but we might as well just
use the one that is already provided to
us so I'm just going to pull this up to
show you what's in it it's a very very
simple application even if you don't
know anything about building web apps
I'm going to walk you through really
easily here okay so we're going to open
up app.py so we are using flask if
you've never heard of flask it is a very
minimal python framework for creating
web apps uh very uninspiring uh homepage
here but it gets the job done it's going
to create a default route for us which
uh we have there we're going to call
hello here and we're going to have hello
world so that's all that's going on here
very very simple and we have a
requirements this is our package manager
I don't know why python uses dxt files
is very outdated to me but that's what
they use and here we have
flask all right so we're going to use
that repo it's a public repo so it
should be very easy for us to connect so
we'll drop down go to GitHub
and uh the next thing we need to do is
authorize GitHub all right so I ran into
a bit of trouble there because I could
not uh authenticate my uh GitHub account
but you know what I just made another
GitHub account so that made it a lot
easier I'm going to go ahead here hit
GitHub and we're going to try to
authorize it and so now I'm logged into
this new one called exampro Dev and
we'll go ahead and authorize this
application and we're now in good shape
this repository doesn't have anything in
it so um if I want to clone something I
guess I'll probably have to Fork that
repo so we'll give it a moment to
authorize and while that's going I think
that's what I'm going to do I'm going to
go and uh Fork the example repo if I can
find the link again here uh
myself uh I
believe it
is that's still authorizing over there
I'm still looking for it so it was like
examples or something samples or examp
examples all right so I found a way
around the problem I just made a new uh
GitHub account so that's all I had to do
um and I just won't be using my primary
account until I get my phone back but um
so what we'll do is go hit connect I'll
hit
authorize and it didn't prompt me
because it already connected to this new
one called exam prodev you might have to
put your credentials in here and it's
going to ask me to select some things
it's a new account so there are no
organizations there are no repositories
there are no branches totally brand new
so what I'm going to need to do is get a
repo in there so we'll just go ahead and
Fork the Azure samples one so that is
azure samples
python docs hello
world and if I type that right we're in
good shape I'm going to go ahead and
Fork this
repository I'll say got it and then I'll
move this off screen here this is now
cloned you should see it cloned here and
we'll go back here and this probably
isn't live so there's no refresh button
here so we'll have to hit discard and we
will give this another go here and we
will select our organization which is
our name there is the
repository uh should be main branch this
is kind of outdated I'm sorry but it's
called Master that's what it is not my
fault that's azure's fault okay um and I
think that's it I don't know if we need
a workflow configuration file I don't
think
so going to double check here no I don't
think so and uh what we'll do is we'll
just go ahead and save
that and so now we are set up for
[Music]
deployment all right so now that that's
all hooked up if we were to go to browse
we're actually still seeing the default
page a deployment hasn't been triggered
just yet yet uh so the way it works is
it's using GitHub action so if we click
into our I'm going to call it main
branch I know they got the wrong name
but uh we're going to click into our
GitHub workflows and then below here we
can see we have a yaml file uh and this
is for GitHub actions integration here
and so what it's doing is it's
specifying the branch uh what how it's
going to uh build it's going to run onto
buntu latest the steps it's going to do
it's going to check it out it's going to
set up the python version it's going to
build it it's going to do that stuff and
so in order for this to um take action
we'd actually have to go ahead and make
some kind of manual change which we have
yet to do so okay so what we'll do is
we'll go back to our main
here and uh it should be as simple as uh
just changing something here so it's not
I'm not sure how it's supposed to know
that it's supposed to be doing the hello
we oh I guess yeah sorry so this means
it's going to Route over to here um so
I'm just going to make any kind of
change here doesn't matter what it is
just one space we'll go ahead and give
it a
commit and um if I go back to my latest
commits we should see that I made that
change there it is we'll go back over
here and this should be
deploying um so if we go over to logs
here you can see one's in progress right
now okay and so that's what we're
waiting we're just going to see that
finish there we could probably open the
logs and get some more information there
and so it just brings you back over to
GitHub actions and say here's GitHub
actions and it's performing the stuff
here so we're just going to give it time
here and I'll see you back in a moment
so we didn't have to wait too long it
only took 1 minute and 29 seconds if we
go back over here um we might need to do
a refresh and so we can see this is
reflected over here and so if we go back
to it doesn't really matter if we go to
settings or logs here but I'm going to
hit browse and see if my page is
deployed it still is not so we do have a
small little problem here and it's
really going to just have to do with how
the app is served so that's what we need
to figure out next all right so our app
is not currently working and uh there's
a few approaches we can take and the
thing I can think right away is we
should go and SSH into that instance if
you scroll on down here from developer
tools you can go to SSH and click this
button and that's going to SSH you right
into that machine right away you can
also uh access SSH via the um CLI
command so I believe it's
like it's like a web
app
um SSH it'll do the exact same thing you
do that from the cloud shell but that's
not what we're doing today if I give
this an LS in here and we're in Linux we
can see we have our app here and uh what
I would do is I would see what's running
so I I would do a puma uh or sorry not
Puma PS Ox grep uh Python and you can
notice that we have a g unicorn that's
running so that is where our python
instances are running so you're not
looking for flas you're looking for
python here and and if we wanted to make
sure that was working we just type in
curl Local
Host um and so that is going to return
up Port 80 so that tells me that because
like curl just means like let's go look
at that page um it should return some
HTML like print out the HTML to us so
that means the app is not running um so
what you could do is run flask run and
it's going to start
on Port
5000 right so what I can
do
is I can go up uh back to my deployment
Center
here and I'm going to go get that link
here I just ignore the fact that it's
working uh it's it's not working right
now I know for certain it's not um but
if we do 5,000 that won't resolve
because Port 5,000 isn't open so we
can't really just uh put 5,000 in there
and the default server here would be
5,000 so if I stop this and I specify
Port
80 right
then this will start up the app on Port
80 and so now when you go
here okay it will work uh this is not a
great way because of course as soon as
you kill it here uh technically the S
should stop running um and so you'll run
into that step uh so what we need to do
is provide a configuration to gunicorn
which is a python thing again it's not
so important that you know how like what
these things are but the idea is that
you understand as administrator you want
to make sure you have an app that runs
after you do a deploy so in this
particular one we need a startup. txt uh
and interestingly enough there is a
example code by the same author of the
other one we were looking at here I
believe it's the same
person or it might not be but uh they
have a startup txt right and so in here
you can see that it binds on Port 0000
it starts up for workers starts up the
app all right um and so that's something
that we can go ahead and do so uh what I
will do is I will go back to my GitHub
repository
that we have
here and I can just go ahead and add a
new file so I'm going to say
um add a file create a new file here
we'll call it startup.
txt I'm going to copy this command here
and paste it in there so gunicorn will
bind the workers and startup on the app
um startup app is being ran by uh
something here so if I go back here I I
think they have a startup High here and
that's all that it is doing um I think I
want
to I could do it this way I suppose let
me just see here there's is a slightly
different I so they actually have like a
full app going on
here and I just want a very simple flask
app so I think what I can
do is put flask run
here Port
and that should start up the app there
I'm going to go ahead and commit that
file okay and as soon as I commit that
if I go back to my actions it created
that startup file there so it should
trigger a
build it's queued
up um and I'll just put this tab up here
so we'll be back here in two seconds and
if I give this a nice refresh yeah you
can see it deploys in progress so uh
this doesn't take too long we'll just
wait close that there we'll just wait a
few minutes we click logs it just opens
it back up here and we'll see how that
goes all right so uh your deploy may
have finished there but the thing is is
that we're not going to really know if
uh a change has taken effect unless we
actually go ahead and update our code so
what I want you to do is go to your code
tab go to your app.py we'll hit edit and
I'm going to go ahead and change this to
Vulcan and then we'll scroll on down hit
commit changes and we'll make our way
back over to our deployment Center and
we'll give it a refresh here and we're
just going to wait until this one is
complete and we will double check to
make sure that that is changed if it is
not we will take action to fix that okay
all right so we just waited a little
while there for that deploy to happen
and if we go to our website here it is
taking effect so that's all we had to do
to get it working so that's pretty good
um so that is uh
deployment so let's talk about
deployment slots in order to utilize
this feature we're going to actually
have to upgrade our account because we
cannot utilize them at this uh the basic
plan here we got to go to standard or
premium so let's go ahead and give that
an
upgrade uh so here's the B1 we're going
to go to production here um and I
think yeah we're going to have to choose
this one here uh very expensive so the
thing is we're going to just upgrade it
temporarily unless there's more options
down below that are
cheaper yeah these are the standard
tiers let's go with this one here
because it's only $880 again we're not
going to be doing this for long but I
want to show you how to do staging slots
and auto scaling okay so we'll go ahead
and apply that
there and now it says that it's applied
so if I go back to our app here and we
click on deployment slots sometimes it
doesn't show up right away if it doesn't
that's not a big deal you just wait a
bit but today it's super fast so we're
going to go ahead and add a new slot
we're going to call it uh staging we're
going to deploy from our production
Branch here and I'm going to go ahead
and create that
there and we'll just wait until that's
done
okay great so we waited a little bit
there and uh our slot is created so I'm
going to just hit close there and so now
let's go take a look and see if we can
actually see the application here so I
just clicked into it I click browse and
we're getting the default page so
nothing is actually really deployed to
it uh so how are we going to do that
that's the the main question here um so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make my way over to the deployment
Center and you can see that it's not
configured for the slot so we are going
to have to set it up all over again even
though it copied over configuration
settings it didn't copy over the code so
we go to GitHub we'll choose our
organization again I'm going to choose
the repository we're going to choose
that main branch again there we're going
to let it add a workflow and notice that
this time it's going to call it staging
do yaml so there'll be separate workflow
that gets created we're going to go
ahead and save that
there and what we can do is again click
onto our Branch name there and if we
click into our workflows we'll not now
notice that we have a staging example
it's the same thing um but it should be
able to now deploy so the whole purpose
of um these deployment branches is that
it helps us uh we can deploy different
versions of our apps but also um it's
just a place where we can uh uh view
things before we actually roll them out
so we want to make sure 100% that they
are working correctly um I don't think
this will automatically push out let me
just go to my actions to see if this is
deploying notice that we have two
workflows now we have staging here uh
and yeah it looks like it's going to
deploy here so we'll just wait a little
bit um but maybe what we can do is try
to have a slightly different version uh
for each one here okay but we'll just
let that finish and I'll see you back in
a moment
all right so our deploy finished there
so now if we go back to our website here
we go browse we should see that
application it says hello Vulcan and if
we go and take out this we still have
hello Vulcan so how can we have a a
variant of this so that we can push out
to that so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go back to my application here
I'm going to go to code and I'm just
going to make a minor change um I don't
say also is that spelled right
startup that does look correct to me um
so maybe I'll go ahead and adjust that
file but it doesn't seem to be affecting
anything which is I'm a bit surprised
there so what I'll do is I'm going to go
and edit that file and give it the
proper name can I rename this file yes I
can so we'll call that startup
file I thought we need that for
deployment I guess it just works without
it which is nice uh if we go back here
I'm going to go and I actually just want
to edit my um app here again and I'm
going to go and edit this and we'll say
um hello
Andor or hello andorians
maybe and so if I go back to my actions
the question what is it deploying is it
going to deploy the production or the
staging and it looks like it's going to
do
both looks like it's doing both here but
one way we could tell is we can go to
our logs here and we can see that um so
we did two deploys so there's one change
here uh if we go back to our main
application and our deployment Center
here and we go over to our
logs you can see that they're both
deploying so it doesn't seem like it's a
great thing that that's how it works so
the question is is then how would we um
facilitate that deploy right how could
we do that I suppose what we could do is
just make a separate staging Branch um
so if I go over to code
here um I don't think we can just make
branches through here so what I'm going
to have to do is go ahead and oh I can
create a branch right here so we'll just
type in staging and we'll go create
ourselves a new
branch and now we are in this branch and
what I'm going to do is go ahead and
modify this and we're just going to call
this
um hello
Klingons okay we'll go ahead and update
that and so this should be a separate
Branch so you think what we could do is
go in and just change our settings so
that it deploys from that one uh we'll
go back to our deployment slots we'll
click into staging
here and we need to change our
configuration settings um I think we
could just do it
[Music]
from here hold on here I I could have
swore it specified the branch if we go
to deployment Center here I think it's
set up on that other branch there I
think we just adjust it here so yeah I
think we could just um adjust these
settings um we can't discard them but
maybe what we can do is just go in and
modify that file so we will go into our
code
here and uh we will go ahead and click
into here go into staging and we'll just
change what the branch is
called so we'll just say staging
and we'll hit start commit and we will
save
that and we'll see if it actually
reflects those changes there so we will
go here and hit
refresh we'll see if it picks up staging
now if we go to
settings it's not picking it up so um
I'm not sure I don't think perform a
redeploy operation we don't want to
redeploy so maybe what we'll do is just
we'll have to do a disconnect here
because it's collect it has the wrong
one here so save workflow file
um okay we'll just go ahead and delete
it it's not a big deal we'll just have
to make a new one
here we'll go to GitHub we'll choose our
uh organization again or repository our
staging Branch this time around we'll
let it add one see it says we can use an
available workflow so we could have kept
it there and added it there um and we'll
go ahead and save that so now we'll have
two separate branches there and we'll
give that some time to deploy because
that will now trigger a deploy off the
bat and so I'll see you back here in a
moment all right so after a short little
wait here it looks like our app is done
deploying so we'll go over here we'll
make sure that this is our staging
server is good and we want to see that
our production is different perfect so
we now have a way to deploy to each one
but imagine that we want to swap our
traffic so we're happy with our staging
server we want to roll that out to
production and that's where we can uh do
some SWAT and so what we'll do is click
the swap button and we're going to say
the source is the staging and this is
our Target production and we're going to
perform that swap uh right now we can't
do a preview because we don't have a
particular setting set that's okay and
it's kind of showing if there are any
changes so set of configuration changes
we don't have any so that's totally fine
as well we'll go ahead and hit
Swap and that's going to swap those two
I believe it's has zero downtime so we
will be in good shape if that happens
there
and we'll just give it a moment to do
that great so after a short little wait
there the swap is complete and so uh if
we remember
clearly this was our production right
and so if I was to hit refresh it so now
say Klingons and if I go to my staging
server it should be the other way around
right good so now imagine that I want to
just split the traffic uh that's
something else that we can do um so
notice over here we have these percent
is here um not sure why it won't let me
change
those so maybe I'll have to look into
that so I'll be back so I'm not sure why
it's not showing us that traffic slot
there but what I'm going to do is just
maybe try to trigger deploy back into
our staging and maybe that's what it
wants to see um so what I'm going to do
is go back to my code here we'll be in
our staging Branch here I'm going to go
ahead and uh edit this file here and we
will just change this to
borans
and we will hit
update and we will let that go ahead and
deploy so we go to actions here we can
see that it is
deploying um and we'll just give it some
time okay so see you back here in a bit
I mean the other reason could be that
we're just not at the main level hold on
here uh if we go back here to deployment
slots you know what I think it's just
because I was clicked into here and then
I was clicked into deployment slots that
they're both grayed out yeah it is so we
can actually do it that top level there
doesn't hurt to do another deploy though
so um we'll just wait for I'll wait for
that deploy to finish and then we'll
come here and uh adjust that there okay
all right so let's take a look at uh
doing some traffic switching here so
right now if we were to go to our
production we have Klingons and if we
were to uh go to our
staging we have Boran so imagine that we
only want 50% of that traffic to show up
so what we can do is put in
50% and what I'm going to do is um do I
hit enter here or oh sorry save up here
there we go um and so what's going to
happen is this should take effect I
think right away yep uh and so now we
have 50 50 50% chance of getting
something else here um so I'm just going
to keep on hitting enter here if that
doesn't work we can try an incognito tab
and there we go we got the opposite
there and so this is serving up staging
right
uh and this is serving up production but
they're both on the production URL so
that's a way you can split the traffic
so uh that's pretty much all I wanted to
show you for deployment slots let's now
talk about
scaling hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure container instances Azure
container instances allow you to launch
containers without the need to worry
about configuring or managing the
underlying virtual machine aure
container instances is design designed
for isolated containers they are
tailored for simple applications task
Automation and tasks like build jobs
containers can be provisioned within
seconds whereas VMS can take several
minutes containers are built per second
whereas VMS are built per hour providing
potential cost savings containers have
granular and custom sizing of vcpus
memory and gpus whereas VM sizes are
predetermined ACI can deploy both
windows and Linux containers you can
persist storage with Azure files for
your ACI containers
once deployed AIS are accessible via a
fully qualified domain name like custom
label. aure region. aure
container. Azure provides quick start
images to start launching example
applications but you can also Source
containers from Azure container registry
Docker Hub or even privately hosted
container
registry container groups are collection
of containers that get scheduled on the
same host machine the containers in a
container group share life cycle
resources local network and storage
volumes
container groups are similar to a
kubernetes pod multi-container groups
currently support only Linux containers
there are two ways to deploy a
multi-container group to deploy a
multi-container group you can use either
a resource manage or template if
deploying additional Azure service
resources or a yml file for deployments
involving only container instances
overall Azure container instances
simplify container deployment and
scaling removing the complexities of
infrastructure
management
the next topic we'll be going over our
container restart policies a container
restart policy specifies what a
container should do when their process
has completed these policies ensure that
the container instances can handle
different scenarios effectively based on
the specific requirements of the
application or task Azure container
instances has three restart policy
options always this policy ensures that
the containers restart continuously
regardless of whether they exit
successfully or not it's useful for app
applications that need to be constantly
available such as web servers never with
this policy containers do not restart
once they've completed their execution
this is ideal for tasks that are
designed to run once and then terminate
such as batch jobs or scheduled tasks on
failure containers will only restart if
they stop due to an error or unexpected
termination this ensures that if a
container crashes or faces an unexpected
error it will try to restart and
continue its operations overall choosing
the appropriate restart policy is vital
for the the stability and responsiveness
of your
applications the next topic we'll be
covering our container environment
variables environment variables are key
value pairs that can be used to
configure and manage the behavior of
applications running inside containers
environment variables allow you to pass
configuration details to your containers
which can be critical in guiding
applications on how to connect to
databases where to find certain
resources or how to adjust their
behavior based on the environment
they're running in in Azure you can
easily set up these environment
variables for your containers using the
Azure portal CLI or Powershell secured
environment variables by default
environment variables are stored in
plain text to address this Azure offers
the option to secure your environment
variables instead of storing them in
plain text which could expose sensitive
information if breached you can Leverage
The secure environment variables flag so
that's a quick overview of container
environment
variables
the next topic we'll be covering is
container troubleshooting
troubleshooting containers in Azure
involves a series of commands that help
diagnose and resolve issues as container
logs this command lets you fetch logs
from your container these logs can
provide insights into application
behavior and possible errors as
container attach if you need diagnostic
data during container startup use this
command it helps in understanding issues
that might arise during the
initialization phase of a container as
container EXA for a deeper dive into the
Container this command starts an
interactive session this is useful for
live debugging and to inspect the
container's current state as monitor
metrics list this command gives you
metrics related to your container such
as CPU usage which can be essential for
performance tuning or identifying bottle
X so these are the commonly used
commands for container
[Music]
troubleshooting hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam Pro and we're going to take a
look at a your container instances so
here it is so all we got to do is go to
container instances we'll hit add and
the nice thing is that Azure provides us
with a Hello World one so it's very easy
for us to get started um it's a Linux
machine and it looks like it's pretty
inexpensive there so we'll stick with
that I'm going to create a new group
here we're going to call it banana um
and we'll name the container instance
banana and East Us 2 seems fine to me
you'll notice we're on a quick start
image if we wanted we could use
something from the docker Hub and
provide our own link but we'll just take
with the quick uh start image for today
we're going to go ahead and hit next to
networking just to see what we have as
options you can make it public or
private we'll go to Advanced hold on
here yep those are just the ports you
can expose we'll go to advance and for
the restart policy we can set on failure
always or never we can pass in
environment variables and I covered this
a lot more in detail in the lecture
content so we don't need to really dive
deep into this um and we'll go ahead and
create this
instance and so we'll have to wait a
little while here and I'll see you back
in a moment okay and so after a short
wait our container instance is ready
we'll go to that resource there and take
a look around so on the left hand side
we can go to our containers and there we
can see it running we can see the events
down below of what's going on so you can
see that it's pulled the image it
successfully pulled it and it started
the container some properties nothing
interesting there the logs if we wanted
to see stuff and if we wanted to connect
to the instance we could also go here
and hit connect which is kind of nice um
I don't have any purpose to do that
right now so and it's also not going to
work the way we're doing it but I just
wanted to show you you had those
opportunities uh you can do identity so
that means manage it with ro base access
controls but what I want to see is
actually this uh hello world working I'm
assuming that must be a a hello page
I've never looked at it before so we're
going to go here grab the public IP
address and paste it on in the top and
there we go so we have deployed a
instance onto Azure container instances
or a container I should say so nothing
super exciting to talk about here um but
we do need to know the basics uh there
um if we wanted to deploy other
containers it's just the one there so
that's all you really need to do um but
yeah so yeah hopefully that uh gives you
an idea there I'll just go back to the
list here so we can see it and we'll go
ahead and just uh delete that probably
do it for the vi the resources on the
left hand side like I always like to do
uh and we will go into banana
here and we will delete banana and there
you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro in this section we're diving into
the Azure container registry Azure
container registry is a managed Docker
registry service based on the open
Source Docker registry 2.0 it's designed
for building storing and managing
containerized applications and images
use Azure container Registries with your
existing container development and
deployment pipelines use Azure container
registry tasks to automate image builds
directly in Azure when you commit code
you can seamlessly pull images from ACR
for deployment to various orchestrators
such as kubernetes DC OS and Docker
swarm many Azure services including
Azure kubernetes service Azure app
service Azure B and Azure service fabric
offer direct support to interface with
ACR this ensures a cohesive workflow for
deploying applications developers can
also push container images to a
container registry as part of a
container development workflow with
delivery tools such as Azure pipelines
and Jenkins ACR offers various
interfaces for interaction you can
manage and configure it using the Azure
CLI Azure Powershell Azure portal Azure
SDK or even the docker extension for
visual studio code in conclusion azure
container registry securely and
efficiently manages your Docker images
streamlining build storage and
deployment the next topic will be
covering our Azure container registry
tasks ACR tasks are designed to automate
the process of patching the operating
system and Frameworks within your Docker
containers for quick tasks ACR tasks let
you instantly push a specific container
image to azure's container registry
without needing a local Docker engine
installation ACR tasks offer automation
flexibility you can set up automated
builds that are triggered by different
events such as updates made to the
source code updates to a containers
based image or predetermined schedules
or timers with ACR tasks multi-step
workflows become easier for example you
could build a web application image run
the web application container build a
web application test image and deploy
the container that will run tests on the
web application each ACR task has an
Associated source code Contex the
location of a set of source files used
to build a container image or other
artifact furthermore ACR tasks support
the use of run variables making it
possible to repurpose task definitions
and enforce consistent image and
artifact tagging standards in summary
ACR tasks amplify the automation
efficiency and consistency of container
management and
Azure the next topic we'll be going over
is Docker Docker is a powerful platform
design designed for automating the
deployment scaling and management of
applications using
containerization Docker abstracts
infrastructure and environment variables
allowing you to create a controlled
environment within your Docker container
we can install Docker images into those
Docker containers with each Docker image
representing one or a group of common
software the machine on which Docker is
installed and running is usually
referred to as a Docker host or host
when you deploy an application on the
host it will create a logical entity to
host where the application called a
container or Docker container container
a Docker container does not have any OS
installed and running on it it has a
virtual copy of the process table
network interface and the file system
outpoint which have been inherited from
the OS of the host on which the
container is hosted in Runing the kernel
of the host OS is shared across all the
containers that are running on it this
allows each container to be isolated
from the other present on the same host
it supports multiple containers with
different application requirements and
dependencies to run on the same host if
the OS requirements are the same Docker
key benefits Docker supports multiple
applications with different requirements
and dependencies to be hosted on the
same host if the OS requirements are the
same storage optimized containers are
typically a few megabytes in size and
consume very little disk space allowing
a large number of applications to be
hosted on the same host robustness
robustness containers don't contain a
full OS making them more lightweight
than virtual machines as a result they
use significantly less memory and can
boot up in mere seconds whereas a might
take several minutes reduces costs
Docker is less demanding when it comes
to the hardware required to run it
better or Disaster Recovery you can back
up a Docker image of the state of the
container at a specific point in time
and restore it later if serious issues
arise faster configuration with
consistency you can just put your
configurations into code and deploy it
saves a lot of time from preparing the
setup and deployment
documentation overall Docker provides a
robust efficient and cost-effective
solution for application deployment and
management through
containerization the next topic we'll be
going over is a Docker file in Docker a
Docker file is a text document that
contains all the commands a user could
call on the command line to assemble an
image by using the docker Bill command
users can automate the image creation
process by executing the instructions
laid out in the docker file here are
some essential points to understand
about Docker files the docker file is a
text file that contains the instruction
that you would execute on the command
line to create an image a Docker file is
a step-by-step set of instructions
Docker offers standard commands for use
within the docker file such as from
specifies the base image to start with
copy copies files from the host system
into the image run executes a command
EnV sets environment variables expose
informs Docker that the container will
listen on a specified Network Port at
runtime CMD provides defaults for the
executing container docker will build a
Docker image automatically by reading
these instructions from the docker file
overall a Docker file provides a
reproducible and consistent method to
build Docker container
[Music]
images hey it's Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll delve into
Azure functions but first it's essential
to understand the concepts of serverless
and functions as a service so what is
serverless serverless architecture
generally describes fully managed cloud
services that classification of a cloud
service being serverless is not a
Boolean answer but an answer on a scale
where a cloud service has a degree of
serverless a serverless service could
have alter most of the following
characteristics High elasticity and
scalability high availability high
durability and secure by default
abstracts away the underlying
infrastructure and are built based on
the execution of your business task
serverless can scale to zero meaning
when not and use the serverless
resources cost nothing pay for Value
model where you only pay for actual use
usage eliminating costs for idle
resources an analogy of serverless could
be similar to an energy rating labels
which allows consumers to compare the
Energy Efficiency of a product some
services are more serverless than others
what is function is a service FAS
empowers developers to concentrate on
Crafting specific pieces of code known
as functions these functions can be
event driven meaning they either trigger
based on events or produce event data
typically several functions are
interwoven to form a serverless
application and these functions are
activated only when called upon function
as a service is not serverless on its
own f is only serverless if it's fully
managed and scales to zero in conclusion
serverless and F represent
transformative approaches in cloud
computing emphasizing efficiency
scalability and cost-effective
me the next topic we'll be covering is
azure functions Azure functions is a
function as a service offering that
allows developers to focus on writing
code and not worry about maintaining the
underlying Computing infrastructure a
function app defines the underlying
compute for a collection of functions a
function app defines the hosting runtime
and other Global
configurations a function represents
code LA with application runtime
configuration a trigger is the chosen
event data that will cause function to
execute you can only have one trigger
input bindings or what are multiple data
sources that will be pass to the
function when a trigger occurs output
bindings are one more data syns that
will receive outputed data from the
function on successful execution there
are four versions of azure functions 1 x
2 x 3 x and 4 x we are currently using
for
X Azure functions storage
considerations every function app
requires a storage account to operate if
that account is deleted your functions
won't work Azure functions uses the
following storage types in the storage
account blob storage maintain binding
State and function keys Azure files file
share used to store and run your
function app code in a consumption plan
and Premium plan Azure files is set up
by default but you can create an app
without Azure files under certain
conditions H Storage used by task hubs
and durable functions and table storage
also used by task hubs and durable
functions Azure functions anatomy of a
function function. JSO n configuration
of a single function defining bindings
code the code for your function Funk
ignore to ignore host. JS n Global
configuration of all functions at the
function app level local project a place
to locally store code in conclusion
Azure functions offers developers an
effortless way to build event driven
Solutions without managing
infrastructure the next topic we'll be
overgo is the authorization levels for
Azure functions HTTP triggers
authorization level determines what keys
if any need to be present on on the
request in order to invoke the function
the authorization level can be one of
the following values Anonymous no API
key is required function a specific API
key for that function is needed admin
the master key for all functions within
that function app is required in this
example we're creating an HTTP trigger
the desired authorization level can be
selected note that the authorization
level can usually be changed after
Creation in the portal and is set on the
trigger Azure functions debugging you
can can enable streaming logs for Azure
functions to see your real-time logging
when an error occurs there are two ways
to view a stream of log files being
generated by your function executions
built-in log streaming the app service
platform provides an inbuilt feature to
stream application log files allowing
developers to trace function executions
live live metric stream when your
function app is connected to application
insights you can view log data and other
metrics in near real time in the Azure
portal using live metric stream it's
worth highlighting that these lock
stream can be viewed both in the portal
and in most local development
environments overall Azure functions
provide adaptable HTTP trigger
authorization and robust debugging tools
enhancing security and developer
troubleshooting the next let's break
them down lightweight and serverless
Azure functions are Compact and
potentially serverless removing the need
for heavy infrastructure efficiency and
speed easy to write deploy and upgrade
without effect other website components
Azure functions are fast to execute
because there is no large application
startup time initialization and other
events fired before the code is executed
event driven execution ensures they run
only when an event triggers them zero
maintenance no need for active
infrastructure management or Associated
costs they scale automatically to meet
traffic demands even scaling to zero
cost when idle development e Azure
functions can be built tested and
deployed directly from the Azure portal
they provide built-in CI CD through
Azure devops and monitoring with Azure
monitor streamline the development
process cost effective you pay only for
the actual runtime eliminating costs
when functions are idle interoperability
using industry standard protocols Azure
functions can seamlessly communicate
with various apis databases and
libraries Azure functions use cases for
business use cases Azure functions are
great for scheduled tasks reminders and
notifications lightweight web API
sending background emails running
background backup tasks and Performing
bin
calculations for technical use cases
Azure functions are ideal in sending
emails starting backup order processing
and task scheduling such as database
cleanup sending notifications messages
and iot data processing Azure functions
are best suited for smaller apps have
events that can work independently of
other websites in conclusion Azure
functions are serverless and efficient
streamlining development for both
business and Technical tasks and event
driven compaction
applications the next topic we'll be
covering is our Azure function templates
Azure provides function templates to get
you started with common function
scenarios in Visual Studio code the
selection of a function template occurs
exclusively during the project creation
phase HTTP triggered by an HTTP request
and returns HTTP tyer triggered based on
a predefined schedule blot storage
triggered when files are either uploaded
or updated in a blob storage container
Cosmos DB executes in response to the
addition or modification of documents in
Cosmos DB Q storage triggered by Azure
storage Q messages event grid triggered
by event from event grid many Azure
Services can trigger a function through
event grid essentially event grid
operates as a serverless event bus that
is deeply integrated with various Azure
Services event Hub triggered by event
Hub event and is particularly effective
for streaming scenar scenarios service
bus Q triggered when there's a new
message in a service bus que making it
optimal for messaging systems service
bus topics triggered by an event from
bus topic aligning it with the pub
submodel send grid specifically designed
to be triggered by an email event within
the third party service send grid
overall Azure function templates offer
developers a structured foundation for
common scenarios enabling quicker
deployment and integration within
azure
the next topic we'll be going over the
functions configuration for Azure
functions each function comes with a
specific configuration file named
function. JSO n this file serves an
important role outlining the trigger
bindings and additional configuration
settings for the function the Essential
Elements of this file include type
specifies The Binding type Direction
indicates whether the binding is for
receiving data into the function or
sending data from the function name
represents the the data binding in the
function in C this would be an argument
name whereas in JavaScript it would
manifest as a key and a key value
pair let's take a look at the host
configuration for Azure functions every
function app has a host configuration
file named host. Json this configuration
file contains Global configurations
options and parameters for all the
functions within the function app the
host has lot of configuration options
these include aggregator application
insights blobs console Cosmos d custom
Handler durable task event Hub
extensions extension bundle functions
function timeout health monitor HTTP
loging manage dependency cues retri send
grid service bus Singleton version watch
directories and watch file settings
essentially these configurations offer
developers a framework to adapt
functions respond to event triggers and
ensure consistency across the function
app the next thing will be be covering
are the plan services and Azure
functions Azure functions offers three
distinct plan Services each tailored to
different needs consumption plan cold
starts you only pay for the time your
code or application is running billing
is based on the number of executions the
duration of each execution and the
amount of memory used just pay while you
have functions running and scale out
automatically even through long loading
times Premium plan pre-warmed the user
has designated a set of pre-warmed cases
which are already online and ready to
react instantly Azure provides any
additional Computing Services that are
required when your function is running
you pay for the constantly pre-warmed
instances including any additional
instances needed to scale the Azure app
in out Azure functions host instances
are added and removed based on the
number of incoming events dedicated plan
VM sharing when you use app service for
other apps your functions will run on
the same plan at no extra cost you may
scale it up manually by adding more VM
instances for an app service plan you
may have autoscale enabled optimal when
you have existing underutilized VMS
which also operate other instances of
the app service in summary when choosing
an Azure functions plan we your budget
responsiveness needs and current
infrastructure for Optimal Performance
and
value the next thing we'll be covering
are triggers and bindings and Azure
functions triggers and bindings let you
avoid hardcoding access to other
services and abstracting Away boiler
plate code keeping your functions lean
what is a trigger a trigger is a
specific type of event which causes the
function to run it defines how a
function is invoked and a function must
only have one trigger triggers can have
Associated data which is often provided
as the payload of the function what is a
binding binding is defined if your
function is connected to another service
the data from bindings is provided to
the function as parameters bindings are
optional and a function can have
multiple input and output
bindings Azure functions support a wide
range of bindings to facilitate
integration and data processing these
include Storage Solutions like blob
storage Azure Cosmos DB and Azure SQL
Dapper event grid and event Hub cater to
event driven architectures with iot Hub
focusing on event data from Hardware
devices HTTP and web hooks facilitate
real-time data interaction while Kafka
processes stream data mobile apps helps
in Mobile development and notification
hubs are for push notifications Hugh
storage rabbit and Q a messaging broker
and service bus ensure seamless data
transfer and messaging send Grit
optimizes email delivery SLE R an open
source.net Library provides asynchronous
notifications to web apps table storage
is the nsql KE Value Store timer
triggers are based on scheduled rejects
expressions and twio offers a cloud
platform for Voice and text messaging
systems the table provides a breakdown
of various Azure functions Integrations
and their support across versions one
Hax and 2 x and higher both blob storage
and Azure Cosmos DB are fully supported
across all categories for both versions
Azure data Explorer Azure SQL Dapper
cafka and Signal are supported from
version 2 x Awards some Integrations
such as mobile apps notification hubs
and send grid have limited support
across the versions specifically with
triggers inputs or outputs others like
event grid event hubs HTTP and web hooks
iot Hub Q storage service bus and table
storage have brought support but may
lack in one or two categories overall
Azure functions offer serverless
computation and seamless service
integration using triggers and bindings
they eliminate redundant code the
platform supports diverse bindings but
some Integrations have
limits the next topic we'll be covering
into is The Binding Direction and Azure
functions all triggers and bindings have
a direction property in the function.
JSO n file the direction of triggers is
always in input and output bindings use
in out or both some bindings support a
special Direction and out out the
trigger is defined alongside the input
and output bindings trigger will have
the same as the input type but with
trigger appended for example an input
binding name blob would have a trigger
name blob trigger if you use an out only
the advanced editor is available via the
integrate tab in the portal if you use
an out only the advanced editor is
available via the integrate tab in the
portal in scenarios requiring periodic
data processing Azure functions offers
tailored Solutions suppose every hour
you want to read new log files delivered
by your app application and you need to
transform the data to be ingested in
your nosql database that resides in
Cosmos DB you'll use the trigger type
timer because it's a scheduled job that
will run at a specific time the blob
storage would be an in binding as the
function reads the data from it the
cosmos DB would be an out binding
enabling the function to write the
processed data into the database in
essence by understanding and effectively
leveraging these binding directions
developers can architect efficient
event-driven solutions that seamlessly
integrate various Azure services
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this section we'll be covering
Azure front door Azure front door is a
traffic manager traffic accelerator
Global load balancer and content
distribution Network Azure front door is
a modern application delivery Network
platform providing a secure scalable CDN
Dynamic site acceleration and Global
HTTP load balancing for your Global web
applications Azure front door featur
fees caching similar to traditional cdns
Azure front door offers caching with
specified rules and expiration policies
resiliency by Distributing incoming
traffic across multiple or different
Azure regions cookie based session
affinity for restful applications when
traffic needs to be redirected back to
the same back end Health probe to
determine the healthiest and closest
backend to the client request web
application firewall a crucial security
measure protecting your back ends from
malicious attacks and vulnerabilities
URL redirect redirecting traffic based
on protocol HTTP or https host name path
and query string URL rewrite with a
powerful engine for rewriting income
requests to a different backend
request an Azure front door is made up
of frontends domains these front-ends
domains are connected to backend pools
where those connections are filtered by
routing rules Azure front door core
components profile containers all front
door components and Point acts as a
pathway or Bridge connecting the front
end to the back end origin groups a
grouping of Origins origin defining the
road to back end rule sets a grouping of
rules rules routing rules overall aure
front door optimizes web application
delivery within the Azure ecosystem by
utilizing its features businesses can
enhance web traffic management
efficiency the next topic we'll be
covering are the tiers for Azure front
door door Azure front door offers two
distinct tiers tailored for different
needs first we have standard this
auction optimizes content delivery
offers both static and dynamic content
acceleration offering Global load
balancing SSL offload domain and
certificate management enhanced traffic
analytics and basic security
capabilities and we have premium this
option includes all the features of the
standard tier asure front door premium
tier offers extensive security
capabilities with Waf by protection
private links support and integration
with Microsoft thread intelligence and
security analytics in conclusion Azure
front door provides standard for Content
delivery and premium with added security
ensuring Global application performance
and
protection the next topic we'll be going
over is routing and Azure front door
routing in Azure front door determines
the path in HTTP request from a user
takes to reach a configured backend
service here's how it works an HTTP
request from a user is directed to the
nearest Edge location it then matches
with an Azure front door profile and
evaluates any web application firewall
rules following this it matches with an
Azure front door route evaluates engine
rules and either returns cash content or
selects the appropriate origin group
finally the request is directed to the
selected origin which then sends it to
the corresponding back end Azure front
door offers four distinct traffic
routing methods latency routes requests
to the backends with the lowest latency
within a specified sensitivity range
priority directs requests based on a
user defined priority number weighted
distributes requests to backends
proportionally based on assigned weight
coefficients session Affinity ensures
requests from the same end user are
directed to the same back end ideal for
stateful backends in summary Azure front
door enhances user experience and
backend performance through its
efficient routing
capabilities the next topic will be
covering is origin and origin grp groups
in Azure front door the origin is what
Azure front door will point at to the
end user origin is the endpoint that
points to your back end Azure front door
provides robust support for a variety of
Origins to seamlessly integrate with its
application delivery Network among the
supported origins or Azure blob storage
which offers vast storage capabilities
and Azure storage with static website
hosting catering to web hosting needs
additionally Azure supports cloud
services app services and static web
apps for diverse application deployments
for comprehensive API management Azure
front door integrates with API
management furthermore application
Gateway public IP address Azure traffic
manager Azure spring cloud and Azure
container instances are also supported
notably there's flexibility for users as
they can also add custom Origins by
providing a host name priority and Azure
front door determines who is the primary
recipient of traffic or who who to send
traffic to First you select a value
ranging from 1 to 5 a lower value
signifies a higher priority and multiple
backends can share this number weights
allow you to determine the split of
traffic distribution between origins of
the same priority a number between 1 to
1,000 the default value is
50 origin groups in Azure front door are
collections of Origins every origin must
be part of an origin Group by default as
your front door profiles contain An
Origin group named default origin group
origin groups facilitate the application
of Health probes to assess the condition
of your Origins and load balancing
settings to manage the distribution
among them
to direct inbound traffic to a
particular origin group and inlo must
link to the origin group through a
designated route overall as your front
door optimizes web traffic management
with diverse Origins prioritization and
weight mechanisms using origin groups it
leverages health probes and load
balancing for efficient application
delivery the next topic will be covering
our health checks in Azure front door
Azure front door uses origin group
Health probes to periodically ping a
backend verifying whether it returns a
healthy response typically a healthy
response is determined by status 20 100
if a backend fails to produce a healthy
response aure front door will redirect
the traffic to other available and
healthy backends assuming other Origins
are configured what is a HTTP Response
Code when a user sends an HTTP request a
HTTP response is returned and HTTP
responses will have a response code to
communicate how a backend server
interpreted the request
a response code is number that
coordinates to what happened for example
200 signifies okay 4003 means forbidden
4004 indicates not found 500 represents
internal server error Azure front door
load balancing settings origin group
load balancing settings and Azure front
door enable you to specify the criteria
determining the health of a back end
essentially these settings Define which
sample set should be used to classify a
backend as either healthy or unhealthy
when the latency sensitivity is set to
zero aure front door prioritizes and
routes traffic to the quickest available
backend if it's set to any other value
the system adopts a round robin approach
Distributing traffic between the fastest
back end and subsequent ones all within
the bounds of the preconfigured latency
sensitivity the next topic will be
covering a routes and Azure front door
routes and Azure front door serve as
mapping tools linking your domains and
corresponding URL path patterns to
specific origin groups routes of caching
and compression features applied rules
from rule sets can be Associated to
routes to apply intelligent
routing one of the standout features of
azure front door is its capability for
traffic acceleration this feature
ensures faster Global delivery of your
application without necessitating any
changes to your existing application
code hazure achieves this traffic
acceleration by directing traffic to the
nearest Edge location to a ramp into the
Azure Network traffic that is following
within the internal Azure Network
travels at accelerated speed while also
taking the most direct path think of it
as an expressway in essence asure front
door routes link domains to origin
groups incorporating caching compression
and intelligent
routing the next topic will be covering
a rule sets in Azure front door Azure
front door rules engine allows you to
customize how HTTP requests gets handled
at the edge and provides a more
controlled Behavior to your web
application this interface is a
configuration screen for defining rules
in Azure front door a Content delivery
and application acceleration service
let's break down what's presented rule
Name by rule this is the name assigned
to the current rule condition if
represents the conditions under which
the Rule's action should be executed
request header the rule is triggered
based on an HTTP header present in the
incoming request header name my header
the rule looks for this specific header
in the incoming request operator equal
specifies the comparison type here it
checks if the header's value exactly
matches the defined value header value
my value the value that my header should
have to meet the condition string
transform to lowercase before checking
the value it will convert the header's
value to lowercase action then
represents the action to be taken if the
condition is met URL redirect the action
taken will be a URL redirect redirect
type found specifies the type of HTTP
redirect 3002 means a temporary redirect
redirect protocol match request the
protocol of the redirected URL will
match that of the original request
destination host not specified in the
image which means it'll redirect to the
same host or domain destination path go
here this is the path to which the user
will be redirected if the condition is
met some of the available conditions
include device type HTTP version and
request cookies it also examines post
args the query string and the remote
address of the requester details like
the request body request file name
request file extension and request
header is scrutinized furthermore the
request method request path request
protocol and request URL are taken into
account during processing aure front
door utilizes rule sets to manage its
operations offering a range of operators
for precise control these operators
include equal contains less than greater
than less than or equal greater than or
equal begins with ends with and re X
additionally each of these operators has
a corresponding knot variant providing
enhanced flexibility and specificity in
defining rule
conditions action cache expiration cache
Behavior bypass override set of missing
cash key query string Behavior include
cach every unique URL exclude ignore
query string modify request header
modify response header operator append
overwrite delete URL redirect redirect
type found moved temporary redirect
permanent redirect redirect protocol
match request HTTP
https URL Rite Source pattern and
destination and origin group overr right
so that's an overview of rule sets for
Azure front
[Music]
door hey this is angrew brown and this
fall along we're going to be utilizing
Azure front door so before we do that
we're going to need ourselves a storage
account to set up some static website uh
storage so what I want you to do is go
to storage accounts and there is a
static web app host uh hosting that we
can use but we're going to do it the old
school way because it's always great to
learn a few different ways to do things
in Azure and so uh there's probably
another fall along where we we use uh
the static static site thing there um so
what we're going to do is create a new
uh we're going to create a new um
Resource Group I'm going to call this
one uh my uh Azure front door and we'll
say okay and from here we'll have to
name it something so we'll just say my
Azure front door or sorry we'll do uh
step static
Storage storage 8888 if you can't get
the 48s because I'm using it then just
give it a different um number sequence
because these are treated like fully
qualified domains choose like a a US
region so that we're all doing the same
thing for performance we're going to
stick with standard it doesn't matter if
it's on Geo redundant we're not doing
anything fancy there so what I want you
to do is go ahead and hit review and
create and then give it a moment and hit
create and we're going to wait for that
to uh finish deployment and from there
we'll then have to enable uh static
website so it doesn't take too long to
deploy so we'll just give it a
moment and while that's going uh we do
need to create ourselves a um index HTML
file so you're going to need some kind
of editor so I'm just opening up visual
studio code on my
computer just give it a moment
there and I'm just creating a new file
here this is taking it Taking a moment
to load
okay so and what we need to do is just
create an index HTML file these are
really basic you can find them anywhere
online but this one's going to say hello
Mars hello Mars very very simple so I'm
going to go ahead and save this to my
desktop so save as and um show local
maybe there we go that's a little bit
more sayane and we'll just say
index.html and we will now go to the
resource and we're going to go to
website static is a blade on left hand
side so we can do St website stuff we're
going to say index HTML I think we have
to set that for it to work I cannot
remember if that's the case we have a
primary end point this is uh these
matter for later but we'll come back to
that and we're going to go over to our
containers and we're going to have to
create a new container so I'm just going
to call that actually we don't because
we're going to put it in web so when we
turned on static website hosting it
already gave us a blob or container a
container for us to uh add our add our
or upload our files there so we'll go to
upload here and then I'm going to go
ahead and select that index HTML file
and upload it in place um we need to
change our access level for this uh this
uh container to um I think just
blob so I'm just double checking
here yeah I think it's blob access uh
can only be anonymous request container
data is not available so we'll say okay
I believe that is
correct okay okay uh sometimes you can
like we're clicked into it but I think
like in the my instructions I do it a
little bit different so I'm just going
to double check to see what the settings
are there just so you can see it if
you're following my instructions so
change
access private blob yeah okay so that's
fine um so blob access should be okay
and so now what we want to do is just
test that our our page is working so if
we go back to static website
here on the left hand side we can grab
this primary endpoint and we should be
able to post it anywhere here see I have
the old tutorial here this is a moment
ago so that's why it's a bit confusing
but um so hello Mars is working but this
is on static stor this isn't in front of
or behind aure front door uh which is
what we'll want to do next so what I
want you to do is just close a couple of
these tabs out we're going to type in
Azure front door or front door should be
enough front there we go and we have a
whole bunch of options we'll just hit
create that's a front door we actually
do use for the platform we have Azure
front door we have create I always go
custom I don't think I've ever done
quick create I just I just have more
trust in custom and from here we will
choose front
door and ECS is
fine I'm just wondering where our
storage account is that's why we should
always just kind of set them to be the
same place so go storage account I don't
think it will matter but I'm just going
to double check storage
account
and this one is in East us so we're
going to be
okay just make sure they match just so
we have less problems and I'm going to
call this one my Azure front
door now there are more functionalities
in the premium but standard is fine for
us we'll go next to Secrets um this is
if we want to add a certificate um like
you could bring your own certificate um
but uh we're not too worried about that
we're going to have to add a new
endpoint so I'm going to just say my
endpoint here there's a lot of small
steps in here so this should be fun
hopefully we don't configure anything
wrong here and then we need to add a
route say my
route and it's going to use the default
domain that's totally fine uh we don't
have to do anything it's going to just
be on the for SL Aster there we do need
to create an origin group so we'll go
here and create a new origin group so my
origin group and then from there we need
to add an origin yes it is very squirely
going through all this my origin the
origin type is going to be Azure or
sorry storage static website and from
here we need to choose the right one we
call it static storage uh this is fine
this is all fine we'll go ahead and hit
add and down below we have some load
balancing we don't care about any of
that uh so you can see it status is
enabled all this should be okay the
protocol here for the health probe
should be HTTP um actually let me double
check I remember this is where I ran
into some
trouble I believe yeah HTTP I think it's
htps okay I think I read somewhere
that's it's like um Stack Storage
doesn't use HTTP but clearly it does
because when we went to the link earlier
it was htps so I might have the
screenshots wrong but I've corrected
them in the actual instructions on my
site we'll go ahead and save that I
think it's htps and then the the the
protocol here um we'll just leave it
matching it's totally fine origin path
is fine we'll go ahead and add that
there and we'll go review create we'll
give it a moment and we'll
create all right so after waiting um
about a few minutes like 2 3 minutes it
looks like uh as your front door set up
so we'll go to the resource and I'm just
hoping this works sometimes you have to
play around with the settings but if you
see the endpoint host name we'll go
ahead and grab that there paste it on in
and we get a 404 so something's not
working just right so we'll have to go
do some debugging which I was hoping we
didn't have to do so we go to the front
door manager this is the same setup we
have here before there are like
different ways to get to it um but we'll
have to just kind of go through and
debug it so we do have my route my
origin group so we can click into our
origin group and then from here we'll
expand it and we have our route so
there's
something that is not correct and that's
what we have to to figure
out so I'm just going to double check my
instructions cuz this was a bit tricky
to figure
out um and it really came down to like
these protocols
here
so let me keep checking and I mean I
think the probe is working correctly so
if we go on the origin if this wasn't
working correctly then it wouldn't it
wouldn't show Green so go back up a step
here you know what maybe we should just
wait a little bit because sometimes it
takes time to propagate and I don't I
don't 100% trust that it's not working
because I feel like we configured it
exactly right so we'll open up a new tab
here says 404
still my origin
group that's fine
we'll go
here yeah so what I'm going to do let go
back to our storage account I just want
to double check uh what that uh string
was for the static website I'm pretty
sure it was
htps it is HPS so there's no reason that
should not
work
this is what I was trying to uh spare
you the uh the debugging of this and
it's very common it's not just Azure
anything that has a CDN sometimes it's
it's difficult to uh figure that stuff
out we'll go ahead and edit that route
and we'll just carefully look at what we
have here so patterns to match that is
fine it's the correct end
point both Protocols are accepted that's
totally fine redirect HPS that's totally
fine match that doesn't
matter so it
should
just work the only thing we didn't do
was enable caching which I think
wouldn't hurt to do um because it is a
CDN we don't take advantage of it if we
don't turn it on so we'll do that and
say ignore that query string I mean
that's not going to fix this problem if
the routing is messed up again I'm just
hoping that maybe it just has to do with
propagation go back to the overview
here and we will open this
again
whoops grab this let's just make sure
it's doing HPS we're working to restore
all services as possible right now what
do you mean our services aren't
available right now let's go look at
Azure
status uh page
here and we will take a look at front
door
as your front door it's saying that it's
fine Us East there's no green beside
it good so we go down here I guess it's
a it's a non- regional service so if
it's green it's
green so you know what I'm going to play
around with this for a little oh 404 web
so this is better right it's just saying
it can't find the
content well I mean I guess that makes
sense because that was there so we'll
just clear that out oh now it's loading
so I think it what the issue
is there was no issue it's just
propagating to all the servers and it
took some time so uh I think that's what
really threw me for a loop um when I was
originally doing it so just give it some
patience and it will work eventually so
we are all done here so we can go ahead
and clean this
up and I'm just looking for the resource
Group here we'll go ahead and delete
it and there you go that's Azure front
[Music]
door and I'll see you in the next next
one
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure CDN Azure content
delivery network is an Azure service
that provides your applications with a
distributed network of servers with
Azure CDN you can improve your
applications load time save bandwidth
with caching strategies and speed up
responsiveness with compressed files
Azure CDN centralizes requests from your
origin into a single location making it
easier to manage your inbound and
outbound traffic with features such as
caching strategies these outline which
requests or cach and specify their
expiration timelines file compression by
minimizing static file sizes Azure CDN
ensures bandwidth the ficiency during
requests Geo filtering disallows or
denies requests based on geographical
regions global distribution azures
regions span across the globe ensuring
widespread reach integration Azure CDN
seamlessly integrates with other Azure
Services robust security Advanced
security measures are in place without
any extra cost scalability and load
balancing Azure CDN makes application
scalability straightforward thanks to
its built-in load
balancing Azure CDN can help you reduce
load times save bandwidth and improve
responsiveness it's used to cach static
content such as images CSS or HTML Azure
CDN is ideal when you're developing or
managing websites or mobile apps
encoding and distributing streaming
media gaming software firmware updates
and iot and points in essence Azure CDN
provides a robust framework to enhance
the delivery and performance of your
digital
assets the next topic will delve into
are the different tiers available for
Azure CDN Azure CDN is available in the
following tiers Microsoft CDN standard
Verizon standard aami premium Verizon
aami is one of the world's largest CD
provider with a large distributed
network of servers around the world on
the other hand Verizon media operates a
global CDN platform with a focus on
media streaming delivery and security
the CDN features greatly vary based on
the chosen option and it requires
exploring a large feature table
comparison keep in mind that Azure CDN
from acami is scheduled to be retired on
October 31st
2023 so that's a quick overview of azure
CDN
tiers
next we'll explore the purge feature in
Azure CDN The Purge function in Azure
CDN serves as an essential tool when you
want to refresh cach content it enables
the removal of cach content from all
Edge points of presence ensuring that
the latest assets are fetched directly
from the origin when requested when
you're looking to purge specific files
within a directory while cards
represented by an asterisk can be
employed for example to clear all files
in a directory you'd utilize this wild
card feature however note that the
capabilities like like Purge all and
wild card Purge AR available for Azure
CDN when sourc from acam overall The
Purge feature in Azure CDM provides
administrators with granular control
over the content caching ensuring that
users always have access to the most
updated
[Music]
assets hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and in this section we're
diving into Azure service bus service
bus is a fully managed Enterprise
message broker that allows you to
publish or subscribe to topics and Q
messages it can scale your applications
with asynchronous messages and built-in
integration with Azure Services Azure
service bus allows for single or batch
messaging message load balancing topic
subscriptions message sessions and
transactions ensuring compliance with
industry standards this includes
protocols such as amqp 1.0 with JMS 2.0
available for premium SKU and JMS 1.1
for standard
SKU service bus key Concepts the
namespace works like a server with cues
and topics Q contains the messages
sender is who sends the message receiver
is who receives the message topic is a
queue with multiple receivers that works
like a queue subscription is a receiver
in a topic a batch is a group of
messages safe batch validates if each
message can be included the batch
session allows you to use fifo and group
your messages in a queue Peak returns a
message to the que without removing it
dead letter q a q for messages that were
unable to be delivered through the
normal queue Peak and lock retrieves a
message from the queue without removing
it and locks it so other receivers
cannot receive it receive and delete
retrieves and delete a message from the
queue Auto delete on idol sets a time
span to delete the queue if it is not
used duplicate detection history checks
if the message was not sent earlier
before sending a message it overall this
gives you a comprehensive overview of
azure service bus and its various
components and
features the next next topic we'll be
covering is a namespace in Azure service
bus an Azure service bus namespace
serves as a container for all messaging
components including both cues and
topics container for messaging
components one namespace can house
multiple cues and topics making them
versatile structures within the Azure
service bus they're commonly used as
application containers capacity slice
think of a service bus Nam space as a
segment of a large scale cluster this
cluster comprises numerous all active
virtual machines that fall under your
control Azure availability zones a
namespace can potentially span up to
three Azure availability zones offering
enhanced availability and resilience
benefits at scale using Azure service
bus means you're using a messaging
system built for large scale operations
offering High reliability and strength
serverless messaging with Azure service
bus it is serverless messaging this
means you get to use the messaging
service without getting bogged down by
the intricacies of the underlying
infrastructure so that's a quick
overview of a nam space in Azure service
bus
[Music]
next let's talk about qes and Azure
service bus cues are used to send and
receive messages messages are stored in
cues until the receiving application is
ready to accept and process them
messages and qes are ordered and
timestamped on arrival once accepted by
the broker the message is always held
durably in triple redundant storage
spread across availability zones if the
name space is Zone enabled service bus
never leaves messages in memory or
volatile storage after after they've
been reported to the client is accepted
messages are delivered in pull mode only
delivering messages when
requested configuration aspects of azure
service bus cues include time to live
this determines the duration a message
remains in the queue if it isn't
processed within this time frame it
either gets removed or is transferred to
the dead letter Q lock duration this
represents the period during which a
message is locked by locking messages
service bus ensures that no two users
can read or process the same message
simultaneously
to sum it up q's and Azure service bus
are efficient tools to handle message
sending and receiving in a structured
and reliable manner so that's an
overview of q's and Azure service
bus the next topic will be covering our
topics in Azure service bus topics can
be used to send and receive messages a q
is often used for pointto point or one
toone communication whereas topics are
useful in publish subscribe or on to
many communication it's important to
endnote that topics are not available at
the basic pricing tier you need to opt
for either the standard or premium tier
a unique feature of topics is their
support for multiple independent
subscriptions multiple independent
subscriptions can be attached to a topic
and work in the same way as cues from
the receiver's side a subscriber to a
topic can receive a copy of each message
sent to that topic it's also worth
noting that subscriptions or named
entities providing an organizational
structure you can Define rules on a
subscription a subscription rule has a
filter that specifies a condition for a
message to be copied into the
subscription as well as an optional
action that modifies message
metadata when creating a topic consider
the following configuration settings Max
topic size you can specify a size
ranging from 1 to 5 GB time to live the
setting determines the duration after
which a message is removed from the
topic duplicate message avoidance this
ensures that duplicate messages are
processed partitioning useful for
efficiently managing a large influx of
events a subscription in Azure service
bus is a named entity associated with a
topic that allows subscribers to receive
copies of messages sent to that topic in
a publish subscribe model of azure
service bus topics can be thought of as
the channels to send messages
subscriptions are like the virtual cues
to receive those messages there are also
additional configuration settings for
subscriptions Max delivery count this
setting can be adjusted between 1 to
2,000 defining the number of delivery
attempts for a particular message
message sessions when sessions are
activated a subscription can ensure that
messages are delivered in a first in
first out sequence so that's an overview
of topics and Azure so that's an
overview of topics and
Azure the next topic we'll be covering
is the different pricing tiers in Azure
service bus Azure service bus has three
different pricing tiers basic standard
and premium the more expensive the tiers
the more functionality it provides let
break down the features and their
availability across these tiers Hughes
this is the foundational messaging
structure in service bus allowing
messages to be sent and received all
three tiers offer support for cues
schedule messages this feature allows
users to set messages to be dispatched
at a future specified time it's
available across all three tiers topics
topics support the publish subscribe
messaging pattern this feature isn't
available in the basic tier but is
offered in both the standard and premium
tiers transactions and uring a set of
operations are completed successfully
and in order transactions are not
available in the basic tier however both
the standard and premium tiers support
this feature to duplication this ensures
that duplicate messages are processed
more than once only the standard and
premium tiers offer this feature with
the basic tier lacking it sessions
ensuring ordered and related sets of
messages are processed in the correct
sequence this feature is excluded in the
basic tier but is available in the
standard and premium tiers forward to
send via this facility Ates forwarding a
message or routing it via a specific
path it's not supported in the basic
tier but is available in the standard
and premium tiers message size dictates
the maximum allowable size for an
individual message the basic and
standard tier support messages up to 256
kilobytes while the premium tier
significantly extends this limit to 100
megabytes resource isolation this
provides isolated computational
resources to ensure better performance
and reliability it's a feature exclusive
to the premium tier G Geo Disaster
Recovery in the event of significant
geographical or infrastructure
disruptions this recovery feature helps
maintain service Integrity it's denoted
with an asterisk suggesting there might
be additional details or conditions this
feature is reserved for the premium tear
Java messaging service supporting JMS a
standard messaging protocol for Java
this feature is only available in the
premium tier availability Zone support
this ensures High resilience and
availability by Distributing Services
across multiple isolated data centers or
zones it's exclusive to the premium
tier the next topic we'll be going over
is a dead letter q and Azure service bus
the dead letter q and Azure service bus
is a specialized queue that stores
messages that couldn't be delivered or
processed successfully these messages
might fail due to various reasons
message that is sent to a queue that
does not exist Hue length limit exceeded
message length limit exceeded message is
rejected by another q Exchange
message reaches a threshold read counter
number because it is not consumed
sometimes this is called a backout q the
message expires due to per message TTL
or the message is not processed
successfully dead letter cues provide
several benefits including monitoring
failed message deliveries to understand
and address the underlying issues ruing
messages for another attempt at
processing especially after resolving
the reason for the initial failure
initiating follow-up actions such as
alerting remediation or alternative
processing paths when specific failure
patterns are detected in essence dead
letter cues are vital for ensuring the
reliability and resilience of a
messaging
system the next topic will be covering
are the Azure CLI commands for Azure
service bus Azure CLI offers various
subcommands specifically tailored for
Azure service bus these subcommands
enable efficient management and
configuration as serviceus geore
recovery Alias as service bu migration
as service bu Nam space as service bu Q
as serviceus topic notably unlike Azure
storage Q Azure service bus does not
have direct CLI commands to send
messages to cues or topics for sending
messages to a que You' need to use the
Azure SDK for example using the node.js
SDK you can install the necessary
package with npm install at Azure
servicebus this will allow you to
integrate Azure service bus
functionalities directly into your
application and send messages
programmatically so that's an overview
of the key Azure CLI commands for Azure
service
[Music]
bus hey this is Andrew Brown from
exampro and we are going to take a look
at service bus so what I want you to do
is type in servers bus at the top here
what's interesting is that this is the
old icon they have a new icon so just
realize that there's some
inconsistencies there and that's not my
fault that's azure's fault um but the
first thing we need to do is create a
name space because a service bus is kind
of like you you know storage account
where you can have uh a variety of
different kinds of storages well you can
have uh more than one type of messaging
system and so we have our traditional
one uh like event messaging similar to
storage CU but with first in first out
functionality and we have Pub sub via
topic so what you'll do is create a new
service bus namespace and I'm going to
create a new Resource Group I'm can call
this the
a204 um service
bus and we'll say message or sorry Q
because we're going to do a que and then
we're going to do a topic separately and
for this I'm going to call the Nam space
um service bus Q to keep it simple we'll
let it launch wherever it wants to
launch and notice there are multiple
pricing tiers depending on the tier
affects the functionality so if we do
basic we're only going to have access to
Q we're not going to have access to um
uh topics and so this is totally safe
and fine to do um like even if we did
premium it's fine because it's based on
your consumption it's not based on um
you know you just having holding around
so we'll get the basic one here and
we'll go to networking I don't think
there's anything interesting there we'll
go ahead and review and create and we'll
let that create click create
again and it's deploying as that is
deploying which will not take too long
what I've done is set up a private
repository here you'll probably see me
use this throughout the course it's
literally an empty repository because I
already have the code done I've been
doing the follow alongs and document
them here in the free Azure developer
associate but when you're doing follow
alongs with me you should do them with
uh do them from scratch and then if you
need to you can reference the stuff here
so um I have this uh separate repository
I have a g pod account which has a free
tier you can totally do this in your own
Visual Studio code on your little local
machine the reason I'm doing a g pod is
because I always want to show you how to
set up the CLI and those other tools um
and when you launch G pod gives you a
blank environment so I'm just going to
launch that up there as that's going
we'll go back here and take a look and
see if this is ready just hit refresh
here it is still going but we already
have our environment and while that is
going in the background I want to go
install the Azure CLI so we don't even
have a single file here I'm just going
to say readme.md so I can see what is
going on here maybe we'll just dump
things in here as we go I'm going to go
get the Azure
CLI uh Linux because this is running
Linux
Ubuntu uh here so something you should
always check is like uh what Linux
version am I running if you're on
Windows of course this is going to be
different but even Windows using the
windows subsystem Linux is using Ubuntu
as well so what I'll do here I'll go to
the first link nope that's not the one I
want maybe the second
one there's usually like a command here
I can run
uh
which Linux version am I
running let's try this one
here
it's usually
like so maybe it's this here cat proc
version it really does vary based on
what you're using and so here I'm going
to go file uh or sorry terminal new
terminal we'll paste that in there hit
enter and so here it says Linux 513
Ubuntu
11 uh 18
so I know that this is
auntu I don't really like that one there
um let's try this
instead because it just doesn't read
very well there we go we're running
Ubuntu 204 I already knew that um but I
just wanted to double check and the
reason that matters is that when you're
installing the CLI it might matter what
version you're using so we're going to
go here and I'm going to go to Linux and
the instructions might vary this one
says 16 18 20 so they're all the same
here and we have this one liner here
that we'll
install and what I'll do here is drop
drop it in here and hit
enter I'm not sure if this font is too
small so while that's going I'm going to
see if I can bump up our font
here I'm looking for the terminal font
size here
terminal let's just say 20 here
there we go and so the Azure CLI should
be installed so I'll just type in clear
so we say Azure or a to run it looks
good to me so we'll type in Azure login
um I don't want to log in with um that
way I want to log with the device so
we'll do ay login device
because if you're on your regular
computer you can just click a button and
go to the browser but I'm not going to
be able to do that so I going to have to
do device
login
device
well I'll have to do it the wrong way
first to do it the right way soit enter
Because the problem is if I go here it's
going to go to Local Host because it's
trying to launch in my local
machine so it does that and that's no
good and so here it says do the a login
use device code okay so that's the one I
really wanted to
use so hyphen hyphen use device code
enter and that will give us a code so
what we do is we will need uh this link
here so I'll have to expand that
to
here and then I'm going to go ahead and
grab that
code continue and so now go back this
will authenticate it'll just take a
second
here close the tab here there we go may
had to close the tab uh and so now I'm
authenticated so I should should be able
to uh do whatever I want um what I need
to do
next
is create ourselves a message Q so we'll
go to the resource here and notice here
entities it only says Q now if we
had uh other than the basic the standard
plan then we would see topics here we'll
go click into que click create a new
queue I'm going to call it my qu we have
some options here the Q size can go up
to 5 gigabytes the max delivery count so
this is the maximum deliveries time to
live that is how long they live in the
queue before they are dropped out or
they are dropped into a dead letter a
system there we have lock duration so
the set the amount of time a message is
locked for other receivers you can
enable partitioning uh that's pretty
complicated but we'll go ahead and
create our que and so this should be
pretty darn quick there is our queue
we'll click into it and you'll notice
that there isn't really a way to view
messages there's not a way to add
messages uh here we have the service bus
Explorer um which I guess technically
you can send and receive here I had not
noticed this before at least it was not
working for me so I suppose we could
send a message here saying like Hello
World this literally wasn't here last
time I checked here um and we can go
ahead and just hit
send okay and notice here it says
there's one active message and we can
receive it say yes and so it says it
received the message it's not showing us
the
answer so I guess they're kind of is
something here I guess they're still
working on it but uh mostly what we're
going to have to do is uh do things
programmatically so that is why we have
this account so what I want you to do is
open a new tab here and we're going to
type in aure service bus documentation
cuz we're going to grab some code there
modify it make it our own so it's a bit
easier to to work with so here I'm in
the service bus we'll go to
tutorials um I'm not sure if this one is
the right
one Azure service bus documentation
Q it's the same thing
here but this is doesn't look
right what is service
bus
I mean it is the right page but it had a
couple tutorials here uh that I had here
so we'll type in like Azure service bus
uh tutorial
topics sometimes things aren't where you
think they're supposed to
be okay we'll type in service
bus
seems like the same page
again ah it was quick starts sorry so we
have tutorials here and then we have
quick starts so under the quick starts
this is where I was Finding uh the
example code that I thought was okay
notice that we could do everything via
the CLI um that is not that fun but I
mean this only does the creation of it
doesn't necessarily do sending and
receiving messages notice so that we
only can use code so we'll use
JavaScript because I think that will be
the easiest to use uh so I already have
node node comes pre-installed on git pod
you'll have to figure that out for
yourself on your own machine or you can
just use get pod as well because it does
have a generous free tier what I'll do
is go ahead and paste on
in this command it doesn't seem to want
to paste today so I'll hit copy and then
we'll go back here and go right click
enter paste hit enter and so what that
will do is install that Library if
you're not very familiar with nodejs
package Json is the package manager and
this is showing that this requirement is
there I want to install one other thing
uh called EnV this will make our lives a
lot
easier um for node it comes for
different things but I just want it
for um JavaScript here so then we'll do
mpm install. emvy
save that's just a safe way for us to
pass along our environment variables and
so now both of these are installed so
what we'll do is we'll go back over to
this code and we'll scroll on down and
they have one called send and they have
one called receive so what I'll do is
create myself a couple files here so
we'll have send.
Js and we'll have receive.
Js and then what we'll do is go ahead
and copy this is the send code so we'll
put this in the sjs
file and then down below we have the
receive
code and we will paste that on in there
so I'll just make this bigger and we'll
take a quick look look here at what it's
doing so what this does is it Imports
the SDK for service bus we need to set a
connection string we need to set the Q
name here is a bunch of messages that we
are going to be passing along here we
establish a service bus client very
common in all sdks a set of a client
first then we are creating a um sender
and then here we are doing uh create
batch messages so it's a way of sending
messages in batch very efficiently so we
have a for Loop here and uh so it says
there's a batch and then it says try to
add the message to the batch if it's not
wait until it's ready then send the
message okay so pretty straightforward
for that code receive is going to be
similar so connection string Q name
create that client create a receiver and
then from there we will set up a Handler
for the receiver an error and so then
we'll subscribe and we will listen for
the message and handlers so even though
we are doing cu's it's called a
subscription still so just don't get too
mixed up with that what I want to do is
just make sure that we're passing our
environment variables in safely or
configuration so this is pretty standard
or uh good uh best practices when
working with any language the idea is
you don't want to hardcode your values
so I'm going to do process
EnV uh and we'll do connection string
here and then we'll do process EnV Q
name this is the way you grab
environment variables in JavaScript for
every language it's a little bit
different
okay and I believe these are the same so
I'm just going to go ahead and grab that
there like
this and I'll paste that on in
here and I want to load environment
variable so I'll make a new file here
called EnV this is all part of that EnV
dot thing they we're looking at EMV dot
I'm just pulling that up again here or
EnV you going to get the the right one
because we need this line here requir
Dov config that will load the
environment variables uh it'll load it
from that EnV
file so we will go above here and hit
paste and then we'll go to the receive
here and do this as
well and in here we need to Define these
so I'm just going to copy this so I
don't have to type it out by hand we
will paste that on in here and so I just
need need the Q Q
name and connection string we'll just
say equals and then
equals so our Q was called my
q and then we need to go grab the
connection
string so I'm just thinking here this is
probably yeah it's at the names Space
level and we'll go to share access
policies notice it's called shared
access policies remember when we were
doing the storage key it was like called
key access so it's totally different
interface this is what I'm talking about
where um Azure is inconsistent we're
clicking on the root manage shared
access key probably could create your
own so it doesn't have full privileges
but for this purpose we're just going to
use this one on the Le hand side we have
a primary and secondary we're going to
use the primary one and we will go back
here and we will paste on that value
in so I'll paste that in there notice we
don't have to do double quotations here
it should uh already Escape in double
quotations but when we're doing the CLI
when we did the storage accounts that
wasn't something that we could do um so
we have these two values here so they
should get loaded when we use them and
this should all be good so we'll type in
node sjs and hopefully it just works
fingers crossed and so it sent a batch
of messages to the queue so we'll go
back over to our Q here and see if we
can see
anything
and we'll click into
here I'm just trying to see so there's
10 active messages that are here right
now and so what we'll do is we'll
receive all those messages so we'll go
up and hit node receive
JS so this code is now receiving those
messages from the service bus q and
we're just going to wait here because it
takes time for whatever reason to uh
finish here but we'll give it a little
bit of time here to figure out that it's
done still
waiting there we go and so that's all
there really is to it so that is q and
we will do this again but next time with
topics so what I want you to do is make
your way over back to your resource
groups we'll find the one that we just
created which was uh this one here AZ
204 service bus Q we'll delete this
Service
Group hit delete delete and there you go
and as always double check to make sure
that you've uh for sure deleted that
stuff and that's it for service bus Q
we'll do topics next
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at service bus
and this time we're looking at topics so
what I want you to do just like before
is go to the top we'll type in service
bus and we'll go to the service bus uh
service you can still see the old one is
there it should be deleting that's how
slow this thing is but we'll create a
new one and we will create a new
Resource Group and we will call it
a204 uh service bus topic we'll say okay
we'll name this service bus topic and
this time it already exists and if it
does just dump a bunch of numbers here
on the end because it's Unique based on
that so having a domain name if somebody
has it you're going to have a problem
and so here I'm going to go to standard
because in order for us to use those
additional features we will need to be
on the standard plan so we'll go ahead
and hit review and
create and that'll take a little bit of
time to create but while that's going
I'm going to uh launch my environment
here so this was the one I was just
using a moment ago with uh GitHub and so
what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to go back to our
repo here I'm just doing it off screen
because I don't want to expose all my
stuff here
here and again if you want to you can do
this in your local V Visual Studio code
I just want to show everything from
scratch every time so here's my M3 repo
with get pod and so I'll just close this
one and it will vanish all that code is
now gone I'll H get pod this will launch
a new environment it's trying to tell me
to open the last one nope I'm going to
make a new one for this workspace here
and we'll get going here in a moment so
this namespace has been created so we'll
go ahead and hit
create and uh I guess it's still making
I I thought I already deployed it there
but I guess I
didn't okay while that's going we'll go
ahead and install the Azure CLI we'll
type in Azure CLI Linux because that is
what we're using here
today we'll go to Linux here we'll
scroll on down grab this oneliner here
to install it I'm going to open up my
terminal your terminal might be
somewhere else
allow I'm going to go ahead and paste
that on in there that's going to install
our Azure CLI as that's installing it
will be done here in a
moment let's see if this is done this is
still creating the uh namespace I
think and this is still installing
shouldn't take too long while this is
going we can start grabbing the code for
this so for this we'll type in Azure um
Azure service bus
documentation and this I found it under
the quick
start so we will go to Quick Start Ser
topics and services because there's some
code here that I want under the
JavaScript and we have one for send to
topic so we'll just grab that name there
make a new file send to topic
JS and we will go down here to this
other one this
is receive from subscription you're
going to notice this is very similar to
doing a q the difference is that you can
have multiple subscriptions consume the
same
stuff uh our CLI is done so we'll type
in a login um I can't remember what it
is so we'll hit enter here I know this
is the wrong way but I just can't
remember what it is I want used device
code that's what it is so I'll go ahead
and grab this and I'll just hit contrl C
to exit out of that and then paste that
in there and then we'll do it the way
that we actually want to do it so then
we will go ahead and grab grab this for
device
login we will provide the code AS
suggested
here we will hit
continue we will close
this and it will say that we are
authenticated so we are now
authenticated we can use a or the Azure
c
um I don't know if we need the CLI well
we have it anyway at least we had to
authenticate so at least that was out of
the way I'm not sure if we're actually
going to use the CLI in this one um but
what we'll do is go to the resource
here and we want to create a topic this
time around and I'm going to call this
my topic we have a topic size between 1
to five you have a TTL you can do U make
sure there aren't duplicates we're going
to go ahead and create this
topic okay so just like last time we
need to install install a couple things
so if we go to the top here there should
be like an npm install here it is npm
install service bus so we'll paste that
on in there we'll need ourv so look upv
again and we will just install npm
install. EnV for environment variables
hit enter we'll create ourselves a newv
file and we will need to look at what
environment variables we are going to
need so uh looks like we didn't copy the
send to topic content at least I didn't
so we will go back over to here and go
up here and get sent to topic paste that
on in there we'll go all the way to the
top and I'm looking for what we need
here so here we have one which is
connection string
whoops did not mean to delete all that
so we'll hit process EnV connection
string and we have to spell it right or
it's going to have a
problem and then we have process EnV
topic name and I think in this one it
actually also has subscription so we'll
have to have a third one so I'm just
going to copy these two over so I'm to
type it 100
times and this one will
be process EnV subscription name you're
noticing I'm not having the um semicolon
that is optional in JavaScript so it
won't break anything if I don't have
them there subscription name
and so these are the three that we'll
need I'm going to just split this to
make my life a little bit easier and I'm
just going to copy this here
paste not exactly how I wanted to paste
it but that's totally
fine I'm going to copy
this I don't think we made a
subscription yet but I know we're going
to call it my subscription to make our
lives easy so we'll say my
topic my
subscription and we'll grab this in a
moment so we'll go back over
to Azure we got too many tabs open here
while we're here we might as well go
grab this code um before we go back to
Azure so I'm going grab grab this EMV
config that is going to load our
configur uh configuration environments
so we go to the top here paste that on
in there for both
files again best practice never to
hardcode your values always pass it in
like that with environment variables
we'll go back to our service bus the
first thing we need well we made a topic
we're going to need a subcription so we
go to topic here and click into it we
can create ourselves a subscription so
we'll go here we'll say my subscription
notice we have Max delivery count we
have to set this between a value of 1
and 2,000 I'm going to say 12 for fun we
can set the idle notice here if we want
to um have first in first out we would
checkbox enable sessions we're going to
leave that alone does not matter too
much for our demo so we'll go ahead and
create that subscription it is created
now what I need you to do is go back to
the the service bus topic namespace and
from there on the left hand side we're
going to Shared access policies we're
going to click into the root manage
shared access we're going to grab the
primary connection string key the
secondary would work too it's just a
second optional one because they always
give you a two we'll paste that on in
there and if this is all correct these
should just work so now what we'll do is
type in
node um actually we did want the CI
installed because I wanted to show you
uh that there was stuff in the queue
whereas with um storage queue when we're
doing Azure storage que I couldn't show
you because um I just didn't know of a
command I believe at least I think that
was the case but any we'll take a look
and see what we can see okay um
so actually we didn't do it at any time
I wonder which one I did that for let's
just double check here I have um off
screen here
somewhere my instructions because I
wrote it for one of these maybe it was
for the que that we did
it
yeah I didn't do the last one but I did
an Azure service bus Q show and the idea
was to show you that there was a message
count 10 so you could see the que but I
think that since we saw it in the UI
just wasn't too worried about it now did
I do it for this one I'm not sure yeah
we do a topic show so we'll do that for
fun but first we need to insert our
messages which are part of the topic
send I don't think we read through these
so let's just quickly read they look
very very similar to the last one so you
have your messages that you want to send
you create your yourself a client uh you
create yourself a sender you create a
batch message send message like it's
basically
identical like I can't even tell the
difference here except here we're
supplying a topic name so
um I mean I see it
here ah here create Center the topic
name is specified there so I just
imagine that instead of providing a
topic name you provide the Q name and
that's how it knows the difference but
anyway what we'll do is go ahead and
execute this code we'll say node sent to
topic uh
JS okay and so it sent the stuff now we
didn't do this last time so let's do it
this time around so we'll type in Azure
service bus topic show um and here we'll
need to set the resource Group so this
was called I don't know let's go take a
look here what is our service group
called it is called AZ
204 bring that down a bit here
a 20
for service bus topic we need to specify
the
namespace name so that's just called
service bus topic hyphen
7238 49 because we couldn't get the
number we want and then we need to
specify the name so I assume it's the
name of the topic so the top is my topic
and I'll
enter and it says service bus name is
misspelled or not recognized by the
service you mean service
bus yeah I got to spell that right
enter and that looks fine but I just
want to specify it as output yaml just
hit up on your keyboard if you want to
go back to those previous commands with
enter so this is a little bit easier to
read and so what we're looking for here
is just kind of like the message
count does it show us here we
subscription count
I don't see it so I guess it's not
visible in the same way as uh the que is
like if we did this and we didn't do in
the last one it would we just saw like
that message count there but let's take
a look at what we can see in the CLI to
just see what information or a UI that
or portal so we can see some information
here so we have one subscription here
we'll click into
here um we have Max size incoming
request
um yeah I don't really see it message
count 10 Max delivery count
12 okay so I guess there was 10 and
that's the 12 so I guess that's where
it's being counted let's go run the
other one to receive I'm going to just
double check to make sure that we set
those we did that's all good so we'll
type in node receive if you're wondering
how I'm Auto completing without typing
that I just hit tab on my keyboard so
it's receiving
those good and that finish I'm going to
go hit refresh see if there's any
difference here notice that the message
counted zero so when the topics were
there it was held in the subscription
saying 10 is here and they've yet to be
delivered when we ran it they were
received and so that number cleared out
that's all we really need to learn for
um uh topics so we are done with topics
so let's make our way over to Resource
groups and we'll go over to our service
bus
topic go ahead and delete this here
delete there it is deleting we are all
good to go um and you know just as
always don't ever trust Azure to delete
these things come back and check in 3
four minutes make sure it's deleted so
you just don't have things lingering
around um but uh yeah there you
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro in this section we're diving into
Azure event grid Azure event grid is a
service that allows you to manage event
routing from any source to any
destination event grid provides a simple
and strong customizable event delivery
process that allows you to manage at a
minimum level which types of events will
be received as well as which subscribers
will receive those events one of event
grid strengths is its event fan out
capability combined with 24-hour retry
reliability ensuring your events are
consistently delivered it's a
costeffective serverless solution with
dynamic scalability making it an
excellent choice for businesses of all
sizes asure event grid is ideal in
event-driven architectures you can
subscribe to events from Azure resources
and then route them to an event handler
or webbook Furthermore with custom
topics you have the flexibility to craft
and publish your own events within your
event grid so that's an overview of
azure event
grid the next topic will be covering our
event sources and handlers in Azure
event grid Azure event grid is divided
into two categories event sources and
event handlers azure's event grid
operates as a central Hub coordinating
between various event sources and event
handlers on the side of event sources
which are services that emit data we
have blob storage signal R resource
groups Azure app configuration
subscription Azure machine learning
event how Azure communication Services
media service Azure cash for Ries iot
Hub Cloud events service bus Azure
policy Azure Maps custom events and
Azure container registry these sources
send their data to the event grid on the
other end we have event handlers which
are the services that receive and act
upon this data the serverless code
category involves functions for workflow
and integration the services user
service bus and logic apps buffering and
competing consumers handle the influx of
data through event Hub and storage queue
additionally there are other services
and applications which incompass hybrid
connections web sockets web hooks
Automation and essentially any service
or application
these handlers effectively process or
route the data sent by the event sources
through event grid enabling a seamless
flow of information across Azure
Services the next topic will be going
over are the key concepts of azure event
grid domains are used to group event
grid topics that are related to the same
application for easier management topics
these serve as the destinations to which
events are dispatched system topics
Azure services offer these built-in
topics in contrast custom topics pertain
to individual applications and
thirdparty topics additionally partner
events enable thirdparty software as a
service providers to broadcast events
events these encapsulate specific
occurrences within a service Publishers
is the service that published The Event
Event sources are where the event took
place event subscriptions are the
mechanism that routes the events event
subscription expiration this allows
users to designate a lifespan for their
event subscriptions after which they
become valid event handlers these are
the applications or Services tailored to
process or act upon the received events
event delivery is the delivery of events
and batches or a single events batching
is the sending of a group of events in a
single request overall these are the key
concepts of azure event
[Music]
grid hey this is angre Brown from exam
Pro and we're going to take a look at
event grid Basics so let's get to it so
the first thing we're going to want to
do is we're going to search up
subscriptions because we're going to
need to make sure that in uh like in
order for us to use aent grid that we
have it turned on and so we'll go into
our subscription and we're going to go
under um resource
providers resource
providers ah there it is and this is all
the stuff that is registered all the
providers that are registered so what
we're doing is just make making sure
that event grid is turned on because
that one's not always turned on by
default and just make sure that it's
registered okay so you'll know that it's
registered because it'll have a green uh
check mark here and it'll say registered
and so once that is done we can proceed
to create a storage account because
we're going to integrate a storage
account into our event grid so we we'll
do is create a new storage account and
we're going to create a new Resource
Group I'm going to call this Resource
Group event grid
Basics and we're going to name our
storage account event
event grid
Basics all right and uh yes you can have
hyphens you can't have anything else um
and we'll just make sure we spelled that
right
Event Event grid Basics I can't remember
if these are fully qualified domains if
they are you might have to add some
numbers on the end there but it is what
it is we're doing uh USC I mean it just
randomizes every time but this is where
you should probably set it to we have
standard premium we'll leave it as
standard and everything else seems fine
so we'll go ahead and create review and
create and then it's going to allow us
to review we'll go ahead and hit create
and it's going to create the resource
Group here we'll just wait for it finish
uh deploying and then we'll go into the
resource all right looks like it is
finished deploying so we're going to go
ahead and go to that resource we're
going to go to containers and we're
going to have to create a couple
containers the first the first one is
going to be called basic we're going to
leave it as uh private just make sure
it's basic not Basics and and we'll
create another container called basic
alt the idea is that we're going to use
an event Grid in order to move one file
from one storage account to another uh
and that's going to be facilitated by
log uh via a logic app because that's
going to be the easiest way to use event
grid um so what I want you to do is
search for logic apps up here and we're
going to go ahead and add a new logic
app and what we want to do is choose our
Resource Group and we'll just go event
grid Basics here
uh we are going to name uh this event
grid
Basics um maybe we'll do LG to indicate
that it is a logic app or LG maybe uh L
yeah LG is fine like short for logic and
from here we have a workflow or a Docker
container we're going to stick with a
workflow um just to knock on wood we're
going to just put in the same region as
our um storage account so East US we
have standard consumption I'd rather do
consumption for this um so you pay only
as much as you use because we don't need
Enterprise level service application
here we just need a consumption model
we're going to leave this uh to disable
so that is totally fine there's nothing
else to do here so we'll go review plus
create and we'll go ahead and create
this logic app and we just have to wait
for this to finish
deploying all right so that should have
been very very quick like under uh 10
seconds there
so we've gone into the resource I just
click go to the resource and so we have
this uh very fun interface and so what
we need to do is start with a common
trigger there's a few different ways to
get to it but there should be something
on the front
here uh I don't know if they redesigned
this
recently so I'm just going to search
start with a comment oh yeah it's up
here okay I'm being silly um and so what
we want to do is because this is an
event grid follow along we want to click
on when an event grid
occurs and so this is the designer where
we can make things a lot easier for
ourself and so we're going to have to
first sign in to authenticate so I'm
this is my tenant exam Pro Training Inc
so we'll go ahead and get connected
there just give it a moment we'll select
Andrew Brown which is totally fine and
now that is connected so that is great
so once we are signed in we can click
continue and we're going to go ahead and
add select our subscription here um and
we need to choose a resource here so I
guess in this case it's going to be
event
grid event
Grid
or could have swore yeah yeah I think
that's what we want to do let me just
double check here oh you know what it's
just not for some reason I'm I'm
searching it's not Auto completing
properly okay I just wasn't sure there
and as far as I can remember this would
be probably an event grid
topic and then we need to give this a
resource name
so
um let me just think about this for a
moment okay all right so I think I
understand where my confusion was it was
because we click continue and I never I
didn't see event crit anymore so I
thought we had to configure it when it
was already configured right so this is
where we were
so we're not we at this stage like event
Grid's already hooked up so it's ready
to be triggered so this is the step that
follows into it which is where we want
to do our storage account so that's
where I was getting confused so we'll
choose our subscription here it's okay
you know if you ever get confused just
step uh step back a couple steps and
just double check what you're doing
happens to me all the time so um what we
want to do is actually um connect
storage uh storage accounts so we type
in storage accounts here great uh we'll
have that selected and then we need to
select our storage account so this one's
called event grid
Basics and then we're going to have to
enter in um some additional information
event type so we want to have it happen
when we add something to The Container
so the basic container so we'll do blob
created um and then from there we need
to actually filter out the information
so we need to add a new parameter and I
think we'll have to do it on the prefix
filter so a filter like whatever yeah so
that's probably a good idea CU then we
could place it into a particular place
and I believe that um there are very
specific uh filters that you can do for
this because if I
recall there's like standardized ones
yeah see here like it's always going to
be SL blob Services default containers
Etc and you'll know that because you
know if you read the documentation and
you have to do that stuff you'll figure
that out so I'm just just going to type
it by hand here blob Services default
containers and then we can put our
container name so basic uh and I believe
we have it without the S
there
so uh Services see I don't trust my
writing here I'm just going to copy
paste it
in okay and that looks good to me um so
I think that is what it needs to be so
we'll go ahead and hit the next
step and so the idea is anything in that
folder
uh like when something's added to that
folder then follow up with this
operation
right um and maybe before we do that we
should probably um you know observe that
this stuff works that's probably be a
good idea so what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to make my way back over to
our storage account so we'll just close
this tab here I'm going to open a new
tab and we're going to make our way over
to storage
accounts and we'll go event grid
Basics and we will go to
containers and we'll click into our
basic container because I want to just
see that this is working um and I'm
going to need a file upload so let me
just go grab an image really quick all
right so I just grabbed an image off the
internet so I just have data here but
before we upload we probably should save
what we have because if we don't save it
we're not going to be able to observe it
so I went back to logic app and we just
hit save in the top left corner so we'll
give it a moment to save and it looks
like it's saved now I'm just going to go
back over to here if we can um look at
some of the code that gets executed I'm
just trying to remember uh where it is
because once it executes we want to um
see what happened right so what I'll do
is I'm going to go all the way back over
here and I'm just going to go and drag
or actually I'll have the upload button
so I don't trust that that there and
I'll drag it onto here nope I still
don't trust it so what I'm going to do
is just click the files and I'm just
going to grab it this way and say open
and we'll do
upload and so that is now uploaded and
so there is somewhere where we can
observe um where stuff has happened so
I'm just trying to remember where it
is
[Music]
um I mean we could run the
trigger we yeah we probably should run
the trigger
right
run
I think it's running so we'll just give
it a moment
okay you know I was thinking about it it
doesn't make sense we shouldn't have to
run it because it should just happen
automatically I think it's on the
overview page ah okay so if we look here
we can see the Run history and so and
there's also trigger history of when the
things are triggered so we could we
could manually but it doesn't make sense
so I think this is the run that we just
did if we click into here yes this is
what it is so here we can see what what
has happened so if we expand it we can
see the inputs right so it's we have a
blob
created um it might show some
information so here we can see data yep
and it's a webp file and so it's gotten
this far through and so that's a great
way to kind of like debug so you can uh
logic run app you can do it each step
but right now we are using um event grid
to do that integration right we're just
doing through logic uh logic app because
it's a lot easier so now that we have
that what we should do is go back to our
designer and we're going to have to add
the follow-up step um so we have this oh
yeah okay so that's the first step event
grid doesn't show up there which is
weird but um so we have this step here
from our storage account and so the next
step what we want to do is put it into
another uh container so that will be the
tricky part
um so I'm just trying to remember what
we do so we'll hit next
step
and
um I think what we need to do is
initialize a variable first because
we're going to have to get some way to
grab the name of the string because if
we go back to our run over
here just give it a moment
here and we go enter a run again here
we need to extract some data to pass
along because there are some limitations
in terms of how Json gets passed along
or data gets passed along and so um what
we want is we just want this part of the
name we want to say take this name as
the identifier so that when we're
copying stuff over it will work and so
what we'll have to do is store that into
an intermediate variable so um we'll
just type in variables
here
and I'm just seeing ah yeah so they look
like this CU I can remember they might
be in the built-in yeah that looks a lot
better um and so we need a variable and
it's an initialized variable and we're
going to name this file
name and this is a string of course and
now we need to insert the value so in
here what we need to do is write an
expression in order to extract that
information out
um so what we'll do is go to the
expression Tab and over here you can see
we have all sorts of Expressions that we
can use so going to type in last
parentheses and then in there we'll do
split
parenthesis and then what we're looking
for is trigger
body and then we'll do question
mark Square
braces single quotations subject how did
I know how to do that I I looked it up I
looked it up somewhere and you know I
just don't feel like there's much uh
reason to to teach this part because uh
you I mean if you really need to know
you can go here um and learn all about
it but a lot of times like if you need
something you can just say I need this
kind of function somebody's already done
it right because there's so many common
use cases so I probably search something
like how do I get the name out of the
the thing you know like for the blob and
somebody had that there but it makes
sense to me so let's hit okay here and
it should turn purple because it is dime
expression if you type it in here it
probably won't work correctly you have
to type it in here and then hit okay so
it shows up like that uh but you notice
we typed in like trigger body so if we
go back over to our run here um this is
the body here so when they say trigger
body they're talking about here and then
it was just grabbing that subject line
there all right um so that would be the
second step and that gets it into a
variable but the next part is we need to
actually um
get the blob content and then insert it
and then create a new blob so what we'll
do is hit next step and we'll type in
Blob and see if we can find anything
here and from here we need to get the
get Blob content using path version
two so I'm just going to scroll down
here and take a look for it there it is
based on the
path and we'll go down here and um
um I guess it would be access key oh
because we're setting up a connection
for the first time
so enter name for
connection
um I know what the storage account is
but what is the connection connection
name I do not remember give me two
seconds okay there wasn't much to help
me here cuz what I remember before was
that you click it and you'd authenticate
it like the event grid but it's not
doing that SoBe maybe we just have to
name it something so I don't know we'll
just say Azure storage account maybe it
just wants a
name maybe it doesn't really
matter oh yeah like they sign in that's
what I want so connection name yeah so
we'll say uh you know storage account
event
grid
okay because if we can just single sign
on let's do that that's super
easy and we'll click that there
okay so this is starting to look how I
expect it to look and so we need the
storage account name I don't know why
it's not showing me any names here but
that's okay we'll just go over back to
our storage account here and it's called
event grid
Basics so we'll type in event grid
Basics event grid
basics
uh that's custom value
sure I mean that's what its name is I'm
not sure why it's not autocom
completing um but here what we need to
do is we need to provide the path so
it's going to be for SL basic ah and so
now there's our environment V or that
variable so we'll just click that there
so that will make it super super
easy now notice that it is showing basic
now so I just clicked here the folder we
typed it in manually but we could have
clicked uh here and then put the
environment variable in or the uh this
this initialized variable in here but I
did type that manually and it still did
work correctly so we are okay here infer
the content type sure why not um it
doesn't matter if they do um so this
gets the content so now this gets the
path and so the next thing is actually
to create the blob you can't like do an
easy clone you have to do it this um
intermediate step that's just how it
works um and so what we'll need to do is
go to our built-in once here we'll type
in Blob again maybe
standard and this time we want to create
a
blob so there it is uh block blob no we
just want a
blob and so what we'll do is um I guess
we have to connect again I'm surprised
it's not showing the name yeah it's just
the name that's fine so we'll go back
over
here I just don't want to type it wrong
so we'll just copy paste in event grid
Basics event grid Basics enter custom
value because it's giving us so much
trouble for no particular reason make
sure there's no space on the end there
there now it works fine um and in this
case what we want is basic
alt and the blob name can be the file
name which is totally
fine and the blob content will be the
file
content and I don't think we need
anything else so what we'll do is go
ahead and click off and we will
save all right so that's just the way
we're going to have to do it um so what
we can do is go back to our
overview and we'll go back to our basic
folder and we'll delete data say
okay and we'll go
upload we'll select our file again we'll
grab it we will upload and then we will
make our way back over to our logic
app close this tab here so we don't get
too mixed up refresh the page and it
failed so it failed for some reason so
something has not been configured
correctly it failed on the initialized
variable so something's wrong there so
unable to process the template language
expression in the actions initialized
variable uh inputs at line Z column zero
template function split is not defined
is not valid so it's possible I just
spelled it wrong so what we'll do is go
back to our event grid we'll go back to
our logic app designer here initialize
variable we will click
it and we probably just spiled it
wrong
spilt spilt what if we do lit spilt
split um so if that's wrong we'll just
scroll on down and we'll just take a
look
I could have swore that it autoc
completed for
us oh you know what it is spelled wrong
it should be SP i l t
spoit all right and I'm just double
checking to see if there's any other
problems here no looks fine to me so go
ahead and say update we will save it in
the top left corner we'll go back we'll
delete our file here we'll say okay and
we'll have to select a new file we'll
click open just double check make sure
that's been saved it looks like it's
been saved we'll hit upload we'll go
back to our overview page it's already
running super fast by the way and we'll
click into it and we'll see if we get
any other failure so there's another
failure that's totally okay so we'll
just expand it this request is not
authorized to perform this operation
using the
permissions um so it does not like the
permissions I gave it totally fine so we
will go back to our app
designer we will go to this second step
here even though it did select this
properly so we'll change the
connection uh I guess we'll add a new
one so we did ad integrated oh let's do
managed identity you you must enable
managed identities in the logic app to
use manage identities authentication you
must Grant required access to the
identity in the Target room
resource
okay uh there is an identity tab so we
can go over there and take a look there
quickly I don't remember it being that
hard to do uh system assign manage
identities restricted to one person one
person resource is tied to life cycle
you can grant permissions etc
etc
um can we just turn that on and hit
save well it can be granted access
resources protected by a sure let's give
it a go
all right so um it seems like we have to
assign some Ro
stuff so we can try and assign a role um
can we do the subscription
[Music]
level
contributor
okay there's few different ways you can
authenticate so hopefully this will be
the EAS way to do it uh we'll refresh
here did assign
it and I don't think it said
it all right so give me a moment and let
me see what I can figure out
okay you know what just to make this
easier I think what we should do is just
do the access key cuz that seems like
the easiest way to do it I was just
hoping that we could have you know just
did a simple sign in here but it's not a
big deal so we'll hit change connection
we're going to add a new connection just
say storage account um
Event Event
grid um key and so this is going to want
the aure storage account name so this
one will be the name of the storage
account if we can find it it's called
event grid
Basics and then we need the Azure
storage account access
key so there's probably a tab called
keys yep and we will show the key and we
will copy the
key if I don't have to pass along keys I
like to not do that please check your
account info again uh storage account
access key should be a correct base 64
encoded string come on give me a break
here I am doing what you asked me to
do so we will try this
again this thing just hates me today
give me a second okay you know what it
was really short so I really don't trust
it so let's just do I just cleared it
out there I didn't do anything else what
we're going to do is go back here click
the copy and then rightclick
and paste that's so much longer okay
that has to be the right key we'll hit
create and we'll give it a
moment okay great so that's for that
one um but this has to have the right
connection as well so what we'll do is
just change the
connection you have a few here e um and
the one we want
is the one that's valid so we'll go to
this one down below as you can see few
attempts here and we'll save it and
we'll go
back to our overview here I'm just going
to close that Tab out we're going to
close this out we're going to go back
into here we're going to go into our
containers we're going to go into our
basic we're going to go ahead and delete
this we'll say
okay and we will upload a new file we
will choose the new file we'll choose
data upload it we'll go back over here
here and I want to see the latest run
here we'll give this a
refresh is it running it looks like it's
running it's hard because this one looks
like it just failed and and now the the
messaging is getting really muddy
here what is it doing so we'll click off
here sometimes the portal is a bit funny
is it just triggering over and over
again did we make an infinite Loop
uhoh okay think we have a problem
here what if we go here is it basic or
it's basic
alt this one's
basic
so what's the
problem we'll
refresh failed why did it
fail
conflict another active upload session
exists please retry after some time
okay uh well let's just go take a look
here go back it's here so it's it's
here uh so it clearly has worked why
it's triggering multiple times I don't
know um don't particularly like
that there we go I'm just go ahead and
delete this one
here and it's just it's just going over
and over and over again so there's
something wrong with my
workflow
so this looks fine to me that looks fine
to
me maybe it's triggering oh you know
what the the parameters out of here so
this is supposed to have a prefix here
so what's happening is that it's
triggering on anytime a basic one is set
up or basic alt one and it's just stuck
in an infinite Loop which is really
really bad um so we did do this earlier
but for whatever reason um the changes
still are not here so what we'll need to
do is set up that prefix so what we'll
do is type in
Blob Services
default
containers basic because we really don't
want to trigger it on any but that that
uh container there and uh
did it save
it it doesn't look yeah I mean it should
be there so what we'll do is go
ahead like why is it not
filtering oh um I guess it wants to
filter based on
name but we gave it its name
so I'm not sure what else
we would have to type
there okay
um I'm just going to put um dot it's the
prefix filter so data I guess I don't
know like it's not letting me save okay
there we go we'll save that I just want
to stop the infinite Loop there for a
moment so we'll go back over to the
overview and we'll just make sure we're
not uh running up our bill
here and I'm just refreshing I just want
to see it's not triggering anymore so it
stopped triggering which is good and
we'll go back over to here and we'll
look at this prefix filter because I I
don't remember having to do this so a
filter like sample etc etc so we'll type
it in again I guess blob Services
default containers
basic
it's very oddd because like we typed it
oh you know what I probably did I typed
in the the filter parameter here we're
supposed to add it then put it in there
so it's just me getting confused by the
UI silly me okay so what we'll do is go
back to the overview and this time we
just want to see it trigger once so we
go back to basic alt we'll go ahead and
delete this we'll say okay and we'll go
back to our vent grid we go in or our
event grid our basic our basic container
we're going to go ahead and delete
delete uh data here again and we're
going to go upload one more
time it's actually good that we had that
problem because I got to show you uh why
filters are so important um when we're
dealing with uh the app logic there um
or logic apps so we'll go ahead and hit
upload we'll go make our way back over
here we're going to give this a refresh
and now we have a new one and it only
happened once and that's what we wanted
to happen so we'll go back over to
here and we go to basic alt there it is
so that's a means to which we can use
event grid to integrate stuff you can
see logic app is extremely useful for
developers uh building uh all sorts of
tools uh but we are all done here and
what we'll do is make our way over to
our Resource Group and we are going to
just go ahead and clean up so we'll go
into event grid Basics and we'll go
ahead and delete this Resource
Group
there we go and it's going to go ahead
and delete there uh yeah and there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure event Hub Azure event Hub
serves as a critical component for event
ingestion capable of consuming millions
of events from mirriad sources and
processing them in real time or via
micro batching its potent Auto inflate
feature automatic scales throughput
units to accommodate varying demands
ensuring seamless processing even during
traffic spikes notably Azure event Hub
offers seamless integration with Apache
cafka applications and clients Bridging
the capabilities of both
platforms Azure event Hub helps you
build your big data pipeline to analyze
logging anomalies user and device
Telemetry where you only pay for what
you use breaking down the key concepts
of azure event Hub Nam space is an
endpoint for receiving and distributing
events to event hubs event Hub is where
your events will be delivered event Hub
cluster is a dedicated event Hub with a
99.99% SLA event Hub capture allows you
to automatically capture and save
streaming events events hubs for Apache
Kafka event Hub and points are
compatible with Apache cafka event
Publishers or applications or services
that publish events to an event Hub
publisher policy is a unique IDE used to
identify Publishers partitions are used
to organize the sequence of events in an
event Hub event consumers or
applications or services that read
events from an event Hub consumer group
enable consuming applications to each
have a separate view of the event stream
stream offset holds the position of an
event inside a partition checkpointing
is the process of distinguishing between
read and unread
events diving into scaling with Azure
event Hub Auto inflate a dynamic feature
that enables automatic scaling up to the
Pinnacle of tus predicated on traffic
exigencies however it's worth noting
that this feature is not accessible
within the basic pricing tier the image
showcases various configuration options
related to Azure event Hub pricing tier
the standard tier is selected priced at
approximately $22 USD per throughput
unit monthly other plans can be browsed
for more features throughput units the
selected number is one in Azure event
Hub throughput units dictate the events
process per second and related data
volume Auto inflate maximum throughput
units the maximum number of throughput
units that can be scaled to using the
auto inflate feature is set to
12 the next topic will be covering are
the pricing tiers for Azure event Hub
plans and their key features basic Plan
cost 1 cent divided by hour for every
throughput unit data input charges 2
cents for every million events storage
holds up to 84 GB of data data hold time
keeps data for only one day does not
offer capture Apache Kafka schem of
registry or extended retention standard
Plan cost 3 cents divided hour per two
data input same cost as Basic 2 cents
per million events capture available at
an additional $73 divided by month for
each two storage same as basic 84 GB
data hold time keeps data for 7 Days
offers Apache Kafka and schem of
registry however it lacks extended
retention Premium plan cost a bit
pricier at
$123 divided hour but now it's for every
processing unit data input included in
the plan no extra cost capture included
as well storage a lot more space with 1
terab for each poo data whole time
retains data for a longer 90 days offers
Apache CFA schema registry and also has
extended retention at 12 cents GB month
with 1 terabyte already included
dedicated Plan cost the highest at
$684 divided our for each capacity unit
data input included in the plan no extra
cost capture also included storage huge
space with 10 terab for each CU data
hold time holds data for 90 days same as
premium offers all the features of
premium and its extended retention is
also at 12 cents GB month but generously
includes 10 terabytes terms capacity
Unit A measure of capacity for the
dedicated plan Processing Unit A measure
of capacity for the Premium plan serit
Unit A measure of capacity for both
basic and standard
plans
the next thing we'll be going over is
the producer in Azure event Hub also
known as the publisher the producer is
responsible for sending data to the
stream Publishers can publish events
using the following protocols https the
majority of azure sdks prefer https amqp
1.0 Advanced message queuing protocol
taffa protocol compatible with the
Apache CFA ecosystem generally
developers use the Azure SDK for
publishing events you can publish an
event either one at a time events can be
published individually or batches
multiple events can be grouped and
published together however there's a
size limit of 1 Megabyte for both
individual and batched events any event
or batch exceeding this limit will be
rejected for authorization Publishers
use either Azure ad with oo2 issued JWT
tokens or shared access
signature comparison https versus amqp
for publishing events amqp requires the
establishment of a persistent by
directional socket in addition to
transport level security or SSL TLS amqp
is higher Network costs when
initializing the session amqp is higher
performance for frequent Publishers and
can achieve much lower latencies when
used with a synchronous publishing code
https requires additional TLS overhead
for every request publisher policies
event hubs enables granular control over
event Publishers through publisher
policies publisher policies are runtime
features designed to facilitate large
numbers of independent event Publishers
with Publisher policies each publisher
uses its own unique identifier when
publishing events to an event Hub
ensuring that events are properly
segregated authenticated and managed for
each individual Source enhancing
security and traceability within the
system the next topic we'll be covering
is a consumer in Azure event Hub the
Azure event Hub consumer also commonly
referred to as a reader is responsible
for receiving and processing data from
the the stream connection protocol all
event hubs consumers Connect using the
amqp 1.0 protocol as events become
available they are delivered through
this session this eliminates the need
for the client to continuously check or
pull for the availability of new data a
consumer group represents a particular
view like a state position or offset of
an entire event Hub consumer groups
enable multiple consuming applications
to each have a separate view of the
event stream and to read the stream
independently at their own pace and with
their own offsets
typically in a stream processing
architecture each Downstream application
equates to a consumer group there's
always a default consumer group in an
event Hub and you can create up to the
maximum number of consumer groups for
the corresponding pricing tier there can
be at most five concurrent readers on a
partition per consumer group however
it's recommended that there's only one
active receiver on a partition per
consumer group some clients offered by
the Azure sdks are intelligent consumer
agents that automatically manage the
details of ensuring that each partition
has a single reader and that all
partitions for an event Hub are being
read from this allows your code to focus
on processing the events being read from
the event Hub so it can ignore many of
the details of the partitions so that's
an overview of a consumer in Azure event
[Music]
Hub next let's talk about offsets in
Azure event Hub in the realm of azure
event Hub the term offset refers to the
position of an event within a specific
partition offsets enables a consumer to
specify a point in the event stream for
from which they want to begin reading
events you have the option to specify
the offset either as a distinct
timestamp or as a numerical offset value
consumers are responsible for storing
their own offset values outside of the
event Hub service every event situated
within a partition comes equipped with
an
offset Azure event Hub checkpointing
checkpointing is a process by which
readers Mark or commit their position
within a partition event sequence
checkpointing is the responsibility of
the consumer and occurs on a per
partition basis within a cons consumer
group the consumer is fully responsible
for checkpointing this means that for
each consumer group every individual
partition reader must monitor its
ongoing position within the event stream
and notify the event Hub service once it
recognizes the data stream to be
complete or processed so that's an
overview of offsets in Azure event
Hub the next topic we'll be covering is
the event retention for Azure event Hub
published events are removed from an
vent Hub based on a configurable
timebase retention policy the default
value in shortest possible retention
period is 1 hour for event Hub standard
the maximum retention period is 7 days
for event hubs premium and dedicated the
maximum retention period is 90 days if
you change the retention period it
applies to all messages including
messages that are already in the event
Hub it's important to note that
individual events cannot be explicitly
deleted the reason for event hubs limit
on data retention based on time is to
prevent large volumes of historic
customer data getting trapped in a deep
store that is only indexed by a
timestamp and only allows for sequential
access if you need to Archive events
beyond the allowed retention period you
can have them automatically stored in
Azure storage or Azure data Lake by
turning on the event hub's capture
feature if you need to search or analyze
such deep archives you can easily import
them into Azure synaps or other similar
stores and analytics platforms so that's
an overview of vent retention for Azure
event
hub
let's break down a comparison between
event grid event Hub and service bus
event grid event Hub and service bus all
event driven services for application
integration and use an event bus as
means to work with event data Azure
event grid provides the backbone for
event-driven architectures without the
need for infrastructure management Azure
service to service communication
primarily designed for communication
between various Azure Services
dynamically scalable cost efficient and
guarantees at least once delivery of an
event Azure event Hub streaming data
ideal for ingesting massive amounts of
streaming data low latency processes
events with minimal delay High
throughput capable of receiving and
processing millions of events every
second and guarantees at least once
delivery of an event Azure service bus
supports both cues and publish subscribe
patterns making it suitable for a range
of web applications reliable as
synchronous message delivery that
requires in advanced messaging features
like first in and first out batching
sessions transactions dead lettering
temporal control routing and filtering
and duplicate detection guarantees at
least once delivery of a message and
offers an optional feature to ensure
messages are delivered in sequence the
breakdown highlights the differences
between Azure event grid event Hub and
service bus showcasing their unique
strengths tailored to different
[Music]
scenarios hey this is angrew Brown from
exam Pro and this fall along we are
going to learn all about Azure event Hub
uh so what I want you to do is go to the
top here and type in event Hub and we
are going to create ourselves a new
event Hub uh namespace so we'll go here
and hit create and we'll create a new
Resource Group as we always do and call
it my event Hub and then for the
namespace name we'll say um my event Hub
if it doesn't let you do that you'll
have to put some numbers on the end I'm
just putting some numbers here because
often these are taken
doesn't matter what location is just
choose whichever one we're going go with
basic because there's not a huge
difference between the pricing terms in
terms of feature sets that we want to
use today so we'll go ahead and create
this namespace so we'll give it a moment
and we'll go ahead and hit
create and then we'll just wait for this
namespace to provision all right so
after waiting about a couple minutes
there our namespace is deployed we're
going to go ahead and create our CES and
event Hub I'm going to call this one My
Hub we'll go ahead and hit review and
create
and we'll create and these create very
very quickly so we're not going to have
to wait too long we need to set some
shared access policies here so I'm going
to go into the Hub here we going to hit
manage I call this my SAS SAS Shar
access policy and there we will now have
the ability to have a primary key and
connection key so we can actually
connect uh to it so what we're going to
do is go to GitHub and I want to create
a new
Repository and we'll go ahead
here and we'll go down below go to exam
Pro we'll say my event Hub that's
already taken because I've done this
before so for M I'm going to call it new
and we'll go down to private we're going
to use nodejs so we'll just type in
nodejs so that it ignores the node
modules you're going to want to have git
pod or a visual studio code installed on
your computer the easiest way is
honestly get pod because these
environments are temporary and it's free
to uh utilize it so if you can go get
the Chrome extension or uh if you don't
want to install the Chrome extension all
you got to do is attach this to the end
of the repo to launch a GitHub or git
pod environment so I'll give that a
moment to
launch and there we go so I do have some
code uh for
this so I'm just looking for it off
screen
here and uh we're going to need to have
a couple files here we're going to need
a new file called send JS and we're
going to need a new file here called
receive Js
I'm not typing the full word receive
because I'm always really bad at
spelling it so I'm just trying to save
myself some
trouble and uh we're also going to have
to initialize a
new package Json file so there we go and
we're going to have to get um a couple
things installed yeah so we'll need mpm
install Azure Event Event
hubs Azure storage blob Azure event
hubs
checkpoint store
blob save Dev and it make our lives a
bit easier seems like I typed something
wrong here I'll just hit up I forgot the
Ford slash
here and so we'll just go event
Hub um Azure
JavaScript because I believe
yeah I kind of use this one but I
modified it to make it a little bit
easier I think this is the one I was
doing no I don't think so
tutorial might be this
one yeah it looks like this um so this
is just the JavaScript there so for send
we will grab this code here we're not
going to do exactly the way they do it
but pretty close and then there is a
receive code so we'll go down below and
we'll grab this as you can see there's a
lot going on
here
that will be our receive couple things
we need to properly set so these will be
all environment variables so what we'll
do is go to the top here and we'll just
do constant process requires process
that's going to allow us to import our
environment
variables so we just
say copy let's just save that we'll
paste that in there as well and then
this is where we need to replace all
environment variables as you can see I
always have things pcking up on me here
so just close my teams
out and just Lin to make this a little
bit
faster so default will be what we'll
keep here um this will be our storage
connection
string say process
EnV uh
storage connection
string then this one will be process
EnV container
name then we need process EnV event Hub
name and up here we'll have process
EnV um event Hub connection string and
then we'll go over to our send here
we'll do something very similar so
process
EnV event Hub connection string and then
we'll have process EnV event
Hub
name so we need to set all of these I'm
just going to copy this for a moment
here I'm going to make a new
file file new file sure it doesn't
really matter we're just using this as a
quick scratch pad and so uh what I want
to do here is just delete out this
part and we're going to do export on the
end here we'll take out this one
here and the idea is that we'll just set
them all here and then we will
make our lives a little bit easier when
we have to mass set Mass set these so we
do have the connection string because we
saw it over here so we we'll grab the
primary one doesn't matter which one
primary secondary and that is for
the uh vent Hub we called
[Music]
the the vent Hub was called My Hub I
believe we'll just double check what the
Hub was called yeah it's called My Hub
up there we'll need a storage account so
what I'm going to do wish this thing we
get out of here get out of here I'm not
I'm not trying to save a freaking file
there we go hit escape a bunch of times
and we'll go back here and we'll create
ourselves a new storage account I'm
actually make this in a new tab so we
can see what we're
doing so we go over to storage
accounts and we'll create ourselveses a
new storage account we'll create this uh
storage account in the same name space
so we'll go down to my event Hub we'll
just say my um or we'll just say my
event Hub 8888 again you might have to
change it based on your standards but um
or like what is available to you we'll
go ahead and go review
create and for the container name uh
we'll probably just call
container maybe container
one we just have to wait for this to
create to grab that connection
string so this usually doesn't take too
long just a couple
seconds okay so there we are um we'll go
over to access keys and we'll grab the
connection string from here I believe
this one should work U let me just
double
check yeah I think this will work so
what we'll do is go back over here if it
doesn't we'll find out pretty soon and
we'll just generate out a a shared
policy uh we'll go ahead and paste that
on in
here and just double checking that this
is the correct one this looks identical
to that one that can't be correct so
we'll go back here this is the storage
account so we'll go oh I have to
actually hit the copy button that's what
it didn't do we'll go ahead and paste
that in and so theoretically this should
work so we'll go ahead and copy these
we'll drag our terminal up a bit we'll
paste these in
here and uh what I'll do is just double
check that they're here so we'll say EnV
GP event
Hub so those are both set and then we'll
do
storage that one is set and we'll do
container that one is set so these are
all in good shape for our storage
account we still have to create the
container so go here and create a new
container say container one we'll go
ahead and create that we'll make our way
back over here and then instead of just
having export we'll do GP EnV this is
just in case we have to restart the
environment for for any reason so that
these environment variables get exported
twice so we paste that in there I
believe those are all set go ahead and
hit enter on the last one there and
let's see if our code works so we'll do
Ascend um actually we have to set up two
scripts here so that we can actually
call them so I one call here is called
send this will be node send
JS and we'll have receive so re just
because I always spell receive wrong and
I just don't want to have to type it a
thousand times times we'll have that
there so now what we'll do is do mpm run
send see if that
works it says a batch of three events
have been sent we'll go and confirm that
over in event Hub if it worked if we go
to the overview it should show us some
messages were
received sometimes there's a bit of
delay so we'll just give it a teeny tiny
amount of time we'll hit refresh
here because we know we sent them but
while we're waiting for those to kind of
propagate what we'll go back here and
just kind of look at the code because we
did didn't really look at it so the way
it works is you are defining a client
and it will be the producer client um
and then down below so we say Okay a
producer is someone that produces events
it's very common in the messaging system
to have a producer and consumer we're
going to create a batch job and we're
going to add them all to the batch job
then we're going to send them all at
once and it's going to close and it'll
and it will complete and if there are
any errors it will alert us about it so
we'll go back over here and we'll do a
refresh so I want to see messages
messages would normally show up here so
since I don't trust it I'm just going to
run it again I mean clearly worked
because there was no
errors and we'll go back over here and
um not here but we'll go back here we'll
refresh and I'm just waiting to
see something
here
processing data this is like something
that's really powerful with
um vent Hub here
so still don't see the messages just
give me a second to debug this I've done
this lab like four times so it should
work but uh you know sometimes sometimes
it's trouble so just a
moment all right so I literally did
nothing and now it's actually showing up
in the uh messaging queue so you know or
The Hub the funnel uh so that's just
something you have to consider is that
sometimes you just have to be a little
bit patient let's see if we can go
receive those messages now by running
the other uh script so what I'm going to
do here is do mpm run
receive and it should receive the
messages as long as something isn't
typed incorrectly so we'll go back over
here we've seem to introduce a little
mistake so I'll go ahead and save that
we'll hit
up and it should receive the events so
it should print the three out so there
we go and so we are streaming that
through the consumer is technically um
Storage storage accounts but if we go to
the storage account there's nothing
really uh um intelligible in terms of
what's in here so like there are stuff
in here
checkpoints I guess it's saved to
checkpoint I personally don't know what
I'm looking at so I'm not exactly sure
what the point of doing that I guess
it's just saying the checkpoint is like
the last point it it wrote but if we
just take a look at the code here
quickly you can see this called consumer
so we hit consumer client there's a blob
check Point store then we have the
consumer client we are subscribing so
it's saying hey are there any events
let's consume them if there are no
events throw a console log so tell us
about it iterate through them then
update the checkpoint so move it to the
next Point um just say hey this is where
it is now and that's pretty much all it
wanted you to do we can go ahead and
save this code we so we'll say um event
Hub code doesn't matter what you name it
there we'll sync the changes and we'll
go ahead and clean up so we'll go back
to our resour resource groups we'll go
to vent Hub and we will then go and
delete this Resource Group and we'll go
here
and there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering the Azure Cloud adoption
framework Cloud adoption framework is a
white paper that is a step-by-step
process to help organizations plan and
migrate their workloads to Azure the
image outlines the Microsoft cloud
adoption framework for Azure a
systematic approach to transitioning to
the Azure Cloud the process is
categorized into stages defined strategy
here the focus is on understanding
motivations grasping the reasons for
cloud adoption business outcomes
identifying the desired results business
justification validating the moves
reasons first adoption project
kickstarting the cloud Journey plan this
stage includes rationalizing digital
estate evaluating current digital assets
initial organization alignment ensuring
everyone is aligned with the migration
goals skills Readiness Plan equipping
teams with necessary Cloud skills Cloud
adoption plan laying out a road map for
the cloud transition ready this phase
ensures preparedness Azure Readiness
guide preparing the environment for
Azure First Landing Zone setting up an
initial secure Azure environment
expanding the blueprint broadening the
Azure setup as per requirements best
practice validation ensuring adherence
to azure best practices adopt the
actionable phase where migrate existing
workloads or moved to Azure this entails
the first workload migration
understanding expanded scenarios
validating best practices and making
process improvements innovate transform
services in the Azure environment using
Innovation guides exploring new
scenarios validating best practices and
furthering process improvements govern
this is about oversight and management
establish a methodology and Benchmark
for governance Implement initial best
practices standards for Azure use
measure governance maturity how well
governance rules are followed manage the
deals with ongoing operations ensure
business commitments are met during the
transition set and assess the operations
Baseline determine operations maturity
gauge the efficiency of cloud
operations now let's take a look at the
security roles and responsibilities of
the Azure Cloud adoption framework
Business and Technology outcomes go and
results expected from security functions
security outcomes results an
organization aims for including
governance prevention and response role
types security leadership provides
security Direction and strategy security
architect designs and implements
security blueprints platform app
security Engineers ensures security of
platforms and applications security
operations manages real-time security
threats
responsibilities security leadership
sets security strategy security
architecture design secure systems
security compliance ensures adherence to
regulations policy and standards set
security policies posture management
manages overall security stance phases
of security implementation plan
identifies security needs build
Implement strategies including access
control and asset protection run manages
ongoing operations including prevention
and response feedback loop
continuous Improvement cycle and
security operations in summary the
framework offers a structured way to
transition to Azure ensuring strategy
alignment preparation adoption
governance and effective
management let's talk about the Azure
well architected framework Azure well
architected framework provides best
practices for Designing and implementing
Solutions on Azure it is structured
around five key pillars cost
optimization this pillar focuses on
maximizing the value delivered by
managing and controlling costs proper
cost management can lead to significant
savings without compromising function or
performance operational excellence this
emphasizes implementing and maintaining
system processes to ensure smooth and
efficient operations in a production
environment it involves routine
operations deployment practices
monitoring and iterative Improvement
performance efficiency refers to
ensuring that systems can scale
appropriately and adapt to varying loads
both expect and unexpected it's not just
about speed but ensuring resources are
used efficiently to meet performance
requirements reliability concerns the
system's ability to recover from
interruptions such as failures or
outages and continue to operate without
significant degradation this pillar
stresses designing for high availability
and disaster recovery security Central
to the Azure well architected framework
this pillar emphasizes the protection of
data and applications from potential
threats it covers a broad spectrum from
access controls and encryption to threat
detection and response strategies so
that's an overview of the Azure well
architected
framework the next topic we'll be
covering is azure migrate Azure migrate
offers a streamlined service for
migration modernization and optimization
on Azure it simplifies the pre-migration
processes like discovering assessing and
appropriately sizing on premises
resources for infrastructure data and
applications with an extensible
framework as migrate easily integrates
with thirdparty tools broadening its
range of supported scenarios here's what
it offers unified migration platform a
centralized portal to initiate execute
and monitor your Azure migration Journey
diverse tool set Azure migrate provides
a suite of tools for both assessment and
migration it features tools such as
Azure migrate Discovery and assessment
in migration and modernization
furthermore it seamlessly integrates
with other Azure Services tools and
third-party offerings from independent
software vendors
comprehensive migration and
modernization capabilities in the Azure
migrate Hub you can assess migrate and
modernize servers databases and web apps
assess and migrate on premises servers
web apps and SQL Server instances to
Azure databases analyze on premises SQL
Server instances and databases and
migrate them to Azure SQL on a VM Azure
SQL managed instance or Azure SQL
database web applications evaluate on
premises web applications and transition
them to the azzure app service or Azure
kubernets service virtual desktops
review your onsite virtual desktop
infrastructure and move it to Azure
virtual desktop data transfer
efficiently and affordably transfer vast
data volumes to Azure using Azure data
box products by using Azure migrate
organizations can streamline and
simplify their migration process reduce
downtime and improve the overall
efficiency and cost effectiveness of
their Cloud
migration
the next thing we'll be covering are the
integrated Tools in Azure migrate the
Azure migrate Hub includes these tools
Azure migrate Discovery and assessment
discover and assess servers including
SQL and web apps discover and assess on
premises servers running on VMware
hyperv and physical servers in
preparation for migration to Azure
migration and modernization migrate
servers migrate VMware VMS hyperv VMS
physical servers other virtualized
servers and public cloud VMS to Azure
data migration assistant assess SQL
Server databases for migration to Azure
SQL database Azure SQL managed instance
or Azure vm's running SQL Server data
migration assistant assesses SQL servers
identifies potential migration problems
unsupported features and suggest the
best path for database migration Azure
database migration service migrate on
premises databases to Azure vm's running
SQL Server Azure SQL database or SQL
managed instances is azure database
migration service is a managed service
for seamless migrations to Azure data
platforms with minimal downtime maneuver
assess servers mover is a SAS platform
that enhances business intelligence by
accurately depicting it environments
within a day web app migration assistant
assess on premises web apps and migrate
them to Azure Azure app service
migration assistant is a standalone tool
to assess on premises websites for
migration to Azure app service Azure
data box migrate offline data use Azure
datab box products to move large amounts
of offline data to Azure so that's an
overview of the integrated Tools in
Azure
migrate the next type of migration
solution we'll be going over is azure
database migration service Azure
database migration service is a fully
managed service that enables seamless
migrations from various database sources
to Azure data platforms with minimal
downtime it simplifies the process of
moving databases to the cloud and
reduces the risk associated with
migration the service supports various
Source database engines such as SQL
Server MySQL Oracle and postgressql and
targets Azure database platforms such as
Azure SQL database Azure SQL managed
instance and Azure database for posters
ql and
nql Azure database migration service
currently offers two versions database
migration service via Azure SQL
migration extension for Azure data
Studio Azure portal Powershell and Azure
CLI
database migration service via Azure
portal Powershell and Azure
CLI use cases migrations of on premises
databases to Azure SQL Services database
consolidation and migration to a single
platform in Azure Cloud bursting and
Disaster Recovery Solutions features
support for a wide range of source and
Target database platforms automated
schema and data migration with minimal
downtime migration assessment to
identify potential issues and guidance
for successful migration real-time
migration monitoring and error
notifications pre and post migration
validation and cleanup tools integration
with Azure services such as Azure
security Center and Azure monitor for
enhanced security and monitoring
capabilities how it works set up the
migration project create a new migration
project in Azure DMS Define the source
and Target environments and specify the
database objects to migrate configure
the source and Target configure the
network connectivity and security
settings for the source and Target
environments and install the Azure DMS
extension on the source database server
start the migration start the migration
and monitor the progress in the Azure
DMS portal the service automatically
replicates The Source database to the
Target environment and tracks the
changes that occur during the migration
perform ceed over and post migration
tasks after replication initiate the
ceed over to transition the application
to the Target environment Azure DMS
offers validation and cleanup tools post
migration
[Music]
the next migration tool we'll be
covering is storage migration service
the storage migration service simplifies
the process of migrating storage to
Windows server or Azure it comes with a
userfriendly graphical tool that takes
stock of data on Windows litex and net
appy ifs servers and facilitates its
transfer to newer servers or Azure
virtual machines the service also
enables the migration of a server's
identity to the destination server
ensuring that applications and users can
access access their data without any
changes to Links or paths why use
storage migration service use storage
migration service because you've got a
server or multiple servers that you want
to migrate to newer Hardware or virtual
machines storage migration service is
designed to help by doing the following
tasks inventory multiple servers and
their data rapidly transfer files file
shares and security configuration from
The Source servers optionally take over
the identity of the source servers also
known as cutting over so that users and
apps don't have to change CH anything to
access existing data manage one or
multiple migrations from the windows
admin center user interface migration is
a three-step process wi inventory
servers to gather info about their files
and configuration shown in the following
figure to transfer data from The Source
servers to the destination servers three
cut over to the new servers the
destination servers assume the source
servers former identities so that apps
and users don't have to change anything
although the source servers retain their
files they enter a maintenance mode and
become inaccessible at a suitable time
these servers can be decommissioned so
that's an overview of storage migration
service the next migration solution
we'll be covering is azure data box the
Microsoft Azure data box Cloud solution
lets you send terabytes of data into and
out of azure in a quick inexpensive and
reliable way each storage device has a
maximum usable storage capacity of 80
terab and is transported to your data
Center through a regional carrier it is
designed to help customers with slow or
limited internet connectivity to move
large volumes of data to the
cloud let's take a look at some of azure
data Box's use cases data box is used to
import data to Azure for onetime
migrations moving large on premises data
transitioning offline tapes relocating
BMS SQL servers applications and
transferring historical data for Azure
based analysis initial bulk transfers
large scale transfers using data box
followed by incremental Network
transfers for example moving vast
backups with Partners like convolt
periodic uploads transferring large
volumes of data generated periodically
like video content from oil rigs or
windmill farms for exporting from Azure
data boxes used for Disaster Recovery
restoring Azure data on premises quickly
security requirements meeting mandates
that require data extraction from meure
Storage tiers Like Us Secret migration
moving data back to on premises or to a
different cloud provider here's how
Azure data box works customers order a
data box from the Azure portal when the
data box arrives customers connect it to
their Network and configure it using the
Azure portal customers copy data to the
data box using standard file transfer
protocols such as SMB or NFS once the
data transfer is complete customers ship
the data box back to Azure Azure copies
the data from the data box to the
customer's Azure storage account so
that's an overview of azure data box
it's cases and
[Music]
workflow let's talk about networking for
Azure and so everything kind of revolves
around the virtual Network also known as
the v-net and this is a logically
isolated section of your Azure Network
where you launch your Azure resources
and here's a very simple uh diagram of
using v-net but there's a lot of
networking components uh that you're
going to be utilizing and we're not
going to go through the exhaustive list
here but let's just go through some of
them just to give you an idea of like
all the things you can do within Azure
networking so you have Azure DNS this
manages your uh your DNS domain then you
have the v-net itself and so underneath
that it'll have like address spaces
route table subnets then you have
network security groups this acts as a
virtual firewall at the subnet or Nick
level you have express route this helps
you create a very fast connection
between your on-prem to your v-net then
you have virtual Wan this is a
centralized Network to rote different
network connections then you have
virtual Network Gateway this is a sight
tosite vpm connection between v-ets and
local networks then you have your NYX or
your network interfaces and these are
virtual network devices to allow VMS to
communicate using IP protocols and then
you have like all your load balancers
and other things like that so again not
an exhaustive list uh but just shows you
that there's a lot you can do uh within
networking on
[Music]
Azure so as your private links allow you
to establish secure connections between
Azure resources so traffic remains
within your Azure Network and so I got
this big old graphic here and so let's
just uh Define a few things I'm going to
pull out my pen here and so imagine you
have workloads on your on Prem or you
have your own virtual Network on Azure
uh and so you have some VMS doing some
stuff and the idea is that you want to
connect them to some other services over
here uh but the thing is is that if you
wanted to connect them they might try to
transverse the internet so if you're on
Prem it's going out here and it's going
over here and so the issue with this is
that um it's not necessarily secure uh
another issue could be um you know it's
just faster if it would to stay within
the actual Network because if you're
already connected you you know your
stuff over here then why wouldn't it
just go through uh the actual Network
another thing is like data transfer cost
so it's always going out the internet
and coming back in and that's not a
great scenario uh so I'm just going to
erase all that stuff there uh the idea
with private link is that it's just
keeping everything within the Azure
Network um and so that's what it's doing
so if you want to uh you know um connect
your workloads in your v-net or your on
Prem that connects to a specific v-net
the idea is that you can launch a
private link endpoint which is a network
interface and this is what's
establishing that connection and you're
going to have to give that private
endpoint a private IP address from your
v-net and so then the idea is that on
the right hand side that's what you want
to connect to there's a lot of azure
Services by default works with private
link so there's no additional
configuration you'll just be able to uh
say use private link and they will uh
same thing with some thirdparty
providers um in the marketplace uh they
might be powered by private link and
then there's a third case where let's
say you have like a private subnet and
you have some VMS there uh so what you
could do is um if you have a load
Bouncer and you need to have an internal
load balcer there you can uh launch the
private link service and this is going
to basically make your uh your workload
in that v-net become compatible or
powered by private link so there you
go let's take a look at subnets and a
subnet is a logical division of an
address space so we just looked at
address spaces so we're cutting it up
one step further and subnets help you
define different kinds of workloads and
allows you to apply virtual is isolation
within your network so when you launch
an aure resource you choose the subnet
you want to launch with within and an IP
from that subnet is assigned to your
resource so uh the thing is is that uh
when you create route tables that's how
you are associating uh the subnet so it
can access the internet or access
anything uh and then there's public and
private subnets but this thing is
interesting because like again if you if
you're using AWS uh those are very
clearly defined things but in Azure uh
they don't have this concept of public
and private you have to Define it
yourself so really a public or private
subnet is just a subnet that doesn't
have access to the internet and so we
saw that when we had the route table and
we over over uh Road um the access to
the internet to none that M essentially
made it a private subnet uh another
thing you can do with subnets is you can
associate a network security group and
this is going to help protect uh protect
your traffic entering and leaving the
subnet so you're making rules based on
the IP address port and protocol uh and
then there's a special thing called a
Gateway subnet so uh it's a specialized
uh type of subnet and it's just for
Azure virtual Network gateways and so um
it's interesting you'll go in and
there'll be a separate section just for
it and so you'll create it it's just for
that
[Music]
service so uh virtual private networks
also know as vpns what they do is they
extend a private Network across a public
network and enables your users to send
and receive data across shared or public
networks as if their Computing devices
were directly connected to the private
Network all right uh and so now we have
to talk about what is a virtual Network
Gateway and so virtual Network Gateway
is the software a VPN device uh for your
Azure virtual Network so that's how
these uh devices are going to connect to
your network so when you deploy a
virtual Network Gateway it will deploy
to or uh two or more specialized uh VMS
in specific subnets you need to create a
Gateway subnet and these deployed VMS
contain routing tables and run specific
Gateway Services you can uh choose the
type of Gateway you want it to be and
this is going to determine whether You'
use something like VPN Gateway or
express route Gateway so it's as simple
as an option like that but to really
understand uh these virtual Network
gateways we should just look at some VP
and Gateway design so you understand why
you're creating these
things so to understand VPN Gateway we
need to understand the utility of the
service and so we'll look at some
different topologies and the first one
is site to site this is when you connect
Azure to on- premise data center or vice
versa and the idea is you create a VPN
Gateway that's going to establish
connection to your on- premise
environment creating IPC tunnel which is
a secure connection IP uh connection
there but you might be asking well isn't
that what Express rout is for well
Express rout goes through a part um a
edge partner uh so there's a lot more
work involved in that setup this one
just goes over the internet so it's not
going to be as fast um and there's some
other uh downsides but the idea is it's
the easiest way to get connected from
your uh your on premise to uh Azure the
next one is multi sight this is when you
connect Azure to multiple on premise
data centers um so it's just like the
same model except there's more than one
uh tunnel here to more than one uh uh
site then you have point to site this is
when you connect Azure to multiple
individual computers so imagine you have
a bunch of employees around the world
and they have laptops and they just need
to connect
uh securely to the um to the the private
v-net or just the v-net in general and
so that's where we're going to need uh
VPN Gateway and the last one is v-net to
vnet this is where you're going to
connect two v-ets in two different
regions and subscriptions uh or have
different deployment models uh and so uh
that's again those are transversing the
internet uh in all these cases here but
yeah that's pretty much it and I guess I
think that if you were to set up Express
Ro I think you'd have to set up VPN
gateways anyway uh but anyway that's
what that is there so hopefully that now
makes
[Music]
sense so Azure Express Roes creates
private connections between Azure data
centers and infrastructure on your
premises or in collocation environments
and so uh connections don't go over the
public internet and as a result offer
more reliability faster speeds
consistent latencies and higher security
so here's a big old graphic here kind of
representing what's going on here and
the idea is that you're going to have
connectivity from different things like
from any to any so that's ipvpn Network
a point-to-point ethernet Network a
virtual cross connection and this is all
going to be going through a connectivity
provider at a co- location facility so
this example would be a uh an edge
partner and so you would be the customer
Network that' be your on premise or
whatever you want to connect so that you
can make it all the way to your Azure
services and the way you would establish
a connection is you create these express
route circuits uh it's pretty common to
have uh more than one because because uh
you want to have high availability just
in case the other one goes out uh the
idea is that you can route them uh route
this traffic to a couple different
places so the first one would be things
like peering to office uh 365 Dynamics
365 or even your Azure public services
so when we say Public Services imagine
you just launch a um a virtual machine
that is in a public subnet that has a an
IP that's reachable from the internet uh
that could just be to that or maybe
you're using like cosmod DB or like you
have fully qualified domains for other
services uh so that's just a way that
you can get there and then let's talk
about the other side which is uh um
doing private peering for uh v-ets so
the idea is that you have a private
v-net so the subnets are private and so
the only way is going to be access it uh
you want a direct way to access it that
way so uh that's the two ways there uh
and just to note there is express route
direct and so this is like express route
with an additional benefit that has
greater bandwidth connections from 50
megabytes per second up to 10 GB per
second and this is really ideal if you
have hybrid Solutions where you uh
you're removing massive amounts of uh
data or where latency matters because
you you want uh to feel like these uh
cloud services are right there with your
on- premise environment you're going to
need a lot of speed for
[Music]
that aure firewall is a managed
cloud-based network security service
that protects Azure vnet's resources and
it's a fully stateful firewall as a
service so you're going to get built-in
High availability and unrestricted cloud
scalability and what you can do is uh is
essentially create enforce and log
application network connectivity
policies across subscription and virtual
networks so Azure firewall uses a static
public IP address for your v-net
resources allowing outside firewalls to
identify originating from your virtual
Network and the service is fully
integrated with Azure monitor for
logging and analytics so here is a
representation of azure firewall and so
the idea is that you're going to launch
an Azure firewall into its own v-net and
then other v-ets and your on premise or
other things are going to pass through
that Central v-net onto wherever they
want to go and the idea is that uh we're
going to be able to uh do things like
utilize Microsoft threat intelligence
this is going to block known malicious
IPS in
fqdns that stands for fully qualified
domain names and by default the traffic
is uh set to deny uh but you can set
connectivity policies to filter out
traffic in a variety of ways to make
sure that you are protected uh there so
yeah that's all there is to
[Music]
it so network security groups filter
Network traffic to and from the Azure
resource
naet uh and so an NSG is composed of
many security rules and so here's an
example of setting an inbound security
Rule and each security rule has the
following properties so you can give it
a unique name which is all the way at
the bottom there uh you can set the
source or destination so you're going to
set an IP address cider block service
tag application group things like that
uh then you set the port range so it
could just be Port 80 could be all ports
where it shows an aster it could be a
range of ports you're going to set the
protocol so you got TCP UDP icmp you set
the action whe whether it's allowed or
denied and then you set the priority
which is a number between 149 96 and we
have two types of security rules we got
inbound rules which applies to traffic
entering the NSG and outbound rules that
apply to traffic leaving the
NSG let's take a look at some of the
default security rules that NSG sets for
you so when you create an NSG you're
going to have some created for you by
default uh and that's going to be for
outbound rules and inbound rules so uh
for inbound rules uh you're going to be
able to uh accept any virtual networks
into your um through the uh NS
uh it's going to allow Azure load
balancer to make its way in and it's
going to deny uh everything else all
right then for your outbound rules it's
allowed to uh go to any other virtual
Network it's allowed to make its way out
to the internet and then everything else
is denied so there you
[Music]
go let's take a look here at the logic
for security rules and there's a lot of
logic here so we'll work our way through
it unfortunately there's no fun way to
visualize this so we just got work
through the textt so you may not create
two security rules with the same prior
priority and Direction you can have
5,000 nsgs per subscription and 1,000
nsgs rules per NSG for priority rules
are processed in priority order with
lowest number uh process before the
higher number and network security
groups uh rules are valuated By Priority
using a five Tuple information to allow
or deny traffic based on source source
ports destination destination ports and
protocol honestly I don't know what they
mean by that uh and I couldn't make any
sense it's in the documentation so I'm
just showing it to you here then there's
flow records They don't exactly explain
what they are but I assume the idea is
that uh when a request throws uh flows
through the NSG they're attaching
additional information to it uh so the
flow record allows a network security
group to be stateful a flow record is
created for existing connections uh
communication is a Lowder denied based
on the connection state of the flow
record and so let's talk about
statefulness so if you if you specify an
outbound Security Port you don't need to
set the inbound Port since it will be
set for you you only need to specify an
inbound uh security rule if the
communication is init initially
externally uh initiated externally and
the opposite is also true if inbound
traffic is allowed over a port it's not
necessary to specify an outbound
security rule to respond to traffic over
the port uh and the reason I know this
when a when another Port is set with
another one that's when it's stateful if
it didn't do that then it would be
considered stateless but it's state F uh
let's talk about Interruption so
existing connections may not be
interrupted when you remove a security
rule that uh enabled the flow and
traffic flows are interrupted when
connections are stopped and no traffic
is flowing in either direction for at
least a few minutes so there's the rules
uh there a lot of stuff there honestly I
won't even remember uh 90% of the stuff
but I just wanted to go uh through it
with you so there you
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this section we'll be
covering Azure DDOS protection what is a
DDOS attack a malicious attempt to
disrupt normal traffic by flooding a
website with large amounts of fake
traffic DDOS attacks are big worries for
people moving their apps to the cloud
these attacks try to use up all of an
app's resources so real users can access
it any online Point can be a target for
these attacks Azure DDOS protection
offers Advanced features to counteract
DDOS attacks when integrated with
recommended application design practices
this service is specifically designed
for Azure resources within a virtual
Network enabling this protection on both
new and established virtual networks is
simple and doesn't require any changes
to apps or
resources most frequent types of DDOS
attack volumetric attacks these are
volume driven attacks that deluse the
network with seemingly legitimate
traffic by doing so they exhaust
available bandwidth leaving legitimate
users unable to access the website these
are typically measured in bits per
second protocol attacks these tax
exhaust server Resources by sending fake
protocol requests that exploit
vulnerabilities examples include UDP and
TCP Flooding at layers 3 and four these
are measured in packets per second
application layer attacks these attacks
Target the application layer examples
include HTTP floods SQL injections
cross- site scripting parameter
tampering and slis attacks to defend
against these web application firewalls
are often
employed Azure offers two tiers of DDOS
protection
DDOS Network protection when combined
with best practices in application
design Azure DDOS Network protection
offers Advanced DDOS mitigation tools
it's automatically configured to
safeguard specific Azure resources in a
virtual Network DDOS IP protection this
is a paper protected IP model while it
shares core features with DDOS Network
protection it provides additional
services like rapid DDOS response
support cost protection and discounts on
Waf so that's an overview of azure DDOS
[Music]
protection so Azure has uh a few
different kinds of load balancers and
one in particular is the application
Gateway and this is for application
Level routing and load bouncing service
so application Gateway operates at the
OS I layer 7 uh which is also known as
the application layer and the idea here
is that when you're working about
applications you're working with HTTP
requests that's what it is uh and so the
idea is that it can look at the contents
of the HTP request and do some
interesting things so maybe it's looking
at the path and saying okay you're uh if
you have a path um and it's payments go
to the VM that has our payment system
and then if it's for admin go to the VM
that does that uh maybe it has to do
something with cookies or um maybe you
want to apply a Waf policy to to it and
so you can look at those HB requests and
determine if it is malicious traffic and
filter it out uh so yeah it's all about
the application which has to do with HP
requests to configure this thing you
need to set up a front ends uh ring
rules and backend pools and there are
two configurations for the front end you
can either have it with a private IP
which makes it now an internal load
balcer or a public IP which makes it
either we would call a public or
external load balancer uh and there's a
both I've never used that option before
um but I mean you just really need to
know the public and private for the
backends you create backend pools and a
backend pool is just a collection of
resources to which your application
Gateway sends traffic uh and so a
backend pool can contain virtual
machines virtual machine scale sets IP
addresses domain names app
Service uh and I think you can also send
it to like on Prem uh so let's just talk
about routing rules which connects the
front end and the back end together and
so uh here is a more complex example
gives you a better idea of this Service
uh uh at full uh and so the idea is that
you have your application Gateway it's
going to send uh traffic or sorry like a
DNS is going to send to application
Gateway and then you have these
listeners and they they listen for
incoming traffic uh and then what it
will do it will pass on that to a rule
and a rule just really says who should
we pass the data to uh and then if you
are defining a backend pool then you
need to have um an HTTP setting that
says how do we handle the HTP requests
okay so now we'll just look at more
granular detail about request or routing
rules let's take a closer look at
routing rules this is where all the
magic happens so a listener listens on a
specified Port an IP address for traffic
that uses a specified protocol if the
listener criteria are met the
application Gateway will apply the
routing Rule and these come in two
flavors we got basic which forwards all
requests for any domain to backend pools
and multisite forward requests to
different backend pools based on host
header and host name so the thing is is
that uh you uh you can have multiple
listeners and you can have an order of
them and the idea is that you really
want the basic to be on the uh be in
last in priority because if it's a first
it's going to capture everything because
that's its job it's like a catchall uh
so just make sure that um if you're
using multiple listeners you put basic
last uh so that's just something you
need to know then for those backend
Targets this is where we either Define a
back and pool or redirection redirection
is just an HTP redirection like uh 403
or whatever you have their temporary or
permanent very simple uh but for backend
pools you have to create HTP settings uh
and this tells us a little bit more
about how we want to handle HTP you know
cookies cook uh connection draining Port
requests Etc let's talk about a little
bit more so here are the actual options
that we can configure for HTP settings
so you have your backend Port uh so
generally it's either Port 80 or 443 it
just depends on where you're doing your
SSL termination uh but generally
um if you need end end encryption it'll
be 443 or uh and then if you are doing
connect or if you're doing SSL
termination at the blow balancer then
it's
80 um then you have cookie base Affinity
this allows you to keep a user session
on the same server so if you need to
persist cookies and use them for
authentication you'll want to enable
that you got connection draining this
gracefully uh removes backend pool
members during plan service updates so
you is that you know when there is an
update it's not just going to abruptly
cut over it's going to wait until a
connection disconnects from a server
before uh not no longer sending more
requests there because you don't want a
a connection dropping in the middle of
an update it's not great for a user then
you have request timeouts this is the
number of seconds the application
Gateway will will wait to receive a
response from the backend pool before it
returns a connection timeout error
message and last our um oh sorry we
still have override back in path these
allow you to override the path in the
URL so the request for spe a specific
path can be red to another path the idea
is imagine you want to send it to um but
bananas and you want bananas actually
internally route to oranges I don't know
why you want to do that or maybe to
plantains that' make a lot more sense so
that's something you can do uh and the
last one is the override the host name
so application Gateway normally leaves
the host name alone uh but you know if
you're using multi-tenant services like
apps uh like app service or API
management it needs very specific host
header set so this is where you can
override them and change them for those
services so hopefully that really gives
you a good picture of application
Gateway but I feel that that's all you
need to
know so let's take a look here at Azure
scale sets and these are used to
automatically increase or decrease your
virtual machine capacity so imagine uh
you have a web application behind an
application load balancer and you have
an increase in traffic you want to be
able to quickly add more capacity by
adding another identical virtual machine
uh or when uh there's a decrease in
traffic remove it to save cost and that
is what Azure skill sets do
um so you're creating uh scale policies
to automatically add remove based on
host metrics host metrics could be like
CPU utilization or uh Network in uh
you're going to create health checks and
you can also uh set a repair policy to
replace unhealthy instances you can
associate a load balancer to distribute
virtual machines across uh availability
zones and you can scale to 100 or even a
th000 VMS using scale
sets
so one thing you're going to probably
want to do with your scale set is
associate with a load Bouncer and in
honest I don't run any kind of
application workload uh unless it is in
a scale set and behind a load balancer
because it's just good practice to do
that and the reason why you're going to
want a load balancer is that it's going
to help you evenly distribute your VMS
across multiple availability zones and
that's going to give you high
availability uh because you definitely
want to try to run uh 3 VMS across three
azs to get that a high Veil ability uh
you can also use a load balancer probe
checks and these are more robust health
checks than what skill set provides you
uh so that's just an added benefit there
uh and when we're talking about um load
balancers we have two different choices
here we have the application Gateway and
so this is for HTTP htps web traffic
load balancer uh and then you also have
Azure load balancer and this is going to
support TCP and UDP Network traffic and
things like that so depending on what oi
layer you need to operate on is going to
determine what kind of load balcer you
need to
use so let's take a look at scaling
policies and these determine when a
virtual machine should be added or
removed to meet the current requirements
and you have this uh Little Wizard here
this is what the What wizard you see or
form you see when you're creating a
scale set initially with very simple
features but let's just focus on two
things scaling out and scaling in so
scaling out is when an instance should
be added to a skill set to increase
capacity so you choose your metric uh
which is hardcode in this case to CPU
threshold so you choose your metric the
duration how many VMS you want to add
and then the scale in is the opposite
that's when you're removing uh uh uh
something from the scale set to decrease
your capacity and again that interface
is very simple uh when you actually go
ahead and create a scale set after you
go and update it you're going to end up
with a lot more options and here are the
options you can see they're extremely
robust and so uh you have the option to
choose one of the built-in host metrics
that are already be being collected on
your virtual machine so uh the most
popular here and there's more than this
but uh the most popular here is CPU
Network in network out dis read and
write uh then you have your Aggregates
so you can decide how you want to group
or uh collect that data uh before you
apply your final operations on it uh
then you have your operator so you can
say greater than or greater than or
equal to then you have your actions you
can say increase the count of so add uh
x amount of of servers or you can say
increase by percentage so imagine you
had um uh 10 servers and you want to
increase the load by 30% that would add
three additional servers if you want
more metrics than just the built-in host
metrics you can absolutely get more uh
but you're going to have to install a
couple things uh for app uh if you want
more app specific metrics like page
performance or page load performance and
sessions count you would uh install a
small instrumentation package for app
insights and uh if you want to have more
detailed host metric so you might have
host metrics but you want them in more
detail or more available host metrics
you'd install the Azure diagnostic
extension within your VM um there are a
few other uh scaling policy options that
are well they're not exactly in that
form but they are around or are
associated with them one is the scale in
policy not to be confused with the scale
in
option um and this determines what
virtual machine should be removed when
you decrease capacity so it's just a
simple drop down and you have a few
different options so there's the default
option this is where it deletes the VM
with the highest instance ID and it's
going to do that b uh uh take in
consideration uh the balancing across
A's and ads or it can delete the newest
virtual machine so delete the newest VM
again uh this one's only across uh virt
or availability zones or delete the
oldest VM this is going to delete the
oldest VM and balance across
availability zones then you have an
update policy and this determines how uh
how VM instances are brought up to date
with the latest scale that model so
again it's another drop down and you
have a a few options here so you have
automatic so increasing the start
upgrade immediately in random over uh
order or or manual so existent or
existing instances must be manually
upgraded or rolling and so this update
upgrades roll out uh in batches with
optional pause uh and just one other
note here is that if you want to do
automatic OS upgrades you can enable uh
this to help ease update management by
safely and automatically upgrading the
OS dis for all instances so there you
[Music]
go Health monitoring is a feature with
scill sets you're absolutely going to
want to turn on uh and what it does is
it determines whether your instance your
virtual machine instance is healthy or
unhealthy so you have that option to
disable or enable it and it comes in two
different modes we're going to have the
application Health extension which is
what we're seeing on the right hand side
here and this is where you ping an HTTP
or htps request with a specific path and
expect a back a specific status so the
status here would be 200 so the idea is
that you could say ping the homepage and
if the homepage appears then therefore
the server must be healthy or you can
make it your own custom uh page that's
what I like to do I have like a health
check page the other mode is load
balancer probe uh this is only going to
work if you have an Associated load
balancer and uh here you can check based
on TCP UDP HTTP request so this is a
little bit more robust um um so I
generally would recommend using this
mode over um the the first mode because
generally when you have a scale set
you're going to also want to have a load
balancer uh now if you want to replace
unhealthy instances they have an
automatic repair policy so this is an
automatic I mean like it's not turned on
by default so you have to uh explicitly
say you want to turn it on and what that
will do is that if it finds an instance
that is unhealthy it's just going to uh
terminate it and then launch a new
instance all right and so there you go
[Music]
all right so now that we have our scale
set we're going to continue on learning
more about availability by creating an
application Gateway so this is actually
a type of load balancer even though it
has Gateway in the name then there's
Azure load balancers and the difference
between these two is this one's layer
seven for the applications and this is
layer four uh so TCP UDP like at a lower
layer so uh you know since we have a web
application which is a simple apoi page
we're going to want to serve it up via
the application Gateway all right so
make your way over to the top here and
we'll click on application Gateway or
just type that in and we'll go ahead and
add ourselves a new application Gateway
we'll choose wolf here I'm going to name
this wolf um uh application
agw and then we do not yeah we don't
need any Autos scaling right now so
we'll just leave that alone I'm going to
set that to one we're going to choose
two one and three because the rule of
three counts here we always want three
and then down below make sure you choose
the correct virtual network if you're
not conf
make sure you go over to your scale set
and just double check to make sure where
it resides so if I go over here into my
scale set and check it's in wolfnet uh
wolf vet
499 how I ended up with more than one I
don't know I just the tutorial I've done
this a few revisions so I've ended up
with an additional one there notice it's
complaining because it's trying to uh
put this in the default but it needs its
own uh subnet so here under subnets
we're going to create one just for the
vgw so vgw and we're going to need a
range first so go over to address uh
space ranges and we'll pick out the next
number so
10.0 uh. 2.02 24 we'll hit
save and once that has created we'll
make our way over to the subnet and when
we hit subnet it will automatically
select the next one for us I'm going to
put vgw in here we'll hit
save and then once that's saved we'll
make our way back to the wizard notice
up here the bread comes if we click one
back we can make our way uh back to
where we are and then choose that vgw
subnet we'll go to the front to the
front end uh section here we got public
private or both we want public today and
we will need a new IP address so I'm
going to call this uh wolf
vgw we'll go ahead and hit okay we'll go
to backends here add a backend pool I'm
just going to call this backend and
we'll drop down and choose a virtual
machine scale set if you do not see it
here it's because they're not in the
same v-net make sure that's the case and
then we'll go to configuration so we got
a front the back end now we got to glue
them together with routing rules we'll
just say my rules we have listeners and
backend targets so we'll name our
listener name my listener if you can
spell it that's a hard one for me so I'm
just going to copy paste that in take
out the space there uh the front end IP
is it's going to be public we're going
to have HTTP on Port 80 we'll have basic
if we had multi sight so if you have
more than one destination but we do not
we'll go to backend targets and we will
choose the backend pool that we created
and then we have to choose or add um
HTTP settings this is all kind of
crammed together it doesn't really line
up very well so I get a bit confused
here so I think what we want to do is
hit add new here and then we'll say my
HTTP
settings uh Port 80 is good we do not
have cookies we do not care about
connection draining all these options
are not important to us uh for our very
simple application um but if you were
creating a real web application that uh
that has a session you probably would
want to turn these both on okay we'll go
ahead and hit add and we do have
path-based routing but this is not
something we need to worry about right
now this is where you could say you
could have multiple targets so you could
say Okay anytime it is uh cookie then go
to this virtual machine and then if it's
another one you could say go somewhere
else or even do a redirect that's a
great way of attaching things to your um
uh virtual machine there we'll go ahead
and hit add and so now we have all of
our information we'll hit tags and we
will go hit create and I'll see you back
here uh when this is done deploying
okay all right so I've been waiting a
while here for uh this to complete but
uh it looks like that we're still having
a bit of trouble uh so what I'm going to
do is make my way over to the actual uh
load balancer here because I just
remembered and this happens because I
don't normally make a scale set
separately I usually make it with the
load balcer but if we make our way over
to the backend pool and we're to click
into here it actually has a a thing that
says down here virtual machine skill set
was added to this backend pool upgrade
all in es of wolf scale set for this
change to work so uh those the scale set
needs to get updated is the is the
problem here so what I'm going to do is
make my way over to the scale
set and we'll see if we can do an
upgrade here so if we just checkbox them
all on there I'm going to go hit
upgrade and then this will perform an
upgrade on the
instances and we'll just give that some
time and I'll see you back here in a
moment okay so that didn't take too long
for the upgrade and if you just hit the
refresh here you're going to wait for
the status was running and now they're
all healthy so if we make our way back
to um our load balancer tab here if you
still have something open just go to
backend pools you should see three
targets if we go up to our overview over
here we'll go grab whoops our IP address
now why the uh they copy the text there
I have no idea but if we go paste that
up into here and take that out we get
our page so there you go that's all it
took to get the availability um or the
actual server
Runing if we go on the left hand side
and we go over to health probes this is
interesting to look at we're not going
to set it up but I just want to show you
that you'd write in your uh health check
here and then you could specify um a
different path so if you had like a page
called and this is pretty common for a
lot of places they'll have a page called
health check and so that's a just kind
of like a way to configure a custom
health check uh for your instances but
this is all I really wanted to
accomplish here today um I don't think
there's really much of anything else
that I'd like to do here um so what
we'll do is we'll go and make make our
way back to all of our resources and
we'll try to find our original Resource
Group here if we can uh find it's
probably easier if we just go to
Resource
groups great and I'll just go ahead
and delete this one
here there we go it's going to delete a
whole lot of stuff uh but yeah there we
go